welcome to this Advanced Journey Through
the depths of c-sharp this course is
designed to elevate your programming
proficiency delving into intricate
aspects like delegates events generics
async await tasks and Link plus you'll
learnabout.net with detailed code
examples and best practice guidelines
you'll explore design patterns user
actions queries operators c-sharp
attributes and more and you'll learn all
this from gavinlan Gavin is an
experienced developer and free code Camp
team member so let's get started
learning Advanced C sharp hi and welcome
I'm Gavin long
I'm a full stack software engineer with
over 20 years of experience
some of the more abstract concepts of
the c-sharp language or any high-level
programming language can seem somewhat
esoteric even to many experienced
Developers
so my goal with this Advanced c-sharp
course was to explain these more
advanced abstract Concepts in a simple
and easy to understand way
I hope you enjoyed this course and I
hope you benefit from it
so what sort of topics do I intend to
cover in the c-sharp advanced course
here are a few examples delegates events
generics extension methods Lambda
Expressions link asynchronous
programming with async await attributes
reflection and more
so what makes these kinds of topics more
advanced than those discussed in the
c-sharp for beginners course where we
covered basic concepts like methods
classes arrays data types variables enum
switch statements if statements Loops
Etc
if I had to pick one word that sums up
the answer to that question that word
would be the word abstract
I found what I believe to be an
appropriate definition for the word
abstract that in my view best fits the
programming context
to consider apart from application or
association with a particular instance
this definition sort of reminds me of
the ancient philosophical Theory or
world view attributed to the great
ancient Greek philosopher Plato
the theory is known as the theory of
forms or theory of ideas
I'm not going to go into too much detail
regarding the theory itself but
basically the theory asserts that
Ultimate Reality exists outside our
temporal and spatial world
for example the human form itself exists
as a thing independently from the actual
humans that exist in plural in our
experience of our temporal and spatial
Realm
an even more simple example is that of
the shape of a triangle if I ask you to
draw a triangle and I was to also draw a
triangle there would be subtle
differences in our drawings but
essentially we would both be able to
recognize the three-sided triangle shape
in both of our drawings
they are forms that are Universal
so in this sense the triangle shape
itself can be seen as an abstract
concept but instances of this shape can
be found and recognized in our real
world experiences
so for example in terms of programming
we have certain abstract Concepts that
exist on their own as universally
recognizable patterns
these patterns can be implemented in our
code to solve multiple real world
problems it can be hugely advantageous
to understand certain Advanced abstract
Concepts that can then be appropriately
applied in code to achieve better code
reuse cleaner code extensibility
flexibility of design easier maintenance
of code separation of concerns
enablement of effective unit testing and
the provision for overall better
performance and efficiency of our
applications if there is one downside to
the implementation of certain Advanced
code patterns it is that to someone
unfamiliar with these advanced concepts
the code implementations of these
advanced concepts can appear as somewhat
esoteric for most people the more
abstract a concept is the more time is
needed to understand the abstract
concept
this I would say is the main difference
between the concepts discussed and the
c-sharp for beginners course and some of
the concepts that we will cover in the
c-sharp advanced course
let's look at a basic code example
so this is just a basic example that
I'll go through fairly quickly it's not
necessary to follow along with the
example
I will however make the code example
available on GitHub please see a link to
the appropriate repository Below in the
description
so let's create a c-sharp Project based
on the.net core console application
project template
let's name the project School HR
Administration
let's create a class Library project
and I'll name this HR Administration API
foreign
within the class Library project let's
first delete the class that is there by
default and then add an interface named
I employee
let's add four property definitions to
the I employee interface ID as integer
first name is string
and this is an interface so we of course
don't need these Public Access modifiers
preceding our property definitions
last name is string and salary as
decimal
let's add an abstract class and name it
employee base
let's make this employee base abstract
class implement the I employee interface
and let's make the salary property a
virtual property
so now we have the basis in our HR
Administration API class Library project
for a basic employee record
so from within our school HR
administration.net core console
application let's make a reference to
the hi Administration API class Library
project let's create a class named
teacher and let's make the teacher class
inherit from the employee base abstract
class
let's ensure that our code includes a
directive to the hi Administration API
namespace
let's create three other classes that
inherit from the employee Base Class
these classes represent some other staff
roles within the school
so head of Department Deputy Headmaster
and Headmaster
let's say there is a requirement to sum
up the annual salaries including bonuses
for these members of staff
first let's create a method named seed
data so the seed data method accepts a
generic list which is strongly typed as
I employee as an argument
foreign
five employee objects and add each of
the objects to the employee's collection
for the sake of this example I'm going
to hard code the property values for
these five employee records
so let's say that a bonus is paid
annually to each of these staff members
and the amount is based on seniority
so let's override the salary property
and add an appropriate bonus for each of
these employees
let's say the teacher gets two percent
the head of Department three percent
the deputy Headmaster four percent
and the Headmaster gets five percent
so let's address the requirements to
calculate the sum total of staff
salaries including bonuses
so to do this we can Implement a for
each Loop in the main method that
traverses the items in our employees
list and sums up the salaries within the
for each Loop using the plus equals
operator
we can then output the sum total of all
staff annual salaries including bonuses
to the console screen
let's run the code
great
we can use more advanced code to achieve
the same thing literally through writing
one line of code instead of the multiple
lines of code used to create the for
each Loop and the mathematical operation
performed within the for each Loop
so let's include a directive at the top
of our code to the system.link namespace
by using the linked technology we are
able to provide the same solution with
one line of code like this
let's run the code
and we get the same result as before
but our code is more concise and much
cleaner
so let's briefly look at some of the
advanced c-sharp concepts that have been
applied in this simple example
my explanation at this point will be
brief because each of these topics will
be discussed in detail as the c-sharp
advanced course progresses
sum is an extension method provided in
the system.link namespace
let's see what happens if we comment out
the system.link directive
the c-sharp compiler immediately
complains the system.link namespace
contains many useful extension methods
including the sum extension method
a Lambda expression is passed into the
sum method the sum parameter accepts a
delegate argument where the delegate
contains a type definition parameter I.E
the I employee type
and as you can see there are several
overloads to the sum method where the
output type of the delegate can vary
so we are passing in a delegate that
accepts an argument of type I employee
and outputs a decimal value
so because we are summing up the salary
field and the salary field is of type
decimal the delegate passed in in the
form of Lambda expression has an output
of type decimal
notice the fun keyword is used to define
the delegate type parameter
also notice the angle brackets following
the funk keyword
and within the angle brackets the date
type definitions are included
this is an implementation of generics
even in this really basic example a lot
of complexity is abstracted away
through the use of Technologies like
link extension methods delegates Lambda
expressions and generics
I won't go into too much detail
explaining these Technologies in this
video because all of these technologies
will be explored in detail in this
course
here is a brief definition of each of
the Technologies we have just discussed
link stands for language integrated
query link enables the developer to
write queries against strongly typed
collections of objects by using language
keywords and familiar operators
extension methods enable the developer
to add methods to existing types without
creating a new derived type recompiling
or otherwise modifying the original type
a delegate is a type that represents
references to methods with a particular
parameter list and return type
a Lambda expression is a shorter way of
representing an anonymous method using
special syntax
the funk type provides a way to store
Anonymous methods in a generalized and
simple way
generics introduced the concept of type
parameters to the.net framework which
make it possible to design classes and
methods that defer the specification of
one or more types until the classroom
method is declared and instantiated by
client code
let's abstract the object instantiation
process for an employee through the use
of a factory class
so we are going to implement the factory
design pattern to implement this code
let's first create an enum at the top of
our code and name it employee type
let's include the members of Staff
employee roles within the context of a
school in the enumerator list
okay let's create a public static class
named employee Factory within this class
let's create a public static method
named get employee instance that returns
an object of the I employee type
let's implement the code for this method
which simply instantiates an appropriate
object based on the type of the employee
foreign
let's write the code that Returns the
employee object to the calling code
right let's use our Factory class to
construct our employee objects within
our C data method
foreign
so we have now abstracted the
construction of our employee objects
let's run the code
but now let's go one step further So
within the HR admin API class Library
project let's create a generic class
named Factory pattern
as discussed earlier to someone not
familiar with generics this class may
seem somewhat esoteric
the method in this class named create
instance instantiates an object
generically even though the object is
generically created generics enables the
code to be strongly typed and therefore
the code is checked at compile time
so let's go back to the calling code in
the school HR Administration project and
in the employee Factory class let's
update the code that instantiates our
employee objects through the utilization
of the generic Factory pattern class
we have abstracted the object
construction process even further so
let's run the code
great
so before I conclude this video I want
to highlight another reason why it is
important to understand the more
advanced concepts in C sharp these
advanced concepts are commonly used in
various.net Project Frameworks like for
example asp.net MVC web API and xamarin
if you are a game developer that uses
the unity game engine knowing the more
advanced concepts in c-sharp will also
be hugely advantageous
foreign
code for each of these types of
applications or games without having a
deep knowledge of the advanced concepts
that are built into the Frameworks or
game engine themselves but having a
knowledge of these Concepts is going to
give you an advantage when building and
maintaining your applications or games
so for example behind the scenes as it
were a reflection is used extensively in
asp.net MVC
for example when the control and action
names are passed from the root
reflection is used to find the
corresponding method to invoke
attributes are also used extensively to
abstract aware complexities and
facilitate the ReUse of common
functionality asynchronous programming
with async await is used here to
increase performance
and generics is also commonly featured
with the Entity framework data access
technology Lambda expressions and Link
are commonly used
Entity framework is commonly used in
asp.net MVC applications and web API
applications
in the web API framework we see the same
Technologies being applied
note that dependency injection is a
built-in feature in the asp.net core MVC
and web API project Frameworks
dependency injection will be explored in
the c-sharp advanced course
[Music]
in the xamarin project we can see here
the use of attributes and generics is
being applied here in code
in this game created with unity generics
is commonly used attributes are also
frequently applied
and these are just a few examples of how
these advanced concepts are applied in
commonly used project Frameworks and the
unity game engine
[Music]
summary what makes the concept in
programming a more advanced concept the
more abstract the concept the more
difficult the concept is to understand
for most people
gaining an understanding of the more
abstract advanced concepts can be
applied to achieve better code reuse
cleaner code extensibility flexibility
of design ease of code maintenance
separation of concerns the enablement of
unit testing and the provision for
overall better performance and
efficiency of our applications
the more advanced concepts are applied
frequently in the various.net project
Frameworks like for example sp.net MVC
web API and xamarin understanding these
advanced concepts will also be an
advantage to game developers that create
games using the unity game engine
some of the advanced concepts that will
be explored in detail in this Advanced
c-sharp course will be for example
delegates events generics extension
methods Lambda Expressions link
asynchronous programming with async
await attributes reflection and more
[Music]
hi and welcome this video highlights the
significance of the release of dotnet 5.
[Music]
I've included this content as part of
the c-sharp advanced course because I
feel that this.net upgrade is a game
changer for net Developers
this will not be a code Focus tutorial
I feel that in order to put c-sharp in
its correct context we must understand
the underlying Plumbing as it were and
how future.net upgrades will affect us
as c-sharp Developers
with the release of.net 5. I thought it
would be prudent to cover how this will
change the context of our c-sharp
applications
[Music]
so.net 5 is expected to be released in
November 2020. the first preview of.net
5 is expected to be available in the
first half of 2020 and will be supported
by Visual Studio 2019 and visual studio
code
here are some key features of dotnet 5.
a single unified platform for everything
including Windows Mac web mobile cloud
iot gaming machine learning and data
science
managed by open source community and
supported by Microsoft cross-platform
with any device anywhere
supports all major platform capabilities
for net framework.net core and xamarin
including Windows forms WPF uwp asp.net
MVC Entity framework link and so on
scalable fast and high performance
smaller development and packages
support for the most productive Ides and
tools including Visual Studio vs code
vs4 Mac and command line interface CLI
okay let's go back in time to just
before May 23 1995.
so what is the significance of this date
well this is the date that Java first
appeared
so what does the phrase close to the
metal mean and what does it have to do
with anything
when programmers say a programming
language or platform is close to the
metal this means the developer is able
to programmatically manage and operating
system's memory
so when Java came along in 1995 this was
a huge deal compiled Java code ran
within its own environment called the
jvm
jvm stands for Java virtual machine
write once run anywhere and automatic
memory management
before.net framework was released by
Microsoft on February the 13th 2002
visual Basics 6 had been released in
1998. Visual Basic is a third generation
event-driven programming language
developed for Microsoft's component
object model com
the first version of Visual Basic was
released in 1991.
Visual Basic was not a fully
object-oriented language and was event
driven
it was also tightly coupled with the
Visual Basic IDE
a framework was a massive upgrade from
this
and the.net framework common language
runtime resembled the Java virtual
machine in many ways
automatic memory management was achieved
for Windows platforms but right once ran
anywhere had not yet been enabled
through.net the dotnet framework could
only run on Windows platforms
so the top similarities between the.net
framework CLR common language runtime
and Java's jvm Java virtual machine
include
they are both virtual machines they both
include garbage collection they both
employ stack-based operations they both
include runtime level security
they both have methods for exception
handling
the.net framework provides developers
with an abstraction that sits above the
operating system a virtual machine I.E
the common language runtime and a suite
of apis I.E bcls or Base Class libraries
the.net framework provides thousands of
Base Class libraries that Aid the
developer with common development tasks
interoperability
multiple.net languages for example
vb.net F-sharp and of course c-sharp can
be included and interact with each other
in the same application this is possible
because the higher level.net languages
are first compiled into the Intermediate
Language
the Intermediate Language is then
compiled at runtime into machine
language through just-in-time
compilation
the.net framework also provides memory
management security and exception
handling
.NET Framework although a massive
Evolution from VB6 and com is not
modular and is not cross-platform
it has to be installed in its entirety
and it can only run on a Windows
platform
the latest version of the.net framework
is version 4.8
this version was released on April 18
2019.
so let's go back in time to the release
of mono
mono was first released on June the 30th
2004. it is a free and open source
project to create an ecma standard
compliant.net framework compatible
software framework
including a c-sharp compiler and a
Common Language runtime
originally created by Simeon it was
later acquired by Novell and is now
being led by xamarin a subsidiary of
Microsoft and the.net Foundation
so mono provided a.net runtime
implementation which allowed c-sharp
code to be compiled and implemented on
multiple platforms
dot net core's initial release was in
June 2016. net core is a free and open
source managed computer software
framework
it is a cross-platform successor to
the.net framework
.net core is similar to mono in that it
enables cross-platform portability
it is an open source and cross-platform
framework
.net core can be said to be a more agile
version of.net framework because only
the components required for a particular
application need to be deployed to the
Target computer
net core has been optimized for the
cloud and can also run inside a Docker
container which makes it an ideal
runtime environment for macro services
the latest release of.net cores version
3.1 and was released on the 3rd of
December 2019.
so at this point we have.net framework
mono and net core providing different
implementations of.net
so you can see how it could be difficult
for Developers for example to be sure
for particular.net Base Class Library
component dependency would be supported
across relevant.net implementations
so in order to create uniformity across
these implementations of.net Microsoft
introduced the.net standard
.net standard is a set of apis that
all.net platforms have to implement
[Music]
it was introduced to unify the.net
platforms and prevent future
fragmentation
for more comprehensive information on
what is supported by the.net standard
please check out this table that can be
found at this URL
dotnet standard was a great step forward
in terms of providing uniformity
across.net platforms
but wouldn't it be great to have one
framework to rule them all
so why.net 5 and not.net core version 4.
Microsoft is following the version
progression of the.net framework where
as mentioned earlier the latest release
of the.net framework is version 4.8
so this is why the next release of dot
net is.net 5.
it follows from the.net framework
visioning rather than the net core
versioning so what is the significance
of dotnet 5.net 5 will be open source
and you will be able to use it to Target
Windows Mac OS iOS Android tvos watch OS
and webassembly and more
I recommend reading this blog from
Richard Lander the program manager of
the.net team this blog post was written
on the 6th of May 2019 and can be found
at this URL
here are some significant quotes from
the blog post
from the Inception of the.net core
project we've added around 50 000.net
framework apis to the platform
.net core 3.0 closes much of the
remaining capability Gap with.net
framework 4.8 enabling Windows forms WPF
and Entity Framework 6.
Net 5 Builds on this work
taking.net core and the best of mono to
create a single platform that you can
use for all your modern.net code
we intend to release.net 5 in November
2020 with the first preview available in
the first half of 2020.
it will be supported with future updates
to visual studio 2019 visual studio for
mac and visual studio code
the blog post goes on to say the
following everything you love about.net
core will continue to exist open source
and Community oriented on GitHub
cross-platform implementation support
for leveraging platform-specific
capabilities such as Windows forms and
WPF on Windows and the native bindings
to each native platform from xamarin
high performance side-by-side
installation small project files SDK
Style
capable command line interface CLI
Visual Studio visual studio for mac and
visual studio code integration
here's what will be new
you will have more choice on runtime
experiences
Java interoperability will be available
on all platforms Objective C and Swift
interoperability will be supported on
multiple operating systems
core FX will be extended to support
static compilation of.net ahead of time
aot
smaller Footprints and support for more
operating systems
we will ship.net core 3.0 this September
referring to September last year
2019.net 5 in November 2020 and then we
intend to ship a major version of.net
once a year every November
and note the depiction of the release
schedule timeline in 2021.net 6
2022.net 7. so no more.net framework or
net core but rather one unified open
source cross-platform
framework.net 5 is a welcome release
so please let me know in the comments
your thoughts on.net 5. I think the move
to unify features from.net framework
mono and Dot net core into one framework
is a big step forward
[Music]
this video serves as an introduction to
delegates and is the first part of a
video series on this Advanced c-sharp
topic
thanks
[Music]
we'll look at a broad overview of
delegates in this video so that we can
understand delegates conceptually and
we'll also create a very basic example
of using delegates and code
my aim is to explain these advanced
concepts in a simple way
so what are delegates
a delegate can be described as a
typesafe function pointer
a variable defined as a delegate is a
reference type variable that can hold a
reference to a method in order for a
delegate to reference a particular
method the delegate must Define
parameters with types that match the
parameter types contained in the
relevant method the delegate must also
Define a return type that matches the
return type of the relevant method
when a developer instantiates a delegate
the developer can associate its instance
with any method with compatible
parameters and return type
the developer can invoke or call the
method through the delegate instance
note that variants can be used in
delegates which means that the types
defined for the parameter list and the
return type of the delegate do not have
to match exactly with the relevant
methods parameter types and return type
in this video we'll keep the example
simple but we'll discuss variants in an
upcoming video in the meantime if you
wish to read about variants you can
navigate to this URL this web page
contains content on both covariance and
contravariance
in this video I'll introduce delegates
through a basic example where a delegate
can reference a static method and an
instance method
we'll also look at multicast delegates
which allows the developer to invoke or
call multiple methods through one
delegate call we'll also look at how a
delegate can be passed as a parameter to
a method and subsequently called within
that method
in a later video on delegates we'll
explore how delegates are used for
asynchronous callbacks and event
handling in c-sharp we'll learn how we
can take advantage of different types of
delegates like action func and predicate
to facilitate callbacks and add
flexibility to our code but let's first
look at the basics in this introduction
to delegates so a delegate can reference
both static methods and instance methods
let's first look at how a delegate can
reference static methods let's say we
want to encapsulate functionality that
logs text and includes a date timestamp
preceding the text
in some situations we want to have the
ability to log the text to the console
screen and in other situations we want
to have the ability to log the text to a
text file
so let's define a delegate that can
reference a method that does not return
a value and accepts one string argument
so to do this we use the delegate
keyword followed by the name of the
delegate type we wish to Define let's
name this delegate log Del
so preceding the logdel delegate name we
have included the void keyword this is
because we want this delegate to
reference a method that does not return
a value then after the logdale delegate
name we can include brackets and within
the brackets a list of parameters
so let's include one string parameter
and name it text
so this delegate can reference methods
that contain one string parameter and do
not return a value note that we have
included our delegate definition within
the program class which means this
delegate type can be accessed from
anywhere within the program class
we could have included this delegate
definition outside the program class and
within the delegate basic example
namespace if we wanted to extend the
delegate's accessibility to anywhere
within the delegate basic example
namespace
in this example we'll Define the
delegate scope so that it is accessible
from anywhere within the program class
and not accessible from outside of the
program class let's create a static
method named log text to screen inside
the program class
this static method contains the void
keyword which is used to indicate that
the method does not return a value and
contains one string parameter named text
the functionality within this method is
very basic we are simply writing the
text arguments value to the screen with
the date timestamp preceding the value
stored in the text argument
you can see that the delegate type we
have just defined named logdel contains
a definition for a method that does not
return a value and contains one string
parameter so the return type and
parameter type defined in our delegate
named logdel matches the return type and
the parameter type in the log text to
screen method signature
let's go to our main method and Define a
variable as the logdoll type
we do this by entering the logdal
delegate name followed by the variable
we'll name logdel then the equals symbol
followed by the new keyword to
instantiate an object
we must then follow the new keyword with
the name of the log Del delegate type
and then pass the name of the method
that we want the logdel variable to
reference into the logdoll types
Constructor like this then to call the
method now referenced by the logdel
variable we can simply write the name of
the variable that references the
delegate and pass in the appropriate
parameter to the delegate like you would
if you were calling a method
note you're also able to invoke
delegates through the use of the
delegate types invoke method like this
but for this example let's call the
delegate without using the invoke method
okay so let's make this example slightly
more interesting let's write code in the
main method to prompt the user for the
user's name and let's pass the user's
input as an argument to the logdel
delegate
let's run the code
and that works as expected
so what happens if we decide to include
the date time stamp as a parameter in
the log text to screen methods method
signature
the c-sharp compiler automatically
complains
this is because the log text to screen
method no longer conforms to the log
dial delegate definition
so let's change the logdel delegate
definition to accommodate a parameter of
the date time data type
right let's run the code
great
so that gives us a basic idea of how
delegates work
let's change the code for the log text
to screen method and the logdel delegate
definition to how it was previously
I.E let's remove the daytime stamp as a
parameter for the logdel delegate
definition
and let's also remove the date time
stamp parameter from the log text to
screen method signature
let's also update the log text to screen
method implementation accordingly
so let's say there is a requirement to
log the text to a text file
to implement this functionality we can
simply create a method that doesn't
return a value and contains a string
parameter
as we now know this will allow this
method to be referenced by a variable
defined as the log delt delegate
so let's create a static method named
log text to file
that contains a string parameter and
does not return a value
let's Implement codelogic detail that
writes the input from the user to a text
file
let's replace the log text to screen
method name being passed into the
logdoll delegate during the construction
of the delegate object with the log text
to file method name so our lockdown
variable is now referencing the log text
of file method so when the logdel
delegate is called this should invoke
the log text to file method
let's see if the user's input has been
written to the relevant text file
right so let's navigate to where the log
file should now have been created
which is the same directory path from
where our code is run
and you can see that the user's input
has been successfully written to the log
file as expected
so we have now proven that we can
reference static methods and delegate
defined variables let's now prove that
delegates can also reference instance
methods
let's create a class named log
let's move our static methods to the log
class
and let's remove the static keyword from
their method signatures because we want
to test that instance methods can be
referenced from delegates
let's go to the main method and create
an instance of the log type
let's then pass the instance method
named log text to screen into the logdel
delegate Constructor
Let's test the code
great the user's input is logged to the
screen as expected
and for good measure let's also test the
log text to file instance method
excellent
we are also able to call both methods
through one delegate call
this can be done through the use of
what's known as a multicast delegate
by using a multicast delegate multiple
objects can be assigned to one delegate
instance by using the plus operator
let's define two delegate variables as
log Del on one line like this
let's name the first delegate log text
to screen Dell and the second delegate
log text to file though
let's instantiate the first delegate
named log text to screen Dell and ensure
that it references the instance method
named log text to screen
let's instantiate the second delegate
named log text to file Dell and ensure
that it references the instance method
named log text to file
let's create a multi-cost delegate named
multi-log Dell and assign it a value
which is a combination of both the log
text to file Dell variable and the log
text to screen dial variable
note that these two delegate variables
have been combined through the use of
the plus operator
we are now able to call the log text to
screen method and the log text to file
method through one call to the multi-log
Dell delegate
Let's test the code
and the user's input along with the
timestamp has been logged to the screen
as expected
let's see if the user's input has been
logged to the relevant text file and it
has great and lastly let's demonstrate
how a delegate can be passed as an
argument to a method then invoked by the
method that receives the delegate
argument
let's create a static method in the
program class named log text
this method does not return a value and
contains a parameter defined as the
logdel delegate type and the log text
method will simply serve as a wrapper
function for calling the logdoll
delegate which will be passed as an
argument at runtime to the log text
method
let's go to the main method and pass the
multi-log Dell delegate as an argument
to the log text static method
Let's test the code
so it is logged the user's text to the
screen as expected
let's also check whether the text has
been logged to our log file
excellent
so you could also pass the log text to
screen dull object or the log text to
file Dell object as an argument to the
log text method
so let's do this
let's first pass the log text to screen
Dell object into the log text method and
run the code
great
and let's also Test passing in the log
text to file Dell object to the log text
delegate
let's look at the appropriate text file
excellent
so you can see how delegates can be used
to separate design from implementation
detail and facilitate flexibility of
design in our applications
please let me know in the comments
section whether you have used delegates
before in your code if not hopefully you
will feel confident that you can use
them in the future
I hope you have enjoyed this basic
introduction to delegates in the next
tutorial we'll dive deeper into
delegates with a more detailed example
[Music]
hi and welcome this is the second part
of a tutorial on delegates please note
that this tutorial is going to be quite
code intensive and I will be going
through the code creation process fairly
quickly
if you are struggling to follow along my
advice would be to download the code
from GitHub and use this video as a
guide
a link to the relevant GitHub repository
is available in the description
the purpose of this video is to help you
understand delegates and how they can be
applied in code and also how certain
code design principles should be adhered
to in order to create reusable
extensible clean and easy to maintain
code
basically we are going to build a club
membership registration form and use
delegates to implement field validation
functionality
the advantage of using delegates for
this purpose is that these delegates can
be reused to validate fields for other
forms that we may wish to add to our
application in the future
this alludes to how delegates can
facilitate extensibility of our design
we are effectively going to decouple
validation from any one particular form
these delegates will be enabled to be
reused to validate any appropriate
fields for any form so we have
highlighted two advantages that can be
gained through the use of delegates code
reuse adherence to the code principle of
dry which is an acronym for don't repeat
yourself and code design flexibility
so in this example we'll build a basic
application using c-sharp and the.net
console project template we'll use
sqlite to store the data entered into
our user registration form we will then
create a login form and write a code to
authenticate the user by validating the
user's login information against
relevant data stored in a table in a
sqlite database
if you are not familiar with SQL Lite
please navigate to this URL for more
information
you can also download a sqlite client
application named sqlite browser from
this location
foreign
[Music]
basic code using Entity framework core
for appropriate database interactions
you may have noticed that I have used
the.net core console project template
for all my tutorials thus far
there is a very good reason for this
we could implement the code we are about
to write using the asp.net MVC framework
we can scaffold our code and leverage
Technologies like specific attributes
provided in.net to facilitate field
validation
separation of model views and
controllers and functionality like
dependency injection is inherently taken
care of for us in the asp.net MVC
framework
please don't misunderstand me Frameworks
like asp.net MPC facilitate rapid
application development and I am a
proponent of using such Frameworks
the only problem is we run the risk of
not fully understanding the underlying
design and code principles that are
abstracted away by such Frameworks
we can easily and effectively develop
web applications for example using
Frameworks such as asp.net MVC without
understanding the fundamental underlying
principles that make such Frameworks so
effective
so because the.net core console project
template doesn't spoon feed us as it
were
it can force us to think about
fundamental design principles that
facilitate for example code reuse
separation of concerns the
implementation of code design
flexibility and dependency and version
principle
with all that said let's look at a
bird's eye view of what our basic
application will look like
we'll start with the main.net core
console project
we'll then create a standard class
Library project which will be referenced
by our main.net core console project
the.net standard class Library project
will be named field validator API and
will contain two classes one class will
be named common field validator
functions it will contain a number of
delegates which will encapsulate
functionality for common validation like
for example required field validation
string length validation pattern match
validation field comparison validation
and date validation
the other class will be named common
regular expression validation patterns
this class will contain a number of
common regular expression patterns that
can be leveraged in our application for
example a regular expression pattern
used for validating an email address a
pattern that can be used to validate UK
postcodes
a pattern that can be used to validate
UK phone numbers
and a pattern for validating strong
passwords
within the main project the.net core
console project will create four folders
a folder named data to store data
related classes and interfaces a folder
named field validators to store
interfaces and classes relevant to field
validation
a folder named models to store our data
structures in this application we are
only going to implement one data
structure which will be a class
containing user registration related
properties
and lastly a folder named views this
folder will contain one interface and
classes relevant to the screens that
will be presented to the user
namely the user login view the user
registration View and welcome view which
is presented to the user
once the user is authenticated through
the use of the login view there's also a
main view which will be instantiated and
run from within the main method
so this application serves as a simple
example of how we can leverage delegates
and design our applications to
facilitate easy maintenance and
flexibility of design we are also going
to create three ancillary classes within
the root of the.net core console
application namely common output text
where we can store and make available
for example heading text common output
format which we can use for changing the
background and foreground color of our
output text and lastly we'll create a
class named Factory which will abstract
away the construction of our main view
object this will demonstrate a very
basic example of the use of dependency
injection and show an adherence to the
last letter of solid I.E dependency
inversion principle
so let's get started first let's create
a.net core console project where
solution as always will be
auto-generated to house our project
let's name this project club membership
application
the theme of this application will be a
user registering for a Cycling Club
right so let's add a folder named models
let's add a class to our models folder
named user
let's add properties to our user class
these properties will store the values
entered by the user during the
registration process
all of these properties must be public
read write properties so they must have
both Getters and setters
so let's create ID as integer first name
is string last name as string password
is string note that the password field
will be stored in the user's database
table without first being encrypted
I have not included any encryption code
because encryption and decryption are
beyond the scope of this tutorial
date of birth as date time phone number
as string address first line as string
addressed second line as string
address city as string and lastly
postcode as string
let's decorate the ID field with the
database generate attribute and pass the
enumerator list item value of database
generated option.identity as an argument
to the database generated attribute
so this is what is known as a code first
approach to developing an application
that uses a database for data storage
we first create a model which is
implemented as a c-sharp class then we
are able to run certain commands either
through.net CLI or Visual Studio to
generate the data structure in our
database from the models created within
our application
in this application we are going to run
the relevant database commands through
Visual Studio
note as an alternative we could use the
database first approach which would
involve creating the database schema in
the database and then generating the
models from the database schema using
appropriate database commands
we'll use the code first approach in
this application
so note that by decorating the ID field
with the database generated attribute
the way we have done here we are
declaring that we wish to create the ID
field as a primary key in the relevant
database table and that this ID field
must Auto increment each time a new row
is added to the relevant database table
so the next step is to install the
relevant Entity framework core package
the package we need for this application
is Microsoft dot Entity framework core
dot SQL Lite so let's browse for the
relevant nuget package using the nuget
package manager facility provided within
Visual Studio
and let's install the microsoft.ensity
framework core dot sqlite package
so the next step is to add a DB context
class to our project
let's first create a folder named data
let's add a class to the data folder and
name it club membership DB context
so this class must inherit from The
Entity Frameworks DB context based class
DB context class resides in the
microsoft.ensity framework core
namespace
so let's create a directive to this
namespace in our club membership DB
context class
and now let's override the DB context
based classes on configuring method
within this method we can configure a
connection to the sqlite database that
we wish to create and access
we are using the DB context option
Builder object to configure our
connection string the connection string
here is very basic it contains a file
path to our database file
the database file will reside in the
same location from where our code will
run this is achieved by using the
appdomain.currentdomain.base directory
property to establish the path to our
sqlite database file
we are then passing the DB context
options Builder object to the DB context
class using a call to the base method
the next step is to create a table
database structure for our relevant
model class
so we only have one model class to worry
about here I.E the user class
so we use the entity Frameworks DB set
generic type and pass the user type as a
generic argument to the DB set type to
establish the type of property that will
contain a reference to the users table
that will be generated in our sqlite
database
Entity framework will use this user's
property to add data to the user's
database table and retrieve data from
the user's database table
we could also use the user's property to
update data within the user's database
table but we won't need to implement
database record updates in this
application
so before we run the update hyphen
database command within visual Studio's
package manager console facility we need
to create what is known as a migration
so we can use the add hyphen migration
command for this purpose like this
okay so why has that failed
the reason is that we need to install
the microsoft.entity framework.tools
nuget package so let's do this
let's try to create the migration again
and this time it succeeds and there's
the migration class created for us
and you can see that the code in this
class contains a method to create the
user's table
and it also creates a method to drop the
so in order to run the migration we can
run the update hyphen database command
like this
okay great
so let's see if our database has been
created as expected
and it has great
let's open the database in the sqlite
browser client facility to see if our
users table has been created as expected
and it has excellent
so now let's create a project that will
serve as an API providing reusable
validation functionality
let's remove the default class
and let's create a class named common
field validator functions
let's make this class public and let's
add five delegate definitions the first
delegate definition defines a delegate
type that can reference a method used
for the purpose of ensuring that a form
field is not left empty
the second delegate that finds a
delegate type that can reference a
method used for constraining the
character length of a text field to
between a minimum and maximum value the
third delegate definition defines a
delegate type that can reference a
method that validates the date
the fourth delegate definition defines a
delegate type that can reference a
method that can be used for validating a
text input field value against a regular
expression pattern
the fifth delegate definition defines a
delegate type that can reference a
method that validates the text field
value against another text field value
we'll use this delegate to store a
method reference to a method that
provides functionality for ensuring that
the user re-enters the user's chosen
password so that it matches the original
entry for the password field during the
registration process
let's create private static member
variables for each of these delegates
let's create the method implementations
for each of these delegates namely
required field valid
string field length valid
date field valid
field pattern valid
and field comparison valid
so to expose our delegate objects to
calling code let's create a public
static read-only property for each
related delegate
with each of these public properties we
are creating a new delegate object of
the appropriate delegate type and
passing in the appropriate method name
into the delegate types Constructor
we are using a Singleton pattern to
ensure that only one instance of each of
these delegate objects can be created
foreign
so let's create a class and name it
common regular expression validation
patterns
I've already sourced four common regular
expression patterns from the following
useful website that can be found at this
URL
I'll also include a link to this URL
Below in the description
I've copied the relevant regular
Expressions to notepad I'll copy and
paste these regular expression patterns
from notepad into the common regular
expression validation patterns class
as stated earlier the code for this
tutorial can be downloaded from GitHub
please see a link to the appropriate
repository Below in the description
note that you are able to copy and paste
these regular expression patterns into
your code from the GitHub webpage at
this URL a link to this webpage has been
included Below in the description
okay so let's create a directory named
field validators this directory will
contain field validator classes each
validator class will correspond to a
particular View
we'll create the view classes in a bit
let's first create an interface named I
field validator
let's make this a public interface
So within the club membership
application.fieldvalidators namespace
let's create a delegate definition named
field validator Dell
this is a very important delegate as it
can reference a method that validates
fields for any form
so for example we are going to reference
a method to validate our user
registration form Fields but say for
example we needed to capture banking
information we could create a custom
validator class for this purpose
and within a newly created banking form
view class we could reference an
appropriate validator object derived
from the validator class and use this
validator object to validate the banking
related fields so we will be using this
delegate definition to create a delegate
that references a method for validating
Fields presented to the user in our user
registration view class
so the parameters defined for this
delegate are field index defined as an
integer for the purpose of referencing a
field value within an array of fields
field value as string this parameter
will be past the field value to be
validated
field array this is an array that will
store all validated fields for a
particular View
and lastly a parameter named field
invalid message
and preceding this parameters definition
is the out keyword
which allows its value to be outputted
to calling code so for field is invalid
a relevant message created within the
relevant referenced method can be
outputted to the calling code
which can then for example output the
message to the user
so let's create a method signature for a
method named initialize validator
delegates
a method that implements code for this
method definition can be used to
initialize the validation delegates that
will be used for a particular View
then field array provides a definition
for a read-only property that stores a
reference to an array of field values
and lastly validated Dell provides a
definition for a read-only property that
stores a delegate object that references
a method responsible for validating the
fields in a particular View
let's create a class named field
constants we are only going to store one
enum in this class which will be used to
index an array which contains field
values for the user registration form
using enum list item values to index our
array instead of integer values makes
our code more readable simply because at
a glance we can see exactly where our
field resides in the relevant array so
let's create an enum named user
registration field
and let's create an enum list item value
for each of the fields in our user
registration form
great
so let's create a class that implements
the I field validator interface
so this class is named user registration
validator
let's define four constants at the top
of the class these will be used a bit
later to validate our first name and
last name field lengths
let's create a delegate that will be
used to determine if an email address
already exists in the system if an email
address already exists the user's entry
will be deemed as invalid
let's create a private member variable
of the field validator Dell type this
delegate will store a reference to a
method responsible for validating the
user registration fields
let's define a private member variable
for each of our common validator
delegates required valid Dell string
length valid Dell
date valid Dell patent match valid dull
and compare field valid Dell
let's create a private member variable
to store the delegate object that will
reference a method responsible for
checking if a user email address input
already exists in the system
let's create a private member variable
for storing an array of valid field
values entered by the user
and let's create a property named field
array that will create a field array
object if one has not yet been created
note how we are using the length
property of the enum.getvalues method to
make appropriate space Provisions for
our field array array
each enum list item in our user
registration field enum must have an
index counterpart in the field array
array
yeah
let's expose the validator Dell delegate
through a public read-only property
and one thing I've forgotten to do is
indicate that this class implements the
I field validator interface so let's do
this
and now let's initialize the appropriate
validator delegates within the
initialize validator delegates method
here we are referencing the delegates
already wired up to their appropriate
methods created for us in the common
field validator functions class which
resides in the field validator API
project
foreign
let's create a private method that will
be responsible for validating each of
the fields used to register a club
member this method will be referenced by
the field validator Dell delegate
let's create the basic structure for the
valid field method
let's wire up the valid field method to
the field validator Dell delegate within
the initialize validator delegates
method
okay let's implement the code for the
valid field method let's first convert
the field index parameter to the user
registration field enum for the purpose
of creating more readable code
so the first field we wish to validate
is the email address field
so let's write code to ensure that text
has been entered into the email address
field by calling the required valid Dell
Delegate for this purpose
so if the text has not been entered for
this field we wish to Output an
appropriate message
to do this we can set the field and
valid message parameter to an
appropriate message
note that the field and valid message
parameter contains the out keyword in
its definition which means its value can
be outputted to the calling code
so we also want to ensure that the
user's email address input conforms to
an appropriate regular expression
pattern used for validating email
addresses
we can do this by using the pattern
match validol delegate
and if the user has entered an email
address but it is not in a valid format
we want to set the field invalid message
output parameter to an appropriate
message
so for the first name field we must
include validation so that the first
name field can only contain a text value
with a length that is between 2 and 100
characters
the last name field must also only
contain a text value that has a
character length between 2 and 100.
foreign
the password field must contain a value
that conforms to the following rules it
must contain at least one small case
letter one capital letter one special
character and must be between 6 to 10
characters in length
an appropriate regular expression
pattern is used to validate the password
the password compare field must contain
a value
and its text value must be an exact
match to the password field
date of birth must contain a value and
be a valid date
the phone number field must contain a
value that conforms to a pattern defined
for a valid UK phone number
address first line must contain a value
address second line must also contain a
value
and address City must also contain a
postcode must contain a value that
conforms to a pattern defined for a
valid UK postcode
foreign
and you can see that the method returns
a Boolean expression if the field
invalid message output parameter has not
been set during the validation of a
particular field
this means that the field is valid and a
Boolean value of true will be returned
to the calling code
however if the field and valid message
output parameter has been set to one of
the validation messages
the field valid method returns false
because the field value inputted by the
user has been deemed to be invalid by
our field valid method
I know there is quite a lot of detail in
that method please feel free to copy the
code for this method which can be found
at the GitHub webpage at this location
okay so let's go back to the data folder
let's add an interface named I register
let's add a method definition named
register that contains a string array
parameter
the method that implements code for this
method definition will accept a string
array argument which will contain valid
field data inputted by the user and this
field data will be saved to the users
table in our sqlite database
this method definition must also return
a Boolean value
then let's create a method definition
for a method that will be referenced by
a validation delegate the delegate will
be executed in order to check if the
email address entered by a user already
exists in the database table named users
this method definition provides a
definition for a method that contains a
string parameter and returns a Boolean
value
right let's create another interface and
name this interface I login
this interface defines one method
definition for a method that accepts two
string arguments and returns an object
of type user
let's add a class named register user
and indicate that this class implements
the I register interface
so let's provide a code implementation
for the register method let's
instantiate a DB context object from the
club membership DB context class with
any using block
let's create a user object and set its
properties so we can save its values to
the user's database table
okay there's a problem here
I forgot to include the email address
field in the user model
so what we need to do is first update
the user model
then we need to add a migration
thank you
and update the database
let's use the SQL browser client
application to see if our email address
column has successfully been added to
the user's database table
and it has great
let's add a directive to the club
membership application dot field
validators namespace at the top of the
code so that we can access the user
registration field enum
and we can use the user registration
field enum to index the field array
passed into the register method
using an enum for the index provides
better readability of our code
we must ensure that we cast the enum
values to integer values when using
these values to index items within the
field array
foreign
once we have finished creating the user
object we can save it to the users
database table
note that we simply pass the user object
as an argument to the add method to add
the data stored in the user object to
the user's database table and to confirm
our intention we must call the save
changes method on the DB context object
to save the data stored in the user
object to the user's database table
let's now Implement code for the email
exists method
foreign
we can use the any extension method
provided in the system.link namespace
to check if the email address text value
passed into the method already exists
within the user's database table
if it does this method will return true
if it doesn't exist this method will
return false
and we can now go back to the user
registration validator class and wire up
the email exists method to the email
exists Dell delegate
first let's make sure that the register
object derived from the register class
that we just created is passed into the
user registration validator classes
Constructor
then let's wire up the email exists
method provided in the register class to
the email exists delegate within the
initialize validator delegates method
we can then implement the appropriate
validation code in the field valid
method to check if the inputted email
address already exists within the user's
database table
foreign
classes let's create two ancillary
classes
let's first create a class named common
output text
let's create and Implement three
read-only static properties
one for returning the main application
heading one for returning a heading for
the user registration View and one for
returning a heading for the user login
View
so let's create three corresponding
methods that write these headings to the
console screen write main heading
right login heading
and write registration heading
let's create another class and let's
name this class common output format
let's create an enum named Font theme
with three enamelist item values namely
default danger and success
let's create a method named change font
color that contains a parameter of type
font theme
so if the font theme is equal to Danger
let's make the output font color red
and let's make the foreground font color
white
if the font theme is equal to success
let's make the background color green
let's make the foreground color white
else if the font theme is equal to
default let's reset our console screen
to its default color settings
right let's create our view classes
let's create a folder named views
within the views folder let's create an
interface named I view
let's make this a public interface
let's create a method definition named
run view which contains no parameters
and does not return a value
let's create a property definition of
type I field validator note that each
view can have zero or one field validate
to objects associated with it
if for example the relevant view does
not contain input fields and therefore
does not need a field validator class
the appropriate property will be set to
null
so let's add a new class name to user
registration view let's add two private
member variables one of type I field
validator the other of type I register
let's indicate that this class
implements the iview interface
let's ensure that the Field validator
property Returns the private member
variables value which is of the same
type
thank you
let's create a Constructor this
Constructor contains two parameters one
of type I register and the other of type
I field validator
let's appropriately assign our two
private member variables the object
values
that will be injected into the user
registration classes Constructor when
the user registration class is
instantiated into an object at runtime
let's create a private method named get
input from user
this method contains two parameters one
parameter of the user registration field
enum type and the other of the string
type
foreign
let's create a local string variable
named field vowel this string variable
will store the user's input
let's create a do Loop
the doolib's condition returns true if
the user's input is deemed invalid by
the field valid method
so when the field valid method returns
false within the while condition the
while condition returns true which means
the do Loop will perform a subsequent
iteration
the effect of this is an appropriate
message will be outputted to the user
instructing the user that the input just
entered is invalid the user will then be
prompted once again to enter a value for
the relevant field
so the user will be prompted for a
particular Field's value until the
user's input is deemed valid by the
validation code
let's write code within the do Loop to
prompt the user for the user's input for
the appropriate field
let's assign the user's input to the
field valve string variable
in the field valid method let's call the
validator Dell delegate and pass an
appropriate arguments
let's write code that will output text
in an appropriate format when the user
input is deemed as invalid
let's write code in the run view method
that will assign the user's input to a
space within the field array array if
the user's input is valid
let's write a private method that will
save the user's registration information
to the user's database table in our
sqlite database let's call the register
user private method from the run view
method
okay so let's create the login View
let's add a class to the Views folder
named user login View
let's write code to indicate that we
want the user login view to implement
the iview interface
let's Auto generate the iview members
that we must implement
let's set the Field validator property
to null because in this code example we
are not going to include validation on
the login fields
we could add a custom validator class
and Implement validation code for the
fields of this login view if we chose to
do so but in the interests of time let's
omit this functionality
let's create a Constructor that contains
a parameter of type I login
let's create a private member variable
of the type I login
let's assign the object argument that
will be injected into the user login
view classes constructed during the
instantiation of the user login view
class to this private member variable
So within the run view method let's
first write the application heading to
the screen and let's then write the
login heading to the screen so let's
make sure we are writing the main
heading to the screen within the run
view method of the user registration
view class
let's go back to the user login view
class
let's write code to prompt the user for
the user's email address let's assign
the user's input to a local string
variable
let's write code to prompt the user for
the user's password
and let's assign the user's input to a
local string variable let's call the
login method on the underscore login
user object and pass in the two local
variables containing the user's input
into the login method
and this method returns a user object if
the user is authenticated
so we need to check if the user object
is not null which means the login has
been successful
and we'll write a to-do comment for now
to indicate that we wish to implement
code here to run the welcome view when
the login is successful
we'll create the welcome view class in a
bit then replace the to-do comment with
the code to run the welcome view else if
the login is not successful we'll simply
clear the screen and output a message
stating that the user's entered
credentials do not match any of the
system's records
so let's create the welcome View
in the run view method of the user
welcome view class we are simply
outputting a message welcoming the user
to the Cycling Club
and let's replace the to do comment in
the run view method in the login view
class with code that creates a user
welcome view object that invokes the run
view method which displays a welcoming
message to the user on the console
screen
so let's create the main view class
we'll set the field validator to null
because this view doesn't have any
fields that require validation let's
Implement code in the run view method
let's write the application heading to
the console screen
let's prompt the user to press either
the L key to log in or the r key to
register
if the user presses the L key
the user will be presented with the
login screen
if the user presses the r key the user
will be presented with the registration
screen
so let's use the console.read key method
to capture the user's key press
let's create an if statement structure
so that the appropriate functionality
can be executed depending on which key
the user presses and let's simply write
goodbye to the screen when the user
presses a key that isn't L or R let's
create a Constructor that contains two
parameters
and let's create two corresponding
member variables
that will store the appropriate objects
that will be passed into this
Constructor at runtime
let's create a private method that will
run the user registration View
let's implement the code for this method
which simply invokes the run view method
on the user registration view object
which is of type I view
and let's also write a private method
that invokes the user login View
let's go back to the if statement
and if the user has pressed the r key we
want to present the user registration
View and once the user is successfully
registered we want to present the user
login View
if the user presses the L key the user
is presented with the login screen
so now we want to abstract the creation
of the main view object
let's create a class named Factory
let's make it a public static class
let's create a public static method
named get main view object that returns
an object of the iview type
let's create a login object this object
will be used to authenticate the user
but it looks like I forgot to implement
the authentication logic
so let's create a class within the data
folder and name it log in user
we are going to need two namespace
directives in this class
so let's create a namespace directive
for the club membership dot models
namespace and let's also create a
namespace directive for the system.link
namespace
this class must implement the I login
interface and let's Auto generate the
members of the ilogin interface that
must be implemented
so the I login interface only contains
one method a method named login
it contains two parameters one is a
string parameter for the user's email
address and the other is a string
parameter for the user's password
and now we can simply write code that
compares the user's email address and
password with the records stored in the
user's database table in our sqlite
database if the user is registered with
the application the first or default
extension method returns a user object
if the user is not registered with the
application null is returned
so let's go back to the factory class
and finish creating code that abstracts
the construction of the main view object
so in order to create the main view
object we must create an object derived
from the user login view class and an
object derived from the user
registration view class
in order to create an object derived
from the user login view class we must
first create an object of the I login
type
which will be injected into the
Constructor of the user login view class
when the user log in view class is
instantiated as an object
in order to create an object derived
from the user registration view class we
need to First create an object of type I
register
the user registration view classes
Constructor also contains a parameter
for a custom field validator object so
let's create an object of Type R field
validator that derives from the user
registration validator class
and in order to initialize the
validation delegates we must first call
the initialize validator delegates
method on the object derived from the
user registration validator class
so we can now create an object derived
from the user registration view class in
order to create the object successfully
we must inject an object derived from
the register user class and an object
derived from the user registration
validator class into the user
registration view classes Constructor we
can now also create an object derived
from the user login view class and
inject an object derived from the login
user class into the user login view
classes Constructor
we are now able to inject the object
derived from the user registration view
class and the object derived from the
user login view class into the main view
classes Constructor when constructing
the object derived from the main view
class
then we can write code to return this
object from the get main view object
method so notice something very
important that is going on here when we
construct our objects
all our classes Constructor parameters
are not concrete types
they are interface types
we are adhering to the dependency
inversion principle which is represented
by the last letter of the solid acronym
the dependency and version principle
states that classes should never depend
on concretions but rather should only
depend on abstractions
so in this method we have implemented
very basic dependency injection
functionality
so when the main view object is created
using the get main view object method an
object derived from the user login view
class and an object derived from the
user registration view class is
automatically injected into the main
view classes Constructor the main view
classes Constructor contains two
parameters that are of the iview type
the user registration view class
implements the iview interface and the
user login view class also implements
the iview interface
so now the way we have designed this
application should allow for the calling
client code to be rather simple
so in the main method we can simply get
an object derived from the main view
class by calling the factory classes get
main view object static method
see how clean the client code is
this is because we have abstracted away
all the complexities of constructing an
object derived from the main view class
then all we need to do is invoke the
object derived from the main view
classes run view method to run this
application
and that is our application pretty much
written
but inevitably there will be bugs Let's
test the code
let's press the r key so that we are
presented with the user registration
view where we'll register a user's
information
so let's leave the email address field
blank and press enter
okay and the required field validation
message should have been presented
so why has this not worked
okay so in the field valid method within
the user registration view class I
forgot to include a not operator in the
if condition where the appropriate field
validation delegate isn't worked to test
if the users input is valid
so we want to Output an appropriate
message to the user when a field is
deemed as invalid and subsequently
prompt the user to try again
Let's test the fix and this time step
through the codes to make sure that the
code is doing what we expected to do
so let's once again leave the email
field blank
great and this time the code that
outputs an appropriate invalid field
message is run
and what happens if we enter a valid
field value on our second attempt at
entering an email address
but this time we enter an invalid email
address format
great that is working as expected and
now let's enter a correct email address
and we have another bug
this email address has not been saved to
the system so why is our application
behaving is there a record with this
email address already exists in the
system right so this time it is because
I included a not operator where I should
not have done so let's remove the not
operator because we want a message to be
displayed when an email address already
exists in the system
Let's test the code again
great that is working as expected
so I don't like the formatting of the
prompts at the moment I want the user to
enter the user's information on the same
line as the prompt text
so let's make the appropriate fixes
let's use the console.write method
rather than the console.writeline method
to prompt the user for the user's input
and let's append a colon followed by a
space to The Prompt text for each of the
users can put prompts
okay so let's test the code let's enter
a valid email address
let's enter a valid first name
and let's enter an invalid last name and
that is working as expected we have
included validation code whereby the
first name and last name fields must
contain a character length between 2 and
100.
this time let's enter a valid last name
let's enter a valid password and for the
field where we have to re-enter our
password let's enter text that does not
match the password we entered
great so the comparison Fields
validation functionality is working
and this time let's re-enter our
password correctly let's enter a valid
date for the date of birth field
let's make up an address for the first
line of our address
and let's leave the second line of our
address blank
great so our validation message is
correctly advising that we must enter a
second line of our address
so on the second try let's enter a made
up second line for our address let's
enter a valid City
and let's enter a postcode in a correct
UK postcode format
great so we have successfully registered
Carl Smith as a member of the Cycling
Club
so let's press any key to continue to
the login screen
and let's enter our credentials
hi Carl welcome to the Cycling Club
great so we have successfully been
authenticated
but the welcome view should be displayed
on its own screen so let's fix this
in the run view method of the user
welcome view class let's clear the
console screen before displaying the
welcome message
so I've noticed that we are not being
prompted for a phone number so let's
navigate to the run view method in the
user registration view class and ensure
that the appropriate functionality for
the phone number field is added
okay let's test the code
and we can use the made updates of Carl
Smith again because I've removed the
record we added earlier from the user's
database table because an old value had
been added into the phone number field
so let's enter some made up but valid
data into the user registration form
and let's open our sqlite database named
Club membershipdb.db in the sqlite
browser client application
we can do this by dragging and dropping
the data file onto the sqlite browser
applications user interface like this
and we can now run a SQL query through
the sqlite browser client application to
check if the record for Carl Smith has
been added to the users table
and has the phone number been added
correctly this time yes it has great
let's enter another record Let's test
that we are now not able to enter Carl
Smith's email address into the email
field
great let's enter information for a
made-up character named Ethel Jones
and we can test some of the field
validation functionality along the way
[Music]
okay let's log in as Ethel Jones
excellent
let's log in as Carl Smith
great
[Music]
hi and welcome this tutorial is being
created to help with your understanding
of covariance and contravariance when
using delegates in C sharp in the first
part of this tutorial on delegates I've
mentioned that the return type and
parameter types of the method referenced
by a delegate object must match the
return type and parameter types defined
in the relevant delegates definition but
I also mentioned that the return type
and parameter types of the relevant
method definition don't have to match
with the relevant return type and
parameter types delegate definition
exactly
so what does this mean
the c-sharp language allows for the
developer to have a little bit of design
flexibility when it comes to a
delegate's compatibility with a method
covariance and contravariance provide
flexibility when matching a delegate
definition with a method definition
covariance permits a method to have a
return type that is more derived than
that defined and the relevant delegate
if you are unfamiliar with what is meant
for a class to be more derived or less
derived than another class that is a
member of the same inheritance hierarchy
please check out two tutorials which
were provided by this channel as part of
a c-sharp for beginners course one on
c-sharp inheritance and the other on
c-sharp polymorphism
a link to these tutorials can be
accessed from the cards in the right
hand corner of your screen and links to
these tutorials have also been included
Below in the description
Contra variants permits a method that is
parameter types that are less derived
than those in the relevant delegates
type
if you haven't yet subscribed please
consider subscribing and please ring the
bell so that you can be notified of
content on advanced c-sharp concepts and
much more
let's look at a code example where we
can demonstrate how covariance works
when using delegates in c-sharp
this example demonstrates how a delegate
object can reference a method that has a
return type that is derived from the
return type defined and the relevant
delegates definition
so I'm going to create two Factory
methods by Factory method Amino method
implemented for the abstraction of
constructing a specific object and
returning the relevant object to calling
code
the first method will return an object
of type ice car
which is a user-defined class that will
create representing a blueprint for an
object that can store information for an
ice car
the second method will return an object
of type EV car which is another
user-defined class that we'll create
representing a blueprint for an object
that can store information for an
electric car
both of these classes will inherit from
a base abstract class named car
we are going to create a delegate that
defines a method definition that
contains an ID parameter of type int and
a name parameter of type string
the delegate type will return the car
type which is the base abstract class
from which the class named ice car and a
class named EV car will inherit
this delegate type can be used to create
an object that can store reference to a
method that returns a type that is
derived from the car base type this is
at the heart of what covariances
regarding delegates
even though the return types of the
delegate and the method it references
are not an exact match because the
return type of the delegate is the base
class for the return type of the method
the c-sharp compiler allows the delegate
to reference the method
let's create a.net core console
application I'll name the project and
solution covariance and contravariance
delegate example
let's create an abstract class named car
let's add two auto-implemented
properties to the car user-defined class
one named ID of the integer data type
and the other named name of the string
dates type
let's add a virtual method that doesn't
contain any parameters and returns a
value of type string let's name this
method get car details
this method is very basic and returns an
interpolated string value containing the
values for the ID and the name
properties
so let's create our first class that
inherits from the car abstract class
let's name this class ice car
and we are going to keep this example
very basic so that we can focus our
attention on the topic of this tutorial
namely applying covariance and
contravariance when using delegates and
C sharp
so let's override the get card details
method
this method will simply return an
interpolated string value which will
contain a value returned from its base
method counterpart followed by the text
which will contain a hyphen followed by
the text internal combustion engine ice
and let's create a class that is very
similar to the ice car class but this
class will serve as a blueprint for
objects that store information about an
electric car so let's duplicate the ice
car class and change it so that it is
appropriate for our EV car class
so this class is named EV car
so the get card details method in the EV
car class will return an interpolated
string value containing a value returned
by its base method counterpart which
will contain the relevant car objects ID
and name property values followed by the
string literal hyphen Electric
so now let's create a factory class
let's name it car factory and let's make
this class a static class
and let's create a static method named
return ice car that returns an object of
type ice car
this method contains two parameters one
of type int and the other of type string
and the code for this method simply
returns an object derived from the ice
car type to the calling code
unless creates another method which is
almost identical to the return ice car
method the only difference being that
instead of returning an object derived
from the ice card type it returns an
object derived from the EV car type
so the question is can we reference
either of these two methods from a
delegate object where its delegate
definition is an almost exact match of
the return ice car method definition and
the return EV car method definition the
only difference being that the delegate
will Define a method definition that
Returns the car type
I.E a less derived type
so let's create a delegate named car
factory Dell
that defines a method definition that
contains two parameters one of type int
and the other of type string and returns
a value of type car
so in the main method let's define a
delegate named car factory Dell and
assign it the method name of return ice
car
the return ice car method returns an
object of type ice car and the delegate
definition Returns the car type
notice that the c-sharp compiler is not
complaining about this because the ice
car type derives from the car type and
covariance is allowed in C sharp so
let's write code to execute the delegate
and assignee object to a variable named
ice car
so we'll give this car object an ID of
one and a name of Audi R8
let's write code to write the type of
the object to screen
let's write code to execute the objects
get card details method
to retrieve the object's available
information and write this information
to the screen
and let's use the same delegate type to
reference the return EV car method
the EV card type is derived from the car
type
so because covariance is permitted in
the c-sharp language
the return EV car method is deemed as
compatible with the car factory Dell
delegate
let's run the code
and we have successfully demonstrated
how covariance can work when using
delegates in c-sharp
so let's demonstrate how contravariance
can work when using delegates and C
sharp
so to demonstrate contravariance when
using delegates and c-sharp we are going
to create two delegates
both delegates will be used to reference
a method used for logging information
about a car
both delegate definitions will not
return values the first delegate
definition contains one parameter of the
ice car type
the second delegate's definition
contains one parameter of the EV card
type
the key to relating this example to
contravariance is that both of these
delegates contain one parameter that
inherits from a car type
note the two delegate definitions
contain a parameter that is more derived
than the parameter contained in the
method that these delegates will
reference
the method that both of these delegates
will reference will contain one
parameter of type car
the method will not return a value
so let's first remove the lines of code
not needed in this example demonstrating
how contravariance Works in C sharp when
using delegates
let's create the first delegate and
we'll name it log ice car details Dell
let's create the second delegate and
we'll name it log EV card details Dell
and now let's create the static method
that will be referenced by both of these
delegates
we'll name this method log car details
and notice how the parameter contained
in its method definition is of type car
note that the delegates that will
reference this method will contain
parameters that inherit from the car
type
so let's implement the code for this
method
the logic for this method is that if the
type of object passed in as an argument
to this method is of type ice car log
the car's object type and information to
a text file
we'll use the
appdomain.currentdomain.base directory
property to establish the path of the
relevant text file so that it is created
in the same path from where our code
will execute
else if the type of object passed into
the log car details method is of type EV
car log the car's object type and
information to the console screen
else throw an argument exception
so let's run code to reference the log
card details method from our log ice car
details Dell delegate
let's write code to execute the log ice
card details Dell delegate
let's write code to reference the
logcard details method from our log EV
car details Dell delegate
let's write code to execute the log EV
card details Dell delegate
notice that even though the parameter
contained in the log ice car details
Dell delegate definition is not an exact
match of the parameter contained in the
log car details method definition the
c-sharp compiler does not complain when
we write code where the log ice car
details Dell delegate references the log
car details method
and the same is true when we write code
where the log EV card details Dell
delegate object references the log car
details method
this is because the parameter type
contained in the log ice car details
delegate definition inherits from the
parameter type contained in the logcard
details method definition
and the parameter type contained in the
log EV car details Dell delegate
definition inherits from the parameter
type contained in the logcard details
method definition
this example demonstrates contravariance
when using delegates in C sharp where a
delegates parameter may not match
exactly with a parameter of a method
that the relevant delegate object
references but if the relevant parameter
in the relevant method definition is
part of the same inheritance hierarchy
and is less derived than the relevant
delegates parameter this is allowed
because contravariance is permitted in
the c-sharp language
let's run the code
and this is an expected result
let's see if the EV car's information
has been logged to the relevant text
file
[Music]
great
I hope you've enjoyed this tutorial on
understanding covariance and
contravariance when using delegates in C
sharp
this is the fourth part of a video
series on delegates
in this video we'll look at the funk
action and predicate built-in generic
delegates
so before we dive into this topic we
must have at least a basic understanding
of generics
generics is a topic that we'll explore
in detail in upcoming videos but for now
a basic understanding will suffice
so what is generics in c-sharp version 2
generics was introduced
generics makes it possible to for
example design classes methods and
delegates that defer the specification
of one or more types until the class
method or delegate is declared and
instantiated by client code
use generic types to maximize code reuse
type safety and performance
a developer can create generic
interfaces classes methods events and
delegates
in this video we'll look at three types
of generic delegates that are provided
in the c-sharp language namely Funk
action and predicate all of these
generic delegates are available in the
system namespace
let's look at an overview of each of
these built-in generic delegates before
we look at basic code examples
demonstrating their implementation
so let's first look at funk
in this depiction we can see the basic
structure for a funk delegate
the T represents a placeholder where the
developer can pass a type parameter in
order to strongly type the parameter
relevance to the encapsulated method at
compile time
in keyword in this context means that
the parameter type is contravariant
we are not going to be discussing
covariance and contravariance in this
video because these topics were
discussed in detail in the previous
tutorial
foreign
[Music]
there are 17 Funk delegates available in
the system namespace
this funk Delegate for example can be
used to encapsulate a method that
contains no parameters and returns a
value
There are 16 more Funk delegates here is
a fund delegate that contains one
perimeter and returns a value here's
another Funk delegate that contains two
parameters and returns a value
Funk delegate definitions always return
a value the return type is always
defined in the last type parameter and
the available func delegates allow for 0
to 16 parameter type definitions
note that the last parameter declared in
the funk generic delegate defines the
type of The Returned value of the method
that the func delegate encapsulates
the out keyword in this context means
that the return type is covariant
the action generic delegates allow
developer to encapsulate a method that
can have 0 to 16 parameters and must not
return a value
the predicate's generic delegate
encapsulates a method that contains one
parameter and returns a value that must
be of the Boolean data type a predicate
delegate represents a method that
defines a set of criteria and determines
whether the specified object meets those
criteria
let's look at code examples using each
of the built-in generic delegates I.E
func action and predicate
at the end of the tutorial we'll look at
an example of using an extension method
that takes a predicate as an argument
let's start by looking at an example
using the funk built-in generic delegate
let's create a.net core console project
I'll name this project and solution func
action predicate examples
[Music]
thank you
let's create a public class named math
class
and add one method named sum the sum
method contains two parameters of the
int data type and returns a value of the
end data type
this method simply Returns the integer
result of the sum of two integer
arguments passed into this method
let's instantiate the math class in the
main method let's use the generic
built-in Funk delegates to encapsulate
the sum method
altar parameters passed into the funk
delegate are of the in-states type
the last type parameter represents the
return type and the first two type
parameters represent the methods
parameters data types
so as you can see through the use of
generics we have made our Funk delegate
compatible with the sum instance method
we have strongly typed the funk delegate
with the in-states type for the
parameter types and the return type
we can therefore use the func delegate
to encapsulate the sum method
let's write code to execute the delegate
and then code to write the results to
the screen
Let's test the code
great
we can replace the sum method with an
anonymous method using the delegate
keyword like this
an anonymous method is as the name
suggests a method that does not have a
name
Let's test the code
great
we can further abstract the method by
removing the delegate keyword the return
keyword
the curly brackets
and the parameter type definitions
so here we have now reduced the
functionality of the sum method to a
Lambda expression
a Lambda expression is an anonymous
function which as discussed is a defined
function not bound to an identifier
we previously created the same function
using the delegate keyword a Lambda
expression is a shorter way of
representing an anonymous method
Lambda Expressions were introduced in C
sharp version 3 along with link
for more information on link please
navigate to this URL
Let's test our code
excellent
to further understand the func generic
built in delegates let's create our own
imitations of a few of the built-in Funk
delegates let's call our delegates funk
2.
foreign
keyword with func 2 in our code
great
but we don't need to do this because
appropriate generic delegates are
already available to us in the system
namespace
let's create a slightly more complex
example where our delegate encapsulates
a Lambda expression that performs the
functionality of adding two operands of
the float data type together then
multiplies the result of this operation
by a value that is of the int data type
great
let's create a more practical example
where our Lambda expression adds a bonus
to an employee's annual salary
foreign
so let's look at some examples using the
action generic built-in delegate
so in this example let's create a Lambda
expression that accepts fields for an
employee record as arguments and outputs
the employee details to the console
screen
note that the action delegate is used to
encapsulate a method that does not
return a value
so in this example we'll output three
fields of an employee record to the
console screen ID first name and last
name
foreign
let's add an annual salary field
so to do this we can use a different
action delegate to accommodate this new
field
let's update the Lambda expression
accordingly
let's add a gender field which is of the
Char dates type and the Boolean field
representing whether an employee is a
manager or not a manager
so to achieve this we need to use a
different action delegate that can
accommodate the two new fields
foreign
excellent
so let's use an example where we'll use
the predicate built in generic delegate
let's first create an employee class
let's create a generic list that will
contain four objects of the employee
data type
let's add some employee objects that
contain made up employee details to the
employees list
foreign
that will filter the employees list
based on criteria that will be passed to
the method in the form of a predicate
so this method simply traverses the
employees list if employee items within
the list meet the criteria of the
predicate passed into the method
the relevant item is added to another
list that is returned to the calling
code once all the items in the original
list passed into this method have been
traversed and evaluated
so let's call the filter employees
method and pass in the employees list
followed by the Lambda expression which
is encapsulated by a predicate delegate
let's say our Lambda expression in this
example is used to return only mail
employees
let's write code to Traverse the list
returned by the filter employees method
and use the display employee Records
action delegate which I have now renamed
to display employee details just for
better readability that we created in
the previous example to write the
relevant employee records to the console
screen
Let's test the code
great
let's alter the logic of our predicate
so that we return only details for
employees that earn less than 45 000 a
year
great
let's alter our logic so that we only
return employee details for employees
that are managers
great
so we can abstract this code even
further through the use of an extension
method
so let's create a public static class
named extensions
let's copy the filter employees method
to our extensions static class
let's make the filter employees method
public and it must also be static then
to finish making this method an
extension method all we need to do is
add the this keyword before the first
parameter
the first parameter is defined as a
generic list that is strongly typed with
the employee user defined type
so the filter employee extension method
should now automatically be available on
generic lists that are strongly typed
with the employee user-defined type in
our main method
if you are not clear on extension
methods don't worry extension methods
will be discussed in detail in upcoming
tutorials
basically three extension methods the
developer can add methods to existing
types without creating a new derived
type recompiling or modifying the
original type
so let's see if we can access the filter
employees method on the employees
generic list and there it is
it shows up in the intellisense as
expected
so we no longer need to pass the
employees list to the filter employees
method as a parameter and all we need to
do is pass in the Lambda expression
Let's test the code
[Music]
great
the system.linknamespace contains a
number of extension methods let's
demonstrate how we can use an extension
method which is available in the
system.link namespace to achieve the
same result
link is beyond the scope of this
tutorial we'll look at Link in detail in
upcoming videos
[Music]
let's include a directive to the
system.link namespace at the top of our
code
the where extension method is available
on the generic I enumerable type
the generic list type implements the
innumerable generic interface so now
that we have added the system.link
directive the where extension method
should now be available on the employees
list object
so let's replace the filter employees
method with the where method
the where method returns a value of type
I innumerable so we must convert our
result to a generic list using the to
list explicit conversion method
Let's test the code
[Music]
great
so let's finish up by using the funk
delegate that we created earlier to add
a bonus to the employee annual salary
fields of each of our employee objects
stored in the employees list
[Music]
Let's test the code
foreign
excellent
I hope you've enjoyed this tutorial on
the three built-in generic delegates
namely Funk action and predicate
hi and welcome this is the fifth part of
a video series on delegates
this is also the final part of this
video series on delegates but there are
a lot more upcoming videos to be
released as part of this Advanced
c-sharp course
in this video we'll look at how
delegates can be used to encapsulate a
callback method
so what is a callback method basically
callbacks are simple functions which are
used to notify the calling instance when
an asynchronous code block has been
executed and the result is available
so I found a great code example on a
Microsoft docs webpage that uses a
callback method encapsulated by a
delegate to run code when asynchronous
tasks have completed
the code in this code sample performs a
basic function of retrieving the IP
addresses associated with user-inputted
domain names using the.net built-in DNS
static class
for example if we input microsoft.com
the DNS class behind the scenes as it
were asynchronously looks up the IP
addresses associated with the
microsoft.com domain name
I'm going to Simply copy this sample
code demonstrating the use of a callback
method interp.net core console
application
we can then demonstrate the code and go
through the code step by step to
understand how it works basically this
code demonstrates using asynchronous
methods available in the built-in DNS
static class to retrieve domain name
system information for user-specified
domain names
you can navigate to this URL to copy the
relevant sample code as well as read
more information about the sample code
the link to this URL has also been
included Below in the description
so let's create a.net core console
application
let's name this project and solution DNS
async callback sample code
let's copy the code from the relevant
web page and paste it into the project
we have just created
so to do this we can select all the code
that has been Auto generated in our
program.cs class file and paste the code
currently copied to our clipboards over
the selected code right so let's start
by running the code
so let's enter a few well-known domain
names
this code has been written so that we
can press the enter key without entering
anything at the input prompt as an
indication that we are finished
inputting our data so let's enter a few
domain names
so for the first entry let's enter
google.com
for the second entry let's enter
microsoft.com
and for the third entry let's enter
yahoo.com
right let's press the enter key without
entering anything at the command prompt
to indicate that we are finished
inputting our data
and then the output presented to the
screen we can see three headings namely
addresses for Google addresses for
Microsoft and addresses for Yahoo
under these headings are the IP
addresses relevant to the domain names
that we have entered
if you're interested in reading more
about what DNS IE domain name system is
please navigate to this URL
so let's go through the code to see how
a delegate is used to encapsulate a
method that is used as a callback method
through the execution of the relevant
delegate once relevant asynchronous
tasks have been completed
so the first line of code in the main
method instantiates a delegate named
async callback
this delegate is built into.net and is
provided specifically for the purpose of
encapsulating callback methods that are
used during asynchronous operations
so I'm going to right click the delegate
name in the visual studio code editor
and click the context menu item named go
to definition
and here we are presented with the
delegate definition of the async
Callback delegate this delegate can
encapsulate a method that doesn't return
a value and contains one parameter of
the I async result type
and if we look at the I async result
type this interface provides a standard
definition for objects that are passed
as an argument to the Callback method
the relevant object that implements the
I async result interface represents the
status of an asynchronous operation
you can see here the async state
read-only property gets a user-defined
object that qualifies or contains
information about an asynchronous
operation
okay so let's go back to our code and
you'll see that a method name is passed
into the Constructor of the async
Callback delegate in the code written
for the purpose of instantiating an
object derived from the async Callback
delegate type
so our callback method is named
processdns information
let's have a brief look at this method
you can see its method signature
conforms to the method definition
defined in the async Callback delegate
so we'll come back to this method in a
bit for now let's go back to the code in
the main method so next the code is
prompting the user for domain names
and you can see that for each entry the
DNS dot begin get host entry method is
fired
DNS is a static class provided in.net
and provides simple domain name
resolution functionality
the DNS dot begin get host entry method
asynchronously Returns the Internet
Protocol IP addresses for the specified
host
you can see that our delegate named
callback that encapsulates our callback
method named process DNS information is
passed as an argument to the DNS dot
begin get host entry method
here the code essentially informs the
DNS static class of the memory address
of our designated callback method which
is stored in the Callback delegate
object
note that above this line of code we
have a line of code that increments an
integer variable named request counter
the number of asynchronous tasks is
stored in the integer variable
now the reason why this incrementation
is done in an unusual way here whereby
the.net built-in interlocked dot
increment method is used for this
purpose
is because each time our asynchronous
process is kicked off as it were by the
DNS dot begin get host entry method a
new thread is created and executed in
parallel asynchronously to the main
thread
when each asynchronous process is
finished processing
the Callback method is executed on the
main thread and if we go back to our
callback method you can see that each
time an asynchronous task completes the
request counter variables value is
decremented within the process DNS
information callback method so because
the timing of when this callback method
will be called by potentially multiple
threads is uncertain we must ensure that
the request counter variable is updated
in a thread-safe way multi-threading
solves problems with throughput and
responsiveness but in doing so it
introduces new problems Deadlocks and
race conditions
for more information in this regard
please navigate to this URL
so the next line of code monitors the
state of the value of the request
counter variable
when the request counter variable's
value is zero we know that all
asynchronous tasks have completed which
means our output data is ready to be
presented to the screen
so this while loop ensures that if our
asynchronous tasks have not yet
completed that the subsequent lines of
code responsible for outputting the
results of the asynchronous tasks are
only executed once the asynchronous
tasks have completed
so this while loop will continue
processing and outputting Status
information to the screen until the
request counter variable has been
decremented to xero within the Callback
method I.E the process DNS information
method so let's look at the process DNS
information callback method and you can
see the
dns.get host entry method is called to
return the result of an asynchronous
task the dns.beginget host entry method
and the dns.get host entry method
are used for asynchronous processing
the dns.get host entry method gets
called from within the Callback method
remember a reference to the Callback
method was passed as an argument to the
dns.beginget host entry method
this was done by passing the async
Callback delegate object stored in a
variable named callback to the
dns.beginget host entry method as an
argument
remember an async callback delegate
object
was coded to encapsulate the process DNS
information method within the main
method this object was then passed as an
argument to the DNS dot begin get host
entry method
so the application knows that an
asynchronous task has completed because
at this stage the Callback method
process DNS information method has been
invoked So within the Callback method it
is safe to call the dns.get host entry
method to return the result of the
asynchronous task to the calling code so
the results here are stored in an
arraylist member variable named host
data the host data arraylist can be used
to retrieve the relevant results
and present the relevant results to the
console screen and you can see the code
here in the main method responsible for
outputting the results of each
asynchronous task to the console screen
so the IP address is relevant to the
domain names entered by the user are
written to the console screen
let's run the code and enter some domain
names
excellent
note that the code we have just
demonstrated here uses the asynchronous
programming model APM pattern also
called the I async result pattern which
is the Legacy model that uses the I
async result interface to provide
asynchronous Behavior
Microsoft recommends moving forward that
we use the task-based asynchronous
pattern tab for asynchronous programming
which uses a single method to represent
the initiation and completion of an
asynchronous operation
the async and await keywords in c-sharp
add language support for the task-based
asynchronous pattern
we'll look at the task-based
asynchronous pattern tab in detail in
upcoming tutorials
this video serves as a demonstration of
how delegates can be used to encapsulate
callback methods and also serves as a
brief introduction to asynchronous
programming
we'll look at the recommended approach
to asynchronous programming I.E the
task-based asynchronous pattern tab in
upcoming videos
please navigate to this URL for more
information on asynchronous programming
patterns available in c-sharp
summarize
in this five part video series on
delegates we discussed that a delegate
is a reference type in c-sharp that
references a method that contains a
particular parameter list and return
type we discussed that due to a concept
called variance the delegate definition
does not have to exactly match the
parameter types or the return type of
the method that it encapsulates
contravariance means that a delegate for
example can reference a method where a
particular parameter in the delegates
definition is more derived than the
parameter counterpart contained within
the method that it encapsulates
covariance means that the return type in
the delegates definition can be less
derived than the return type of the
method that it encapsulates
we looked at three built-in generic
delegates namely Funk action and
predicate we looked at how these generic
delegates can be used in code for better
code reuse type safety and to improve
performance we also briefly looked at
Anonymous methods Lambda expressions and
extension methods
in this final video on delegates we
looked at how a delegate can be used to
encapsulate a callback method that can
be called once an asynchronous task is
completed
we haven't looked at delegates in
relation to events yet an upcoming
tutorial on events will include how
delegates are used in relation to events
in C sharp I hope you have enjoyed this
tutorial on asynchronous programming
using delegates to encapsulate callback
methods
and I hope you've enjoyed this video
series on delegates if you didn't fully
understand all the concepts discussed in
this video please don't worry the more
you practice the more you'll understand
and the more proficient you'll become as
a software engineer learning to become a
proficient software engineer is a
marathon and not a Sprint I'd also like
to add that I think it is more important
to understand the concepts behind the
code rather than the code itself
[Music]
hi and welcome
this is the first part of a tutorial on
c-sharp events
in this video we'll look at the basics
of c-sharp events by examining a piece
of code taken from a Microsoft docs web
page
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts like this and much more please
consider subscribing and please ring the
bell so that you'll be notified of
future releases from this channel
I usually use my Windows PC to record my
demonstrations but I've decided to
demonstrate this code example using
visual studio 2019 Community Edition for
Mac
it doesn't ultimately matter which code
editor you use if you want to follow
along
it makes no difference because this
video is about the code more
specifically about the basics of what
events are and how they relate to
delegates
so I'm going to use Visual Studio 2019
for Mac Community Edition to create
a.net core console project
you can name it what you like
I'll name this project threshold reached
event application
I'm going to copy the code from the
appropriate Microsoft docs web page and
paste it over the code in the program.cs
file like this
code sample is available at this URL
so the code here performs a very basic
function
it first generates a random integer
value which can be any non-zero integer
value where the maximum value is 10.
the centage of value serves in this
example as a threshold value
the code then prompts the user to press
the a key to increment an integer value
by a value of 1.
when the integer value has been
incremented to the extent that it
reaches the threshold value I.E the
generated random integer value and event
is raised and the calling code handles
the raised event by outputting text
stating that the threshold value has
been reached
the text also includes the date and time
when the threshold value was reached by
the value that the user is able to
increment by pressing the a key
so let's start by running the code and
then we'll look at the code in order to
see how an event and a delegate have
been implemented in the code
let's press the a key until the
threshold is reached
and the threshold has been reached so
the event is raised and the event
handler outputs appropriate text to the
console screen
so what exactly is an event in C sharp
events are special kinds of multicast
delegates that can only be invoked from
within the class or struct where they
are declared
if other classes or structs subscribe to
the event their event handler methods
will be called when the class where the
delegate has been declared raises the
event
[Music]
events can be marked as public private
protected internal protected internal or
private protected these access modifiers
Define how users of the class can access
the event for more information on access
modifiers please navigate to this URL
events.net are based on the delegate
model the delegate model follows the
Observer design pattern
which enables the subscriber to register
with and receive notifications from a
provider
we'll discuss the Observer design
pattern in an upcoming video
an event sender pushes a notification
that an event has happened and an event
receiver receives the notification and
defines a response to it an event is a
message sent by an object to Signal the
occurrence of an action delegates were
explored in detail in the last tutorial
the third part of this course links to
the playlist on delegates have been
included Below in the description you
can also access this playlist through
the card available in the top right hand
corner of your screen
let's recap what is a delegate a
delegate is a type that holds a
reference to a method a delegate is
declared with a signature that shows the
return type and parameters for the
method it references
and it can hold references only to
methods that match its signature a
delegate is thus equivalent to a type
safe function pointer or a callback
a delegate declaration is sufficient to
define a delegate class
right let's look at our code example to
see how an event can be implemented in C
sharp so an event can be fired through a
user action for example button press or
through the code logic itself in this
example the event is raised through the
code logic
here we have a user-defined class named
counter where an event is declared the
name of the event is threshold reached
let's look at how this event is defined
so this event has a public access
modifier
and to Define an event we must use the
event keyword then the event keyword is
followed by a built-in c-sharp delegate
named event handler delegates have many
uses in.net in the context of events a
delegate is an intermediary or
pointer-like mechanism between the Event
Source and the code that handles the
event
you associate a delegate with an event
by including the delegate type in the
event declaration
let's select the event handler delegate
name in the code editor
let's right click and select the go to
declaration menu option
if you are using visual Studio for
Windows this context menu item will be
marked go to definition
so here you can see the event handler
delegate declaration that can be used to
store reference to a method that
contains a matching parameter list and
return type to the event handlers
parameter list and return type in the
delegate definition
this is a built-in delegate provided in
the system namespace
notice the T event args generic
parameter there is another built-in
event handler delegate of the same name
also provided in the system namespace
this particular delegate declaration
looks like this
the difference between this delegate and
the one we are using
is you are restricted to using the event
args class to provide event data to the
event handler method using this delegate
notice that in the definition of the
event-handed delegate that we are using
we are able to provide a type parameter
through generics
this means we are not restricted to the
use of the event args class to pass data
to the event handler method and we can
use a custom class for this purpose
here you can see we are using the
threshold reached event args custom
class where data are about an event can
be stored in two public properties
namely threshold and time reached
so this event handler delegate contains
two parameters in its delegate
definition
the first parameters of type object
which allows for the calling code event
handler method to accept an argument
that references an object instance
derived from the class where the
relevant event resides
that this keyword can be used as a
reference to the object that contains
the event
so that this keyword can be used to pass
a reference of the sender object
to the appropriate event handler method
when the relevant event is raised
the second parameter through generics
allows the developer to define a type
for this parameter
the advantage of being able to use
generics
with this delegate is that we are able
to create our own custom user-defined
type that can contain the relevant event
data which can be passed as an argument
to an appropriate event handler method
in the calling code
so let's look at a basic overview of the
counterclass I.E the user-defined type
where our event is declared
here we have two member variables both
of the integer data type
one to store the threshold value the
other to store value that will be
incremented by the user so the threshold
value is passed through by the calling
code through a parameterized Constructor
when the calling code instantiates an
object derived from the counter class
the past in argument is then stored in
the member variable named threshold
let's look at the add method
this method can be used to increment the
member variable names total
the value stored in the total member
variable is then compared to the values
stored
in the threshold member variable
if the value stored in the total
variable
which is incremented by the user reaches
the value stored in the threshold
variable and event is raised
let's look at the code responsible for
raising the relevant event
firstly an object derived from the
threshold reached event args class is
instantiated the threshold reached event
args used to define type is the custom
type we have passed as a parameter to
the event handler delegate
an object instantiated from the
threshold reached event args class can
be used to store event information
if you look at the threshold reached
event args class you can see that it
contains two properties one named
threshold for storing the threshold
value and the other named time reached
when the user incremented value stored
in the total member variable reached the
value stored in the threshold member
variable so these two properties are
appropriately set on an object derived
from the threshold reached event args
class
this object is then passed into a method
named on threshold reached the on
threshold reached method contains the
logic for raising the appropriate event
in this method code is first created
where a variable named Handler is used
for referencing the threshold reached
event
the next line of code is an if statement
checking if the Handler variable
contains a value
if the Handler variable is null this
means that calling code has not
subscribed to the relevant event
which means no appropriate method has
been designated on the client calling
code to handle the relevant event when
the event is raised
in a bit we'll look at how a calling
client can subscribe to an event that
resides in a particular class
so if however calling client code has
subscribed to the relevant event the
Handler delegate is invoked
this delegate will point to a method
that has been defined in the calling
client code
the relevant method is designated to
handle the relevant event at the point
where the calling client subscribes to
the relevant event
so let's look at the calling client code
let's go to the main method so the first
line of code is instantiating an object
derived from the counter class
note that the random.next method is
being used to pass a non-negative random
integer that is less than the specified
maximum which in this case is hard coded
to a value of 10.
so the randomly generated number is our
threshold
which will be stored in the relevant
object derived from the counter class
so the object derived from the
counterclass is stored in a variable
named C
using the object referenced by the C
variable we are now able to subscribe to
the event named threshold reached which
is declared in the counter class
so the code here is assigned a method
that resides in the program class to the
threshold reached event we can do this
because the method named C underscore
threshold reached is compatible with the
event handler delegate in other words
the parameter list and the return type
of the C threshold reached method
definition matches the parameter list
and return type of the event handler
delegate definition
the effect of this is that when the
threshold reached event is raised from
the add method within the counterclass
the subscribed method in the calling
code IE the C underscore threshold
reached method will be invoked
a reference to the relevant object
derived from the counterclause or sender
object is passed in to the C underscore
threshold reached method as well as the
object that stores the relevant event
data in this case the object arrived
from the threshold reached event args
class
note how in this example the event
handler delegate is an abstraction
that allows any calling client that
contains a method with a method
definition that matches the event
handler delegate definition to handle
what happens when the relevant event is
raised
this means the calling client is Loosely
coupled with the class where the event
is declared
you see the calling code doesn't have to
know anything about the class where the
event is declared and the class where
the event is declared doesn't need to
know anything about the calling code
the event handler delegate in this case
is used to establish a loose coupling
this is a key concept to understand when
it comes to using events in C sharp how
delegates can be used to create a loose
coupling between components
so let's watch this in action let's put
a breakpoint in the code to a point
where the value incremented by the user
has reached the threshold value and the
event is about to fire
we can then see what happens when the
threshold reached event is raised
let's run the code
and let's press the a key to increment
the value that is compared to the
threshold value until our breakpoint is
hit which means the user incremented
value matches the threshold value
and there it is a breakpoint has been
hit
so a variable named Handler is set to
the threshold reached event the code
checks if their Handler variable is null
if the Handler variable is not null this
means the calling code has subscribed to
the event
so I'm going to put a break within the C
underscore threshold reached method
which is the designated method for
handling the relevant event
and when we step through the code the
threshold reached event is raised the C
underscore threshold reach method is
invoked and the C underscore threshold
reached method handles the event in the
custom way that the method has been
coded
and if we look at the values associated
with the two arguments passed into the C
underscore threshold reached method we
can see that this is an expected result
we have the sender object which is the
object from where the event was raised
and we have an object derived from the
threshold reached event args class where
the relevant event data is stored
and let's press F5 to run the code right
through and you can see the expected
output presented to the screen
I hope you've enjoyed this video on the
basics of events in c-sharp please
consider subscribing for more content on
advanced c-sharp concepts like this and
much more
and please ring the bell so that you can
be notified of future content released
by this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please consider
hitting the like button and please feel
free to share any of my videos with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content a link to the Microsoft web page
that contains the code example I have
used in this video is available Below in
the description
[Music]
thank you
hi and welcome this video is the second
part of a tutorial on events in C sharp
in this video we'll create a practical
example where multiple events exist in a
class
we'll look at using add and remove
accesses to encapsulate the
functionality that gets executed when
client code or calling code subscribes
or unsubscribes to the relevant events
code within the add accessor is executed
when the client code subscribes to the
relevant event code within the remove
accessor is executed when the client
code unsubscribes to the relevant event
we'll use the event handler list
built-in c-sharp collection class to
store the relevant delegates associated
with the relevant events when the
calling code subscribes
the event handler list collection class
is a built-in c-sharp collection class
that can be found in the
system.component model namespace and is
a collection specially suited for
storing delegates
so here's the basic idea behind this
code example a device could be any
device contains a thermostat which
contains a heat sensor as well as a
cooling mechanism
so we'll have a class to represent the
device a class to represent the heat
sensor and a class to represent the
cooling mechanism each of these classes
will Implement an appropriate interface
so the heat sensor class will contain
three events one event that gets fired
when the temperature of the device
reaches or goes above 27 degrees Celsius
which is 80.6 degrees Fahrenheit
this event Flags a warning alert a
cooling mechanism is switched on to cool
the device back down to an acceptable
temperature we'll create another event
that gets fired when the temperature of
the device has reached or gone above 27
degrees Celsius and then subsequently
Falls below 27 degrees Celsius this
event Flags an informational alert and
the cooling mechanism is Switched Off
and lastly we'll create an event that
gets fired when the temperature reaches
or goes above 75 degrees Celsius which
is 167 degrees Fahrenheit
this event Flags an emergency alert the
device is shut down and Emergency
Services Personnel are notified about
the event
foreign we discussed in the previous
part of this tutorial that an event is
raised either by the user's action for
example the user clicks a button or the
code logic itself in this example we are
going to use codelogic to raise specific
events
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts like this and much more please
consider subscribing and please ring the
bell so that you will be notified of
future releases from this channel
right let's get started
let's create a.net core console app and
let's name this project and solution
thermostat Events app
[Music]
let's start by building a custom class
to store our event information let's
name this class temperature event args
and let's make this class inherit from
the c-sharp built-in event args class
we want our custom class to store the
current temperature
so this will be the temperature at the
time when an event is raised and we also
want to store the date and time when the
event was raised so let's create an auto
implemented property named temperature
and Define it as the double data type
let's create another autoimplemented
property named current date time and
Define it as the date time date type
next let's create an interface named I
heat sensor
and we'll include definitions for three
events in the eye heat sensor interface
all the events are associated with the
built-in c-sharp delegate named event
handler
and here we can pass our custom class
the one we have just created named
temperature event args that will be used
to store event information as a generic
parameter to the event handler delegate
so let's create a definition for an
event that will be fired when the
temperature reaches or exceeds a
predefined emergency level
let's create a definition for an event
that will be fired when the temperature
reaches or exceeds a predefined warning
level and lastly let's define an event
that will be fired when the temperature
has reached or exceeded the warning
level and subsequently Falls below the
warning level
so next let's create a heat tensor class
to implement the eye heat sensor
interface and we want to explicitly
implement the events defined in our eye
heat sensor interface for the heat
sensor class
so one way we can do this is hover our
Mouse pointers over the red squiggly
line under the eye heat sensor text then
select show potential fixes and then
select Implement interface explicitly
and now you can see Visual Studio has
created our event implementations with
add and remove accesses
note that these add and remove accesses
are very similar to the get and set
accesses that are implemented for
c-sharp read write properties
the add accesses will contain code that
is fired when the client code subscribes
to the relevant event the remove
accesses will contain code that is fired
when a client unsubscribes to the
relevant event
so we'll add code to the add and remove
accesses in a bit
so one thing I forgot to do was include
a method definition for running the heat
sensor
let's include the appropriate method
definition in the eye heat sensor
interface
and now you can see a red squiggly line
under the eye heat sensor text in the
class definition for the heat sensor
class this is because we are not
implementing all the members of the eye
heat sensor interface
so to fix this we can hover our Mouse
pointers over the red squiggly line
click show potential fixes and then
click Implement interface and you can
see that Visual Studio generates a
method implementation for the method
that we had not yet implemented for the
eye heat sensor interface the Run heat
sensor method
we'll Implement code for the Run heat
sensor method a bit later let's create
two member variables at the top of the
heat sensor class
both defined as double
the first member variable is named
warning level and the second member
variable is named emergency level
these member variables will store values
that serve as our triggers for when a
relevant event should be raised for
example if the temperature of the device
rises above the emergency level the
appropriate emergency event is raised so
let's set these values within a
parameterized Constructor
so let's create a member variable named
underscore has reached warning
temperature and this is defined as the
Boolean data type
we'll see the significance of this
member variable in a bit
let's create another member variable
which will reference a collection of
delegates associated with the events
implemented in this class we could use
any of the appropriate collection
classes in c-sharp for storing these
delegate objects but we are going to use
the built-in c-sharp event handler list
class for this purpose
so to use the event handler list class
like this we must include a directive to
the system dot component model namespace
at the top of our code
as mentioned earlier the event handler
list class is a member of the system dot
component model namespace we are going
to use the event handler list classes
add event handler method to add the
appropriate delegates
the add event handler method accepts a
key value of type object for its first
argument this object value serves as a
unique key for accessing values in the
collection
and its second argument is a value of
type delegate
the event handler list collection class
allows the developer to store delegates
that can be accessed within the
collection using a unique key
we are also going to implement code
using the remove event handler method to
remove delegate objects from the
relevant collection
the method definition for the remove
event handler method is the same as the
method definition for the add event
handler method definition
please navigate to this URL for more
information on the event handler list
class
so let's create three static read-only
objects which will serve as key values
that can be used to access the relevant
delegates from within the event handler
list collection let's create another
private member variable which is an
array of the double type named
underscore temperature data so this
array will Store Mock data to simulate
data coming from the heat sensor at
regular time periods so this data will
be used to simulate the heat sensor
outputting temperature data
so let's create a method named seed data
and populate the underscore temperature
data array with data
note that I'm deliberately including
temperature data that is greater in
value than 27 which will be used as our
warning level
and toward the end data that is greater
in value than the emergency level which
will be set to a value of 75.
this is so we can raise our events
appropriately when the heat sensor
outputs our mock values
okay so now let's implement the code for
the add and remove accesses for the
events that reside in the heat sensor
class
so in the add accesses all we want to do
here is add the appropriate delegate to
the event list Handler collection which
is done at the point where the client
code subscribes to the relevant event
so in the remove accesses all we want to
do is remove the appropriate delegate
from the event list Handler collection
and this is done at the point where the
client code unsubscribes to the relevant
event
you can see we are using the appropriate
key objects when adding the relevant
delegates to the collection
we are also able to use the appropriate
key to remove the relevant delegate from
our event list Handler collection
so let's encapsulate functionality for
raising the relevant events by creating
three methods responsible for raising
the relevant event for each of the
events to find in the heat sensor class
let's name the first method on
temperature reaches warning level
this method accepts one argument which
is our custom type named temperature
event args the temperature event args
class is responsible for storing event
data
let's then write code to reference the
relevant event using the underscore
temperature reaches warning level key
variable to reference the appropriate
delegate within the underscore list
event delegates object which is derived
from the event handler list class
when assigning the value stored in the
underscore list event delegates
collection object to the Handler
variable we must type cost the delegates
to the appropriate delegate type which
is the event handler delegate that
accepts the temperature event args type
as a generic parameter
then we need to see if indeed the client
code has subscribed to the relevant
event
if the client code has subscribed then
the Handler variable will not be null
so if the Handler variable is not null
we can raise the relevant event by
executing the handle delegate object and
passing in the appropriate arguments to
the Handler delegate though this keyword
is the first argument which references
the current object which of course is an
object of the heat sensor type
the second argument contains relevant
event information and is of the
temperature event args custom type
if you'll recall we made Provisions for
storing the current temperature as well
as the date and time of when the
relevant event occurred and the
temperature event args class right and
we can now repeat the same basic pattern
for the other two methods responsible
for raising the other two events
declared in the heat sensor class
thank you
so let's Implement a method to
encapsulate raising the temperature
Falls below warning level event handler
event
and let's Implement a method to
encapsulate raising the temperature
reaches emergency level event handler
event
and now let's Implement a private method
named monitor temperature
this method simulates the heat sensor
outputting temperature information for
the device being monitored
so this method traverses the data stored
in the underscore temperature data array
which contains our mock temperature data
let's write code to display the
temperature to the console screen each
time a temperature is read from the
underscore temperature data array
then we can create an else if letter
whereby we can compare the temperature
output to the warning level and the
emergency level
the emergency level has the highest
value that will be evaluated so this is
the first value that will be evaluated
if the temperatures above the emergency
level the emergency event is raised else
if the temperature is above the warning
level but below the emergency level the
warning event is raised
else if the temperature was above the
warning level and subsequently Falls
below the warning level we can raise the
temperature Falls below warning level
event
note how we are using the underscore has
reached warning level Boolean member
variable to evaluate if the temperature
Falls below warning level events should
be raised
the underscore has reached warning level
variable
must be set to True when the warning
level reached event is raised so that
the temperature Falls below warning
level event can be raised when the
temperature subsequently Falls below the
warning level
when the temperature subsequently Falls
below the warning level we must set the
underscore has reached warning level
variable to false
and for effect I'm going to introduce a
one second delay between iterations of
the underscore temperature data array
as you can see I'm using the
system.threading.thread.sleep method for
this purpose
I'm passing 1000 as an argument to this
method
this value denotes one thousand
milliseconds which is one second
and let's finish off the heat sensor
class by implementing code for the Run
heat sensor method
so we'll simply write the text heat
sensor is running to the screen to
indicate that the heat sensor is running
and then let's call the monitor
temperature method
okay so let's create the interface for
the cooling mechanism class
let's keep this really simple so this
interface contains two method
definitions one named on and the other
named off as the names imply these
methods represent the behaviors of
switching the cooling mechanism on and
off
let's create a class named cooling
mechanism
and implements the eye cooling mechanism
interface
and each method will simply write
appropriate text to the screen
let's create an interface named I device
this interface contains two method
definitions one named run device
the other named handle emergency
we'll create the class that implements
the I device interface in a bit but
let's first create a class to represent
the thermostat
let's first create an interface named I
thermostat
this interface contains one method
definition named run thermostat
right let's create a class named
thermostat that implements the Run
thermostat method
let's create a member variable of type I
cooling mechanism
heat sensor and let's create a member
variable of type I device
let's create two constants one to store
the warning temperature level which is
set to 27 degrees Celsius and want to
store the emergency temperature level
which is set to 75 degrees Celsius
please note that these figures are
arbitrary and serve only to help us with
the code example
let's create a parameterized Constructor
that accepts an argument of the eye
cooling mechanism type an argument of
the eye heat sensor type and the idevice
type we want the thermostat to have a
reference to the device to which it is
attached
let's set the appropriate member
variables to their counterpot arguments
within the Constructor
let's create a method where we'll wire
up the events contained in the heat
sensor class
let's name this method wire up events to
event handlers
so let's use the heat sensor object
passed into the thermostat class to wire
up all of the appropriate events
so to do this we can write
underscoreheatsensor dot the event name
which is in this case temperature
reaches warning level event handler Then
followed by the plus equals operator
then we are able to press the Tab Key to
Auto generate an appropriate method
definition
then we can rename the method if we
choose and click the apply button to
confirm the change
so let's write code to wire up the
remaining events
so in the Run thermostat method let's
add code to write that the thermostat is
running
let's call the wire up events to event
Handler's private method
and lastly let's call The Run heat
sensor method on the underscore heat
sensor object
let's write code for each of the client
event handlers
so to handle the event for when the
temperature reaches or exceeds the
warning level let's first change the
color of the font to dark yellow
let's write warning alert the warning
level is between warning level and
emergency level to the console screen
let's then write code to switch on the
cooling mechanism
then when the temperature subsequently
Falls below the warning level we want
the font to change to a blue color
and let's write information alert
temperature Falls below warning level
warning level is between warning level
and emergency level
and then to handle the emergency event
let's change the font to a red color
let's output emergency alert emergency
level is emergency level and above
and this event is handled slightly
differently to the other event handlers
because we are calling the underscore
device objects handle emergency method
we are using the idevice interface to
handle the emergency event and the
device object's code which we'll soon
implement
and we must make sure that each font
color is reset after each event is
handled
okay so now let's create a class to
represent our device I.E the device that
we are monitoring for temperature
changes let's name it device and within
the classes definition let's indicate
that we wish to implement the idevice
interface
let's hover our Mouse pointers over the
red squiggly line under the idevice text
show potential fixes and then click
Implement interface and visual studio
Auto generates implementations for the
members of the idevice interface for us
so let's Implement code for the handle
emergency method
and we'll simply write out a basic
Narrative of what should happen in the
event of an emergency so let's write
sending out notifications to Emergency
Services Personnel to the console screen
and then in the event of an emergency we
also want to shut down the device
so let's create a private method named
shutdown device
and this method simply outputs a
narrative stating that the device is
shutting down
let's call the shutdown device private
method from the handle emergency method
let's Implement code for the Run device
method
so let's simply output that the device
is running to the console screen
then we want to construct our objects
for our cooling mechanism heat sensor
and thermostat components
and we'll use their interface
abstractions to Define each of their
types
and I've encountered a bit of a snag
here when writing the code to construct
the heat sensor object
we have already created the constants
for the warning level and emergency
levels in the thermostat class I think
these constants should rather be members
of the device class and passed into the
heat sensor class during the
construction of the heat sensor object
so let's create the two relevant
constants in the device class and so
that we can encapsulate the values of
these constants and expose the values of
these constants publicly let's create
two corresponding read-only properties
let's first create definitions for these
read-only properties in the idevice
interface
and then let's implement the code for
these properties in the device class
and then within the thermostat class
which has a reference to the relevant
device object we can replace the
references to the relevant constants
that once resided in the thermostat
class with references to the relevant
read-only properties of the device
object
okay let's then write the code to run
the device from our main method so let's
write code to prompt the user to press
any key to run the device
then let's instantiate an object for the
device
then let's call the relevant object's
run device method
sorry I know I'm jumping around here a
bit we still need to finish off the code
for the Run device method let's finish
creating the thermostat object
then let's call the object's run
thermostat method
let's run the code
foreign
and you can see by the status output the
device is running the thermostat is
running and the heat sensor is running
the temperature changes of the device
can be seen with the output of each
temperature to the console screen
a warning event is raised when the
temperature exceeds 27 degrees Celsius
the cooling mechanism is then switched
on but there's an issue because when the
temperature subsequently Falls below 27
degrees Celsius the relevance status is
not being outputted to the screen
instead the code is raising the warning
event
so let's investigate what is going on
here
and the issue was caused I think because
of all the copying and pasting I forgot
to change the call to the on temperature
reaches warning level method to a call
to the on temperature Falls below
warning level method obviously a call to
the on temperature reaches warning level
method is inappropriate for the
condition when the temperature has
reached or is over the warning level and
then subsequently Falls below the
warning level so let's fix this issue
and let's run the code
foreign
and that is a correct result we can see
the cooling mechanism is turned on when
the temperature of the device exceeds
the warning level
and when the temperature has been above
the warning level and subsequently Falls
below the warning level the correct
event is raised the correct status is
therefore outputted to the screen in a
blue font and then the cooling mechanism
is Switched Off
and we can see that all the events are
firing correctly and being handled
correctly toward the end the emergency
event is being handled correctly which
is in line with the mock temperature
data that we created for this example
great
I hope you have enjoyed this video on
handling multiple events within a class
using the add and remove accesses
we also use the event handler list
built-in c-sharp collection class to add
and remove the relevant delegates for
when a user subscribes or unsubscribes
to an event
me
[Music]
hi and welcome to the third part of this
tutorial on c-sharp events
we have discussed that events can be
triggered either by code logic or
through a user's actions for example
clicking a button
in the previous parts of this tutorial
we focused on events triggered by code
logic in this video we'll focus on
events triggered through user actions
[Music]
so in most of the tutorials provided by
this channel regarding C sharp the.net
core console app project template has
been used as a starting point for
creating the relevant sample code
this has been done deliberately so that
we can focus on the language of C sharp
and not be distracted by framework
related Concepts
in this video we'll do something a
little bit different we'll create a very
basic code example and we'll use the
blank app universal windows project
template to create the project
responsible for the front-end
functionality of our application
so we are going to develop a basic
application using the uwp or universal
windows platform framework
this is so that we can look at how user
actions for example a button click can
trigger events and how the relevant
events can be handled appropriately in
code
in this video we'll show how a
separation of concerns can be achieved
whereby the front-end display
functionality is Loosely coupled with
the back end functionality so
specifically we'll look at how events
can be implemented to achieve this
so one of the advantages that can be
achieved by separating concerns is we
can have one team that specializes in
front-end design working on the look and
feel of the application and the back-end
functionality can be developed by a
completely different team these two
concerns can evolve independently from
one another and in parallel to one
another
the integration of the relevant
components at an appropriate time can
become a relatively trivial task
we are going to show how this loose
coupling effect is achieved through the
appropriate use of an event
a design pattern that can be used to
achieve this loose coupling of front-end
and back end components is called mvvm
which stands for model view view model
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you can be notified of future
content released from this channel
another advantage of implementing the
mvvm design pattern to achieve this
loose coupling of components is we are
able to easily port for example the
back-end functionality to other
platforms
let's say for example you have a
particular app which is being
distributed via the Microsoft store this
app was written using the uwp framework
let's say the app is selling really well
marketing research tells us that there
is a huge demand for this app to run on
IOS and Android platforms
time is a key factor in keeping the
momentum of sales going for this
application so we want this app to be
appropriated for IOS and Android
platforms as soon as possible so that
the app can be distributed via Apple's
app store for the iOS implementation of
the app as well as Google Play for the
Android implementation of the app
so we know that we can use the xamarin
technology to create a cross-platform
app for IOS and Android devices
so if we have designed our app
appropriately using the mvvm design
pattern
the back end functionality that we have
already created would not need to be
recreated for the IOS and Android
platforms
please navigate to this URL for more
information on xamarin
a team specializing in Android and iOS
front-end design could focus on the
native front-end functionality for their
respective platforms
or the use of xamarin forms could also
be utilized for the creation of the
front-end design using xaml we'll
discuss xaml in a bit
the backend code already created for the
uwp version of the app can be reused for
the Android and iOS apps created using
the xamarin technology
for more information on xamarin forms
please navigate to this URL
the appropriate use of the mvvm design
pattern could make the integration of
the front-end functionality with the
backend functionality a relatively
trivial task
the details of mvvm are beyond the scope
of this tutorial please navigate to this
URL for more detailed information about
mvvm
model view view model
uwp stands for universal windows
platform
so a uwp application can run on any
Windows device that runs Windows 10 or
Windows versions greater than version
10. Windows 11 is due to be released on
July the 29th 2020.
these devices can include PC tablet Xbox
hololens surface Hub and Internet of
Things devices so we are not going to go
into depth regarding the universal
windows platform uwp demands an entire
course on its own if you want to learn
more about universal windows platform
please navigate to this URL
foreign
[Music]
but let's look at a very basic example
of loosely coupling back-end
functionality from front-end
functionality using events on the
universal windows platform
so let's create a Project based on the
blank app universal windows project
template
[Music]
thank you
let's name this project and solution
employee uwp app
so once we click the create button we
are prompted with a dialog box where we
are able to choose the minimum version
and Target version that our uwp
application will support
so to Aid us with our decision let's
click on the link labeled which version
should I choose which is available in
the bottom left hand corner of the
relevant dialog box
so we are presented with a web page and
at the end of the first paragraph on the
web page it states
projects using.net standard 2.0 must
have a minimum version of build
16299 or later
so we are going to develop our backend
functionality using.net standard 2.0 so
let's choose version
16299 from the drop down list labeled
minimum version
right let's add a standard Library
project to our solution
and let's name it employee component
this Library will contain our back-end
functionality
so firstly let's reference our employee
component project from our uwp project
so let's right click the references node
within our uwp project and add a
reference to the employee component
project
okay let's delete the class that has
automatically been generated
let's create a class that will serve as
our view model and let's name this class
employee view model
as the name suggests a view model
represents the data that will be
displayed to the user
let's make this class a public class
let's write code so this class
implements the I notify property changed
interface
we must include a directive to the
system.component model namespace the I
notify property changed interface is a
member of the system.component model
namespace
so to do this we can hover our Mouse
pointers over the red squiggly line
click show potential fixes and then
click using system.componentmodel
this interface contains an event that is
key to how we can achieve a loose
coupling between the backend components
and the uwp front-end component that
will soon develop
so to implement the I notify property
changed interface let's hover our Mouse
pointers over the I notify property
change to text
which has a red squiggly line under it
and click show potential fixes and then
let's click Implement interface note
that a public event named property
changed which is defined as the delegate
type property changed event handler is
generated for us
this event will be raised to the front
end code when a relevant property value
in this class has changed
this example is going to be simplistic
so that we can focus on the Core
Concepts of this video namely how events
can be used to achieve a loose coupling
between front end and back-end
components
so let's create a read write property
named first name and let's create a
private member variable named underscore
first name
let's encapsulate the underscore first
name private member variable within the
first name property
and within the set accessor of the first
name property let's include code to
raise the property changed event
so if the first name property is changed
we want to raise the property changed
event
which will have the effect of notifying
the front-end view presented to the user
that the relevant field must be changed
on the front-end display so that the
change in value of the property is
presented to the user
and this is a key concept to understand
when the view model is changed the event
notifies the actual view presented to
the user of the change and the change is
then reflected in the view presented to
the user
so the view presented to the user is
never directly changed for example by
referencing an element of the view
presented to the user the underlying
view model which is part of the back end
code is changed and this change is
propagated to the view presented to the
user through the implementation of the
property changed event we'll demonstrate
later on how the uwp front-end component
subscribes to the property changed event
to receive notifications when a relevant
property value changes
let's wrap the relevant functionality
that raises the property changed event
and a private method and let's name this
method notify property changed
notice that this method accepts a string
argument which will contain the name of
the property that is changed
so now within the set accessor of the
first name property let's write codes to
call the notify property changed private
method for when the first name property
is changed
and let's create auto implemented
properties for the other employee fields
ID last name annual salary gender and is
manager
let's create a class named employees
we are going to be storing the employee
view model objects in a generic
collection type
called an observable collection
the observable collection type
represents a dynamic data collection
that provides notifications when items
get added removed or when the whole list
is refreshed
for more information about the
observable collection class please
navigate to this URL
so firstly let's include a directive to
the
system.collections.object model
namespace
the generic observable collection class
is a member of this namespace
this class will simply contain a method
that returns a collection of employee
records
let's create a public method named get
employees
we want this method to return a
collection of employee data so the get
employees method returns an object of
type observable collection the
observable collection is a generic
collection type and we are able to
strongly type the collection with the
employee view model type
so let's include code within this method
that creates a new observable collection
object and assign the relevant object
reference to a variable named employees
let's write code to return the employees
object
and I have made up some employee data
for our employee view model objects that
we can add to the observable collection
object we have named employees
so to save time let's navigate to a
GitHub repository where I have already
uploaded the code for this tutorial
so please navigate to this URL
let's select the relevant code that adds
the employee data to the employee's
observable collection and appropriately
paste it into our code editors
we could have written code to retrieve
this data from a data source like for
example a SQL Server database but in the
interests of keeping this code sample
simple we are using mock data as a
substitute
the observable collection object
represents a dynamic data collection
that provides notifications when items
get added removed or when the whole list
is refreshed we are going to use our
observable collection type which is
strongly typed to store objects of type
employee view model to bind our
collection of employee view model
objects to a list view that we'll create
in our front-end design when we develop
the uwp component
okay so let's develop our uwp component
so the user interface for a uwp
application is created using a
declarative markup language named xaml
which stands for extensible application
markup language
we are not going to go into the details
of xaml in this tutorial
but she has a basic explanation of what
xaml is in a uwp application xaml is
used to define UI elements data bindings
events and other features
xaml elements map directly to Common
Language runtime object instances while
xaml attributes map to Common Language
runtime properties and events on those
objects
for more information on xaml please
navigate to the following URL
so as mentioned earlier I have already
uploaded the relevant code sample to
GitHub
in the interest of time let's copy the
relevant xaml from GitHub and then we'll
paste the xaml code over the xaml
currently in the main page.xaml file
right so let's navigate to this URL
let's copy all the xaml code from this
page to our clipboards
foreign
let's paste the xaml code in our
clipboards over the xaml code currently
in our main page.xaml file and if we
look at the xaml code here you can see a
blue squiggly line under the code where
we are binding a list view data template
elements to the employee view model type
the reason for the blue squiggly line is
because we need to compile the employee
component so that our uwp project is
referencing the relevant latest compiled
assembly
so let's compile the employee component
and the blue Squiggy line goes away
great
and we can also see a design view
rendering of our xaml code
if we take another look at the xaml code
you can see that the data binding
functionality in the first name field
includes a mode attribute which is set
to the value of one way
this is an important part of the
functionality that allows changes to the
first name property of our employee view
model objects to be reflected in the
relevant list view displayed to the user
so in our code example here we are
demonstrating one-way binding from The
View model to the list view element of
The View
let's write the code and the code behind
file named Main page.xaml.cs
the code we are going to write here will
enable the user to select an employee
record from the list view that is
created through the xaml code which will
contain a collection of employee records
the user will then be able to
dynamically change the first name field
for the selected employee record by
typing the new first name value into a
text box and clicking a button to
confirm the change
let's create a member variable named
underscore employees OC which is of the
observable collection generic collection
type and is strongly typed with the
employee view model type
thank you
let's create a public Field named change
first name command
this is a public field and is defined as
the xaml UI command type for more
information on the xaml UI command type
please navigate to this URL
let's write the code in the Constructor
of the main page class
let's create a new object of type
employees
so let's take a quick look at the xaml
code
and you can see here we have a list view
named employee list
and you can see that there is data
binding markup to bind the fields in the
list view named employee list to each of
the fields to find in our employee view
model type so let's go back to the main
page.xaml.cs class and let's write code
to bind the data stored in the
underscore employees OC observable
collection object to the employee list
list View
note that the item Source property in
the employee list list view is set to
the underscore employees OC observable
collection
so let's go back to the xaml code notice
here we have a button named BTN change
first name that contains an attribute
named command
and this code is binding the BTN change
first name button to the public Field
named change first name command
that we defined as the xaml UI command
type in the main page class
also notice that the command parameter
attribute includes code that binds to
the employee list list view element
so let's go back to the main
page.xaml.cs class and let's create a
new xaml UI command object for the
change first name command public field
and let's use the plus equals operator
to subscribe to the execute request
event on the change first name command
xaml UI command object so after we have
typed the plus equals operator we can
press the Tab Key and a method with the
appropriate method signature is
generated for us
so when the user clicks the button named
BTN change first name the code in this
method will be invoked
so let's write the code for this method
firstly let's write code to get a
reference to the employee list list view
object
we can use the args.parameter property
to get a reference to this object
we must type cost this object to the
list view type
then let's write code to check if an
item in the list view has been selected
If an item has not been selected the
selected index property will be negative
one so if the selected index property is
not negative one we can use the relevant
list view object selected index property
to index the underlying observable
collection object and we want to set the
relevant items employee first name field
to whatever the user types in the
relevant text box
if we look at the relevant xaml mock-up
code we can see that a text box element
is included in our markup this text box
can be used to rename a selected
employee's first name field to whatever
the user types in the relevant text box
so let's run the code
so the employee list view is not
populating
let's investigate why this is occurring
okay so we haven't included the code to
assign the relevant observable
collection object named underscore
employee OC
with a value returned by the employees
classes get employees method the get
employees method populates the
observable collection object with
objects of the employee view model type
and Returns the relevant observable
collection object to the calling code so
to fix the issue let's write the code to
assign the underscore employee OC
variable
with a value returned by the
employees.get employees method
let's run the code again
great
that has resolved the issue we can see
that our list view is populated with
employee view model data okay so let's
select the third record and in the text
box here let's type Bob and then press
the button that is wired up to our
change first name command object
and let's repeat the same process for
some of the other employee records
great
we are now able to change the employee
records first name field on the
front-end display by updating the
underlying observable collection
note that the code is not updating the
employee list listview object directly
when the relevant underlying observable
collection has changed an event notifies
the employee list list view object of
this change and the relevant changes are
reflected on the front-end display
if we look at the change first name
command underscore execute request
method that gets invoked when the BTN
change first name button is clicked we
can see that the underlying observable
collection object is changed and the
employee list object is not directly
changed this highlights the decoupling
of the uwp front-end component from the
employee component which is responsible
for data handling and business rules
for example when the first name field
was changed for the third employee
record the property changed event which
is a member of the I notify changed
property interface was fired signaling
to the front end that there has been a
change to the first name field and the
relevant employee view model object
which must be reflected in the relevant
list view front-end object
and just for fun let's include code to
make our application speak to the user
so I've already prepared the code that
will make our application talk to us in
the relevant GitHub repository
so let's navigate to this URL
let's copy the speak async method to our
clipboards and paste it into the main
page.xaml.cs file
this method includes an asynchronous
method called to the synthesized text to
stream async method
in order to call the speak async method
that we have just included within our
code we must appropriately include the
async and await keywords
I'm also going to make a minor change in
that I'm going to rename the underscore
employee OC variable to underscore
employees OC so that the code we have
just created is consistent with the code
in the relevant GitHub repository
let's run the code
foreign
first name from Bill to Bob
changing first name from Jamie to Dom
changing first name from Sally to Debbie
excellent
so to summarize
this code that we have just created
shows how the I notify changed interface
and the generic observable collection
can be implemented to Loosely couple the
front-end component from the relevant
code within the backend component this
loose coupling effect has many
advantages which can include reuse of
components across disparate platforms
for example let's say we have an initial
application written to run on multiple
windows devices through the use of the
appropriate uwp project template and
then at a later stage we decide that we
want this application to run on IOS and
Android platforms
the component responsible for the
implementation of business rules and
data handling written using the standard
Library project template can be easily
ported to run on the Android and iOS
platforms without the need to change the
relevant code
we do not need to rewrite this code for
the Android and iOS platforms
separation of concerns allows separate
teams to work independently from one
another for example the front-end xaml
experts or as the case may be the
Android and iOS front-end developers
could focus on the look and feel of the
application and the user experience of
the application while not having to
worry about the details of the business
rules and the database handling
functionality a separate team that
specializes in writing the business
rules and database related functionality
can focus on this concern without
worrying about the implementation detail
of the front-end design
the front end and back-end functionality
can evolve independently from one
another and in parallel to one another
the front-ended back-end components can
then be seamlessly integrated with one
another at an appropriate time
I hope you have enjoyed this tutorial on
events raised through user actions in
the context of a uwp application uwp is
a very powerful platform that can be
used for creating Rich user interfaces
that can run on multiple windows devices
examples of related Windows specific
Frameworks include WPF or Windows
presentation foundation and win forms
if you want to learn more about WPF
please navigate to this URL
and if you want to learn more about
winforms please navigate to this URL for
more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of new releases
from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button and please feel free to share any
of the videos released from this Channel
with anyone you feel May benefit from
their content as always the code created
in this video can be downloaded from
GitHub a link to the relevant repository
has been included Below in the
description thank you and take care
[Music]
hi and welcome to the fourth part of
this tutorial on c-sharp events
this video is also part of a tutorial
that serves as the fourth part of an
advanced c-sharp course
in this video we'll focus on the
Observer design pattern
this is a very powerful design pattern
and is suitable for any scenario that
requires push-based notifications
the implementation of the Observer
design pattern entails subscribers
registering to receive notifications
from a provider push notifications
simply means that the notifications are
sent pushed from a central point to the
relevant subscribers
the source of the push notifications is
known as the provider also known as the
observable
observers register with the provider in
other words subscribe to the provider
and whenever a predefined condition
event or state change occurs one of the
observer's methods is called by the
provider
in this method call the provider can
also provide current state information
to observers
so note that the observable can also be
referred to as the provider and
observers can also be referred to as
subscribers
so I'll be using these terms
interchangeably throughout this tutorial
for more content like this on advanced
c-sharp concepts and much more please
consider subscribing and please ring the
bell so that you'll be notified of
future releases from this channel
in.net the implementation of the
Observer design pattern can be achieved
when the subscribers class or observers
implement the genericsystem.i Observer
generic interface and the provider class
implements the system.observable generic
interface the generic type represented
here with the capital T represents the
type which can be a user-defined type
that encapsulates the notification
information communicated from the
provider to its subscribers through push
notifications so the generic type
represented by the capital letter T in
the interface definitions of both the
provider class and the subscriber
classes is key to how loose coupling
between provider and subscribers can be
facilitated while still enabling rich
and extensible data to be pushed from
providers to subscribers
the system.i observable and system.i
observer built-in.net generic interfaces
enable this pattern to be reused for
multiple scenarios
the generic type represented by the
capital T allows for users to find types
to serve as communication vehicles that
can be extended without breaking the
design of the relevant application
so let's look at a quasi-real world
example that can be used to explain the
Observer design pattern and give us an
idea of when it is appropriate to use
this design pattern so we'll have to use
our imaginations a bit to Picture This
example
let's say a particular company owns a
building with an automated security
system
one of the functions of the security
system is to identify external visitors
arriving at the building for example to
have a business meeting with one of the
employees that work inside the building
so the process first involves the
external visitor registering to visit
the relevant employee on a particular
day
let's say that before an external
visitor arrives at the building for the
relevant visit
the external visitor must first register
and during the registration process
provide a clear photograph of the
external visitors face as part of the
registration process
so when the external visitor arrives on
the day of the visit and attempts to
enter the building a camera first scans
the external visitors face and
subsequently sends the relevant
pictorial facial information to a system
whereby biometric artificial
intelligence algorithms are applied to
ascertain whether this particular visit
can be authenticated I.E has this person
registered and if so can this person be
verified as the person the person claims
to be
so this is essentially an automated
authentication process
once the relevant visitor has been
identified the visitors automatically
given access to the building this
triggers notifications to be sent to the
building's security team and any
internal staff members I.E employees of
the company that owns the relevant
building who have subscribed to receive
notifications regarding the relevant
actions of the external visitors the
information that is sent to the
subscribers I.E the notification data
sent from the provider contains
information about the relevant external
visitor and the time the relevant
external visitor gained access to the
building and then subsequently once the
visit is completed a notification is
sent when the external visitor exits the
building another notification will be
sent to All subscribers from the
provider when a predefined time is
reached and all external visitors have
exited the building for example the
predefined time could be 6 pm which has
been deemed the end of the Working Day
for the relevant company the rule could
be that after this time no external
visitors can gain access to the relevant
building in this example we'll refer to
this time as the cut-off time
okay so as I've said we need to use our
imaginations of birch here because we
are going to implement code for the
scenario just described within a
consoleapp.net core framework in other
words the code will be highly simplified
so that we can focus on understanding
The Observer design pattern
so the provider in this example will be
the security surveillance system used to
identify external visitors that have
registered to visit a member of Staff
within the relevant building on a
particular day
this example will contain two types of
subscribers one of the types of
subscribers that we will create will
represent the security team they must be
notified of all significant movements of
external visitors for example entering
and exiting the building
the other type of subscriber will
represent any individual internal staff
member who has subscribed to receive
relevant notifications regarding
external visitors
this employee would subscribe because a
visitor must have a point of contact
inside the building in order to
successfully register as an external
visitor
when the external visitor is
authenticated on the day of the visit a
notification will be sent to the
security team as well as any employee
who is registered as the point of
contact for the relevant external
visitor
okay let's look at an overview of the
main classes that will be created for
this example
so here is a class that represents the
observable this class will represent a
central place where surveillance data is
processed
we'll create two classes that represent
two types of Observer the first class
represents an employee I.E a person that
works inside the relevant building who
wants to be notified when a particular
external visitor enters the building
this class is named employee notify the
second class represents the security
team who must be notified when any
external visitor enters or exits the
relevant building this class is named
security notify we have a class here
named external visitor which represents
an outside visitor to the relevant
building
this class serves as a generic type
argument to both the I observable
generic interface implemented by the
observable class as well as the generic
arguments to the I Observer generic
interface which is implemented by The
Observer classes
so this class allows data about the
external visitor to be communicated from
the observable object to its Observer
objects when the relevant notifications
are sent
we have an eye employee interface and an
employee class that implements the I
employee interface
the employee class provides a way to
store details about an employee who
works inside the relevant building this
class represents the employee details of
a person who serves as a point of
contact for an external visitor
an employee object is passed into the
Constructor of the employee notify class
during the instantiation of an object
derived from the employee notify class
so in summary here are our main classes
employee notify and observer class
security notify and observer class
security surveillance hub
the observable class I employee and
interface defining and internal staff
member record
employee a class that implements the I
employee interface so it represents an
employee record
external visitor a class representing
the person that has registered to visit
a member of staff that works inside the
relevant building
this class represents a person that must
be authenticated on the day of the
relevant visit
let's look at the class that will serve
as our observable class we'll name this
class security surveillance hub
this class represents a central location
where surveillance system information is
processed
and will be responsible for notifying
subscribers with the relevant
information about an external visitor
so notifications will be sent to the
relevant observers when an external
visitor enters the building and another
notification will be sent to the
relevant observers when an external
visitor exits the building
firstly let's answer the question how
can we Implement a class so that it can
be instantiated as an observable object
the answer to that question is that a
class that will be instantiated as an
observable object must implement the eye
observable generic interface the eye
observable generic interface is a
built-in.net interface that is a member
of the system namespace
the next question is what makes the
observable interface a generic interface
the I observable interface is generic
because the calling code is able to pass
a type as a generic argument to a class
that implements the eye observable
generic interface
in our example the type that will pass
as the relevant's generic type argument
will be a user-defined type named
external visitor
as you may have guessed this class will
represent an external visitor
we'll discuss the external visitor class
in more detail a bit later
the I observable generic interface
contains one method definition this
method definition is for a method named
subscribe the Subscribe method contains
one parameter of a type that implements
the I Observer generic interface so this
parameter is defined as an observer type
we'll discuss the I Observer generic
interface a little bit later so the
Subscribe method must be implemented by
the type that implements the I
observable generic interface
the implementation of the Subscribe
method must contain functionality that
is executed when an observer subscribes
to receive notifications from the
relevant observable object
so we've now looked at the essence of
what we are trying to achieve here by
implementing The Observer design pattern
let's get started and create the code
example let's create a Project based on
the consoleapp.net core project template
let's name this project and solution
building surveillance system application
so for our first class let's create a
class that represents the external
visitor
this class represents the information
about an external visitor that will be
sent to the relevant subscribers when an
external visitor enters the building and
subsequently exits the building once the
external visitor completes the external
visitors visit
so let's create a public class and name
it external visitor let's create the
properties for the external visitor
class so let's create a property for ID
defined as int first name defined as
string last name defined as string
company name defined as string job title
defined as string entry date time
defined as date time this property will
store the date and time of when the
relevant external visitor entered the
building exit date time defined as date
time this property will store the date
and time of when the relevant external
visitor exited the building
and lastly an auto-implemented property
named employee contact ID and let's
define this property as int this
property facilitates the storage of the
ID of the internal employee I.E an
employee who works within the building
responsible for being the point of
contact for an external visitor on the
relevant day of the external visitors
visit great and that is our external
visitor class
so let's create our observable class
let's create a public class named
security surveillance Hub as explained
earlier this class serves as a metaphor
for a central location where security
related information is processed so for
example an external visitor's face is
scanned before gaining access to the
building and this pictorial information
is subsequently sent to the security
surveillance Hub where the biometric
information and the relevant image is
compared against registered image
information captured when the external
visitor registered to visit the building
so if the two pieces of information
match the visitor is granted access to
the building which will trigger
notification information about the
external visitor to be sent to the
relevant Observers
so as discussed earlier in order for
this class to represent our observable
it must implement the I observable
generic interface
so let's write the code to do this and
let's pass in the external visitor type
as our generic type argument what makes
the eye observable interface a generic
interface
it is a generic interface because we are
able to strongly type the I observable
interface the capital T within less than
and greater than symbols in the eye
observable interface definition means
that we are able to replace the T with
our c-sharp type
when this is done it means we have
strongly typed our generic interface so
let's strongly type the I observable
interface with our external visitor
class like this
generics allows us to stipulate a
particular type for the relevant type
placeholder at compile time
note that a capital t is commonly used
to represent the generic type
placeholder
generic functionality can also be
accomplished through the use of the.net
system.object type as we know all types
in c-sharp ultimately inherit from the
system.object type
so we are able to type cost a variable
at runtime to any managed.net type the
advantage of using generics for the same
purpose is that we can achieve the same
functionality but this is done at
compile time
this provides the advantage of compile
time type checks ensuring type safety as
well as results in Greater performance
for our code because we are able to omit
the need for runtime typecasting
typecasting which is performed at
runtime also carries the risk of
incurring runtime errors
please don't worry if you didn't
understand this brief explanation of why
generics is significant generics will be
discussed in detail in upcoming
tutorials so let's develop the security
surveillance Hub class
so you can see that there is a red
squiggly line under the eye observable
text and the class definition this is
the c-sharp compiler letting us know
that we have not yet implemented code
for the member definitions of the I
observable generic interface in the
security surveillance Hub class
so let's hover our Mouse pointers over
the red squiggly line click show
potential fixes and click Implement
interface as you can see there is only
one method definition in the I
observable interface that we must
Implement in the security surveillance
Hub class this method is named subscribe
notice how the Subscribe method
definition contains a parameter of type
I Observer and the I Observer parameter
type definition is automatically
strongly typed with the type definition
with which we have already strongly
typed the I observable interface
so we have strongly typed the I
observable interface with the external
visitor type and this has propagated to
the Subscribe method definition when we
automatically generated the method
definition that is contained in the I
observable generic interface I.E the
Subscribe method definition
this is a key concept to understand when
understanding how we are able to use the
I observable and I observe a generic
interfaces to implement the Observer
design pattern
the generic type gives us a means for
creating a loose coupling between the
observable component and the relevant
Observer components
the generic type both defined in the I
observable and I Observer interfaces
allows the developer to strongly type
these two interfaces with a common type
in this example we are strongly typing
these two interfaces with the external
visitor user-defined type
this will become clearer as we develop
this example application
right let's implement the code for the
security surveillance Hub class
so let's create two member variables
both of these member variables are of
the generic list type
let's define the first one and name it
underscore external visitors
as the name suggests this list will
store a list of external visitors
when an external visitor gains access to
the building the external visitor is
added to the underscore external
visitors list
and you can see that we are strongly
typing the underscore external visitors
list with the external visitor user
defined type
let's include a directive to the
system.collections.generic namespace
the second generic list we need to
Define will store a list of observers so
this list will contain objects that are
derived from the I Observer generic type
that is strongly typed with the external
visitor user defined type
let's name this generic list variable
underscore Observers
so when an observer subscribes to
receive notifications from the
observable
the relevant Observer is added to the
underscore observers list conversely if
an observer unsubscribes the relevant
Observer is removed from the underscore
observers list
so the Subscribe method will be the last
method that we will Implement as
discussed the Subscribe method has to be
implemented because it is a member of
the I observable generic interface which
the security surveillance Hub class
implements
for now let's create a public method
that gets called when an external
visitor gains access to the building
let's name this method confirm external
visitor enters building
this method's parameters contains
relevant information associated with an
external visitor namely ID defined as
int first name defined as string last
name defined as string company name
defined as string job title defined as
string entry date time defined as date
time and employee contact ID defined as
int then we can write the functionality
to instantiate an external visitor
object and set the properties of the
object we have derived from the external
visitor user defined type with the
values that will be passed as arguments
to the confirm external visitor enters
building method
then let's write the code to add the
newly created external visitor object to
the underscore external visitors list
as mentioned the underscore observers
list is populated with observers
observers are of course objects that
have subscribed to be notified when
certain conditions are met for example
an external visitor entering the
building
so this method represents an external
visitor entering the building the
visitor has been authenticated and is
automatically given access to the
building
so let's use our imaginations and let's
say that when an external visitor enters
the building the framework in which our
observable exists invokes the confirm
external visitor enters building method
the observable can Now notify all
subscribers of this event as well as
send the relevant data pertaining to the
event to all the relevant subscribers
in this particular example the relevant
data is encapsulated with the external
visitor object which is derived from the
external visitor class
remember the I Observer generic
interface is strongly typed with the
external visitor user defined type which
makes it easy to send the data to the
relevant Observer objects
the relevant Observer objects are stored
within the underscore observers list
so in order to notify the relevant
observers with the relevant data we can
write code to Traverse the underscore
observers list and call each Observer
objects on next method note that when we
call each Observer objects on next
method we are passing the relevant
external visitor object as an argument
to the on next method this is how each
Observer receives notification data
whenever the relevant event occurs
in this example the relevant event is an
external visitor gaining access to the
relevant building
so how does the observable I.E and
object derived from the current class we
are creating know that an observer
object implements a method named on next
and even further to that how does the
relevant observable object know that the
on next method accepts an argument of
type external visitor
this is at the heart of how the Observer
pattern Works in c-sharp each Observer
object is derived from a class that
implements the I Observer generic
interface if we look at the definition
for the I Observer interface we see
three method definitions namely on next
on error and on completed the on next
method contains a parameter of a generic
type
so when we create an observer class a
bit later we'll strongly type the I
Observer interface that our class must
Implement with the external visitor user
defined type this action will mean that
the on next method will be strongly
typed with the external visitor
user-defined type so the external
visitor type becomes a common
communication facility between the
observable and the relevant Observers
so the fact that we know that each
Observer implements the I Observer
generic interface means we know that
each Observer object implements a method
named on next
the fact that the I Observer interface
for each Observer class is strongly
typed with the external visitor
user-defined type means that we know the
type of the argument that needs to be
passed into the our next method
the I Observer generic interface
contains a definition for a method named
on error this allows for the observable
to notify relevant Observer objects if
an exception occurs
and also provides information about the
exception through the built-in exception
type
we are not going to implement custom
functionality for the on error method in
this example each Observer object must
however Implement code for the on error
method because the definition for the
method is contained within the I
Observer generic interface
the last method that we need to talk
about is the uncompleted method
so we will be implementing custom code
for the uncompleted method in this
example
the uncompleted method does not contain
any parameters the uncompleted method
notifies The Observers that the
observable has finished sending
notifications so this method should be
called for each Observer when a
condition is met whereby no more
notifications need to be sent to the
relevant Observer objects in this
example the uncompleted method will be
called on all Observer objects within
the underscore observers list when the
relevant cutoff time has been reached on
a particular day and all external
visitors have exited the building the
cutoff time could be for example
designated as 6 pm
there may be external visitors who
exceed this time constraint due to for
example a meeting that goes on for
longer than expected or something of
that nature so two conditions need to be
met for the uncompleted method to be
invoked a certain time in the day is
reached for example 6 pm and all
external visitors have exited the
building
so next let's Implement a method that is
called when an external visitor exits
the building
so let's name this method confirm
external visitor exits building
this method is a public method that
contains two parameters one parameter
which is a value that serves as a unique
identifier for an external visitor
it is defined as the int data type
the other parameter is named exit date
time and as the name suggests this
parameter denotes the date and time when
an external visitor exits the building
so firstly let's write code to find the
external visitor within the underscore
external visitors list
foreign
if the external visitor is not now I.E
the external visitor is found within the
underscore external visitors list let's
write code to update the relevant
external visitor objects exit date time
property to the date and time when the
external visitor exited the building
let's then write code to Traverse the
underscore observers list and call each
observers on next method and pass an
argument to the on next method of the
relevant external visitor object to
notify The Observers that a specific
external visitor has exited the building
so let's create another public method
that will be called when the cut-off
time is reached so by cut off time I
mean this is a time after which external
visitors are not allowed to enter the
building so we need to use our
imaginations for some of these methods
because we are basically saying that
this method is called when certain
conditions are met in this case when a
certain time in the day is reached just
like for example when the external
visitor enters the building the confirm
external visitor enters building method
is invoked or when the external visitor
exits the building the confirm external
visitor exits building method is invoked
so let's create a public method that
will be executed when the visitor cutoff
time is reached let's name this method
building entry cut off time reached
so this method is called at a particular
time but we only want to call each
observer's on completed method if all
external visitors have left the building
the fact that the uncompleted method is
called means that no further
notifications will be sent from the
observable object to the Observer
objects for a particular day
so we are going to use the Link
Technology to check if any external
visitor objects exist within the
underscore external visitors list
but first i'm going to extend the
external visitor class to include a
property named inbuilding this property
is of type Boolean and we can set this
property according to the external
visitors current location
so we want to set the inbuilding
property value to True when we confirm
external visitor enters building method
is invoked conversely we want to set the
inbuilding property value to false when
a confirm external visitor exits
building method is invoked
so we can now use the inbuilding
property value to check if there are
still external visitors left inside the
building after the cutoff time has been
reached
if you don't fully understand this code
don't worry link will be discussed in
detail in upcoming tutorials as part of
the c-sharp advanced course
if the count of external visitor objects
within the underscore external visitors
list that have their in-building
property values set to True is equal to
zero this means that the cut of time has
been reached and all external visitors
have exited the building so we can now
call the uncompleted method on all the
Observer objects that are currently in
our underscore observers list
by calling the uncompleted method on
these Observer objects this is notifying
the relevant observers that no further
notifications will be sent
okay let's implement the Subscribe
method so notice that the Subscribe
method contains a parameter of type I
observable which is a generic interface
the implementation of the I observable
generic interface in this class I.E the
security surveillance Hub class is
strongly typed with the external visitor
user defined type
so this is automatically propagated
through to the Subscribe method
definition where the I Observer generic
interface is also strongly typed with
the external visitor user defined type
note that when an observer object
subscribes to the observable object The
Observer object passes a reference to
itself into the Subscribe method though
this keyword can be used for the purpose
of referencing an object derived from
the class in which that this keyword is
implemented we'll implement this code
when we create the Observer classes in a
bit
for now let's implement the code for the
Subscribe method
and the code for this method is pretty
simple we first check if the Observer
object exists within the underscore
observers collection if the Observer
object does not exist within the
underscore observers list this means
that a new Observer object is
subscribing so we can write code here to
add the Observer object to the
underscore observers list which means
that the relevant Observer is now
subscribed
the subsequent lines of code reverse all
the external visitor objects within the
underscore external visitors list and
notifies the new Observer object of the
current information related to external
visitors that exist within the
underscore external visitors list
now notice that the Subscribe method
returns a type that must implement the
built-in eye disposable interface
so we are now going to create a class
named unsubscriber and this class will
implement the eye disposable interface
as the name suggests the purpose of the
unsubscriber class is to provide a
facility for the Observer objects to
unsubscribe to the observable object I.E
to elect to no longer receive
notifications from the relevant
observable object the unsubscriber class
implements the built-in I disposable
interface which contains a definition
for a method named dispose when an
observer object calls the dispose method
this action causes the relevant Observer
object to unsubscribe from the relevant
observable object
so you can see that the Subscribe method
in the observable class in this case the
observable class is the class named
security surveillance Hub allows for an
observer object to subscribe to the
relevant observable object
the Subscribe method returns a reference
to the relevant unsubscriber object
which is derived from the class that we
are about to create I.E the unsubscriber
class
that implements the eye disposable
interface
The Observer object can simply call the
dispose method which is a member of the
eye disposable interface to unsubscribe
to the relevant observable object
the built-in eye disposable interface is
a member of the system namespace
let's create the unsubscriber class
as mentioned the unsubscriber class
implements the eye disposable interface
which contains a method definition for a
method named dispose so let's create the
class definition for the unsubscriber
class
let's indicate that we wish to implement
the eye disposable interface
let's ensure that we are implementing
all the members of the I disposable
interface the eye disposable interface
contains one member a method named
dispose
let's create the Constructor you can see
that this Constructor contains two
parameters the first parameter is a list
that contains Observer objects the
second parameter is an observer object
so the functionality for this class is
literally just to remove the past in
observer object from the relevant
observers list
so let's create two member variables
these member variables will be
appropriately assigned to the passed in
arguments to the Constructor
then the logic within the dispose method
is simply to check if the relevant
Observer object exists within the
relevant observers list
if it does remove the relevant Observer
object from The Observers list
the result of this action is that the
relevant Observer is unsubscribed from
the relevant observable object and will
therefore no longer receive
notifications from the observable object
so let's go back to the Subscribe method
in the security surveillance Hub class
and let's return a new unsubscriber
object derived from the user-defined
type that we have just created
note that the construction of the
unsubscriber object entails passing a
reference to the relevant Observer and a
list of all observers currently
subscribed
okay so we have now written the code for
the observable object the class that
defines the observable object is the
security surveillance Hub class
so we can now create the classes that
will represent our Observer objects
we are going to create two classes which
represent two types of Observer objects
the first tab we'll create is a class
named employee notify
this class will represent an employee a
staff member that works in the building
that has been designated as the contact
point for an external visitor
so this employee wants to know when the
relevant external visitor has entered
the building so that the employee can
welcome the relevant external visitor at
the entrance of the building
the second type or class will represent
the security team
which must receive details of the
external visitor when the external
visitor enters the building and later
exits the building
so let's first create code for the
employee notify class
this class is an observer so it must
implement the generic I Observer
interface
we also need to strongly type the I
Observer generic interface with the
external visitor type
so one way we can automatically generate
the definitions for the members of the I
Observer interface that we must
Implement is to hover our Mouse pointers
over the red squiggly line under the I
Observer generic interface text within
our class definition and click show
potential fixes and then click Implement
interface
and visual studio automatically
generates default implementations for
three methods the method definitions for
these three methods are members of the I
Observer generic interface
the red squiggly line disappears because
we now have implementations for the
members contained in the I Observer
generic interface
so in a bit we'll Implement more useful
code for these methods
before we create a Constructor for this
class I want to create a definition for
an employee record
let's create an interface named I
employee
we'll keep the employee record really
simple so let's create definitions for
just four properties ID as int first
name as string last name as string and
job title as string let's create a class
named employee that implements the I
employee interface
so let's go back to the employee notify
class and create the Constructor for
this class
so when an object is Created from the
employee class we want an employee
object to be passed into the Constructor
of the employee notify class
so let's include a parameter of the I
employee type within the Constructor
definition
we want to adhere to solid principles
the last letter in the solid acronym is
dependency inversion principle which
states that classes should not depend on
concrete implementations but should only
depend on abstractions
this is why the parameter within this
Constructor is defined with an interface
type rather than a class
so we are defining this parameter of
type I employee rather than of type
employee
very basically solid is an acronym
representing a set of principles that
are design principles that can be
followed in order for a programmer to
develop software that is easy to
maintain and extend
we'll discuss solid principles in detail
in upcoming tutorials
solid principles serve as a foundation
for object-oriented design patterns like
for example The Observer design pattern
these design patterns can be implemented
to solve problems that have been
repeatedly identified in real world
scenarios if you wish to read more about
solid principles please navigate to this
URL
so let's create an appropriate member
variable of the I employee type and
within our Constructor let's assign the
past and value to the member variable we
have just created
so let's Implement our code Logic for
our on next method notice that the
parameter contained within this method
is of type external visitor when we
automatically generated our default
method implementations through Visual
Studio the fact that we had strongly
typed the I Observer interface with the
external visitor uses defined type
propagated through to the on next method
so the purpose of the on next method is
that it gets called by the observable
object every time it is appropriate to
send out notifications to the relevant
Observers
this is how the observable object is
able to send out notifications to each
of its subscribed Observer objects
because the observable object knows that
each Observer object implements the on
next method
so the observable object traverses all
of its observers and calls the on next
method on each of its Observer objects
to send out the relevant notifications
each Observer is able to handle the
notification through its custom
implementation of logic within its on
next method
so the code we are about to write gets
called when the observable sends out its
notifications
in this case we want the designated
employee contact to receive a
notification when the relevant external
visitor has gained access to the
building
so let's write the logic for this method
firstly let's assign the past in
argument of type external visitor to a
local variable named external visitor
let's create an if statement the
condition for the if statement checks
the external visitor objects employee
contact ID property value against the ID
property value of the employee object
reference that is passed into the
Constructor of this employee notify
object if these two values match this
means that the relevant employee is the
registered point of contact for the
external visitor referred to in this
particular notification so we want to
maintain an up-to-date local list of
external visitors for this employee
notify Observer object so let's define a
member variable named underscore
external visitors as a generic list that
can store external visitor objects
so let's write code to check if the
external visitor object passed into the
on next method exists within the
underscore external visitors list we can
do this by using link and checking if
the ID of the external visitor object
passed into the on next method matches
any of the external visitor objects ID
properties currently stored within the
underscore external visitors list
and we are assigning the result of the
link expression to a local variable
named external visitor list item
so let's write a nested if statement
where the if condition checks if the
external visitor list item variable
value is null
if it is null the external visitor
object does not exist in our local list
containing external visitor objects so
let's add this external visitor object
to our list
then the next line of code simply
outputs a message to the relevant
employee that the expected external
visitor has entered the building and we
can also include the external visitors
details within the message
thank you
so if the else part of the nestative
statement condition is true the external
visitor has already visited and the
notification must refer to the relevant
external visitor exiting the building
so the logic simply updates the
inbuilding property of the relevant
external visitor object within the
underscore external visitors list to
false
the relevant external visitor list items
exit date time property is also
appropriately updated with relevant exit
date Time Properties stored in the
external visitor object passed in from
the observable object to the on next
method of this object so we have now
implemented the logic for the on next
method of the employee notify Observer
class
so in the interests of time we are not
going to bother implementing code for
the on error method we'll simply retain
the default implementation generated by
Visual Studio in this example but please
note that this method provides a
mechanism for observers to handle
exceptions that may occur within the
observable object
so now we must implement the logic for
the uncompleted method the purpose of
this method is so that the observable
object can notify the relevant Observer
objects when no further notifications
need to be sent
in this example there is a rule that the
observer's on completed methods will be
called from the observable object when a
cut-off time is reached for example
perhaps 6 pm on a workday
and all external visitors must have left
the building
so a few external visitors may still be
in the building past 6 PM for example
they may be in meetings that have gone
on for longer than was first anticipated
the uncompleted method on all relevant
Observer objects will only be invoked
from the observable object once all
external visitors have left the building
and the cutoff time has been reached
let's say the cut of time means that no
further external visitors are allowed to
gain entry into the building on a
particular work day after a predefined
cut off time so if these conditions are
met the observable can notify all
observers through the observer's
implementation of their uncompleted
methods and this means that no further
notifications will be sent at this point
the relevant Observer objects will have
a complete list of external visitor
objects that visited the building during
the course of the day
the external visitor objects will
contain relevant information like for
example certain details about the
external visitors as well as their entry
and exit times to and from the building
on the relevant day
so the Observer at this point is able to
create a final report relating to the
external visitor data on a specific day
so let's implement the code for the
uncompleted method in the employee
notify class let's say that the relevant
employee is only interested in the
details of those external visitors that
were there to visit the employee during
the course of that day
so in the on next method we have only
added the external visitors where the
relevant employee was registered as the
external visitors contact in the
building
so we can simply output the details of
external visitors stored within the
underscore external visitors list for
the implementation of the on completed
method
so let's first write an appropriate
heading to the console screen this
heading will simply contain the employee
name followed by the text daily visitors
report
let's write code to Traverse the
underscore external visitors list
let's set the inbuilding property to
false because if this method is being
invoked this means that all external
visitors have left the building and we
want to keep our local copy of the
underscore external visitors list up to
date
let's then write the details of each
relevant external visitor to the console
screen
this information serves as a final daily
report for a specific employee and
contains information about the external
visitors that have visited the employee
so this is a report and we want to space
The Columns for each of the outputted
fields evenly
one way we can achieve this is by using
the pad write method which is available
on all string objects the pad write
method accepts an integer value as an
argument so if for example we wish for
the ID field to always occupy six
character spaces we can pass an argument
of six to the pad write method so if for
example the ID value only takes up one
character space the pad write method
will add the extra five character spaces
which will be empty spaces or white
spaces to the relevant field output we
can actually achieve the same effect
when outputting variable values using an
interpolated string like this
so using the interpolated string
Technique we can achieve the same thing
and use less code
foreign
and that is the implementation for the
uncompleted method of the employee
notify class
so we also want to include a method that
performs the action of subscribing to
the observable
in this case as we know the observable
is represented by the surveillance
system Hub class
so let's create a method named subscribe
that contains a parameter name to
provider
which is of the generic interface type I
observable
and is strongly typed with the external
visitor user-defined type
and to subscribe we can simply write
provider.subscribe and pass a reference
to the current object using the this
keyword to the observables Subscribe
method
but remember that the observable
subscribe method returns an object that
implements the eye disposable interface
so let's create a member variable of
type I disposable
let's name this member variable
underscore cancellation
so now we can create a method named
unsubscribe
the logic to unsubscribe The Observer is
simply underscore cancellation dot
dispose
so as mentioned we also want to
implement code for another type of
Observer class
so the class we'll create for this will
be named security notify and as the name
suggests this class denotes the security
team that must receive a notification
every time an external visitor enters
the building
and a notification when the external
visitor later exits the building
so let's include the I Observer generic
interface that is strongly typed with
the external visitor user defined type
within our security notify class
definition
let's Auto generate the methods that we
must Implement for the I Observer
generic interface so let's hover our
Mouse pointers over the red squiggly
line click show potential fixes and then
click Implement interface
so the first method we need to implement
is the on next method
the logic here simply checks if the
external visitor object already exists
within the underscore external visitors
list
if it doesn't exist we add the external
visitor object passed into the onnext
method to the underscore external
visitors list
we then output notification text
that is appropriate for the security
related Observer to the console screen
foreign
visitor does already exist within the
underscore external visitors list this
means the relevant external visitor has
just exited the building so we must
update the relevant properties for this
external visitor object list item
appropriately
so we update the inbuilding Boolean
property to false and we also update the
exit date time property with the date
and time when the external visitor
exited the building
and then let's update the code to Output
text to the security team that the
relevant external visitor has now exited
the building
and we have just written the on next
method
so let's implement the code for the on
completed method
So within the uncompleted method we
simply want to Output the details
contained within the underscore external
visitors list to the console screen and
this serves as a report to the relevant
security team conveying information
about the entry and exit times of
external visitors throughout the day
so we can simply copy the implementation
for the uncompleted method within the
employee notify class to the uncompleted
method within the security notify class
and then manually change the heading to
reflect that this is a daily report for
the security team regarding external
visitors so let's finish off this class
by implementing our subscribe and
unsubscribe methods so you may have
noticed that we would actually be
repeating the code for the Subscribe and
unsubscribe methods across our Observer
classes namely the employee notify and
security notify classes
so if we repeat the Subscribe and
unsubscribe implementations here we are
violating the principle of dry
which is an acronym that stands for
don't repeat yourself
yeah we would be clearly repeating
ourselves
so let's refactor our code so that the
Subscribe and unsubscribe methods are
reusable across our Observer classes and
are written in only one place
to centralize the functionality for
these methods let's create an abstract
class named Observer
let's make the Observer class implement
the I Observer generic interface let's
strongly type the interface with the
external visitor class
so the rule here is that we must
implement the members of the I Observer
generic interface in this case however
we don't want to centralize the
functionality for the on next on error
and on completed methods defined in the
I Observer generic interface
we have different implementations for
the on next and on completed methods for
our two different Observer classes
so what we can do is we can create
abstract method definitions for the
relevant methods within our Observer
class
we can consolidate two member variables
within this abstract class I.E the
underscore cancellation member variable
and the underscore external visitors
member variable
the underscore cancellation member
variable is of the I disposable type
and is used for unsubscribing and
observer object the underscore external
visitors variable is of type generic
list and is strongly typed with the
external visitor type
the underscore visitors list maintains a
central local storage facility for the
relevant Observer object of external
visitor information
we can then centralize the functionality
for the Subscribe and unsubscribe
methods so that these methods can be
reused across both Observer classes
as you may have guessed The Observer
classes will inherit from this abstract
class
so we can now change the class
definitions for our Observer classes
namely the employee notify class and the
security notify class to inherit from
The Observer abstract class
we then need to include the override
keyword within the on next on error and
on completed methods within our employee
notify and our security notify classes
which are of course classes that
represent our Observers
this is because we are no longer
implementing the I Observer generic
interface directly we need to override
the abstract method definitions for
these methods that have been defined in
the Observer abstract class
so before we Implement code in our main
method and run the code let's create a
basic class that will help us
differentiate between the text that will
be outputted by our two Observer classes
namely the employee notify class and the
security notify class
so the obvious way that we can do this
is by changing the color of the
outputted text for each of these
Observer classes so let's create a
static class
let's create a public enum and name it
text output theme
each list item value in this enum
denotes an output theme
so let's name the first enum list item
security let's name the second enum list
item employee
let's name the third enormous item
normal let's add a method to the static
class
let's name this method change output
theme
this method contains one parameter named
text output theme and is defined as the
enum we have just created I.E the enum
named text output theme
then the logic for the change output C
method simply evaluates through an if
else if block the value passed into this
method
so if the value passed into the change
output theme method is the employee
enormous item value let's write code to
change the background color to dark
magenta and the color of the text to
White
else if the value passed into the change
output theme method is the security e
number list item value
let's change the background color to
dark blue and the color of the text to
Yellow
else let's reset the state of the text
color and the background color back to
their default colors
so let's go to the security notify class
and we can now change the color theme
for the output text colors in the on
next method accordingly
and once the relevant text has been
outputted let's change the foregrounded
background colors back to their default
values
and we can do this using our change
output theme method like this
let's go to the employee notify class
and implement the same functionality but
of course change the color theme to the
appropriate color theme we have defined
for the employee notify output text
so now when we test our code we will be
able to differentiate between the output
coming from an object derived from the
employee notify class and the output
security notify class okay so let's
write some code in the main method to
test our implementation of the Observer
design pattern
we have implemented code here for the
purpose of understanding The Observer
design pattern and to keep things simple
and focused on the Observer design
pattern itself we have used the
consoleapp.net core project template to
create the infrastructure or framework
to house our code logic
so before we write calling code in the
main method to test our Observer design
pattern it may be helpful to use our
imaginations to picture a real world
representation of this example
so in the real world we would have three
types of entities
we have our two types of observers
namely an employee who works within the
building and the building's security
team so the relevant Observer employees
I.E the employees who have subscribed to
receive notifications when an external
visitor enters or exits the building may
have apps running on a handheld device
like tablets or smartphones
that alert the employees when relevant
external visitors enter or exit the
building
the security team may have various
Personnel whose responsibility it is to
monitor the entry and exit of external
visitors
so the relevant security Personnel may
be notified through security related
software where one of its components is
subscribed to receive notifications when
an external visitor enters or exits the
building
so the relevant security officer or
officers may be sitting at a laptop or
desktop monitoring the relevant
notifications
then we have the observable entity which
could be a server that resides
on-premises or in the cloud that is
constantly receiving surveillance
information from security cameras
it provides facial recognition
functionality and assesses whether a
registered external visitor can be
authenticated and therefore enter the
building
so in summary The Observers I.E
employees within the building and a
security team are subscribed to the
observable and receive notifications
from the observable once a certain
condition is met in this case the
condition is an authenticated external
visitor entering or exiting the building
with all this in mind let's Implement a
few scenarios within our main method to
test our implementation of the Observer
design pattern
so let's create an instance of our
observable class
let's create an instance of the Observer
class named employee notify and pass an
employee object as an argument to the
employee Notifier Constructor
so we can imagine that Bob Jones is
carrying a handheld device that receives
a notification when an external visitor
that has registered Bob Jones as the
external visitors point of contact
arrives
let's create another instance of the
Observer class employee notify and pass
a new employee object as an argument to
the employee notify Constructor
so it's essentially the same scenario as
before but this time we can imagine that
Dave Kendall is carrying a handheld
device that receives a notification when
an external visitor arrives that has
registered Dave Kendall as the external
visitors point of contact
and these employees will also receive
notifications once the relevant external
visitor exits the building although they
don't receive text output when the
relevant external visitor exits the
building the notification is received
and the relevant employee notify
external visitors object list containing
the relevant external visitor object is
updated with relevant information for
example the time the relevant external
visitor exited the building
this information is relevant when the
employee receives a report regarding
external visitors
when the relevant cutoff time is reached
and all external visitors have exited
the building
and let's create the other type of
Observer object which is represented by
the security notify class
this type represents a security team
that must receive notifications whenever
an external visitor enters the building
and later exits the building
all observers will also receive a report
once a cut-off time is reached and all
external visitors have left the building
remember the cut-off time denotes a time
after which no further external visitors
are allowed to enter the building so for
example this cutoff time could be 6 PM
which could be deemed as the end of the
Working Day for the relevant company
so now we have three Observer objects
which is comprised of two employees and
the security team and we have a provider
which can also be called the observable
object which is the central location
where security related data is processed
so let's subscribe all of our Observer
objects to receive notifications from
the observable object
so when we call the Subscribe method we
must also pass a reference to the
observable object
so we can call the confirm external
visitor enters building method to
simulate an external visitor entering
the building
the arguments that we are passing to
this method denote information about the
external visitor the time the external
visitor enters the building
as well as the ID of the employee that
serves as the contact point for the
external visitor
so let's call the confirm external
visitor enters building method to
simulate the entry of an external
visitor named Andrew Jackson and then an
external visitor named Jane Davidson
note that the last argument passed into
the confirm external visitor enters
building method denotes the ID of the
employee whom the external visitors have
registered as their point of contact
so the point of contact for Andrew
Jackson is Bob Jones and the point of
contact for Jane Davidson is Dave
Kendall
let's then call a method to simulate
these two external visitors exiting the
building
we can do this by calling the confirm
external visitor exits building method
on the observable object once where the
ID pertaining to the external visitor
Andrew Jackson is passed into the method
we can then call the method again but
this time passing the ID of the external
visitor Jane Davidson signifying that
Jane Davidson has exited the building
these two method calls to the confirm
external visitor exits building method
simulate these two external visitors
exiting the building
so let's say that Andrew Jackson exited
the building two hours after entering
the building and let's say that Jane
Davidson exited the building three hours
after entering the building
lastly let's call the building entry
cutoff time reached method on the
observable object which denotes that the
end of the working day has been reached
we have referred to this term as the
cutoff time throughout this tutorial if
all external visitors have exited the
building a report of external visitors
is sent out to all the subscribed
Observer objects
on a technical level this is achieved
through the observable object calling
the uncompleted method on all relevant
Observer objects
we have structured the code in the main
method so that all external visitors
have left the building before the cutoff
time so a full report should be sent to
All Observers
and this also means that no further
notifications will be sent for that
particular day
so let's run the code
okay so an error is flagged because the
underscore observers variable is null
and we have tried to call its contains
method
so I've realized I forgot to include a
Constructor for the security
surveillance Hub class
where we should have instantiated an
appropriate generic list object and
assigned it to the underscore observer's
member variable as well as instantiate
an appropriate generic list object and
assign it to the underscore external
visitors variable
so let's fix this issue and implement
the appropriate Constructor code for the
security surveillance Hub class
okay
let's try again let's run the code
great
and if we look at our output we can see
that this is an expected result Bob
Jones an employee is notified when
Andrew Jackson an external visitor
enters the building
Dave Kendall an employee is notified
when Jane Davidson an external visitor
enters the building
the security team is notified when both
external visitors have entered and
exited the building
when the cutoff time is reached an
appropriate report is sent to the
employee Observer objects as well as the
security Observer object
the employee report contains information
regarding external visitors where the
employee served as the relevant external
visitors point of contact
the security Observer object is notified
of the relevant activities and relevant
details of all external visitors for the
relevant day through a report tailored
for the security team
great so our Observer design pattern has
been implemented correctly and is
therefore working as expected though
I've noticed that the date time output
is not in the format I would prefer
I want to include whether the time is AM
or PM
so we can do this by including TT within
the date time formatting string passed
to the relevant tostring methods
this is not ideal because notice that we
are having to change this format in
several places in a professionally
developed application it would be good
practice to configure this format in one
place
for the purposes of this demonstration
we'll update the date time string
formatting in several places but let's
be cognizant that this is not the best
way to implement this formatting
functionality
let's run the code again
great
so let's simulate the scenario where the
cut of time is reached
so no further external visitors are
allowed to enter the building past the
cutoff time
but there are still external visitors in
the building
so we can simulate this scenario by
commenting out the line of code that
simulates the external visitor Jane
Davidson exiting the building
so in this particular case Jane Davidson
has not yet exited the building let's
run the code
and the output reflects this
we see the correct output pertaining to
the entry and exit of Andrew Jackson
but we only see an output for Jane
Davidson entering the building and not
exiting the building this is an expected
result
note that we also do not see any of the
reports outputted to The Observers
because these reports are only sent when
the cutoff time is reached and all
external visitors have exited the
building the code implementation for
this is implemented in the building
entry cut of time reached method
contained within the observable class
I.E the security surveillance Hub class
in the building entry cut of time
reached method the uncompleted methods
of all relevant Observer objects is
called but only if all external visitors
have left the building and if we include
the method called to the confirm
external visitor exits building method
for Jane Davidson
but call the unsubscribe method on the
employee notify object after this
external visitor has entered the
building but before the building entry
cutoff time reached method is called so
let's appropriately call the unsubscribe
method on the Observer object pertaining
to the employee Bob Jones
let's run the code
and you can see that Bob receives a
notification when his external visitor
enters the building but a report is not
sent to Bob Jones when cutoff time is
reached because he has unsubscribed
before cutoff time is reached
this is because if an observer
unsubscribes The Observer will not
receive any further notifications after
the Observer has unsubscribed on a
technical level when the Observer
unsubscribes the code removes The
Observer from the observer's list
contained within the observable object
and therefore that Observer is excluded
from the list of observers that has
traversed and sent notifications when
certain predefined conditions are met
I hope you have enjoyed this video on
the Observer design pattern this
completes the final video in a video
series on c-sharp events and completes
the fourth part of a course on Advanced
C sharp
so in this video series we looked at the
basics of events in C sharp we
demonstrated how we are able to
subscribe to an event contained within
another class and how we can designate a
method to handle the event
event handling code and c-sharp is
implemented by using a delegate
as an intermediary between the event and
designated method that is called when
the relevant event is raised
we demonstrated the use of racing events
through codelogic I.E when certain
logical conditions are met in a class
where the relevant event resides the
event can be raised in order to invoke
the methods that have been designated to
handle the relevant event we
demonstrated how we're not calling
clients subscribes or unsubscribes to an
event that this functionality can be
encapsulated with an add and remove
accesses
which are similar in nature to the use
of get and set accesses for properties
we demonstrated how events can be raised
through user actions for example a
button click
we use the uwp universal windows
platform project framework as a
foundation for this demonstration we
briefly touched on how the mvvm model
view view model design pattern is used
to Loosely couple front-end
functionality from business rules
related functionality when implementing
code for a uwp project in this regard we
also discussed the advantages of
separating concerns for example to allow
for cleaner code to facilitate easier
unit testing to facilitate better
maintainability of code and to allow for
separate teams to specialize in
different aspects of a project
so relevant aspects of the project can
evolve independently and without
adversely affecting one another
lastly in this video we demonstrated an
example where the implementation of the
Observer design pattern was deemed as
suitable because its core functionality
involves pushing notifications out to
multiple entities from a central point
when certain conditions are met
please consider subscribing for more
content on advanced c-sharp concepts
like this and much more and please ring
the bell so that you can be notified
when this channel releases new videos
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released from this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
and please feel free to provide feedback
about this video in the comments section
as always the code can be downloaded
from GitHub
a link to the relevant GitHub repository
has been included Below in the
description
[Music]
hi and welcome to the first part of a
tutorial on c-sharp generics
tutorial is also the fifth part of a
course on Advanced c-sharp topics
this video will serve as a basic
introduction to generics and c-sharp
we'll first answer the question what is
meant by generics we'll look at a basic
example of implementing generics in
c-sharp and the advantages associated
with the use of generics and c-sharp so
let's start with the question what is
meant by generics in relation to the
c-sharp programming language
generics was introduced in c-sharp
version 2 and enables developers to use
type parameters and code
this makes it possible to design classes
and methods that defer the specification
of one or more types until the classroom
method is declared and instantiated by
client code
for example by using a generic type
parameter T you can write a single class
that other client code can use without
incurring the cost or risk of runtime
costs or boxing operations
we'll discuss what is meant by boxing
operations and runtime casting a bit
later in this video
generic classes and methods combine
reusability type safety and efficiency
in a way that their non-generic
counterparts cannot
generics are most frequently used with
Collections and the methods that operate
on them
for more content like this on advanced
c-sharp concepts and much more please
consider subscribing and please ring the
bell so that you'll be notified of
future content released from this
channel
let's look at a simplistic example to
help us understand generics and C sharp
to help us understand generics as a
whole we're going to look at a c-sharp
collection type the arraylist versus a
c-sharp generic collection type a
generic list
an arraylist provides the advantage of
encapsulating the functionality of
dynamically increasing the size of the
list as more items are added to the
arraylist in other words unlike with an
array we do not have to Define an
arraylist with a size
it will dynamically handle its size as
items are added to the arraylist
the arraylist stores values as objects
this involves implicitly boxing value
type items when they are added to the
arraylist
unboxing these items is required when
these items are retrieved from the
arraylist we'll discuss boxing and
unboxing in a bit
so we are only using an arraylist in
this example to highlight the benefits
that replacing an arraylist with a
generic list provides
in doing so we can understand the
overall benefits provided through the
use of generics
note that Microsoft has stated that
Microsoft does not recommend using the
arraylist for future development
so we'll first use the arraylist
collection in our example and later
replace the arraylist collection with a
generic list to highlight the benefits
of generics
let's create a console app.net core
project
I'm going to name my project generics
basics
let's create a class named salaries
let's define a member variable as an
arraylist
the arraylist type is a member of the
system.collections namespace so let's
ensure that we include a directive to
the system.collections namespace at the
top of our code
and let's create a Constructor
within the Constructor let's populate
our arraylist with data that denotes
salaries
let's create a public method named get
salaries that simply Returns the
arraylist that has been populated with
the salary data
so this method returns an object of the
arraylist type to the client code
so the code within our main method is
our calling client code the code share
will create an instance of the salaries
class and then call the get salaries
method and assign The Returned
collection from the get salaries method
to a local arraylist variable so let's
write the code in the main method to do
this
let's say there is a requirement to add
a bonus of two percent to the second
item within the collection
so let's write code to achieve this
we know that the salaries collection
contains floating Point numbers so let's
assume that we can assign a member of
the collection to a local variable
defined as float
so let's write the code for this
okay great so this is good we have a red
squiggly line under the code where we
are assigning the second item of the
relevant arraylist to a variable we have
defined as float so a type in
compatibility has been flagged by the
c-sharp compiler if we hover our Mouse
pointers over the red squiggly line we
can see a message from the c-sharp
compiler which is telling us that we
cannot implicitly cast an object to a
float but that an explicit conversion
exists
so let's write code to explicitly
convert the relevant object value stored
in the relevant arraylist to the float
data tab like this
great and the red squiggly line goes
away and all seems well
then we can finish off The Code by
writing code to write the salary which
now includes a bonus of two percent to
the console screen
let's run the code
oh what is happening here we have
received a runtime error specifically an
invalid cost exception
the exception message States unable to
cast object of type system.double to
system.single remember float is an alias
for system.single
so note that when we added the salaries
to the arraylist within the Constructor
of the salaries class we simply added
literal values that our floating Point
values we did not explicitly Express the
type of the relevant literal values the
type of floating Point literals are by
default interpreted as the double date
type we could have expressed the types
for these literal values as float data
types by adding an F after the relevant
literal value like this but we did not
do this
so in the main method or in our client
code we assumed that a value within the
arraylist was of the float data type and
this assumption resulted in a runtime
error occurring
in a bit we'll talk about how generics
preemptively prevents such erroneous
assumptions from causing runtime errors
let's first discuss boxing and unboxing
okay so an arraylist stores values that
are automatically typed as the root
c-sharp data type which is the
system.object data type
note that all.net data types ultimately
inherit from the system.object data type
when a value type in our case a numeric
floating point value type is stored
within an arraylist the value type is
wrapped within an object type and stored
in memory on the Heap this process is
known as boxing
what does boxing mean
boxing is the process of converting a
value type to the type object or to any
interface type implemented by this value
type so when the common language runtime
boxes the value type it wraps the value
inside a system.object instance and
stores it on the managed Heap
for more information on data types in
c-sharp please access a video created by
this channel by clicking on a card made
available in the top right hand corner
of your screen a link to this video has
also been included Below in the
description so when a value is retrieved
from the arraylist as we are doing in
the main method the value must first be
unboxed
unboxing extracts the value type from
the object
boxing is implicit unboxing is explicit
the concept of boxing and unboxing
underlies the c-sharp unified view of
the type system in which a value of any
type can be treated as an object
so this highlights two disadvantages of
using an arraylist where a generic list
can be used instead and can be
implemented whereby the values contained
within the generic list can be strongly
typed through generics at compile time
firstly as we have proven writing code
in this way can result in runtime errors
because the values in an arraylist are
not strongly typed at compile time
secondly when a value type is stored
within an arraylist the value type is
automatically boxed and when a value
type is retrieved from the arraylist the
value must be explicitly unboxed this is
done through explicit type casting
this boxing and unboxing functionality
carries with it a performance overhead
boxing and unboxing can affect the
performance of our applications
using a generic list to strongly type
the values stored within the relevant
generic list has two distinct advantages
one type safety the code is type checked
at compile time which preempts runtime
errors this makes typecasting at runtime
not necessary which eliminates the
potential for type-related runtime
errors occurring
number two enhanced performance
unlike with an arraylist the overhead of
boxing is not necessary when adding a
value to a strongly typed generic list
and the overhead of unboxing is not
necessary when retrieving a value from
the strongly typed generic list
like an arraylist the generic list
carries the advantage of being able to
grow dynamically I.E it is not necessary
to define the size of the collection
when it is declared
so with all that said let's Implement
generics in our code
to implement generics let's replace the
arraylist within our salaries class with
a strongly typed generic list the
generic list is part of the
system.collections.genericnamespace so
let's ensure that we have a directive to
this namespace at the top of our code
thank you
let's hover our Mouse pointers over the
list type in our code
so notice the T with an angle brackets
this T serves as a placeholder for a
data type the developer is able to pass
a data type as an argument to the
generic list in order to declare that
only the type passed into the T
parameter must be stored within the
relevant generic list
so we have passed in the float data type
to our generic list notice how there is
a red squiggly line under each of the
floating Point values we are attempting
to add to our strongly typed generic
list the c-sharp compiler is insisting
that we express these floating Point
values as the float data type and we
know we can do this by adding an F to
the end of each of these values like
this
through the use of generics the c-sharp
compiler checks our code at compile time
which prevents the possibility of type
related runtime errors
so we are simply commenting out the code
where we previously used the arraylist
and in its place applying the relevant
generic list code
our list is now strongly typed with the
float data type which means that our
list can only store value types that are
of the float data type
this is the basics of generics
let's run the code
great
I hope you have enjoyed this video which
serves as an introduction to generics
and C sharp in the second video we'll go
further into generics and introduce
Associated Concepts like for example
constraints
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it'll be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released from this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
your comments are of course welcome
the code created in this tutorial can be
downloaded from GitHub please see a link
to the relevant repository Below in the
description
[Music]
hi and welcome
this video is the second part of a video
series on c-sharp generics
this video is also the second part of
the fifth tutorial in a course on
Advanced c-sharp topics
so in this video we'll create a class to
encapsulate the bubble sort algorithm
cost will be a generic class that can be
implemented to sort an array that
contains values of any managed c-sharp
data type
this will include user-defined types
so in order to enable sorting
user-defined types the relevant
user-defined type must implement the eye
comparable interface
the generic class that will implement
the bubble sort algorithm will contain a
constraint as part of its class
definition we'll discuss the
significance of using constraints in the
context of generics and c-sharp and
we'll demonstrate the use of a
constraint through the code example
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
firstly to highlight the advantage of
using generics and c-sharp I'm going to
implement the functionality for this
example in a non-generic way
we'll then modify the code to implement
generics to create the equivalent
functionality
so let's get started
let's create a.net core console
application
and let's name this project generic
bubble sort application
I'm not going to explain the details of
the bubble sort algorithm in this
tutorial
there are many available online
tutorials regarding the bubble sort
algorithm
if you'd like me to explain the details
of the bubble sort algorithm please let
me know in the comments section and I'll
be happy to make a video on the details
of how the bubble sort algorithm works
very basically the bubble sort algorithm
is a simple sorting algorithm that
repeatedly steps through a collection of
values Compares adjacent elements and
swaps them if they are in the wrong
order
our implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm will work for any array of any
c-sharp value type string data type as
well as any user-defined type that
implements the eye comparable interface
so let's create a class that
encapsulates a method containing the
bubble sort algorithm
let's first create this class as a
non-generic class so that we can later
turn this class into a generic class and
in doing so highlight the benefits of
using generics in our c-sharp code
so let's create a public class named
sort array
let's create a public method within the
sort array class named bubble sort
this method does not return a value and
contains a parameter which is an array
defined as the system.object type
remember we are first implementing our
code in a non-generic way
we want to be able to sort an array of
any built-in value type string type and
even user-defined types
we are using the object dates tab rather
than generics to enable sorting arrays
of varying data types we are able to
achieve this because all managed data
types in c-sharp ultimately inherit from
the system.object data type for Value
types boxing functionality can be
applied to store value type values
inside an object reference type
for more information on boxing and
unboxing please click the card in the
top right hand corner of your screen to
watch the first part of this tutorial on
c-sharp generics
a link to this video has also been
included Below in the description
so let's write the code for the bubble
sort method firstly let's set a local
variable of the integer dates type to
the length of the array that will be
sorted by our bubble sort code this is
the array that will be passed into this
method at runtime we are now going to
create two for Loops an outer loop and
an inner loop
let's create the outer loop first so
this Loop simply traverses all the
elements of the array that will be
passed into this method at runtime
for every traversal of the outer loop
the inner loop traverses all the
elements of the array minus the current
value of the outer Loops incremented
value in this case an integer value
stored and a local variable named I
and of course we know that the minus one
and both the outer and inner Loops is
there because arrays and C sharp are
zero based
so now within the inner loop we can
write the code that compares the current
elements value I.E the value currently
being traversed with the value of the
adjacent element in the relevant array
so we can get the adjacent element by
adding 1 to the value stored in the J
variable which is being incremented by
the inner for Loop statement
so notice the red squiggly line when we
try to perform our comparison code using
the greater than symbol
this is because the object type does not
support the use of this operator for
comparing one object value to another
so value types like for example intload
long Etc and the string dates type
implement the eye comparable interface
so we should be able to use the compare
to method to perform the comparison
functionality we need for our bubble
sort algorithm the compare two method
definition is a member of the I
comparable interface
the system.object type does not
implement the eye comparable interface
so we need to perform a runtime casting
operation in order to use the compare to
Method this highlights the danger of
using the object data type and code like
this because we are assuming that the
elements of the array passed into this
method at runtime will implement the eye
comparable interface so this code runs
the risk of causing a runtime error and
at the very least carries the
performance overhead and could when the
costing operation is performed at
runtime
so we can perform the casting operation
like this
the way that comparet2 method works is
that the current value is compared to
another value and if the current value
is greater in value than the other value
an integer value greater than zero is
returned to the calling code if the
values are equal an integer value of 0
is returned from the compare to method
to the calling code
if the current value is less than the
other value that it is being compared to
the compared to Method returns an
integer value less than zero to the
calling code
so with regards to the bubble sort
algorithm if the compare to Method
returns a value greater than zero this
means that the current value is greater
than the value it is being compared to
and the two elements need to be swapped
in terms of their positions in the array
so let's write the code for this
let's set a variable named temp to the
value of the current item being
traversed
let's then set the value for the current
item in the array to the value of the
adjacent item in the array I.E the value
that the current item is being compared
to
then let's set the adjacent items value
in the array to the current items value
in the array I.E the value that is
stored in the temp variable
so in effect we have simply swapped the
positions of two adjacent values in the
relevant array
so in the interests of cleaner code
let's encapsulate the swapping
functionality and a private method named
swap
and that's it we have implemented our
bubble sort algorithm
so let's go to the main method and write
code to test our sort array class
let's create an array of integer values
where the values are stored in no
particular order
let's write code to instantiate an
object of the sort array type
let's write code to invoke the bubble
sort method and pass in the relevant
array that we want sorted
okay there's a red squiggly line under
the past in Array argument to the bubble
sort method in our code
this is because we need to change our
definition of the relevant integer array
to an object array
let's write the code to write the values
stored in the relevant array to the
console screen
let's run the code
great and we can see that the values
have been appropriately sorted
Let's test our bubble sort functionality
for an array of strings
let's run the code
great
and let's now test our bubble sort code
for an array of a particular
user-defined type let's create our
user-defined type so let's create a
class named employee
this will be the user-defined type that
we'll use for this example where our
bubble sort code sorts an array of a
particular user-defined type
let's keep this class simple and give it
two Auto implemented properties ID as
int name as string
let's go to the main method and create
an array of employee objects
I'm going to add made up data for each
employee object and these employee
objects are deliberately unordered
foreign
let's run the code
and we are getting a runtime error this
is because our bubble sort code relies
on the compare to method to compare the
relevant values in the relevant array
this means that the object stored within
the relevant array must implement the
eye comparable interface
this highlights one of the reasons why
our code should Implement generics we'll
implement the generic version of this
code in a bit
for now to fix the runtime error let's
make the employee class implement the
icomparable interface
let's hover our Mouse pointers over the
red squiggly line under eye comparable
click show potential fixes then let's
click Implement interface
we can now see that Visual Studio has
created a method named compare to
so we must Implement code here that
compares the current object's ID with
the ID of the object passed into the
compare to method
so to get the current object we can
simply use the this keyword
the object that will compare our current
object to is the object that will be
passed into the parameter named object
which is a parameter contained within
the compare to method
as you can see the relevant parameter
named object is of type object so we
need to type cost this object to
employee notice that we need to perform
a lot of runtime casting to make this
code work this is not a good thing and
we'll solve this problem in a bit using
generics
so we are going to sort the employee
objects in the relevant array by their
ID properties
the ID property is of type integer
integers and c-sharp implement the
compare to Method so we can simply write
code to return the result of the compare
to method to the calling code like this
so this code simply compares the ID of
one employee object with the ID of
another employee object and returns an
appropriate value to the calling code as
stated earlier a value greater than zero
if the current employee object's ID is
greater then the other employee object's
ID
0 if they are equal in value and a value
less than zero if the current employee
object's ID is less then the employee
object ID that the current employee
object's ID is being compared to the
string data type also implements the eye
comparable interface so we could replace
this code with similar code that
compares the current employee object's
name property with the other employee
object's name property we'll test this a
bit later
I'm also going to override the tostring
method in the employee class so that we
can display the employee objects ID
property followed by the employee
object's name property when an employee
item's values are written to the console
screen
so when we write an employee item to the
console screen both the ID and the name
properties of the relevant employee
objects will be outputted to the screen
so let's run the code
okay so this is not the result we
expected in order for our override of
the tostring method to be executed we
need to type cast the item we are
writing to the screen
to the employee type note the need for
more bad type cost and code
let's try again
and now our code works as expected you
can see that the employee objects within
the array have been ordered by their ID
properties as expected great
so the sort array class now works for
multiple data types
we have achieved this functionality by
using the system.object type
this is because all managed data types
in c-sharp ultimately inherit from the
system.object type for more information
on c-sharp data types please click the
card made available in the top right
hand corner of your screen to view a
video on c-sharp data types
so let's see how we can achieve the same
functionality but through the use of
generics
we'll also see why it is more
advantageous to use generics to avoid
the performance penalties incurred by
using the system.object type to achieve
the desired functionality
so through our use of generics we can
also eliminate the risk of data type
related runtime errors
so let's change our sort array class
into a generic class
we can do this by adding a placeholder
represented by a capital T with an angle
brackets after the sort array class name
and our class definition
let's then replace all of our object
type definitions with the placeholder
data type represented by the capital T
in our code
in the main method we must add angle
brackets after the sort array type when
we instantiate an object of type sort
array like this
within the angle brackets we must
include the relevant data type to
strongly type the class
in this case we are testing sorting an
array of employee objects so we must
include the employee data type within
angle brackets
we can now remove the costing operation
from the code that writes the employee
data to the console screen
let's run the code
great
we are using generics now so let's
remove the typecasting functionality
where we are casting type object to type
I comparable in the bubble sort method
foreign
squiggly line under the compare to
Method call within the bubble sort
method
the red squiggly line is a result of the
fact that we have not told the c-sharp
compiler that type T implements the eye
comparable interface which contains the
compare to method so you'll notice when
we add a DOT after an item referenced in
our array the compare to method is not
available in the intellisense drop-down
list this is because visual studio and
the c-sharp compiler has no way of
knowing that type T implements the eye
comparable interface
so how can we declare that type T
implements the eye comparable interface
we can do this through the
implementation of a constraint
by adding a constraint we are
constraining our T-Type parameter to a
rule that any type passed as an argument
to the T parameter must implement the I
comparable interface
so to add the desired constraint we can
add the following code to our sort array
class definition where space t colon I
comparable
so we have now implemented the desired
constraint for our generic sort array
class and the red squiggly line goes
away
and now if we add a DOT after our item
referenced in the relevant array we can
see the compare to method which is a
member of the icon Parable interface and
our intellisense drop down list
so let's go to the main method
let's first test our new generic version
of the sort array class that now
contains a constraint with an array of
integers
now that we are using generics to
implement the sort array class we can
use the int type to declare our array of
integers rather than the object type
so notice how we are passing in the end
dates type between the angle brackets
for the code that instantiates the sort
array class
we are now able to strongly type our
sort array class
Let's test the code
great
Let's test our string array so this time
we must include the string data type
within angle brackets when we
instantiate the sort array class
great
and then let's test our code with our
array containing values of the
user-defined type employee
but before we do this
you'll notice that we currently need to
perform a conversion operation within
the compare to method of the employee
class to convert the obj argument which
is defined as object to an employee type
we don't want this extra overhead caused
by the costing operation at runtime so
to solve this problem we can implement
the generic version of the icomparable
interface we can pass the employee data
type as an argument to the generic
version of the eye comparable interface
like this
so let's modify our code so that we are
implementing the compare to Method
contained within the generic version of
the icomparable interface to do this
let's first comment out our current
compare to method
let's then hover our Mouse pointers over
the red squiggly line in our class
definition
click show potential fixes and then
click Implement interface
you'll notice that the new version of
the compare to Method generated by
Visual Studio contains a parameter that
is strongly typed with the employee
user-defined type
so let's copy our old implementation of
the compare to method and paste it into
our new version of the compare to method
we can now remove the casting operation
from our new strongly typed version of
the compare to method
so now there is a red squiggly line
under the employee type being passed as
a data type argument to the sort array
class in our main method
this is because in our sort array class
definition we have a constraint which
enforces a rule at compile time that any
type passed into the sort array class
must implement the eye comparable
interface our employee class is now
implementing the generic version of the
eye comparable interface so we need to
modify our constraint and our sort array
class definition to establish a rule
that any data type passed to the
relevant T data type parameter must
implement the generic version of the
icomparable interface so our constraint
now pertains to any type that implements
the generic I comparable interface
following this modification our code
will still work for the integer data
type which is a value type and the
string dates tab because both the int
data type and the string data type
implement the generic version of the eye
comparable interface our sort array
class will also work for any user's
defined type like our employee type that
appropriately implements the generic
version of the eye comparable interface
Let's test our code
great
so let's say we want to sort our
employee objects by name to achieve this
we can simply change the implementation
of the compare to Method within the
employee class like this
Let's test the code
great
let's also test the code for an integer
array
foreign
let's firstly select the int dates type
in our code right click on it and then
select go to definition you can see the
in-states type implements the
non-generic version of the eye
comparable interface and also implements
the generic version of the eye
comparable interface
let's run the code
great let's also test the code for a
string array
great
so we have written a generic class that
can sort an array of any built-in value
type string data type as well as any
user-defined type that appropriately
implements the eye comparable generic
interface
by using generics we eliminated the need
for a lot of type conversion operations
which would be performed at runtime and
carries the risk of incurring runtime
errors
using generics can also enhance the
performance of your application because
the.net runtime no longer has the
overhead of Performing these casting
operations at runtime
generics allows us to defer type
specifications for a unit of code this
allows us to strongly type a unit of
code for example a class method or
collection type at compile time this
means generics inherently has the
advantage of compile time data checks to
prevent the possibility of type-related
runtime errors occurring
we use the constraint to indicate to the
compiler that the generic type parameter
represented by the capital T between
angle brackets in our class definition
must implement the generic I comparable
interface this allowed Visual Studio to
make available the compare to method on
an object defined as T through
intellisense and ensured that the
compare to method is available on all
relevant elements within the relevant
array which are of type T at runtime
so generics and the use of a constraint
has been implemented so that we can
Implement one pattern of logic in this
case the bubble sort algorithm for any
c-sharp built-in value type EG int long
float double Etc the string dates type
as well as any user-defined type that
appropriately implements the generic I
comparable interface
I hope you've enjoyed this video on
using generics with constraints in C
sharp
in the next video we'll delve deeper
into generics
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released from this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content your comments are of course
welcome the code created for this
tutorial can be downloaded from GitHub
please see a link to the relevant
repository Below in the description
[Music]
hi and welcome this video is the third
part of a video series on c-sharp
generics
this video is also part of a tutorial
which is the fifth part of a course on
advanced c-sharp concepts
in this video we'll look at generic
delegates and events in c-sharp we'll
also look at other Concepts associated
with c-sharp generics including the use
of a generic c-sharp built-in data
structure namely the queue data
structure
we'll explore these Concepts associated
with generics through a practical
example
the theme I've chosen for this practical
example is a warehouse management system
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
we need to use our imaginations a bit
because the example will be highly
simplified and expressed through a.net
core console application
so the code will provide the
functionality of a real-time monitoring
system for items entering a warehouse
and subsequently being processed by
processed I mean the item is placed in a
predefined location within the warehouse
for storage
so an event is raised when an item
enters the warehouse and an event is
subsequently raised once the relevant
item has reached its predefined location
within the warehouse
note that when I refer to an item I'm
referring to a batch of units of a
particular type so in our example the
item can refer to a quantity of units a
unit in this example will be a hardware
related item for example a drill hammer
ladder Etc
so if we use our imaginations we can
picture the scenario in the real world
an item enters the warehouse and is
scanned
so let's say the item has a QR code
attached to it
that when scan provides necessary
information about the item
when the item is scanned an event is
raised so for example a supervisor could
be monitoring the relevant activities
relating to the warehouse and when an
event is raised the relevant information
is displayed on a screen in real time
so the supervisor could for example be
monitoring these real-time events using
a handheld device
a desktop computer or a notebook
computer the display could perhaps be a
large screen TV that multiple employees
can monitor
the use of events decouples the
component that raises the event which
could for example be an on-site scanning
facility from a component that receives
the event notification which could for
example be a handheld device used by a
supervisor to monitor events either on
site or even remotely if required so for
example a box containing drills arrives
to be stored at the warehouse
the QR code attached to the relevant box
that the drills are in is scanned the
box is then transported to a predefined
location in the warehouse to be stored
so when the box is placed in its
relevant location perhaps pressure pads
at the location are used to detect that
the box of drills has been processed
when I say processed Amin has arrived at
its designated location to be stored in
the warehouse
so when the relevant pressure pad
detects that the relevant box has been
placed in its designated location in the
warehouse an event is raised
and the relevant information about the
event is sent to the calling code
which will then display the relevant
information about the event and the
processed item to the supervisor's
screen
so this is a real-time monitoring system
for a warehouse
please note I have never actually worked
in a warehouse and this example is
purely from my imagination it's
obviously always best when building a
particular kind of application or system
to consult with someone with the
relevant domain knowledge this example
only serves to help with the
understanding of generic delegates and
events
right let's begin
let's create a.net core console
application
[Music]
and let's name this project hardware
warehouse management system so this
project will contain our calling client
code
we want this project to reference
another component responsible for
generic functionality associated with a
warehouse
so let's add a net standard Library
project and let's name this project
warehouse management system API
let's create a reference to the
warehouse management system API project
from the hardware warehouse management
system project
so we'll start by building the generic
functionality for our hardware warehouse
management system by adding code to our
warehouse management system API project
so we have separated concerns here we
have created two components one to
handle the specific functionality of the
hardware warehouse this functionality
will be encapsulated in the hardware
warehouse management system project
the code in this component will focus on
displaying the status and data about
specific Hardware related items to a
screen in real time as certain events
are raised
the other component is a generic
component specifically created for
handling the management of any warehouse
this component is responsible for racing
events associated with any warehouse to
the calling client code
when each event is raised from the
warehouse management system API
component to the hardware warehouse
management system component the relevant
data associated with the relevant event
and item is displayed to the screen in
real time to for example a supervisor so
let's write the code for our example
let's start by deleting the default
class from our warehouse management
system API project
let's add a class named custom queue in
the custom queue class we are going to
wrap the functionality provided by the
built-in c-sharp generic Q data
structure
we are going to customize the
functionality of the queue by adding two
events simply put one event will be
raised when an item is added to the
queue the other event will be raised
when an item is removed from the queue
as you may have guessed when an item is
added to the queue this denotes an item
for example a box containing drills
entering the warehouse the second event
denotes the event that will be raised
for example once the relevant box
containing the drills has been processed
I.E has been placed in its specified
location to be stored within the
warehouse
so let's make our custom Q class a
generic class
a generic class can contain more than
one type parameter but we are only going
to add one type parameter for this class
so using the capital t is the generally
accepted way to represent the
placeholder for a type parameter and a
generic type definition if there were
two type parameters
we could add a comma and then the
capital letter U to represent a second
type parameter this generic class will
only contain one type parameter so let's
remove the second type parameter
so by adding t with an angle brackets
following our class's name we have
created our custom Q class as a generic
class
so let's create a private member
variable of the inbuilt c-sharp Q
generic collection type
so let's define this member variable as
the generic Q data type and let's name
our variable underscore Q
and you can see that a directive at the
top of our code already exists to the
system.collections.generic namespace the
queue data type is a member of the
system.collections.generic namespace
let's create a parameterless Constructor
for the custom queue class
let's instantiate the underscore Q
variable within our Constructor
let's create a read-only property and
Implement code that Returns the number
of items currently stored in the
underscore queue collection
let's create the definitions for the
public methods that will be included in
the custom queue class
we'll first add their definitions and
then implement the code for each method
let's create a method named add item
that contains a parameter of type t
this method will be called when an item
is added to the custom queue
let's create a method named get item
this method will return an item stored
within the queue to the calling code
this method returns a value of type T
and contains no parameters
let's create a protected virtual method
named On Cue changed this method will
encapsulate the functionality for
raising the events of this class
it contains a parameter of a
user-defined type that we need to create
the value passed to this parameter will
store information about the relevant
event being raised from within this
method
so let's create a class definition for a
class named Q event args this class will
extend the functionality of the
system.eventorg's built-in class so
let's write code so that this class
inherits from the system.event args
built-in class
let's add a read write autoimplemented
property named message to the queue
event args class
the message property will return a
string narrative which will include
details about the item to which the
event pertains as well as information
about the event itself
so the last method we need to create is
a public method named get enumerator so
this method returns a value of the
generic I enumerator interface type to
the calling code
so let's implement the code for this
method the implementation is one line of
code which Returns the value returned
from the underscore Q member variables
Getty numerator method by implementing
this get enumerator method on our custom
queue class this will allow the calling
code to Traverse the elements stored
within the custom Q class collection
using a for each Loop
we'll demonstrate this at an appropriate
time during the development of this
example
so let's create our delegate type
which will be used to define an event in
the custom queue class I.E the event
that is raised when an item is added to
the queue and also an event raised when
an item is returned from the queue
let's define our generic delegate type
directly within the warehouse management
system API namespace let's create a
public delegate named Q event handler
that does not return a value and
contains two generic parameters
the first parameter is of type t
and the second parameter is of Type U
this is a generic delegate that contains
two type parameters
so we must include the placeholder data
types within angle brackets
the capital letter T represents a
placeholder for the first generic data
type parameter and the capital letter U
represents a placeholder for the second
generic data type parameter
so now we can define the definition for
the event contained within our custom
queue user-defined type
so to do this we use the event keyword
this is a public event to which we want
our calling code to subscribe so we
proceed the event keyword with the
public access modifier then we follow
the event keyword with the generic
delegate type that we have just defined
the generic Q event handler delegate and
let's strongly type our generic delegate
let's pass the custom Q generic
user-defined type to the first generic
data type parameter and let's pass the Q
event args use the defined type to the
second generic data type parameter let's
name our event custom queue event
so let's implement the code for the On-Q
changed method this method centralizes
the code for raising the custom queue
event event
so the first argument passed to this
event
is of the generic user-defined type
named custom queue which is the class in
which this method resides
so to get the current object we can use
the this keyword
the second argument is the argument
passed to this method's parameter and
will contain information about the event
and is of type Q event args so we pass
the On Cue changed methods argument a as
the second arguments to the custom queue
event event
so let's implement the code for the add
item method
firstly let's write code to add the item
passed into the add item method to the
underscore queue collection
note that in order to add an item to the
built-in C Sharp Q data structure we
must use the NQ method
so before we write the code to raise our
custom queue event event which will be
executed every time the relevant queue
is changed let's look at the Q generic
collection type in C sharp
when we use the NQ method to add an item
to a queue data structure in C sharp the
underlying functionality of the Q
collection type is adding the relevant
item to the back of the queue as it were
so later when we write the functionality
to retrieve an item from the queue we'll
use the DQ method the DQ method
retrieves an item from the front of the
queue
the queue data structure works on a fifo
basis fifo is an acronym for first in
first out
so the item in the queue that was the
first item to be added to the queue when
the NQ method was executed will be the
first item to be retrieved from the
queue when the DQ method is executed
we'll use the DQ method when we
implement the functionality for the get
item method
note that when the DQ method is executed
to retrieve an item from the queue the
first item added to the queue which will
be the item at the front of the queue is
removed from the queue which means the
item that was added to the queue right
after the item that was just retrieved
from the queue takes the position
previously occupied by the item just
retrieved from the queue
so the way the ordering of the Q data
structure works is just like how a queue
works in the real world for example
consider people queuing to buy tickets
to an event
when a person joins the queue the person
joins the Queue at the back of the queue
the person at the front of the queue
buys a ticket then leaves the queue
making the person that was behind the
person who has just left the queue now
the person at the front of the queue
this person can now buy a ticket and the
cycle repeats
so after the NQ method has been executed
this means the relevant queue has
changed so we want to raise an
appropriate event to the calling client
code to let the client code know that
the relevant queue has changed
when the event is raised we can pass two
arguments to the calling client the
first argument is the queue itself which
is encapsulated in our custom Q generic
class
the second argument contains information
about the event as well as information
about the item that triggered the event
this information is encapsulated in the
queue event args user-defined type
so let's write code to instantiate an
object of type Q event args
and we want to send information about
the item being added to the queue
through the message property which is a
member of the Q event args class to the
calling client code
notice at the moment if we include a
full stop after the item variable we
don't get any properties in the
intellisense drop down list in Visual
Studio
for example we don't get the ID name or
type properties that could provide
useful information to the calling client
code about the item that triggered the
relevant event
so how can we solve this problem
we can solve this problem by ensuring
that items added to the queue Implement
a specific interface
then we can add a constraint to our
generic custom queue class that enforces
a rule that type T must implement the
relevant interface
so let's add an interface to our
warehouse management system API project
let's name this interface I entity
primary properties
foreign
let's add three property definitions ID
as integer name as string and type as
string
let's go back to the custom Q class
and let's add a constraint to our custom
queue class
so we can add the constraint like this
where space t colon I entity primary
properties
so we now know that any item added to
the queue will implement the I entity
primary properties interface which means
the item will have an ID property a name
property and a type property
so because we have added this constraint
we should now be able to see these
properties if we add a DOT at the end of
an object passed into the add item
method as an argument
so let's add a DOT at the end of the
item variable and you can see the ID
name and type properties in the
intellisense drop down list
this means we can include the
information stored in these properties
in our message to the calling client
code
so in the message property let's add a
timestamp
foreign
so I'm going to add a new class named
constants so that I can store a string
constant that can be reused to represent
a date time format for this project
and let's include the formatting for the
relevant date time stamp using our date
time format constant
followed by the relevant ID name and
type property stored for the relevant
item
great but let's say we want to include
additional information in our message to
the calling client code
we want to include the quantity of units
that make up the item that has entered
the warehouse remember items are
composed of units we also want to
include the value of each unit with the
additional information
for design reasons we don't want to
include the quantity property and the
unit value property in the I entity
primary properties interface
so let's add another interface to the
warehouse management system API project
and let's name this interface I entity
additional properties
let's add two properties to this
interface
quantity as int unit value as decimal
let's go back to our custom queue class
and let's add another constraint to the
custom Q class definition
to do this we can simply add a comma and
then I entity additional properties to
the custom Q class definition for
now let's see if our new properties
appear in the intellisense drop down
when we add a DOT after the item
variable which is of type t
and there you can see our additional
properties quantity and unit value
so let's include the quantity property
in our message
the unit value property will be
displayed to the user along with all the
other properties in a tabular format
every time the queue changes we'll see
this when we develop the calling client
code
let's add the following narrative text
literal to the message property has been
added to the queue
so let's implement the code for the get
item method so let's first assign The
Returned value from the relevant Q IE
the value returned from the DQ method to
a local variable of type t
the DQ method also removes the item at
the front of the queue
so let's write the code that will notify
the calling client that the queue has
changed
let's set the message property of the
queue event args object in much the same
way as we did in the add item method
the difference is that this method
denotes that the relevant item in the
queue has been processed so let's
reflect this in our narrative
so let's add the literal text has been
processed to our narrative
so an item is removed from the queue
once the item has been processed by
processed we mean that the item has been
placed in a designated location in the
warehouse for storage
the item is added to the queue
when it first enters the warehouse then
the item is scanned
when the item is scanned the event and
the add item method is raised
when a predefined amount of items are in
the queue the items in the queue are
processed I.E each item is placed in a
specific location in the warehouse to be
stored
each time an item is placed in its
location for storage a pressure pad is
activated at the relevant storage
location which raises an event to notify
the calling client code that the
relevant item has been processed
we have now implemented the code for the
custom queue class and we have also
completed the code for the warehouse
management system API component
let's implement the code for the calling
client
so in this example we have a warehouse
used for storing Hardware related items
when we refer to an item in the context
of this example we mean a collection of
a certain type of Hardware item
so for example we are going to use four
distinct item types drill hammer ladder
and paintbrush
so in this example an item could refer
to a collection of drills a collection
of hammers a collection of paint brushes
or a collection of ladders
so let's define an abstract class named
Hardware item which must implement the
interfaces we created in the warehouse
management system API component namely
the I entity primary properties and the
I entity additional properties
interfaces
we have already created a reference from
the hardware warehouse management system
project
to the warehouse management system API
project but we must also ensure that we
have included a directive at the top of
our code to the warehouse management
system API namespace
so let's do this
great
let's create auto implemented properties
for each property definition in the I
entity primary properties and the int
additional properties interfaces
foreign
classes representing a specific type of
item that will be stored in the
warehouse let's start with the drill
so we must make the drill class inherit
from the hardware item abstract class
let's say we also wish to create more
specific Properties or behaviors for the
drill class we can do this by adding an
interface to define specific Properties
or behaviors relating to the drill class
by creating an interface that the drill
class must implement
so let's create an interface named I
drill
for the sake of keeping our example
simple let's just add one property
definition for the ideal interface let's
make it a string property and name it
drill brand name
so this property is only intended to
acknowledge that we are able to extend
each of the classes representing
specific products in this example but we
won't be using these properties further
than this
so let's ensure that the drill class
implements the idrill interface
let's implement the same design for our
other items ladder
paintbrush
and Hammer
great
so let's go to our main method and
simulate items entering the warehouse by
adding items to a custom queue object
let's instantiate an object of the
generic custom Q class to find in the
warehouse management system API
component that our calling client code
references
let's strongly type our queue with the
hardware item abstract class
we do this because all items in our
warehouse will inherit from the hardware
item abstract class
so the next step is to wire up a method
to handle the event defined within the
custom queue class this is an event that
is raised whenever the relevant queue
changes for example an item is added to
the queue denoting a hardware item
entering the warehouse or an item is
removed from the queue denoting that the
item has been processed I.E the item has
been moved to a predefined location
within the warehouse for storage
so to wire up the relevant event we type
the object reference custom queue add a
DOT and then we can see the relevant
event in the intellisense drop down list
so let's select the event named custom
queue event
then we can type in the plus equals
operator to establish a method that we
want to execute when the relevant event
is raised
so we can Auto generate the relevant
method through Visual Studio by pressing
the Tab Key
we can now implement the custom code we
want to execute it every time the queue
changes within the relevant method we
have just generated
so let's first write code to clear the
screen
so notice that the first argument passed
to this method is an object of type
custom Q it is named sender because the
event that is fired resides in this
class
so the event notification is sent from
the custom cue class when the relevant
event is fired
so the second argument is of type Q
event args and encapsulates relevant
information about the relevant event so
let's write code to check if the sender
object which is an object of type custom
queue contains any items
so to do this we can use an if statement
to check the Q length property of the
custom queue class
so if the Q length property is greater
than zero let's write the properties of
the items stored within the queue to the
console screen
let's create a private method named
write values in queue to screen that
contains a parameter of type custom
queue
which is strongly typed with the
abstract class Hardware item
let's write a for each Loop to Traverse
the items in the queue and write each
item's properties to the console screen
so these items will be written to the
screen in a tabular format so I've made
sure that each column is set to a
specific length
let's call this method from the custom
queue underscore custom queue event
method I.E the event handler method
so let's go to the main method create 10
Hardware items and add them to the
custom queue
I'm actually going to change the name of
the variable we are using to reference
the custom queue object
to a more specific name
let's change the name of this variable
from Custom queue to Hardware item queue
so I've already uploaded the code for
this example to GitHub
in the interests of time let's copy the
code that adds Hardware item objects to
the relevant queue
from the code I have already uploaded to
a GitHub repository so let's navigate to
this web page
from within our browsers and copy the
relevant code
foreign
and then appropriately paste this code
into the main method
so this code which adds Hardware items
to the custom queue simulates items
entering the warehouse
to give this example a more real world
feeling
to simulate that these items are
entering the warehouse at random times
I'm using the
system.threading.thread.sleep method to
add a time delay between the lines of
code that add items to the queue
so for example here we are delaying the
main thread for 2 000 milliseconds which
equates to a two second delay
let's go back to the custom queue
underscore custom queue event method and
add an else part to the Top If statement
so if the queue does not contain any
items we want to Output status
information to the user let's output the
following text to the user when the
queue does not contain any items
status all items have been processed
so let's run the code
and you can see that each time an item
is added to the queue an event is raised
and our calling client code writes the
details of the item to the console
screen great
so let's create the code for when items
in the queue are processed
for the sake of keeping this example
simple let's say that when the queue
contains five items we want the items in
the queue to be processed
so let's define a constant as an integer
and let's name this constant batch size
let's set this constant to a value of 5.
so we can now write a nested if
statement in our custom queue underscore
customqueue event method that checks if
the queue has five items in it if the
queue has five items in it we want code
to execute that simulates the processing
of each of the items in the queue
so let's write a private method named
process items it contains one parameter
of type custom queue that is strongly
typed with the hardware item
user-defined abstract type
let's write code to Simply Traverse the
items in the queue through the use of a
while loop the condition of the while
loop is that iterations of the loop must
continue while the queue is not empty
so we want to de-queue each of the items
in the queue meaning that the item has
been processed remember that when the
get item method is called the DQ method
on the underlying queue data structure
is called which means the item at the
front of the queue is removed from the
queue let's add a three second delay
before each item is removed from the
queue to simulate that the item is being
processed
let's go to the custom queue underscore
custom queue event method and write code
to call the process items method
let's run the code
now you can see that when the queue is
populated with five items the items are
processed and each item is removed from
the queue once the relevant item has
been processed
when the queue is empty the next five
items are added to the queue and once
five items have entered the queue the
items are processed one by one until the
queue is empty
great
so to further clarify to the user the
status of each item in the queue let's
write the message property of the event
args object to the console screen
this message property contains a
narrative describing the relevant item
and the event pertaining to the item
let's run the code
excellent the supervisor can see
relevant information about the item as
well as the event
the supervisor can see status output for
each item as it enters the warehouse and
is processed
the final thing to do is enhance the
formatting of the output
in the interests of time let's copy and
paste relevant formatting functionality
from GitHub
so let's navigate to this location in
our browsers
and please feel free to copy my actions
here
let's copy the code situated between the
two comments that have the text headings
let's then paste the code into our code
editors
we can then write the code to call these
output formatting related Methods at
appropriate points within the custom
queue underscore customque event method
foreign
let's run the code
thanks
so lastly I'm going to put a few break
points in the code to clarify the
execution path of the code
so in the calling client code when the
code adds an item to the custom queue
you can see the event that resides in
the custom queue class in the warehouse
management system API component is
raised and the code in the calling
client handles the event through a
method that was designated to handle the
event when the calling client code
subscribed to the relevant event
when the predefined batch size of five
has been reached I.E when the custom
queue contains five items each item is
processed once an item has been
processed it is removed from the queue
the event is raised to the client and
the client method that has been
designated to handle the event is
executed
when the calling client subscribed to
the event in the custom queue class a
method that resides in the calling
client code was designated to handle the
event when the event is raised the
relevant event handler method is
executed in this event handler method we
are writing status information to the
screen so that this information is
available to for example a supervisor in
real time
I hope you've enjoyed this video which
demonstrates the use of the c-sharp
generic built-in Q data type a generic
class with constraints and the use of a
generic delegate used to define an event
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing
and please ring the bell so that you'll
be notified of future content released
from this channel
if you feel you have gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it'll be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released from this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
your comments are of course always
welcome
the code created in this tutorial can be
downloaded from GitHub please see a link
to the relevant repository Below in the
description
[Music]
hi and welcome
this video is the fourth and final part
in a video series on c-sharp generics
[Music]
shop generics video series is the fifth
part of a course on advanced c-sharp
concepts
in this video we are going to first look
at how in terms of generics the msil
code or Microsoft Intermediate Language
code is handled by the common language
runtime under the hood as it were
if you stick around till the end I'll
show you how a utility that ships with
Visual Studio for Windows named
Intermediate Language disassembler can
be used to disassemble an assembly
whereby the msil code can be extracted
from the.net assembly and inspected
we'll then look at a basic code example
whereby the factory design pattern is
implemented and generic supplied to our
Factory class so that this class can be
reused to instantiate multiple types
we'll apply multiple constraints to our
Factory class to enforce design rules
driven by the requirement for our code
example
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
releases from this channel
so let's briefly look at how generics in
the msil code or Microsoft Intermediate
Language code is handled by the common
language runtime
I'm not going to go into a lot of detail
in this regard but please check out this
Microsoft document for a more detailed
description regarding how generics is
handled by the.net runtime
this document explains how generics is
handled differently for Value types and
reference types by the.net runtime
let's look at a few excerpts from this
document
specialized generic types are created
one time for each unique value type that
is used as a parameter
this means conversions are no longer
necessary because each specialized
generic class natively contains the
value type
generics Works somewhat differently for
reference types the first time a generic
type is constructed with any reference
type the runtime creates a specialized
generic type with object references
substituted for the parameters in the
msil
then every time that a constructed type
is instantiated with a reference type as
its parameter regardless of what type it
is the runtime reuses the previously
created specialized version of the
generic type
this is possible because all references
are the same size
because the number of reference types
can vary wildly from program to program
the c-sharp implementation of generics
greatly reduces the amount of Code by
reducing to one the number of
specialized classes created by the
compiler
for generic classes of reference types
so two benefits are highlighted in this
document with regards to value types and
reference types in terms of generics
conversions are no longer necessary
because each specialized generic class
natively contains the value type
generics greatly reduces the amount of
Code by reducing to 1 the number of
specialized classes created by the
compiler for generic classes of
reference types
my goal here was only to draw your
attention to the extra information
regarding how the.net runtime implements
generics and c-sharp under the hood as
it were
please read this document to gain a
better understanding in this regard
so let's Implement our code example
where we'll implement the factory design
pattern and use generics so that the
object instantiation code is abstracted
and can be used to instantiate multiple
types
we'll use multiple constraints
appropriate to our requirement so that
special rules at compile time are
enforced
let's create a.net core console app and
let's name it digital product inventory
application
so in this very basic example we're
going to create classes for representing
specific types of digital products
we'll also create classes for
encapsulating data associated with the
various categories of digital products
we are going to create a factory class
used to abstract and centralize the
construction of these different types
into objects
we'll then copy code from a GitHub
repository and this code will serve as
the calling client code
this client code includes a link query
used to compile a report containing
digital product information and their
Associated digital product category
information
code is also included to Output the
results of this link query to the
console screen
this example is more about understanding
the application of generics than
understanding link
please don't worry if you don't fully
understand the link aspect of this
tutorial link will be discussed in
detail in upcoming tutorials
so let's create our Factory class
this tutorial is not about design
patterns but the factory design pattern
is used in this example as a device to
show how generics and constraints can be
implemented to abstract the construction
of objects of varying types special
rules will also be applied through the
use of constraints
let's name this class Factory pattern
so this class contains two generic types
so let's include the constraints for the
type T parameter
and our definition of the factory
pattern class
as we know from our previous tutorials
constraints enforce compile time rules
on our type parameters
so this constraint is enforcing a
compile time rule that type T must be a
reference type denoted by the class
constraint must inherit from Type U I.E
the other generic type parameter and the
type T argument must also contain a
public parameterless Constructor
this is denoted by the new constraint
note that when the new constraint is
used with other constraints the new
constraint must be specified last
in our code we are going to instantiate
an object of type t
note that a generic type cannot be
instantiated if the new constraint is
not specified for the type that must be
instantiated we'll prove this in a bit
so let's also add a constraint to our
u-type parameter
we can do this by including another
where keyword followed by the relevant
constraint or constraints for the U data
type note that this class constraint for
this example is in fact redundant for
the U parameter and I will remove this
from the relevant GitHub repository I'm
applying this constraint at this point
in the tutorial to show how we are able
to apply constraints to multiple type
parameters
thank you
so let's add a method to our class and
name it get instance
so the code Logic for this method is
instantiating an object of type T which
is derived from Type U the instantiated
object is then returned to the calling
code
so now just to show you that we cannot
instantiate an object of type T unless
the new constraint has been
appropriately applied to the relevant
class definition let's comment out the
new constraint and you can see that the
c-sharp compiler immediately complains
we must ensure that we have
appropriately applied the new constraint
in order to be able to create an
instance of type T so let's now create
an interface named I primary properties
let's add two property definitions to
our interface ID as int and title as
string so now let's go back to the
factory pattern class let's add a
constraint to enforce a rule that Type U
must implement the I primary properties
interface
so we can do this by adding a constraint
like this
remember the class constraint can be
removed from the U type parameter
the code will still work as expected
with it there but for this example it is
redundant
so let's add an abstract class name to
product base that implements the I
primary properties interface
let's implement the properties defined
in the I primary properties interface as
Auto implemented properties
let's create an abstract class named
category base that also implements the I
primary properties interface
let's extend the product based class by
adding an auto implemented property
named category ID
the category ID property will be
included within our link query to join
the data stored in a list containing
objects of type category base to
relevant product objects stored in a
list containing objects of type product
base we'll look at the link query in a
bit
let's extend the category-based abstract
class and add an autoimplemented
property named description
so let's create our category classes
let's create our digital product classes
so our category classes inherit from the
category-based abstract class and our
product classes inherit from the product
base abstract class
note that both the product-based
abstract class and the category base
abstract class both implement the I
primary properties interface
notice I am extending these classes with
additional properties just for
demonstration purposes these additional
properties won't be used further than
this in this example
so I'm going to create a class named
product view model and this class will
be used as a template to centralize
information from the product related
classes with information from their
relevant category related classes
so we want our calling code which we'll
copy from GitHub to create several
product objects and related category
objects then using link we'll return a
collection of objects of type product
view model to the calling code this
collection will be the result of a join
operation joining objects of type
product base with the relevant objects
of type category base
link is not the focus of this tutorial
but I thought I'd include the link
functionality to make our example more
interesting
as stated earlier we'll discuss Link in
detail in upcoming tutorials so don't
worry if you don't understand the link
related code so I've already uploaded
the code for this example to GitHub
so let's copy the code which will serve
as our calling client code from the
relevant GitHub repository which can be
found at this location this URL has also
been included Below in the description
let's copy all the code from within the
program class like this
and let's select the main method within
our program class and our code editors
and paste the code we have copied from
GitHub over the main method in our code
editors like this
and you can see that we have red
squiggly lines under our code relating
to our generic lists
so to fix this let's add a directive to
the
system.collections.generic namespace
and in our get products method where we
are executing a link query we have a red
squiggly line here
so to fix this we need to add a
directive to the system.link namespace
great
so let's look at the calling client code
we have just copied from GitHub the add
properties to product method
encapsulates functionality to add values
to the properties of an object of type
product base
the add properties to category method
encapsulates functionality to add values
to the properties of an object of type
category base
you can see that these methods are
currently public methods but they don't
need to be public so we can change these
methods to private
I'll update the relevant GitHub
repository with this change
you can see here that our link query is
encapsulated in a method named get
products
the link query is selecting all product
related objects in the products list and
joining each product with its relevant
category
each product is joined to its relevant
category through the category ID
property
the result of the link query is a
collection of objects of type product
view model which appropriately combines
product information with relevant
category information
as stated earlier link will be discussed
in detail in upcoming tutorials
so let's look at the code in the main
method
so notice how the factory pattern
generic class is being used to
instantiate each object of type product
base
for example we are instantiating an
object here which represents a digital
book entitled The Old Man and the Sea we
are instantiating an object here
representing a movie entitled Shawshank
Redemption
the factory patent generic class is then
reused to instantiate several objects of
type category base
for example we are instantiating an
object representing the category with
the title of movie here and we are
instantiating an object representing the
product category here with the title of
music
so the factory pattern class has been
implemented to abstract the object
creation functionality for this code
example
we have adapted the factory design
pattern to our requirements by imposing
rules on the instantiation process
through the use of constraints
so in the main method we are
instantiating our product related
objects appropriately adding values to
the relevant object's properties then
adding the objects to a list of product
related objects
we are doing the same thing for our
category related objects
we are then appropriately amalgamating
information from the product related
objects with relevant information from
the category related objects into an
object of type product view model
through the use of a link query
we are then looping through the items
returned from the link query and writing
each item's properties to the console
screen
so let's run the code
great
I want to draw your attention back to
the constraints in our Factory pattern
class
note that we have implemented a
constraint that the U argument must
implement the I primary properties
interface so if for example we were to
comment out the code in our class
definition for the category-based
abstract class that indicates that this
class implements the I primary
properties interface look at how the
c-sharp compiler responds
note how the constraint imposes a rule
at compile time that the U argument must
implement the I primary properties
interface
for more detailed information on
constraints please navigate to this URL
so we were discussing earlier how
the.net runtime handles generics based
on the msil code
we are able to examine the msil code for
an assembly by using a utility like for
example the IL disassembler utility
so now if we wanted to look at the msil
code for this project we can use this
utility this utility ships with the
visual Studio for Windows IDE
so let's run our developer command
prompt for visual studio
let's make the directory where our
Target assembly file resides our current
directory
we can then type the following command
this command generates a file containing
the msil code within the directory of
the relevant assembly this is the msil
code that resides within the target
assembly created when we built our
c-sharp project
so now we can open the file we have just
created in a text editor like notepad
and look at the relevant msil code
great
for more detail on the IL disassembler
please navigate to this URL
all urls mentioned in this tutorial can
be found Below in the description
lastly if you are interested in reading
about generics and reflection please
navigate to this URL
if you are interested in reading about
generics and attributes please navigate
to this URL reflection can be used to
inspect generic types in c-sharp at
runtime and this will be discussed in
later videos created on c-sharp
reflection
generics used with attributes will be
covered in future videos created on
c-sharp attributes
in this video series we discussed that
generics was introduced in c-sharp
version 2. we looked at why it is better
to use the strongly typed generic list
to store a collection of items rather
than an arraylist for this purpose
we discuss the benefits of generics
generic classes and methods combine
reusability type safety and efficiency
in a way that their non-generic
counterparts cannot
we looked at how constraints can be
applied to generic type parameters in
order to enforce compiled time rules on
generic type parameters
we created a code example representing a
warehouse management system in this
example we used the built-in c-sharp
generic Q collection type to store
objects representing various Hardware
items that enter the warehouse and are
subsequently processed
generic delegates and events were
instrumental in this real-time
monitoring system
lastly in this video we briefly looked
at how the msil code or Microsoft
Intermediate Language code is used by
the.net runtime to efficiently handle
both value types and reference types in
terms of generics
we also implemented a generic version of
the factory design pattern and a basic
code example to demonstrate how the use
of multiple constraints can be applied
to generic types in order to enforce
special requirement-driven compile time
rules
I hope you have enjoyed this video
series on c-sharp generics for more
videos on advanced c-sharp concepts and
much more please consider subscribing
and please ring the bell so that you'll
be notified of future content released
from this channel
if you feel you have gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released from this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
your comments are of course welcome
the code created in this tutorial can be
downloaded from GitHub please see a link
to the relevant repository Below in the
description
[Music]
hi and welcome this is the sixth
tutorial in an advanced c-sharp course
and this is the first part of a video
series on asynchronous programming using
the c-sharp programming language in this
video we'll look at an overview of
asynchronous programming in c-sharp with
a particular emphasis on Microsoft's
recommended approach to using
asynchronous programming for new
development
Microsoft's recommended approach to
including asynchronous behavior in new
applications is to use the task-based
asynchronous pattern tab
the two Legacy methods for providing
asynchronous Behavior are event-based
asynchronous pattern EAP
and asynchronous programming model APM
the event-based asynchronous pattern
will not be discussed in this video
series
but if you wish to learn more about this
Legacy pattern please navigate to this
URL
we have already covered the asynchronous
programming model APM and the advanced
course in part 3.5 of this course we
looked at using a callback method and a
built-in delegate to implement
asynchronous Behavior
please navigate to this URL to view a
video released on this channel that
covers the asynchronous programming
model APM
as always all links mentioned in this
video can be found Below in the
description
later on in this tutorial we'll look
closer at how using the task-based
asynchronous pattern can result in
asynchronous behavior for our
applications and ultimately ensure that
our users have a smooth user experience
when using our applications
for more videos on Advanced t-sharp
topics and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified for future
videos released from this channel
right so tab or task-based asynchronous
pattern is the recommended design
pattern for creating asynchronous
behavior for new development c-sharp
version 5 produced a simplified approach
to asynchronous programming that
leverages asynchronous support in
the.net framework 4.5 and higher.net
core and the windows runtime
dotnet framework 4.5 or higher and net
core contain many members that work with
async and await
these members can be identified by their
names which contain an async suffix
so what gave rise to the task-based
asynchronous pattern
we live in an age where our applications
should not only run on desktop computers
and notebook computers our applications
in a lot of cases will also need to run
on smaller devices for example handheld
devices like tablets and mobile phones
these smaller devices may not have the
powerful resources that desktop
computers and notebook computers have to
handle resource intensive operations
so an operation like for example
downloading a large document from a
remote server May ultimately result in
poor performance of our applications a
poor ux or user experience with our
applications can cause user frustration
and cause our users to take a dim view
of our applications
thank you
implementing this pattern in our code
can result in a smoother ux user
experience
the code is easy to implement and even
though the code results in asynchronous
Behavior the code can be written in a
synchronous way we'll look at a code
example to further elucidate this point
in a bit
the c-sharp compiler makes it very
difficult for a developer to implement
the task-based asynchronous pattern
incorrectly for example in an IDE like
Visual Studio red squiggly lines will
appear in appropriate regions of code if
the relevant asynchronous code has been
written incorrectly
messages will also be made available to
the developer from the c-sharp compiler
in Visual Studio to guide the developer
on how to fix the incorrect code
so how can long-running operations
result in a poor user experience with
our applications
say for example a button is clicked and
within the event handler method of the
relevant button click event a long
running operation is invoked if this
operation were to be invoked
synchronously the threat of execution on
which the relevant time-consuming
operation is running is blocked until
this long-running operation has
completed
while the relevant thread is blocked the
application is unresponsive meaning the
user cannot perform other operations
with the application until the
long-running operation completes
so this ultimately results in poor user
experience with our application
there are two kinds of blocking
operations CPU bound operations and I O
bound operations so let's look at CPU
bound operations
this occurs when an intensive
computation needs to be carried out by
the device's CPU
for example you might have a game
running and a single action from the
user may cause multiple characters in
the game to incur damages
the calculations of these damages may be
CPU intensive an operation like this if
done synchronously can result in the UI
to freeze or stutter
running the calculations in parallel
across multiple cores can alleviate this
and make the UI or user interface
perform smoothly and responsively so the
developer could use the task.run method
to run calculations in parallel to
alleviate the effects that handling
these computations synchronously could
have on the user's experience
other examples of applications that may
need to run intensive CPU bound
operations could be Financial or
scientific applications
so let's look at i o bound operations i
o bound operations are performed when
requesting data from a network accessing
a database or reading and writing to a
file system
the blocking effect during an i o bound
operation causes the CPU to wait for the
relevant i o bound operation to complete
so the CPU will need to wait basically
light dormant while for example
information is retrieved from an Azure
SQL database that resides in the cloud
once the information is retrieved and
for example appears in local memory the
information can then be processed by the
CPU the CPU can only then continue
processing other instructions while the
i o bound operation is running the CPU
is blocked from running any other
operations performance will not be
optimal for our applications when the
code for these relatively long running
operations are handled synchronously
i o bound operations are the most common
encountered blocking operations so we
are going to focus on resolving the
blocking effect of i o bound operations
through the implementation of the
task-based asynchronous pattern in this
video
note that generally speaking io-bound
operations are far slower than CPU bound
operations in business applications i o
bound operations will be far more common
operations that will be encountered and
should be handled asynchronously and let
me emphasize i o bound processing is far
slower than CPU processing
so let's look at a basic code example we
won't implement this particular code in
Visual Studio
this code serves to give us a general
idea of what the task-based asynchronous
pattern looks like in c-sharp code and
we'll also get an idea of how it works
let's first look at the synchronous
version of this code example we'll then
modify the code so that it is
implemented using the task-based
asynchronous pattern so in this
synchronous version of the code example
we have a higher level button click
event handler named button underscore
click
when the user clicks the button that
invokes code within this event handler
method a call to a method named get
document content is made this method
accepts an argument which is the name of
the remote file that our code needs to
retrieve and process so let's say that
the path of the remote document is
handled under the hood as it were
a relatively long running operation is
encapsulated within a method named get
document content as string which is
invoked within the get document content
method the long-running operation in
this case is downloading a document from
a remote server after the long-running
operation completes a string is returned
from the get document content as string
method containing the relevant document
content
a method named save document locally is
then called
which as the name suggests saves the
content returned from the get document
content as string method to a local file
store as a new file
the document content is then returned to
the calling code from the get document
content method
once the get document content method
completes and Returns the content to the
button-click event handler method the
content is subsequently displayed to the
user this is denoted by a call to a
method named display content
so while the code is performing the
relatively long-running operation
executed by the get document content as
string method the thread of execution on
which this operation is running will be
blocked leaving the CPU idle until the
get document content as string method
completes and returns a value
so let's say that we are in luck and
there is an asynchronous version of the
get document content as string method
available to us named get document
content as string async
note that this version of the method has
the same name as the synchronous version
with the exception of the async suffix
added to the end of the method's name
adding the async suffix to the end of an
asynchronous method's name is a naming
convention used for asynchronous methods
that are part of the implementation of
the task-based asynchronous pattern
so the method we want to call is named
get document content as string async
so we need to use the await operator
preceding the method called to the get
document content as string async method
like this
this is telling the c-sharp compiler
that we wish to call this method
asynchronously
if any of our method calls within the
get document content method are
awaitable
as is now the case here
where we are using the await operator we
need to include the async modifier in
the method signature of the method where
one or more asynchronous method calls
are invoked which as stated is denoted
by the await operator preceding the
relevant asynchronous method being
called
so let's include the async modifier in
the method signature for the get
document content method
let's also adhere to the correct naming
convention so let's rename the get
document content method to get document
content async like this
the get document content async method
will return a string value once the
async method has completed but when it
is first called and hasn't necessarily
completed a generic task object will be
returned
I'll elaborate on what the task object
and the generic task object is in a bit
so we must include the relevant generic
task type in the method signature of the
get document content async method like
this
we are calling an asynchronous method
from the button click event handler
named button underscore click so we need
to include the await operator preceding
a call to the get document content async
method like this
we are now calling an awaitable method
within the button underscore click event
handler method so we need to include the
async modifier within the method
signature of the button underscore click
event handler method like this
we don't need to include a task type in
the button underscore click event
handler method signature because it is a
high level event handler
all asynchronous methods that are not
high level event handlers like the
button underscore click event handler
will return a task object if the
relevant method does not return a value
or a generic task object if the relevant
method does return a value as is the
case with our get document content async
method which returns a string so for
example the get document content async
method returns a string value once it
has completed so to reflect that this
method is an async method that returns a
string value we include the generic task
type in its method signature and this
generic task type accepts the string
data type as its argument
so basically the new asynchronous
implementation of this example code
means that when asynchronous methods are
called with the await operator the
control is immediately returned to the
calling code meaning that the thread of
execution on which it is executed is
free to process other operations while
the asynchronous method is running
so the CPU is not left idle while an i o
bound operation is underway as is the
case in this example where a file is
retrieved from a remote server
in this asynchronous implementation the
CPU thread of execution on which the
relevant relatively long running
operation was invoked can be used to
perform other operations while the
remote file is being retrieved from the
remote server
in this case the UI thread is the thread
of execution so if for example the user
needed to execute a different button
click event
another operation could run concurrently
to the long-running operation and vote
by the get document content as string
async method
this means the user's experience with
the application will not be negatively
impacted by this relatively long-running
operation
the user experience is not adversely
affected by the relatively long-running
operation performed by the get document
content as string async method
so when the get document content has
string async method is called a generic
task object is returned immediately to
the calling code
the string value that is returned only
once the get document content has string
async method completes is returned at
that point of execution in the code but
at a later time
while the relatively long operation
invoked by the get document content as
string async method is running other
operations can be performed by the user
without negatively impacting the user's
experience with the relevant application
basically the task object is a state
machine if you'd like a comprehensive
explanation of what a state machine is
please navigate to this URL
the task object encapsulates information
about the asynchronous process
and either delivers the final result
back once the asynchronous method
completes or throws an exception if an
exception occurs within the asynchronous
method so we can put traditional try
catch code around the call to our
asynchronous methods as if the methods
were synchronous to handle exceptions
that may occur in our asynchronous
methods
so when the awaitable method is executed
a task object is immediately returned to
the calling code the string value is
only returned later once the awaitable
method completes
when the task object is returned the
relevant thread of execution is then
immediately released to the caller the
thread of execution is not blocked while
the asynchronous operation is running
so the async method first Returns the
task object in this case a generic task
object that promises to return a string
value at this point in the code once the
operation performed within the relevant
async method has completed
this model is known as the promise model
of asynchrony
if you wish to read more about the
promise model of asynchrony please
navigate to this URL on the c-sharp side
of things the c-sharp compiler
transforms your code into a state
machine that keeps track of things like
yielding execution when an await is
reached and resuming execution when a
background job has finished
the async modifier is doing two things
number one it is a message to the
c-sharp compiler that this method can
use the await operator inside it the
await operator designates the suspension
points in the execution
number two the method itself can be
awaited by methods that are calling it
the async modifier also is a message to
the c-sharp compiler that the method can
be called asynchronously using the await
operator
the await operator is telling the
compiler that the execution of code
cannot continue past this point until
the awaited method has completed
so in the meantime control returns to
the caller of the method which is the UI
thread in this case which allows for
example the user to click other buttons
while the incomplete asynchronous task
is still running
under the hood as it were when you
compile your code through Visual Studio
the c-sharp compiler rewrites your code
into Intermediate Language splitting
apart your async method calls into lots
of callback methods
so we as coders don't need to worry
about the complexity of implementing
callback methods ourselves
with this explanation I'm admittedly in
the interests of brevity glossing over a
mass of complexity involved in making
this asynchronous abstraction model work
for more detail and a comprehensive
diagram of how the underlying framework
is handling the asynchronous code please
navigate to this URL
note that the line of code that includes
the await operator is in fact doing two
things
it is returning a task object when it is
first invoked and then later when the
asynchronous operation completes it is
returning the value returned by the
relevant method in this case a string
value
so we can write the code like this to
make this clearer we could first assign
the task object returned by the relevant
asynchronous method to a variable of
type task this is done without the await
operator
we can then call the relevant task
object with the await operator later in
the code in this case the string value
will be returned from the task object
when the relevant operation completes
in this particular example we can write
what is achieved by two lines of code
here in one line of code like this
so let's put the code back to how we
originally had it
so let's create a code example
we are going to create two.net projects
one project will represent the calling
client code I.E the code that will
contain the user interface the other
project will represent the server-side
code
the calling client will be implemented
as a uwp project or universal windows
platform project
the server-side code will be implemented
as a web API project
this example is very basic we'll
Implement a button click event handler
on the user interface which will be
included within the uwp project
code within the relevant button click
event handler will asynchronously call a
method included within the web API
server side component
in the relevant web API action method
we'll deliberately Implement a delay to
represent a task that is relatively time
consuming and should be awaited by our
client code IE should be called
asynchronously
we'll Implement another button-click
operation on the uwp projects user
interface which will Implement code that
runs a much faster local operation
we'll run the code and demonstrate that
when clicking the button that kicks off
the time consuming operation implemented
in the web API code that this does not
impede the user's experience and the
user is able to click the second button
which carries out a much faster local
operation
perhaps the user can click this several
times while the application is awaiting
for the more time consuming operation
carried out on the server side to
complete and return a value to the
calling client code
will prove that the fast local
operations can run concurrently while
longer asynchronous operations are
running in the background
and because we have written the long
running operation to run asynchronously
that the user's experience is not
adversely affected by running the
relatively long operation
so let's create a web API project
and let's name this project test time
consuming operation web API
note that when the web API project is
created a controller class is
automatically included in the web API
project
this automatically included class is
named weather forecast controller code
within this controller simply outputs
made up data representing a weather
forecast we'll come back to this web API
project in a bit and create our own
controller class
let's create a uwp project
and let's name this project test client
async uwp
okay so let's go back to the web API
project and let's create a web API
controller class
foreign
and let's name this controller test long
operation controller
so the code in this method is faking a
relatively long running operation that
needs to be performed before returning a
value to the client code
the call to the server-side component's
relevant action method will be handled
through an HTTP get request from our uwp
project
we'll write the code for this in a bit
please note that this tutorial is not
about uwp or web API so I'm not going to
go into detail explaining these two
types of projects the focus is on
writing code using the task-based
asynchronous pattern in c-sharp to
ensure that the user's experience is not
adversely affected by long-running
operations perhaps being run remotely
through a web API call
so note that we are not only going to
use the task-based asynchronous pattern
on the client side we are also using the
task-based asynchronous pattern for this
action method in the server-side code
we have discussed how client-side UI
synchronous code can negatively affect
the user's experience and that
implementing the task-based asynchronous
pattern on the client side can make the
user's experience much smoother
the task-based asynchronous pattern can
also be implemented for server-side
components like for example a web API
component or an asp.net MVC component
this creates better performance on the
server side which ultimately can affect
client-side UI responsiveness
on the server side it means for example
that the thread of execution on which a
relatively time-consuming method runs
will not be blocked while the relevant
time-consuming operation is performed
and the relevant thread can handle other
requests while the relatively time
consuming operation is running
in terms of the user's experience if a
time-consuming operation blocks the
threat of execution because of
synchronous code this could tie up
server-side resources causing a delay in
performance on the server side and at
worst could cause for example a client's
HTTP request to time out
so server-side synchronous code can also
adversely affect the user's experience
so in order to fake the long-running
operation I'm simply going to create an
await statement and use the task classes
delay method to pause the method
at this point for 5 000 milliseconds in
other words it will cause a delay of 5
Seconds
once the five second delay representing
our long operation is finished the code
returns a string value so let's return
the text web API long running operation
completed to the calling client code
so let's test the code
and you can see that the output from the
weather forecast controller code is
written to the browser window
let's change the URI in our browsers to
point to the controller code that we
have just created so let's make a get
request to our test long operation
controller
great there is a clear delay of 5
Seconds before the expected string
results is written to our browser
windows
okay let's write the calling client code
in our uwp project
so we are going to drag two buttons onto
the design surface from our list of xaml
controls
let's drag our first button onto the
design surface
foreign
a bit
let's name this button BTN local
operation
let's label this button local operation
so let's zoom in a bit so we can have a
clearer view of our button
let's drag our second button onto the
design surface
so let's enlarge this button a bit
let's name this button BTN web API call
let's label this button web API call
so let's drag a list view component onto
our design surface
you can see the list view is currently
the same size as our design surface and
is covering the whole design surface
let's resize it so its contents will
appear to the right of our buttons
let's name our list view component lvw
output
you may have noticed that creating a
beautiful design for our UI here is not
a concern for this video
but in the interests of Saving Time this
design will be adequate for what we are
demonstrating here
it might be a good time to make the
point that ux is not just about
Aesthetics which of course is very
important but it is also about
performance
we are focusing on how we can write
asynchronous code to drastically improve
the user's experience so let's go to the
code behind our design surface and let's
write a private method named add list
item
and here we are writing a piece of
reusable code for adding a string value
to our list view component
within each of our two button click
event handlers we want to add relevant
string results to our list view
component we'll write the code for the
two button click event handlers in a bit
let's create two integer member
variables one named underscore local
operation counter and the other named
underscore web API operation counter
let's write the code that executes when
the button that performs the fast local
operation is executed
so we can Auto generate the method
signature for the relevant button-click
event handler method by double clicking
on the relevant button on our design
surface like this
so when this button is clicked we want
to increment the underscore local
operation counter integer member
variable by a value of 1. and append
this integer value to the literal text
fast local operation completed
we are adding this string value to the
list view component that we named lvw
output through a call to a private
method named add list item
so let's implement the code to call the
web API method that implements the long
running operation and we want this code
to fire when we click the button we have
named BTN web API call
so let's double click the relevant
button on our design surface to Auto
generate the relevant button click event
handler method like this
so the code share is a little bit more
involved than the code that runs when
the user clicks the button we have named
BTN local operation
let's first write the code to increment
the underscore web API counter integer
member variable by a value of 1. so we
are going to use the HTTP client
built-in class to make a HTTP get
request to the relevant web API action
method
so let's instantiate a HTTP client
object like this
the HTTP class is a member of the
system.net.http namespace
so let's ensure we include the relevant
directive
let's use a HTTP response message object
to encapsulate The Returned value
returned from our web API components
relevant action method
so we need to run this line of code
asynchronously which means we need to
include the await operator before
calling the get async method note the
get async method has the async suffix so
we know that this is an asynchronous
method note the red squiggly line here
because in order to run this code
asynchronously we need to include the
async modifier within our BTN web API
call underscore click event handler
methods method signature
note that we don't need to return a task
object from this button-click event
handler method because this method is a
high level event handler
so we need to pass the URI of our web
API action method to the get async
method
so that the relevant action method is
invoked on the server when the user
clicks the button named
BTN web API call
so let's run our web API component by
running the relevant web API project
so a get request is made to the weather
forecast controller by default remember
this code was Auto generated when we
created our web API project
let's change the URI within our browsers
so that a get request is made to the get
action method within our test long
operation controller class let's refresh
our browsers
and note a five second delay before the
expected result is written to the
browser window
so let's copy the URI that our browser
is currently pointing to let's go to our
uwp project and let's paste the URI here
as a string argument to the HTTP
client.getasync awaitable method
let's call an awaitable method named
read as string async to retrieve a
Content returned from our call to the
web API component
then let's write code to add The
Returned string to the list view
component that we named lvw output
we can do this through a call to our
private method named add list item
so let's move the code that increments
the underscore web API counter variable
to just above where we have added our
string results to the list view
component
so we need to ensure that our web API
project is first running before we run
our uwp client code so let's do that
let's run the uwp project so we can test
the performance of our user interface
let's first test that we are able to get
a result back from our web API component
so let's click the button labeled web
API call
great the result appears on the list
view as expected
the result is added to the list View and
we can see it as output on the client
side displayed within the list view
component
notice that there was a delay before the
result appeared in the list view because
we want this call to emulate awaiting a
long-running operation now let's test
that when we execute this long-running
operation that the UI thread is not
blocked the UI thread should not be
blocked because we are making our get
request to the web API component
asynchronously
so let's once again click the button to
make our web API request
and now let's click the other button
several times to run our fast local
operation several times
great and you can see that the local
task is running even while awaiting the
result from our remote long running
server-side operation
the UI thread is not being blocked and
our asynchronous code is working as
expected
you can see that when the asynchronous
operation completes the appropriate
result is added to the list view
component
and while we were waiting for the
relatively long-running asynchronous
operation to complete we were able to
run several local fast operations so the
fast local operations are running
concurrently with the long-running
asynchronous operation
so let's make several requests to our
web API component and let's also run our
fast local operation concurrently
several times
great and you can see by the output
appearing in our list view component
that the user's experience is smooth the
user's experience is not adversely
affected when the long-running web API
operation is executed the user is able
to perform other operations using our
application without the user's
experience being impeded by other
incomplete long-running operations this
is why the task-based asynchronous
pattern is so powerful
this in my opinion is one of the reasons
why the c-sharp language is so powerful
because a lot of the complexity in
making a long-running operation run
asynchronously is hidden from the
developer this complexity is abstracted
the c-sharp language makes the inclusion
of asynchronous behavior in our
applications easy to implement
please download the code for yourself
and play around with the code so you can
experience how the relevant asynchronous
code results in a far smoother user
experience than if the same code were
implemented synchronously the links to
the relevant GitHub repositories have
been included Below in the description
I hope you have enjoyed this video on
using the task-based asynchronous
pattern in our code to include
asynchronous behavior in our
applications
in my opinion this is one of the most
important Concepts in c-sharp
programming in an age where smaller
devices are used to perform relatively
long-running operations we need to
ensure that our users experience with
our applications are not adversely
affected by poor performance of our
applications caused by synchronous code
implementations of relatively
long-running operations we can
drastically improve the performance of
our applications by running these
relatively long-running operations
asynchronously
this is now easy to achieve using the
c-sharp programming language
please consider subscribing for more
content on advanced c-sharp concepts and
much more and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please hit the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos released on this channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
I of course love reading your comments
so please feel free to share your
thoughts with me in the comments section
as always the code examples that were
created in this video can be downloaded
from GitHub a link to the relevant
GitHub repositories can be found Below
in the description
thank you and take care
[Music]
hi and welcome to the second part of a
tutorial on asynchronous programming
using the c-sharp programming language
this video is also the second part of
the sixth tutorial in an advanced
c-sharp course
in the first part of this video series
on asynchronous programming using
c-sharp we specifically focused on the
async modifier the await operator and
the task object
[Music]
we discussed that there are essentially
two CPU blocking operations that we may
encounter When developing our
applications namely i o bound operations
and CPU bound operations these CPU
blocking operations can result in poor
performance of our applications and
ultimately result in a poor user
experience ux with our applications
[Music]
with the increased use of smaller
devices that may not have the
capabilities of say for example a
notebook or desktop computer to handle
resource intensive operations it is
essential that we apply coding
methodologies in our applications to
ensure that the users are not negatively
impacted by potentially resource
intensive CPU bound or i o bound
long-running operations
the way c-sharp developers can solve
these ux issues is through the
implementation of asynchronous code
the c-sharp programming language makes
available several methodologies that can
be implemented in our code to achieve
asynchronous Behavior namely
asynchronous programming model APM this
was covered in part 3.5 of this Advanced
c-sharp course event-based asynchronous
pattern EAP and the task-based
asynchronous pattern tab Microsoft's
recommended approach to implementing
asynchronous behavior in our c-sharp
code is to use the task-based
asynchronous pattern
I recommend that you watch the first
part of this video series before
watching this video
for more videos on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
so in the first part of this video
series on asynchronous programming in
c-sharp we focused on how to apply the
task-based asynchronous pattern to
handle the negative ux effects that can
be caused by long-running i o bound
operations in this video we'll focus on
how to apply the task-based asynchronous
pattern to handle the negative impact on
the user's ux that can be caused by
long-running CPU bound operations
so let's start by briefly going over
what is meant by i o bound operations
and CPU bound operations
io-bound tasks are delegated to the i o
subsystem and while the relevant i o
bound operation is handled the CPU
thread on which the i o bound operation
was invoked is blocked from running any
other operations so while the relevant i
o bound operation is running the CPU is
idle
all other operations are blocked from
being processed by the CPU this can mean
that if the relevant operation runs for
a relatively long period of time that a
delay in the user's interface or
responsiveness can be noticed by the
user
this means the user's experience is
negatively impacted by the relevant
relatively long-running i o bound
operation
so the characteristic of non-cpu-bound
processes is that they don't occupy the
CPU when they are performing other
operations like I O bound operations
i o bound operations include tasks such
as writing to your hard disk drive
waiting for a response from the network
or querying a database
these operations cannot be sped up by
fast local processing as performance is
constrained by the i o subsystems
hardware and performance
the hardware drive's write speed will
dictate how long something takes to be
written the third-party server response
time will determine how quickly you can
process a request CPU bound means the
limiting factor in a particular task or
algorithm is doing calculations the only
way to speed up the relevant CPU bound
operation is increased CPU power
adding more memory a faster i o for
example will not help
examples of CPU bound tasks are video
audio content conversion compression
algorithms
search algorithms Graphics processing
rendering games or videos heavy
mathematical computations like
calculating factorials matrix
multiplication finding prime numbers
Etc encryption decryption operations
so basically tasks that require the CPU
to perform computations
so tasks that perform
particularly intensive calculations may
cause performance issues and ultimately
ux issues when a user runs our
applications
the asynchronous handling of CPU bound
operations are implemented differently
than the way I O bound operations are
implemented for a comprehensive
explanation of how we can handle i o
bound operations asynchronously in
c-sharp code please view the first part
of this video series
in this video we'll focus on handling
CPU bound operations asynchronously
so let's look at a code example where
we'll run a number of CPU bound
operations in parallel to one another so
let's look at a code example where we'll
run a number of CPU bound operations in
parallel to one another which as we'll
demonstrate will result in an overall
performance advantage over running the
same CPU bound operations synchronously
so let's create a console application
and name it Financial trading platform
application
so the theme of this code example is a
trading platform the user of this
application can analyze stock market
charts that will include technical
indicators to help the user decide to
open or close a position regarding a
particular stock
I'm going to drastically simplify this
code example so that we can focus on the
principles involved in running multiple
computational operations asynchronously
the technical indicator information that
will be presented with the relevant
stock chart will be calculated on the
Fly
so in this example the technical
indicators that will be calculated on
the Fly and presented to the user with
the relevant stock chart or for example
stochastics fast moving average slow
moving average and Bollinger Bands
I'm not going to go into detail
regarding the meaning of these technical
indicators basically they aid the trader
in deciding whether a stock is
overbought or oversold or whether it has
growing price momentum or losing price
momentum ultimately these technical
indicators Aid the trader and the
Trader's decision to buy or sell a
quantity of a particular stock
so for example the stochastics the fast
moving average the slow moving average
and the Bollinger Bands can all be
calculated in parallel to one another
these calculations can be coded to run
concurrently rather than consecutively
so let's create a public class named
stock market technical analysis data
let's create a Constructor in our new
class
just for the sake of making this example
feel more authentic let's add three
parameters to this Constructor
we are going to keep this example very
simple and these parameters will not
actually be utilized
the arguments passed into these
parameters would be used as query
criteria when getting the raw stock
market data from a remote source
so the first parameter is stock symbol
AS string representing a particular
stock that the user wishes to analyze
for example Apple Amazon Tesla
Anglo gold whatever it might be the
second parameter represents the start
date and is defined as date time the
third parameter represents the end date
and is also defined as date time
so the date time arguments passed into
the second and third parameters will
represent time period criteria
pertaining to the time period over which
the relevant stock market data was
captured
in the interests of keeping this example
simple and in the interests of time we
are not going to include any code within
this Constructor
let's simply comment that code would go
here for retrieving data from a remote
server
so let's use our imaginations and say
that an i o bound asynchronous HTTP
request is made to a web API component
to download the relevant raw stock
market data within this Constructor
this data will be used to calculate
relevant technical indicator information
so that the user can glean meaningful
information from the downloaded raw
stock market related data
so let's create a few methods the first
four methods won't be all that
computationally intensive the first four
methods will be responsible for getting
the daily opening closing high and low
prices for the relevant stock
we'll then include the more
computationally intensive methods in
this class I.E the methods used for
calculating the relevant technical
indicator information for example the
stochastics fast moving average slow
moving average
Etc
so the first method will be responsible
for performing an operation to get the
daily opening prices for the relevant
stock from the raw data that is
retrieved within the Constructor
so this method is appropriately named
get opening prices
so The Returned values for all of these
methods defined within this class will
be an array of values of type decimal
this method will return an array of
decimal values representing the opening
prices for the relevant stock
so in each of the methods we'll create
for this class we'll write the method's
name and the thread ID representing the
thread on which the method will run to
the console screen
we are going to run multiple methods in
this class on multiple threads
concurrently
so let's write code to Output a
narrative to the screen which will serve
as a substitute for presenting the
actual data that would be required in a
real world application
foreign
to represent the duration of time the
operation performed by the relevant
method could take
let's make the thread on which the
method will run sleep for a specified
amount of time so for this method which
won't require much computation we'll
make the threat of execution sleep for a
thousand milliseconds which is one
second
and then let's just return an empty
decimal array
the data in this example is not
important in this example we want to
focus on the asynchronous principles
rather than the real world trading
platform example that this code
represents
okay and the other methods can be
implemented in much the same way let's
copy this method
and let's paste it eight times
then let's modify the code appropriately
for each method
so the next method is named get closing
prices
and is responsible for retrieving the
daily closing prices of the relevant
stock from the raw downloaded stock
market data
let's say it runs for a thousand
milliseconds
the next method is named get price highs
this method is responsible for getting
the daily highs for the relevant stock
this operation also runs for a thousand
milliseconds
the next method is named get price lows
this method is responsible for getting
the daily lows for the relevant stock
let's say this method runs for a
thousand milliseconds so all of the
methods that we have added so far run
for a thousand milliseconds
now we are getting to the methods that
are more computationally intensive this
method is named calculate stochastics
this method is responsible for
calculating technical indicator
information to help a Trader decide
whether a stock is overbought or
oversold
which ultimately AIDS the trader with
the decision to buy or sell a quantity
of a particular stock at the current
stock price
so let's say that this may be a
particularly computationally intensive
operation so let's say this operation
takes 10 seconds to complete so let's
pass in an argument of 10 000
milliseconds to the thread.sleep method
the next method is named calculate fast
moving average
let's say that this operation is also
computationally intensive so let's put
the relevant thread to sleep for six
seconds
the next method is named calculate slow
moving average let's put the relevant
thread to sleep for 7 Seconds
the next method is named calculate upper
bound Bollinger band
the next method is named calculate lower
let's put the relevant thread to sleep
for 5 seconds
let's put the thread on which this
method runs to sleep for five seconds
the Bollinger Bands can also be used by
Traders to ascertain whether the
relevant stock is overbought or oversold
which ultimately AIDS the Trader's
decision to buy or sell a quantity of
the relevant stock
so you can see that the last five
methods in this class could potentially
be computationally intensive as these
methods perform the operations of
calculating technical indicator
information from potentially large
amounts of raw stock market data
so let's go to the main method where
we'll write code to call the methods
that we have just created in our stock
market technical analysis data class
so let's first route to the console
screen that the main method is being
called in this output to the screen
let's include the ID of the thread on
which the main method will run
we can get the thread ID from the
thread.current thread dot managed thread
ID property and we also want to include
the thread name which of course is the
main method
so let's first demonstrate running the
first four methods in the stock market
technical analysis data class
synchronously
so that we can later run these methods
asynchronously and then compare the
performance difference
so let's instantiate a new object from
our stock market technical analysis data
user-defined type
let's say we want to download raw stock
market data relating to the fictional
stock represented by the symbol of
stkza for data captured between the
dates first of January 2010 and 1st of
January 2020 so we want the specified
stock market data for a particular stock
captured over a specified 10-year period
let's write code to run these methods
synchronously
so let's call the get opening prices
method
then the get closing prices method
then the get price highs method and
lastly the get price lows method
so in order to see how long it takes for
all four methods to complete let's
capture and store the current date time
value captured before we call the
relevant for methods
then let's subtract the date time value
captured before the four methods are run
from the date time value captured after
our four methods have completed
we are doing this so that we can see how
many seconds have elapsed between the
time we started to run our four methods
and the time the operations carried out
within these methods completed
so each of these methods have been coded
to take one thousand milliseconds or one
second to complete
let's add a method that denotes adding
the relevant data to the stock chart
that will be displayed to the trader
let's name this method display data on
chart
to keep things simple we can simply
write a message to the screen
representing that this method has
displayed the chart with all the
requested data including relevant
technical indicator information to the
trader
so let's run the code
and we can see from the results that all
of these methods are running
synchronously on the main thread
the thread ID of all of these methods is
one
we can see that each method ran
consecutively
we can see this because each of the four
methods ran for one second and a total
of four seconds was taken for all four
methods to complete
so now let's run these methods
asynchronously using the task.run method
so let's create a generic list to store
the generic tasks that accept an array
of decimals as the generic argument
remember each of our methods within the
stock market technical analysis data
class return an array of decimal values
let's ensure that we include the
relevant directives
so we need to include the
system.threading.tasks directive and we
also need to include the
system.collections.genericdirective
to be explicit let's first create our
generic task objects and appropriately
encapsulate the four method calls
and note that the generic argument for
each of the generic task objects is an
array of decimal values because each of
the relevant methods that the task
objects encapsulate returns an array of
decimal values
foreign
thank you
right let's write the code to add each
of the methods encapsulated within the
task objects to our list
now we can use the task.weight all
method to block the main thread until
all the tasks have completed
so all of our tasks will run in parallel
on background threads and the main
thread will be blocked by the
task.weight all method until all four
methods have completed
for more information on the task.weight
all method please navigate to this URL
so we need to pass our list of tasks to
the task.weight or method
but the task.waitol method expects an
array so let's use the two array method
to explicitly cast our list of generic
task objects to an array of generic task
objects
so at this point in the code I.E after
the task.weight or method call we know
that all of our tasks have completed so
we can get the results of each of our
tasks like this
great let's run the code
if we look at the output we can see that
the threads on which each of these
methods ran have different thread IDs
behind the scenes our code has run these
methods on different threads
when we ran these methods synchronously
these methods ran consecutively and ran
on one thread the main thread so I've
noticed there's a little problem with
the text output it says one seconds and
should say one second so let's add a
ternary operator to our code so that
when one second has elapsed our code
outputs one second rather than one
seconds
foreign
we only want to Output seconds if the
time that is elapsed is greater than one
second
let's run the code to check our fix
great
so let's write code to run all nine
methods synchronously and after this
we'll run all nine of these same methods
asynchronously so we'll now be running
some of the more computationally
intensive methods within our stock
market technical analysis data class in
this demonstration
foreign
let's run the code
and you can see that there is a
significant time lag when running this
code synchronously before all our
methods complete and output is presented
to the screen
yeah
let's write the code to run our methods
asynchronously using the task.run method
foreign
thank you
right let's run the code
you can see by the thread IDs outputted
to the screen that our methods are not
running on the main thread and are
running concurrently on background
threads
so in this video we have covered the
basics of running multiple CPU bound
operations asynchronously in this video
series on asynchronous programming in
c-sharp we have covered the basics of
how we can improve performance of our
applications through asynchronous
programming when encountering either of
the two types of blocking operations
namely i o bound operations and CPU
bound operations in the next video we'll
look at the best practices and caveats
of which we must be cognizant when
running i o bound and CPU bound
operations asynchronously
for more content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so that you'll be notified
of future content released from this
channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please smash the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos created by this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
I love reading your comments so please
feel free to share your thoughts with me
in the comment section
all code created in these videos can be
downloaded from GitHub
please see below in the description
links to the appropriate GitHub
repositories
[Music]
hi and welcome to the third part of a
tutorial on asynchronous programming
using the c-sharp programming language
this video is also the third part of the
sixth tutorial in an advanced c-sharp
course
in the first and second parts of this
video series we looked at how to apply
asynchronous code so as to alleviate the
negative effects of blocking operations
on an application's ux user experience
certain long-running operations
performed by our applications can be the
source of poor performance of our
applications
for example long-running operations
perform from WPF uwp or xamarin
applications can cause the UI user
interface to be periodically
unresponsive
this can be frustrating for the user of
our applications
the user will have a sub-optimal user
experience
C sharp provides us as developers with
appropriate tools to handle these
long-running operations asynchronously
with relative ease
so let's discuss the difference between
i o bound operations and CPU bound
operations and this will set us up for
later when we create a code example to
help us understand best practices when
applying asynchronous code to handle i o
bound or CPU bound operations
so in this video series we have already
discussed that the two kinds of CPU
blocking operations are CPU bound
operations and I O bound operations CPU
bound operations operations that perform
computations that need to be handled by
the CPU for example mathematical
operations encryption decryption
operations Graphics related operations
Financial calculations Etc basically
computational operations
i o bound operations or operations that
are delegated to the i o subsystem to
perform tasks such as writing to a hard
disk drive engaging the i o subsystem to
perform requests across the network file
handling operations Etc
we discussed that I O bound operations
are more commonly encountered than CPU
bound operations io-bound operations are
also generally a lot slower than CPU
bound operations
so this video is about best practices
when applying asynchronous code in our
applications
please view the first and second parts
of this video series on asynchronous
programming for a foundational
understanding of i o bound operations
and CPU bound operations in the context
of asynchronous programming in c-sharp
the recommended coding methodology
provided by Microsoft in the c-sharp
language to create asynchronous behavior
in our applications is known as the
task-based asynchronous pattern tap
over the last two videos in this series
we have discussed why we should
Implement asynchronous code
the simple answer is to improve the
performance of our applications in this
video Let's clarify the best practices
when applying writing code to run the
relevant code asynchronously
let's start with i o bound operations as
we have discussed io-bound operations
refer to operations like for example
file handling operations making requests
across a network writing data to a
database reading data from a database
Etc
operations that Engage The i o subsystem
we can handle io-bound operations
asynchronously both on the client side
for example in WPF uwp winforms or
xamarin applications we can also handle
i o bound operations asynchronously on
the server side and for example web API
or asp.net MVC applications
I have bound operations can be handled
using async await
in simple terms an asynchronous method
that returns a task object can be
preceded with the await operator which
means we can run the operation
asynchronously using async await
so for example for a.net client
application a button is clicked within
the button-click event handler method an
asynchronous method is invoked
so the asynchronous method is invoked on
the UI thread
this means that immediately after the
asynchronous method is invoked the UI
thread is free to be utilized to process
other operations
the user interface UI does not freeze
while the asynchronous method is running
the user is able to for example click
other buttons and invoke other
operations that can be invoked on the UI
thread
when an asynchronous method is called to
perform the relevant i o bound operation
the task is immediately delegated to the
i o subsystem
and instead of blocking the CPU as would
be the case if we were running the i o
bound operation synchronously the async
modifier and await operator instruct
the.net runtime to ensure that the CPU
is not blocked during the running of the
i o bound operation
this means that other operations can
utilize the CPU even while the i o bound
operation is running
very briefly what is happening is that
when the.net runtime encounters the
await operator as discussed the thread
on which the operation is invoked on the
client this would be the UI thread for
example is immediately released
so at this time code in the relevant
method is suspended I.E the lines of
code that follow the line of code that
contains the await operator and the
relevant method will not be executed
until the asynchronous i o bound
operation completes
while the asynchronous i o bound
operation is running however the UI
thread can be used to process other
operations for example invoked from
clicking another button on the UI
But A promise is returned to the line of
code containing the await operator is
made
so when the relevant asynchronous
operation completes the dotnet runtime
returns to the line of code containing
the await operator returns a value if
required and continues to execute the
lines of code
from that point in the relevant method
so the key point of this explanation is
that unlike for CPU bound operations i o
bound operations generally don't require
additional background threads in this
example the.net runtime is delegating
the i o bound operation to the i o
subsystem and not to a new thread
required from the thread pool
so I think before we continue let's
ensure that we have a clear
understanding of what is meant by the
following terms thread and thread pool
let's start with the term thread
a thread in computer science is short
for a thread of execution
threads are a way for a program to
divide itself into two or more
simultaneously or pseudo-simultaneously
running tasks
thread pool a thread pull is a group of
pre-instantiated idle threads which
stand ready to be given work so a thread
pool is created so that threads are
readily available to a program which
means when a program requires a thread
the program can acquire the thread from
the thread pool rather than incur the
overhead of instantiating a new thread
so let's go back to the example
demonstrated in the second part of this
video series where the task.run method
was used to run CPU bound operations
we demonstrated how each method that was
run through the implementation of the
task.run method was run on its own
dedicated background thread
so each time the task.run method is
invoked a new thread is taken from the
thread pool and used to run the relevant
CPU bound operation
so this resulted in the methods that
encapsulate the CPU bound operations
running concurrently I.E asynchronously
rather than running one after the other
I.E synchronously
if you haven't yet viewed the second
part of this video series please view
this video for a foundational
understanding of running multiple CPU
bound operations concurrently on
multiple background threads
so the key takeaway here is that when an
i o bound operation is run using the
async modifier and the await operator a
background thread is not required to
handle the operation the operation is
delegated by the.net runtime to the i o
subsystem
when a CPU bound operation is run using
the task.run method a background thread
is used to run the operation in the
background concurrently with the main
thread of execution
so now with a foundational understanding
of the differences of how i o bound and
CPU bound operations are handled
asynchronously let's look at Best
Practices regarding implementing each of
these types of operations asynchronously
so with running i o bound operations
asynchronously
there's less to be concerned about
simply because of the way the i o bound
operations are handled under the hood i
o bound operations can be delegated to
the i o subsystem and the need to use
additional background threads is not
necessary
with running CPU bound operations
asynchronously under the hood the.net
runtime employs additional background
threads to run the CPU bound operations
this for example means that multiple
tasks can run on the additional
background threads concurrently
there may be times where using multiple
threads is undesirable and may not
result in the desired performance
benefit there are times when running
multiple threads to perform tasks in
parallel may result in an overall poorer
performance
an example of this is running CPU bound
operations from within server-side code
for example code implemented for asp.net
MVC applications or code implemented for
web API components
we'll discuss why CPU bound operations
should be run synchronously
under these scenarios a bit later in
this video
so let's create a code example to help
us understand best practices when
confronted with issues relating to
asynchronous programming in c-sharp
the theme of this client application
will be the same as the theme we used in
the previous video in this series I.E a
financial trading platform
so in the last video we created a
console application to get a general
idea of running CPU bound operations
in this video Let's create a new blank
uwp project
uwp stands for universal windows
platform
let's name this project Financial
trading platform uwp
thank you
let's set up a basic UI user interface
let's drag a button onto the designer
surface
let's enlarge this button a bit
foreign
TN fast local operation
let's label this button fast local
operation
let's drag another button onto the
designer's surface just below the button
we have just added
let's name this button BTN CPU bound
operations let's label this button CPU
bound operations
and lastly let's drag a list view
control onto the designer surface and
position this control to the right of
our buttons like this
foreign
let's name this list view control lvw
output
so before we add code directly to this
file let's add another project to the
solution
we want our code to be reusable across
both server-side and client-side
projects so let's create a standard
Library project to our solution
and let's name this project stock market
component
let's add a reference to the stock
market component standard Library
project from our uwp client project
foreign
let's delete the class file that has
been generated in our standard Library
project
and let's add a class named stock market
data to our project
let's add a method named get data async
this method represents retrieving
relevant stock market data from a server
so it is an i o bound operation
the method will return a string to the
calling client code
so let's include the async modifier in
the method definition as well as a
generic task type that accepts a string
as the data type argument
notice that we have included the async
suffix in our method name
this lets the developer know that this
is code that should be called
asynchronously
so when the calling client code writes
code to call this method the developer
should include the await operator
preceding the method call as well as
include the async modifier in the method
definition of the method where the
relevant async call resides
so in the interests of time we'll simply
include placeholder code for this method
so let's use the task.delay method to
represent the time that the work could
take to carry out our relevant i o bound
task
so let's say this process takes 5
seconds so let's pass 5000 milliseconds
to the task.delay method
let's then simply return a string value
representing the stock market data that
has been retrieved from the remote
server
so let's simply return the literal text
stock market data from this method
we must also include the await operator
preceding our call to the task.delay
method
let's add a new class and let's name
this class stock market data analysis
so let's add a Constructor that contains
a parameter named data which will
represent the downloaded stock market
data
for the purposes of this example we
don't need to include any code within
the Constructor
so very much like the code example in
the previous video of this video series
let's include methods that calculate the
technical indicators that the user of
our application can use to Aid the
user's decision to buy or sell a
quantity of a particular stock
the technical indicators that we'll
refer to in this example will be the
fast moving average the slow moving
average stochastics and Bollinger Bands
if you are not familiar with these terms
don't worry the only thing that you need
to know to follow along with this
example is that calculating the data for
these Financial trading related
technical indicators are CPU intensive
they are CPU bound operations this is
why I've chosen these technical
indicators for this example IE to serve
as intensive long-running CPU bound
operations
so let's include a method to calculate
the fast moving average
so for these methods that represent CPU
bound operations we can simply put the
current thread to sleep for a specified
amount of time representing the time
that the relevant operation may take to
complete
so for this method let's put the thread
to sleep for six seconds
then for the purposes of this
demonstration let's simply return the
method name and the thread ID to the
calling code
foreign
let's duplicate this method three times
these additional three methods represent
the calculation of other technical
indicators
so we can maintain the general structure
of the methods that we have just created
as they are and simply change the method
names and the time durations that
represent the time the method takes to
complete
please note that the time durations that
are being specified here are completely
arbitrary and have been chosen only for
demonstration purposes
so this method represents calculating
the slow moving average
let's name this method calculate slow
moving average
let's put the relevant thread to sleep
for seven seconds
this method represents calculating the
stochastics
let's name this method calculate
stochastics let's put the relevant
thread to sleep for 10 seconds
this method represents calculating the
Bollinger Bands
let's name this method calculate
let's put the relevant thread to sleep
for five seconds
great so let's say that we now have a
reusable standard Library component for
calculating stock market technical
indicator information completed
so just to confirm that we have already
referenced this reusable component from
our uwp client application
great so let's add some code to add the
output of our methods to our list view
control that we named lvw output
so let's create a private method named
add list item
so you're of course welcome to follow me
as I create the code for this method or
you can of course copy the code from
GitHub a link to the relevant GitHub
repository is available Below in the
description
great so let's include code within our
button click event handlers
to create a button click event handler
definition we can simply go to our
designer surface and double click on the
relevant button like this
so we are first going to create code for
the fast local operation
foreign
so let's create the button click event
handling method definition for the
method that will execute our CPU bound
operations
these CPU bound operations are
encapsulated within the methods in our
stock market data analysis class that
reside in our standard Library project
let's ensure that we have a directive to
the stock market component namespace
so let's instantiate an object from our
stock market data analysis class
which resides in our stock market
component standard Library project for
now let's simply pass in the literal
Text data to the Constructor of the
stock market data analysis class to
represent the raw stock market data
downloaded from a remote server
so let's write code first to run all of
these CPU bound operations in parallel
to one another in much the same way as
we demonstrated in the code example in
the previous part of this video series
so firstly let's create a list of
generic task objects
that accept the string data type as
their data type arguments
so we know that the task.run method
returns a task object or generic task
object
the methods we wish to call all return
strings so each item in the relevant
list must be strongly typed with a
generic task object that accepts the
string data type as an argument
right so let's add the tasks we wish to
run to our list like this
then we can call the task.weight all
method
and in a bit I'll explain why the
task.weight or method is not the best
method to call in this context
foreign the code following the
task.weight all method we know that the
relevant methods that have run
asynchronously have completed so we can
add The Returned values from our methods
to our lvw output list view control
let's write the code to do this
right let's run the code
so now when I press the button marked
CPU bound operations notice that our UI
is unresponsive when we try to perform
any other operations
so I'm attempting to click the button
marked fast local operation the button
cannot be clicked because the screen is
frozen and therefore the output from
this action is not presented to the
screen in our list view component
the UI is unresponsive when I click the
button labeled fast local operation
because the UI thread is blocked
we have written our code to run a batch
of methods asynchronously but we have
also written code to block the UI thread
while our CPU bound operations are
running
the weight all method blocks the UI
thread until all the relevant tasks have
completed
so even though the CPU bound operations
like for example calculate stochastics
calculate fast moving average
Etc or running in parallel to one
another on background threads which will
give us a performance Advantage the UI
thread is being blocked while the CPU
bound operations are running this is not
ideal
so we can solve this issue because we
can in fact use the await operator when
running a batch of CPU bound operations
we can achieve this by using the when
all method instead of using the UI
blocking weight all method for running a
batch of CPU bound operations on
background threads
so let's replace the weight all method
with the when all method
for more information on the when all
method please navigate to this URL
so please note that the weight all
method does not return a task object or
generic task object so this means we
cannot call this method using async
await
the weight all method blocks the UI
thread until the tasks within the
relevant batch have completed the tasks
will be run concurrently on separate
background threads but the UI thread
will be blocked while the tasks are
running the when all method however does
return a task object or generic task
object this means we can call the when
all method using async await which means
that we can call the when or method to
run our tasks concurrently without
blocking the UI thread the UI will still
be responsive even while we are running
a batch of CPU bound operations when we
are using the when all method
so let's proceed our call to the win or
method with the await operator like this
we of course need to also include the
async modifier in the relevant button
click event handler method signature
like this
let's run the code
let's click the button marked CPU bound
operations
and now when we run the code the UI
thread is not blocked and we are able to
perform the fast local operation while
the CPU bound operations are running in
the background
we can perform other operations
concurrently while the relevant CPU
bound operations are running
so the task.run method returns a task
object or generic task object this means
we can use the await operator when we
call a CPU bound operation in this way
so to prove this rather than calling a
batch of CPU bound operations as we are
doing here let's run just one of the CPU
bound operations using the task.run
method
so let's run the calculate stochastics
method using the task.run method
so we can call this method on a
background thread asynchronously like
this
let's run the code
let's click the CPU bound operations
button and you can see that while the
calculate stochastics method is running
we are able to click the fast local
operation button the fast local
operation button can run concurrently
with the operation performed by the
calculate stochastics method and as we
have already proven we can also run a
batch of CPU bound operations on
background threads without blocking the
UI thread using the when all method
so let's change the code back to the way
it was so that we can call a batch of
CPU bound operations using task.run
async await and win all
then we could reuse this functionality
because we have written our CPU bound
operations
in a reusable Library component
this brings us to an important best
practice when implementing asynchronous
code for CPU bound operations
the developer should never include the
task.run method within reusable
components
always let the developer decide whether
to run an operation synchronously or
asynchronously so the consumer of the
component should always have the choice
to run an operation contained within for
example a library component
synchronously or asynchronously in our
example we have chosen to run our
operations encapsulated within the stock
market data analysis component project
asynchronously but we could have chosen
to run them synchronously we have proven
in our demonstration that running the
CPU bound operations asynchronously
gives us a huge performance Advantage we
did however have the choice to run these
operations synchronously or
asynchronously because the operations
are not implemented to run
asynchronously within any of the methods
of the component itself I.E we have not
implemented the task.run method within
the stock market data analysis component
project
so in the stock market data class we
have written an i o bound operation
that is responsible for downloading the
raw stock market data from a remote
server
this is different to a CPU bound
operation because it engages the i o
subsystem and not the thread pool to
acquire a background thread
so let's write code to run this i o
bound operation in order to download the
relevant raw stock market Data before
calculations are performed from the raw
stock market data
so we could invoke the i o bound method
lazily like this
so let's create a member variable named
underscore data then within the relevant
button click event handler we can check
to see if the underscore data variable
is null if it is null we can then run
the i o bound operation if the
underscore data variable is not null
then it means we have the data and can
pass it into the stock market data
analysis classes Constructor when
instantiating the relevant object
it is best to include the task.run
method close to the relevant event
handler method as we have done here
we have control over whether we want to
run these operations using the task.run
method on background threads or run them
synchronously
so calling the task.run method directly
from the relevant event handler method
like for example a button-click event
handler is a best practice
another best practice is that if the
relevant methods code doesn't need to
run on the original thread once the CPU
bound operations have completed then we
can in fact gain a bit of a performance
boost by not returning to the main
thread
the rule of thumb here is don't run code
on the main UI thread unless you have to
so we can achieve this performance boost
by using the configure await method
so the when all method returns a task
object which implements the configure
await method this means we can call the
configure await method like this
notice we are passing in false as the
parameter to this method we are saying
that after the calculations are
performed by the CPU bound operations
don't return to the main thread
so for example a context where this
would be appropriate would be once the
calculations are completed we want to
save the calculated data to a file
so in this scenario we don't want to
display the data on for example a stock
market chart we only want to save the
data locally in this context there is no
reason to return to the main thread
however in a context where we need to
display the information on a chart
we of course would need to return to the
main thread
the last best practice I would like to
include in this video
is that we should avoid including the
task.run method within methods
implemented in server-side components if
for example we implemented our trading
platform calculation functionality as a
software as a service application for
the purpose of providing calculated
technical indicator information to
web-based client trading platforms we
should not implement the CPU bound
operations using the task.run method on
the surface it may seem like this would
give us a performance Advantage but in
reality this puts an unnecessary strain
on server resources and ultimately can
adversely affect performance
the reason for this is that with a
server-side component say for example
implemented as an asp.net web API
component you may have thousands of HTTP
requests coming in to the relevant web
API component each HTTP request requires
a thread from the server's thread pool
if the code within the relevant
server-side method is coded to run four
operations asynchronously through the
use of the task.run method then your web
API component needs to acquire an
additional four threads to carry out the
instructions implemented in the relevant
method
this could cause an unacceptably high
use of server resources which could
adversely affect the overall performance
of the relevant server and ultimately
negatively impact the user's experience
with the relevant application
so the moral of this story is avoid
running additional background threads on
the server side rather run CPU bound
operations synchronously on the server
side you can still ensure that the
client-side UI is responsive by calling
the server side code using async await
remember an HTTP request from the
client's perspective is an i o bound
operation
note that running i o bound operations
on the server is different to running
CPU bound operations on the server an
example would be downloading the raw
stock market data from the server
perhaps the server-side code simply
retrieves the raw stock market data from
a database before returning the relevant
data to the client this i o bound
operation can be written on the server
using async await
the i o bound code does not require
additional threads and therefore
additional server-side resources when a
client request is made to run the method
responsible for running the relevant i o
bound operation on the server the thread
used for processing the request can be
released to handle other requests while
the relevant i o bound operation is
being performed
CPU bound operations that are invoked
using task.run will require additional
threads which means additional server
resources will be required
in summary when it comes to best
practices in terms of asynchronous
programming in c-sharp know the nature
of your asynchronous code ask the
question is the operation CPU bound or i
o bound and then apply the relevant
asynchronous code appropriately
avoid writing CPU bound operations
within reusable Library components using
the task.run method
[Music]
let the consumer of the library
component choose whether to run the CPU
bound operations synchronously or
asynchronously
methods that run i o bound operations
asynchronously included within reusable
Library components should include the
async suffix as part of the relevant
method's name
this will let the consumer of your
library know that the relevant method
should be run asynchronously using async
await
on the client side run CPU bound
operations close to the relevant UI
event handler method for example use the
task.run method directly within the
relevant button click event handler
method
if for example a button-click event
handler method needs to perform a CPU
bound operation asynchronously on a
background thread and subsequently code
within that method does not require a
return to the UI thread explicitly let
the.net runtime know that it is
unnecessary to return to the UI thread
once the CPU bound operation has
completed by appropriately calling the
configure await method this can result
in a performance boost
avoid running CPU bound operations on
the server side using the task.run
method
these operations require additional
threads which can result in a strain on
server-side resources and the issue will
be compounded if the server is handling
hundreds or thousands of HTTP requests
running i o bound operations for example
retrieving information from a web API
component reading data from a database
or routing data to a database on the
server side using async await it's good
practice because the main thread of
execution is free to handle other client
requests while the relevant i o bound
operation is running
so in this video we covered how to
implement best practices in our code
when running code asynchronously in C
sharp
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future videos
released from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
viewing this video please smash the like
button it will be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share any of the
videos created by this Channel with
anyone you feel May benefit from their
content
I love reading your comments so please
feel free to share your thoughts with me
in the comments section
all code created in these videos can be
downloaded from GitHub please see below
in the description links to the
appropriate GitHub repository
[Music]
hi and welcome to the fourth and final
video in a video series on asynchronous
programming in c sharp
this video is also part of the sixth
tutorial in an advanced c-sharp course
this video is a continuation of the last
three videos in this video series on
asynchronous programming so please view
each of the preceding videos in this
video series before viewing this video
[Music]
in this video we are going to look at
how to use a cancellation token Source
object to explicitly cancel an
asynchronous task or many asynchronous
tasks encode before the relevant tasks
or tasks have completed using one
cancellation token Source object
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
right so to gain an understanding of how
we are able to implement code to cancel
one asynchronous operation or multiple
asynchronous operations using one
cancellation token Source object let's
look at a practical code example
so I'm going to base this code example
on an example included in the Microsoft
Docs
so please navigate to this URL
a link to this URL has been included
Below in the description you can see
that this webpage is entitled cancel a
list of tasks in Brackets C sharp
so let's first look at the prerequisites
section of this document
I want to draw your attention to the
first prerequisite so this tutorial
requires the following dotnet 5 SDK
I'm actually not going to install
the.net 5 SDK on my windows platform at
this time and we'll be creating this
example using the.net core version 3.1
runtime
we are able to run this example using
the.net core version 3.1 runtime but we
will need to make a small modification
to the code to get this working
if you do decide to install the.net 5
SDK
know that the version available at the
time of writing this tutorial is not yet
the official release
it is an RC release which stands for
recommended candidate
so if you install Net 5 SDK I recommend
reading all Associated content that can
be found at this URL
that we can navigate to when we click
the link here marked dot Net 5 or later
SDK
this content can guide us in for example
which version of Visual Studio should be
installed to support the current RC
version of.net 5.
I also recommend reading this blog post
posted by Richard Lander this blog post
can be found at this URL
for a foundational understanding of.net
5 I recommend viewing a video created by
this channel which can be found at this
URL as always I have included all
relevant links Below in the description
I'll demonstrate how we are able to
implement and run this code example so
even if you decide not to install.net 5
SDK at this time and your latest version
of the.net runtime is.net core version
3.1 you're still able to follow along
with the implementation of this example
to enable running this code using
the.net core 3.1 runtime
we only need to apply one simple code
modification we'll apply this
modification when appropriate
let's look at the first paragraph on
this webpage in the first paragraph on
this webpage it states you can cancel an
asynchronous console application if you
don't want to wait for it to finish by
following the example in this topic you
can add a cancellation to an application
that downloads the contents of a list of
websites
you can cancel many tasks by associating
the cancellation token Source instance
with each task
if you select the enter key you cancel
all tasks that aren't yet complete
so we are going to base our practical
code example on the example here
provided in this webpage in the
Microsoft Docs
however we are going to implement our
code example as a uwp universal windows
platform project
instead of how it is implemented in this
Microsoft example as a net core console
application
we are going to copy aspects of the code
provided in the Microsoft code example
over to our code editor in a
step-by-step fashion so let's create a
uwp project
[Music]
and let's name our project can cancel
download async operations uwp
let's set up a basic UI user interface
so let's start by dragging a button onto
our designer surface
let's name this button BTN cancel
download and let's label this button
cancel download let's drag another
button onto the designer surface just
below the button we have just added
let's name this button BTN download
content let's label this button download
content let's drag a list view control
onto the designer surface
and position it so that the contents of
the list view control will appear to the
right of our buttons
let's name this list view control
lvw output
so let's access the main
page.examl.cs file to add the relevant
functionality for our UI
firstly let's ensure that we include all
the relevant using directives let's copy
them from the relevant section of the
relevant Microsoft web page and paste
them into our code editor like this
okay
let's then copy and paste the relevant
Fields like this
these fields contain an object reference
variable of type cancellation token
source that will be used to cancel the
relevant asynchronous tasks
a collection of URLs of type I
enumerable that will store the addresses
of the web pages that will be downloaded
by the relevant asynchronous operations
and an object reference variable of type
HTTP client that will handle
the connection to the relevant web pages
and also handle the download
functionality so in our application
these fields don't need to be static so
let's remove the static keywords
let's read the explanation provided
under the relevant code fragment
containing the fields we have just
copied
the cancellation token source is used to
Signal a requested cancellation to a
cancellation token
the HTTP client exposes the ability to
send HTTP requests and receive HTTP
responses the S underscore URL list
holds all the URLs that the application
plans to process
so the next section of the Microsoft web
page
there's an explanation of the code
within the entry point of the
application I.E the main method
as discussed the Microsoft code example
is based on the.net core console project
template
we are basing our application on the uwp
universal windows platform project
template so our code implementation will
be slightly different
so the main difference between our code
and the Microsoft example is that the
Microsoft example is implemented so that
when a user presses the enter key this
action will trigger the cancellation of
the relevant operations I.E the
operations responsible for downloading
the contents of a collection of web
pages
the uwp project template makes our code
implementation simpler because we can
leverage a button-click event handler
for this purpose
so in this Microsoft example the tasks
responsible for downloading the content
and outputting the relevant information
about the content are invoked through a
call to the method named sum page sizes
async the cancellation functionality is
handled in the code above this method
call
the method is implemented through a
Lambda expression here
code is implemented here using the when
any method the when any method basically
accepts an array of task objects
so the sum page sizes async method
returns a task
and the relevant Lambda expression
responsible for the cancellation
functionality is run using the task.run
method which also returns a task object
then an array containing a task object
encapsulating the cancellation operation
as discussed this is implemented as an
asynchronous method in the form of a
Lambda expression and the download
operation which is implemented as a
named method are passed into the when
any method the task dot when any method
will complete when any one of the
operations passed within the relevant
array argument completes
this means that if the user presses the
enter key before the download operation
IE which is invoked by the call to the
sum page sizes async method completes
this will effectively cancel the
asynchronous web page download
operations and Associated functionality
for example summing up the number of
bytes downloaded Etc
so we use the when all method in the
previous video which allowed us to run a
collection of tasks in parallel without
blocking the main thread
the when any method is similar but the
differences that the when all method
completes when all the relevant
operations have completed
the when any method completes when any
one of the relevant operations have
completed like the when all method the
when any method does not block the main
thread
so this means that in the context of the
Microsoft example here if the user
presses the enter key before the
operations invoked by the sum page sizes
async method complete this will result
in the downloading operations being
canceled the cancellation operation will
complete before the download operations
complete resulting in the download
operations being canceled
so we are going to implement similar
code within our example the differences
that we'll Implement a cancellation
button to enable the user to cancel the
download operations by pressing the
cancellation button rather than
implementing code to allow the user to
press the enter key for this purpose
with our uwp project we have the benefit
of a rich user interface
so let's go to our code behind class I.E
the
mainpage.xaml.cis file
and write a private method that will
encapsulate the functionality to add a
list item to our list view control I.E
the control we have named lvw output
we have already written a private method
encapsulating this functionality in our
previous example so let's navigate to
the relevant GitHub repository and copy
this private method this URL has been
included Below in the description
so here we can see the relevant method
named add list item let's copy this
method to our clipboards
and appropriately paste this method
within our main
page.xaml.cs file
so we can now write the codes to handle
the button click events
let's start with the download
functionality first let's create two
private methods that are responsible for
downloading the relevant content
calculating the size of the relevant
content and outputting Status
information to the user regarding the
relevant downloaded content so in the
Microsoft docs webpage let's look at the
section entitled create the asynchronous
some pages sizes method
let's copy this method and appropriately
paste the method within our
mainpage.xaml.cs file
in our example this method does not need
to be static so let's remove the static
keyword from the method definition of
the sum page sizes async method and
let's include the private access
modifier within the sum page sizes async
methods method definition
the next thing we need to modify in our
example for the sum page sizes async
method is where the code writes text to
the console screen our output will be
added to the list view control that we
named lvw output
so let's replace the console.write
methods with a call to our private
method named add list item we can remove
the backslash n character sequences from
the relevant text because we don't need
a line feed
due to the fact that we are adding each
item of text as its own item within the
list view control let's read the brief
description of this method provided
within the relevant Microsoft web page
the method starts by instantiating the
starting of a stopwatch
it then Loops through each URL
in the S underscore URL list and calls
process URL async
with each iteration the S underscore CTS
dot token is passed into the process URL
async method and the code returns a
generic task where T result is an
integer So within the relevant Microsoft
web page let's look at the section
entitled add process method
so the first line in this section reads
adds the following process URL async
method below the sum page sizes async
method
so let's copy the process URL async
method to our clipboards like this and
appropriately paste it within the main
page.xaml dot CS file like this
let's remove the static keyword from the
process URL async methods method
definition let's include the private
access modifier within the process URL
async methods method definition
let's replace the console.write method
with the add list item method like this
and if you'll remember before we started
implementing this example I spoke about
one of the prerequisites for creating
this code example the prerequisite being
the installation of the.net 5 SDK
so this is the only line of code that
doesn't work if we do not have the.net 5
SDK installed
and if we are running this example using
the.net core 3.1 runtime
so if you're running this project using
the.net core 3.1 runtime simply remove
the argument named token from the line
of code that calls the response.content
dot read as byte array async method
so let me just say that it is preferable
to pass in the token argument to this
method but if you don't wish to install
the.net 5 SDK at this time we are still
able to run The Code by removing the
token argument
this is not ideal but we are still able
to gain an understanding of the
cancellation token Source object and how
we are able to cancel one or more
asynchronous operations using one cancel
token Source object
let's read the explanation of this
method in the relevant Microsoft web
page
for any given URL the method will use
the client instance provided to get the
response as a byte array
the cancellation token instance is
passed into the HTTP client dot get
async and HTTP content dot read as byte
array async methods
the token is used to register for
requested cancellation
the length is returned after the URL and
length is written to the console
so obviously where it says the URL and
length is written to the console in our
example we are instead adding the
relevant text to our list view control
okay so let's implement the code for the
button that invokes the download
operations let's go to our designer
surface and double click on the button
labeled download content
let's implement the code that calls the
awaitable some page sizes async method
to perform the downloading of the
relevant content the calculation of the
size of the content as well as the
outputting of the relevant information
about the content to our list view
control
so in order to call this method
asynchronously we need to include the
await operator we also need to include
the async modifier within the method
definition of the relevant button-click
event handler
let's implement the cancellation
functionality
let's go to our designer surface and
double click on the button marked cancel
download
within the relevant button click event
handler let's implement the cancellation
functionality
to add the operation we can simply call
the cancel method on the relevant
cancellation token Source object like
this
okay let's run the code
firstly let's demonstrate what happens
when we click the download content
button
so let's allow the operations to
complete so we can see what happens when
we don't cancel the operations
we can see that the appropriate output
is presented to us as each operation
completes
when the content for a particular web
page has been downloaded the web page
URL followed by the number of bytes
downloaded is presented on our list view
control
and then once all the operations have
completed we are presented with the
total number of bytes downloaded as well
as the time that has elapsed between the
time when we started to download the
content and the time that the relevant
download operations completed great
so let's run the code again
let's click the download content button
and we are presented with the relevant
output in our list view control as
expected
right let's see what happens when we
press the cancel button
and a runtime error occurs
so in order to handle the cancellation
operation appropriately we need to
handle a particular type of exception
so when the cancel method is called
while the asynchronous operations are
running an exception of type task
canceled exception is thrown so we can
simply include our code that calls the
sum page sizes async method within try
catch code like this
and handle the task canceled exception
appropriately so we could access the
throne exception object to access
details about the exception but in this
case we only want to Output status
information to the user that the
operations have been canceled
so let's do this let's simply add the
literal text download operations
canceled
so remember we are passing a token
object as an argument to the get async
method here in the process URL async
method the process URL async method is
called within a loop from within the sum
page sizes async method this token
object allows us to trigger a
cancellation of all running asynchronous
tasks that reference this token object
when the cancel method is invoked on the
relevant cancellation token Source
object an exception of type task
canceled exception is thrown
and we can appropriately handle this
exception in our code
right let's run the code
so let's click the download content
button
and we are presented with the relevant
output as expected
so let's see what happens when we cancel
these operations
and there we have it the task canceled
exception is thrown when the cancel
method on the cancellation token Source
object is invoked and we are handling
the throne exception in our custom way
I.E in a way that suits our application
so we can see the output text download
operations canceled which is an expected
result
okay so we are also able to
automatically cancel the operations
after a predefined duration of time
so let's say we wanted our download
operations to be canceled if they
haven't completed within a specific time
duration
the way we can do this is by calling the
cancel after method on the relevant
cancellation token Source object
we can call this method before the
relevant operations are invoked like
this
we need to pass in the duration of time
in milliseconds to the cancel after
method this number represents the time
elapsed from the moment the relevant
operations are invoked so let's specify
3500 milliseconds or three and a half
seconds
let's run the code
and you can see that after three and a
half seconds the relevant operations are
automatically canceled
so you can see how this functionality
can be useful when we want to
automatically cancel an operation or
operations after a specified amount of
time
great
for further information about
asynchronous programming in c-sharp I
recommend reading relevant content
provided in the Microsoft Docs
foreign
so to summarize in this video series we
looked at Microsoft's recommended
approach for implementing code to run an
operation or multiple operations
asynchronously namely the task-based
asynchronous pattern
we discussed that running certain
relatively long-running CPU blocking
operations can adversely affect the
performance of our applications
to alleviate these negative effects on
user experience ux we can run these
relatively long-running CPU blocking
operations asynchronously
in order to implement the asynchronous
code correctly we first need to know the
nature of the operations that we wish to
run asynchronously
we need to first ask the question is the
relevant operation a cpu-bound operation
or is the relevant operation an i o
bound operation
in the first part of this video series
we focused on running i o bound
operations asynchronously using the
async modifier the await operator and
the task or generic task object
in the second part of this video series
we looked at running CPU bound
operations asynchronously using the
task.run method to run operations on
background threads
we also looked at the task.weight all
method in the third part of this video
series we looked at Best Practices when
implementing operations in c-sharp to
run asynchronously we also looked at the
task dot when all method and how it
differs from the task.weight all method
in this video which is the final part of
this video series we looked at how we
can provide the user with the ability to
cancel one or more running asynchronous
operations
before the relevant operations have
completed using one cancellation token
Source object we also demonstrated how
we can automate the cancellation of
running asynchronous operations after a
specified amount of time by calling the
cancel after method on the relevant
cancellation token Source object
I hope you have enjoyed the final video
in this video series on asynchronous
programming in c sharp the next Topic in
this Advanced c-sharp course will be
link language integrated query
for more content on advanced c-sharp
concepts and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
that you'll be notified of future
content released from this channel
if you feel you've gained value from
this video please hit the like button it
will be greatly appreciated please feel
free to share any videos released from
this Channel with anyone you feel May
benefit from their content I really
enjoy reading your comments so please
feel free to share your thoughts with me
in the comment section as always the
code in this tutorial can be downloaded
from GitHub a link to the relevant
GitHub repository has been included
Below in the description
foreign
[Music]
to the first part of a video series on
link
this video is also the first part of the
seventh tutorial in an advanced c-sharp
course later in this tutorial we'll look
at a code example to help with our
understanding of Link but let's first
answer the question what is link
link stands for language integrated
query
link is defined in the Microsoft docs as
the name for a set of Technologies based
on the integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
link was originally released as a major
part of NET Framework 3.5 in 2007
here is a paragraph
from the Microsoft docs which provides
an excellent overview of what link is
language integrated query link is the
name for a set of Technologies based on
the integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
traditionally
queries against data are expressed as
simple strings without type checking at
compile time or intellisense support
furthermore you have to learn a
different query language for each type
of data source SQL databases
XML documents various web services and
so on
with link a query is a first class
language construct just like classes
methods events
you write queries against strongly typed
collections of objects by using language
keywords and familiar operators
the link family of Technologies provides
a consistent query experience for
objects link to objects relational
databases linked to SQL and XML link to
XML
note that you can write link queries in
c-sharp for SQL Server databases XML
documents ado.net datasets and any
collection of objects that support the I
enumerable interface or the generic I
enumerable interface
so for example you can perform link
queries against collection types like an
array generic list generic dictionary
generic Q
generic stack Etc
basically any collection type that
implements the I enumerable interface or
the generic I enumerable interface
link support is also provided by Third
parties for many web services and other
database implementations
you can create custom providers using I
queryable
custom providers will not be discussed
in detail in this video series
if you would like to learn more about
implementing your own custom provider
please navigate to this URL
in this video series we'll primarily
focus on link to objects and link to
entities
link to entities provides language
integrated query link support that
enables developers to write queries
Against The Entity framework conceptual
model using either Visual Basic or
visual c-sharp
so Entity framework core is a modern
object database mapper for net it
supports link queries change tracking
updates and schema migrations
Entity framework core or EF core can be
used to work with many databases
including SQL databases on-premises and
Azure sqlite MySQL postgres and Azure
Cosmos DB
in this video series we won't look at
the link to data set or link to XML
please navigate to this URL for more
information on linked dataset and please
navigate to this URL for more
information on linked to XML
to get started with link in this video
we'll focus on link to objects so that
we can first get a basic idea of what
the implementation of Link looks like in
code and how it can be used for querying
c-sharp collections
so in the spirit of cross-platform
Development I've decided to demonstrate
this code example on my Mac platform
using visual studio 2019 for Mac
Community Edition
if you have a Mac platform and wish to
follow along on your Mac and you don't
yet have Visual Studio installed
you are able to download and install
Visual Studio Community Edition 2019
free of charge from this location all
links mentioned in this video are
available Below in the description
if you are using a Windows OS please
don't let the fact that I'm using a Mac
platform put you off following along
with this tutorial in terms of the code
example that we'll create in this video
the coding experience using visual
studio for Mac is almost exactly the
same as the coding experience using
visual Studio for Windows so this should
not be a barrier for a learner to follow
along with this demonstration
if you haven't yet installed Visual
Studio 2019 on your windows platform
please view a video created by this
channel which provides a guide to
installing Visual Studio 2019 Community
Edition free of charge
so firstly let's create a.net core
console application
let's name this project the pretend
company application
before we write calling client code in
the main method we are going to add two
standard Library projects let's first
add a standard Library project named TCP
data
let's then add another standard Library
project named TCP extensions
so let's now go to our project that we
named TCP data let's delete the class
that has been automatically generated
for the TCP data project
let's add a new class named employee
let's add six Auto implemented
properties to the employee class ID as
int first name as string last name as
string annual salary as decimal is
manager as Boolean and lastly Department
ID as int
let's add another class to the TCP data
project
let's name this class Department
let's add three Auto implemented
properties to our department class
ID as int short name as string and long
name as string let's add a class named
data to our TCP data project let's make
this class a static class
so let's add two public static methods
to the data class
let's first create a static method named
get employees which returns a generic
list strongly typed as employee let's
ensure
that we include the appropriate using
directive for the use of generic list
objects at the top of our code editor
so let's include a using directive to
the
system.collections.generic namespace
like this
let's write the code to add some made up
employee records to a generic list that
is strongly typed with the user defined
type employee
foreign
foreign let's write code to return the
list of employee records to the calling
client code
let's add another static method and
let's name this method get departments
this method also returns a generic list
object but this generic list object is
strongly typed as Department
let's write the codes to add some made
up Department Records to a generic list
that is strongly typed with the
user-defined type Department
foreign
let's write code to return the list of
Department Records to the calling client
code
so as you can see the get employees
method returns a list of employee
records and the get departments method
returns a list of Department Records
so in order to gain an understanding for
how Link Works let's ensure that we
properly understand two fundamental
concepts I.E the concept of extension
methods and the concept of Lambda
expressions
so let's go to our TCP extensions
project
let's delete the class that was
auto-generated by Visual Studio when we
created the project
let's add a class named extension
so in order for our extension method to
work we must make the extension class a
static class
so we are going to add a method named
filter
the idea here is we want a way where we
can extend the functionality of any
generic list that is strongly typed with
any c-sharp data type including
user-defined types
we can achieve this by creating our own
extension method so for example if we
want to filter employee records by
criteria that we are able to specify
through a Lambda expression on a generic
list that is strongly typed as the
employee
we can do this through our filter
extension method this will be
demonstrated in the calling client code
in a bit
so how do we create our own custom
extension method
so I'll first create the method
signature for the filter extension
method
first notice that our method like the
class in which it resides must be static
which is achieved by including the
static keyword
in the relevant extension methods method
signature
so if we look at the first parameter in
the filter methods method signature we
can see
that we are using for this keyword
preceding the data type of the first
parameter which is a generic list of
type t
but this keyword in this context
indicates to the compiler that the
relevant method can be called on an
object of the data type of the relevant
parameter in this example that is a
generic list which contains a type T
placeholder as we know from the video
series on c-sharp generics a developer
is able to pass a data type argument to
the parameter of type T which can be any
c-sharp data type including user-defined
types
the data type specified will be chosen
depending on the requirement that needs
to be met by The Calling client code
we'll demonstrate the consumption of
client-side code for the filter
extension method in a bit
so let's look at the second parameter
which is of the delegate type func for
more information about the funk delegate
type please view a video created by this
channel on this topic a link to this
video is available Below in the
description
the first data type parameter passed to
the funk delegate type represents the
first data type of the first parameter
of the method referenced by the relevant
argument passed into this parameter
the last parameter in the funk delegate
type definition is the return type of
the method referenced by the argument
passed into this parameter so the first
parameter passed into the funk delegate
is of type T and the second parameter is
of type bull
note that a predicate delegate type can
be used to define method definitions for
a method that returns a Boolean value
so we could replace the func delegate
type with a predicate delegate type
let's use the funk delegate type but
please note that we could also achieve
the same end using the predicate
delegate type
and as you can see this method will
return a list of objects of type t to
the calling client code
so let's complete the logic for this
method let's implement the code for the
filter method
so basically we are looping through the
list on which the filter extension
method is invoked we are then adding its
elements to a new generic list also of
type T whether or not we add this list
item is based on the Boolean value
returned by a method reference passed
into the second parameter of the filter
method so the relevant method reference
is stored in the argument passed to the
parameter named funk
as you can see the method that the
variable named func references accepts
an argument of type t
so we are passing in each item stored in
the calling clients list
which is the generic list on which
calling client code will invoke the
filter extension method
if the method that the func variable
references returns true the items stored
in the iterated list is added to a new
list
we then return the new list containing
the filtered items to the calling client
code
so this effectively means that the
calling client code is able to use our
filter method to filter any generic list
based on a method created in the calling
client code this method created in the
calling client code will contain the
logic for filtering the relevant generic
list
a reference to this method will be
passed into the second parameter of our
filter extension method and must adhere
to the method definition represented in
the second parameter of the filter
method I.E the definition represented in
the func delegate type
so we are now going to implement the
calling client code and you'll see that
the method passed into the second
parameter of our filter method will be
an anonymous method I.E a method that is
not named this method will be expressed
as a Lambda expression
we'll now see how we are able to filter
a generic list using our filter
extension method through calling client
code in the main method of our
application
right so let's go to the.net core
console project and write the calling
client code in our main method
firstly let's reference our two standard
Library projects from our.net core
console project
so let's right click the dependencies
node in the.net core console project and
tick TCP data as well as TCP extensions
so let's test our filter extension
method in a bit I'll further elucidate
why it is important to understand
extension methods and Lambda expressions
with regards to link
through the magic of how extension
methods work in c-sharp we should be
able to call the extension method on any
generic list object
so let's define a generic list that is
strongly typed as the employee user
defines type
so we have a red squiggly line under our
generic list type definition so to fix
this we need to include a directive at
the top of our code to the
system.collections.generic namespace
we can see that there is a red squiggly
line under the code that strongly types
our generic list as the user's defined
type employee
so to fix this let's include a directive
at the top of our code to the TCP data
namespace
great
so through the magic of extension
methods we should see the filter method
appear in the intellisense drop-down
list when we add a DOT after the
employee list variable
okay so why are we not seeing the filter
method appearing in our intellisense
drop-down list
the reason for this is because we
haven't included a using directive to
the appropriate namespace so let's
include a using directive at the top of
our code to the appropriate namespace IE
TCP extensions
so now if we add a DOT immediately after
the employee list variable the magic of
extension methods is revealed to us and
we can see our filter method in the
intellisense drop-down list
so note that when we Open brackets to
pass in appropriate arguments to the
filter method we see that only one
parameter is required this parameter was
the second parameter we defined for this
method so why is the first parameter in
the filter method not listed when we
open the brackets in this way
well the answer to that question is this
is how extension methods work
the consumer of the code IE the calling
client code does not need to pass in the
first parameter this is automatically
handled behind the scenes as it were
by default the first parameter is the
object on which the relevant extension
method is invoked
so in this case the list of employees
stored in the employee list variable
is passed into the filter method into
this parameter automatically
so if we look at the filter extension
method we can see that this keyword
precedes the definition of the first
parameter
that this keyword in this context
is telling the c-sharp compiler that the
argument passed into this parameter is
the object on which the relevant
extension method is invoked
so we have access to the argument passed
into the first parameter automatically
okay so the second parameter
accepts a delegate object that points to
a method that needs to be created on the
calling client so this method that we'll
create essentially tells the filter
method how we want our list filtered
so we are able to Define this method and
the calling client code through the use
of a Lambda expression
a Lambda expression is a concise way to
represent an anonymous method if we look
at the definition of the relevant
delegate parameter we need to define a
method that accepts an argument of type
T and returns a Boolean value
so the c-sharp compiler has enough
information to infer that the intended
type for type T is employee in this
context we are calling the filter
extension method on a strongly typed
generic list the generic list is
strongly typed with the employee user
defined type
so say we want to filter our employee
list based on the value of each relevant
employee items is manager property
we want to filter the list where we only
want to return those employee records
where is manager is true
so we want to return all the records
from our list where the relevant
employees are managers
so to achieve this we can pass in this
Lambda expression
here we are telling the filter method
how we want our list filtered
let's write code to print the results to
the console screen
right let's run the code
okay so we have no data
ah we of course need to populate our
employee list with data so let's assign
the value returned from data.get
employees to the employees list variable
right let's run the code
great and you can see that only the
employee records where the relevant is
manager property value is set to true or
returned to the calling client code
great
and we can of course inject the converse
of this logic into our filter method
through the relevant Lambda expression
like this
so we are now saying we only want to
bring back our employees who are not
managers let's run the code
great
and for good measure let's modify our
Lambda expression so that the filter
method only returns employees that earn
less than 50 000 a year
great
and because we have used generics for
our filter method we can call the filter
method on a list of various c-sharp
types including user-defined types so
let's prove this and call our filter
extension method on a list of
departments
foreign
let's filter the Departments based on
the Department's short name so let's
bring back the finance department and
the human resources department
great
let's bring back only those departments
with IDs greater than one
so the point of this is to show you the
flexibility that the combination of
extension methods and Lambda Expressions
create when writing the calling client
code
the combination of extension methods and
Lambda Expressions not only provide this
flexibility but at the same time ensure
that the calling client code is clean
and concise
once we understand how extension methods
and Lambda Expressions work they are
incredibly powerful tools
so how do extension methods and Lambda
Expressions work in relation to the
topic of this video link language
integrated query
extension methods and Lambda expressions
are fundamental to how link is
implemented in C sharp
the innumerable class and the queryable
class are two static classes that
contain extension methods the enumerable
class and the queryable class are both
members of the system.link namespace
so to gain access to the extension
methods provided through link we can
simply include a using directive to the
system.link namespace
without including a using directive to
the system.link namespace you can see
that we are not able to access the where
extension method provided by link to
perform our filtering operation on a
collection that implements the I
enumerable interface
so let's include the system.link
namespace
we now have access to Links where
extension method so we can now replace
our custom filter extension method with
the where link extension method like
this
we don't need to create our own filter
extension methods to perform such
queries on our data link has got us
covered for this
foreign
link also provides us with a SQL like
query syntax
so for example if we wanted to produce a
query result by joining selected fields
from data selected from our collection
of employee objects with selected fields
or field in this case from data in our
collection of Department objects we can
use Link query syntax to perform our
inner join operation on these two
collections of data like this
and the link query we want to include
the department long name field so that
we can have a descriptive name for our
department in our results set rather
than displaying a result that only
contains the department ID which is
available in the employee type so we can
achieve this result by using the join
clause in a link query to perform our
inner join on our collection of employee
objects with our collection of
Department objects we have the
department ID property in the employee
type so we can join using this
type to the ID property which is a
member of the department type
so say we were to write the equivalent
query using transact SQL against the SQL
Server database that contained an
employee table with the same data schema
as our employee type and a department
table that contains the same schema as
our department type the transact SQL
query syntax would look something like
this
we are using an inner join to join data
in an employee table with data in a
department table
we are able to make the join because the
employee table contains the department
ID
which can be joined in our query the ID
of the department table
so you can see the similarities and
syntax between the transact SQL syntax
and the link query syntax
the link query is dealing with objects
encapsulating the employee and
Department Records
the employee list collection is like the
employee table and the department list
is like the department table in this
particular context
we have a select Clause a from clause
and a join clause in the Syntax for both
the link query and the transact SQL
query however the from clause in the
link query appears at the beginning of
the query and the select clause in the
link query appears at the end of the
query
so there are differences in The Ordering
of the Clauses When comparing the syntax
of the transact SQL query with the
syntax of the relevant link query
an advantage of link is that can be
leveraged in our c-sharp code to query
data in a standardized way
that is independent from the format of
the underlying data source the data
source could be a mongodb database a
sqlite database a SQL Server database
Etc
this will not affect the syntax of our
link queries
so the object layer provided by link can
be used for abstracting our queries of
the data from the underlying data source
and by using link we also have the added
advantage of compile time strong typing
and the type checking provided by the
c-sharp compiler
let me draw your attention to the select
clause
we are able to return the data as an i
enumerable collection of anonymous types
we are assigning The Collection returned
by the link query to a variable preceded
by the VAR keyword
beginning with c-sharp version 3
variables that are declared at method
scope can have an implicit type VAR
through the use of the VAR keyword the
c-sharp compiler is able to infer the
types included in the collection
returned from the query
so we are able to return a collection of
objects that are of an anonymous type
that we have defined directly within the
link query
Anonymous types provide a convenient way
to encapsulate a set of read-only
properties into a single object without
having to explicitly Define a type first
you can see how the use of anonymous
types can provide the developer with
flexibility and convenience when
constructing relatively complex queries
foreign
note that Microsoft recommends using the
query syntax where possible as opposed
to using relevant extension methods for
the same purpose this is because of the
readability Advantage provided in the
relevant query syntax
there are however times
where you'll need to use appropriate
extension methods included within the
link namespace because some
functionality in link does not have a
query syntax counterpart
for example if we wanted to calculate
the average salary for all employees we
would need to use the average extension
method like this
the same applies if we wish to query for
the highest salary from a list of
employee records we would need to use
the max extension method like this
this functionality cannot be performed
through the use of query syntax
but where possible query syntax is
preferable
due to the code readability advantage
that this syntax provides
I hope you've enjoyed this video which
provides an introduction to link
this video was created to help with the
understanding of the fundamentals of
Link the advantages that link provides
and how we are able to implement basic
link queries in code
link provides us with an integration of
query capabilities directly into the
c-sharp language it is a very powerful
technology that decouples query logic
from relevant types of underlying data
formats link provides a layer of
abstraction that provides the developer
with easy to implement Syntax for
querying collections of objects
the relevant collection types must
implement the I queryable or generic I
queryable interface or the I enumerable
or generic I.E numerable interface
note that the I queryable interface
inherits from the I enumerable interface
and the generic I queryable interface
inherits from both the I enumerable
interface and the generic I enumerable
interface
a suite of extension methods and query
syntax are made available to c-sharp
developers which provide flexibility
when constructing powerful readable
queries against data encapsulated with
an appropriate c-sharp collections
this video is a basic introduction to
leveraging link in the c-sharp language
and the next tutorial we'll delve deeper
into the subject matter
[Music]
hi and welcome to the second part of a
video series on link
this video is also the second part of
the seventh tutorial in an advanced
c-sharp course
link stands for language integrated
query in the first part of this video
series we looked at an overview of Link
we discussed that link is the name for a
set of Technologies based on the
integration of query capabilities
directly into the c-sharp language
in this video we'll demonstrate examples
where we'll create link queries using
method syntax and subsequently show how
we can express the same link query using
query syntax as discussed in the
previous video in this series query
syntax is recommended because the logic
within the query syntax is easier to
read
in this video we'll look at code
examples using the following link
operators select where join and group
join we'll discuss what is meant by
Method chaining and demonstrate an
example that makes use of method
chaining in the context of a link query
we'll look at what is meant by deferred
execution of Link queries and what is
meant by immediate execution of Link
queries we'll discuss the inherent
advantages of the third execution in the
context of Link
to further clarify our understanding of
deferred execution we'll create a code
example where we'll Implement deferred
execution for our own custom extension
method for an I enumerable type
we'll demonstrate how the c-sharp yield
keyword is implemented in the relevant
code example as part of code to
implement deferred execution
at the end of the tutorial we'll look at
the join operator and the group join
operator
we'll create code examples to help
clarify our understanding of these two
link operators
in the first part of this video series
we discussed that extension methods and
Lambda expressions are fundamental to
how Link Works
we created our own extension method for
filtering a generic list that can be
strongly typed with any c-sharp type
including user-defined types
we then demonstrated how a Lambda
expression can be created and calling
client code which enables the calling
client code to determine how the
relevant list of data must be filtered
the reason we created our own filter
extension method was to help us
understand the fundamentals of Link Link
functionality is encapsulated in two
static classes that are members of the
system.link namespace these two static
classes are named queryable and
enumerable
these classes mostly contain extension
methods
as with the previous video in this
series I'm going to demonstrate the code
examples in this video on my Mac
platform if you are using a Windows
platform the fact that I'm using visual
studio for Mac should not be a barrier
to follow along with these code examples
the code creation process is almost
exactly the same experience when
compared to implementing the same code
using visual Studio for Windows
so let's create a net core console
project
let's name this project link examples
underscore one
so to save time let's copy data related
code that we created in the previous
video of this series from the
appropriate GitHub repository
so please navigate to this URL in your
browser to access the relevant GitHub
repository
as always all urls referred to in these
videos can be accessed through
appropriate links included Below in the
description
so let's copy the data related
functionality from this repository to
the project we have just created
so in your browser window click the
directory icon labeled TCP data like
this
click the class icon labeled employee
let's copy the code for the employee
class from this page to our clipboards
like this
and simply paste the contents of the
clipboard below the program class in our
new project
let's also copy the code for the
Department class like this to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
below the employee class within our new
project
let's then copy the code in the data
class to our clipboards
then paste the contents of our
clipboards below the department class in
our new project like this
so we have some red Squiggy Lines within
our data class
to fix this let's include a directive to
the system.collections dot generic
namespace at the top of our code like
this
we are just creating throwaway code in
this video to help us understand the
relevant topics discussed in this video
so we are not too concerned with code
neatness in this video
in our main method let's create a
strongly typed generic list
that is strongly typed with the employee
user-defined type let's name our generic
list variable employee list
let's assign the value returned from the
data.get employees method to the
variable we have just named employee
list
this line of code will populate the
employee list collection with made up
data that was hard-coded in the data
class in the previous video of this
series
let's define a generic list that is
strongly typed with our department
user-defined type let's name our
variable for this list Department list
let's assign the value returned from the
data.get Departments method to the
variable we have just named Department
list
this will populate the department list
collection with made up data that was
hard-coded in the data class in the
previous video of this series
so let's create a link query that makes
use of the select link operator
in order to use a link operator we of
course need to include a using directive
to the system.link namespace
for this query we want to select
everything from the data stored in our
employee list collection
we can do this by simply invoking the
select method on the employee list
object like this
the select method is an extension method
provided to us through link
we can shape our data through the use of
a Lambda expression like this
we discussed Anonymous types in the
previous video of this video series
so the select operator returns an i
enumerable collection of objects the
Lambda expression passed into the select
extension method provides an instruction
on how we wish to shape each item of
data within the returned I enumerable
collection
this is specifically expressed through
this Anonymous type
Anonymous types provide a convenient way
to encapsulate a set of read-only
properties into a single object without
having to explicitly Define a type first
you can see how the use of anonymous
types can provide the developer with
flexibility and convenience when
constructing queries
so here we are providing an instruction
that we want each item of data in The
Returned I enumerable collection to
contain a full name property which is a
concatenation of the first name and the
last name properties of the relevant
employee record and a property
containing the employee's annual salary
so let's write the code to Output the
results of this query to the console
screen
let's see the code in action
great
so if we want to filter this data we can
do this by chaining the where extension
method to our select operator like this
method chaining is a common Syntax for
invoking multiple method calls in C
sharp
each method returns an object allowing
calls to be changed together in a single
statement without requiring variables to
store the intermediate results
so the select operation will return an
innumerable collection object we can
filter this returned inumerable
collection within the same link query by
chaining the where extension method to
the select extension method
the where extension method filters the
data stored in the innumerable object
returned from the select method
through a Lambda expression passed to
the where extension method the Lambda
expression provides instructions to the
where extension method on how the data
must be filtered
once the data has been filtered through
the wear extension method and I
enumerable collection of results is
assigned to our results variable
we are then traversing our results using
a for each Loop and displaying each item
in the I enumerable collection to the
console screen
we discussed the VAR keyword which
allows for local implicit typing within
methods in the previous video of this
series please view the previous video in
this series for more details
so here we are implementing link
explicitly using the extension methods
provided by link we are using the select
operator and the where operator in a
link query
implemented using method syntax
let's run the code
great we can execute the same
functionality using query syntax
so let's comment out the previous code
and include a comment to label this code
so that we are able to refer to this
code later if need be
so let's first implement the link query
using query syntax without the where
clause
okay
let's run the code
great
let's implement the link query
implemented using query syntax and this
time include the where Clause within the
link query using query syntax
let's run the code
excellent and we get exactly the same
result when compared to running the
query that we implemented using method
syntax
but we have constructed our link code
using link query syntax as opposed to
using relevant extension methods the
query syntax is more readable and we
don't need to chain our extension
methods as we did in the previous
example where we changed the where
extension method to the select extension
method
let's take a closer look at our query
where we used method syntax versus the
same query where we used query syntax
note that standard query operators in
our query syntax are converted into
extension Methods at compile time
so standard query operators are
essentially the same as their
counterpart extension methods
Microsoft recommends using query syntax
as opposed to directly implementing the
relevant extension methods where
possible
as discussed this is due to the
readability Advantage inherent in the
query syntax
there are times when you will need to
use extension methods directly where
equivalent query syntax is not available
we looked at a few examples of this in
the previous video of this series for
example using aggregate functionality
like for example finding the average Min
or Max annual salary for a collection of
employee records we would need to use
the respective average Min or Max
extension methods to calculate and
return the relevant values
the developer is able to execute link
queries with deferred execution or
immediate execution
so let's first understand what is meant
by deferred execution
the third execution means that the
evaluation of an expression is delayed
until its value is required this
improves performance because only
necessary executions are carried out I.E
at the point where the relevant value is
required
let's use our last query example to
illustrate this point
so when we first assign the value
returned by our query to our results
variable
the query is not executed
it is only when we Traverse the items in
our results variable that the actual
execution takes place I.E with each
iteration of the for each Loop an
execution is performed whereby the
relevant item is evaluated and returned
from the collection
another advantage of deferred execution
is that an update to the relevant data
collection will immediately be reflected
in the results
so for example let's add a record to our
employee collection
note the salary for this new employee is
above 50 000. so this employee should
appear within our results
let's run the code
and you can see that this is proof that
the results are evaluated within the for
each Loop
and the query itself is not executed at
the line of code where the relevant
query is located
the execution of the query is deferred
until the results are traversed within
the relevant for each Loop
to further understand the concept of
deferred execution let's create a code
example where we'll Implement deferred
execution for our own custom extension
method for an innumerable type that is
strongly typed as the employee
user-defined type
foreign
let's create a static class named
innumerable collection extension methods
let's create a static method within the
static class that we have just created
and let's name this method get high
salaried employees
we discussed extension methods in the
previous video for this video series
for more information on extension
methods please access a link to this
video as discussed a link to this video
is available Below in the description
so let's implement the code for the get
high salaried employees extension method
like this
note the use of the yield keyword
you can use a yield return statement to
return each element one at a time
the sequence returned from an iterator
method can be consumed by using a for
each statement or link query
each iteration of the for each Loop
calls the iterator method when a yield
return statement is reached in the
iterator method the relevant value in
the I enumerable collection is returned
and the current location in code is
retained execution is restarted from
that location the next time that the
iterator function is called
let's go to our main method
and Implement a query that calls our
extension method on the employee list
collection
let's copy and paste the code that we
have already written to Traverse the
results and output the relevant data
and let's add another employee records
to the employee list collection as we
did before
let's run the code
and you can see that the new employee
record is reflected in the results the
results are kept up to date due to
deferred execution
note that the third execution
reevaluates on each execution which is
known as lazy evaluation
the converse of deferred execution is
immediate execution immediate execution
means the relevant query is executed
immediately
to execute a query immediately we need
to apply an appropriate two conversion
method to the query
so let's copy the previous code example
let's uncomment the relevant code let's
change this code so that the query
executes immediately
we can use the two list conversion
method for this purpose
we are using query syntax here so in
order for us to use the to list
conversion method we first need to wrap
the relevant query in Brackets add a DOT
and then the to list conversion method
we are explicitly typecasting the I
enumerable value returned from the query
to the list type through the
implementation of the to list conversion
method we are also executing the query
immediately
let's uncomment the rest of the relevant
code for this example
and let's run the code
you can see that the execution of our
query is immediate because this time
after we've added a new employee the
query has not been evaluated again to
include the new employee record in the
results this is of course why the new
employee does not appear within the
results output to the screen
this proves that our query has executed
immediately at the line of code where
the query is located
and remember that query syntax does not
support two operators so we need to wrap
our query in Brackets as we have done
here and call whichever two method is
appropriate for example to list two
array or two dictionary
by calling the relevant to method in
this case the two list method we are
causing our query to execute immediately
without the two conversion method the
relevant query execution would be
deferred until the relevant results are
iterated
so let's move on to the join operator
and then we'll look at the group join
operator and highlight the difference
between these two join operations
in the previous video in this series we
looked at the join operator and
discussed how we can perform an inner
join on two inumerable collections using
a link query
so here we have two collections that we
wish to join in this specific use case
we need to include a descriptive
Department name in our results displayed
to the user we only have a department ID
field in our employee type so in order
to merge the properties from our
employee type with the relevant property
from our department type we need to join
records of type Department that reside
within our department list collection
with records of type employee that
reside within our employee list
collection we can do this by matching
the ID field in the department records
that reside in the department list
collection with the Department ID
property of employee records that reside
in the employee list collection
we can do this through link by using the
join operator
later we'll demonstrate a join operation
but using the group join operator we'll
also discuss the differences between the
join operator and the group join
operator
let's look at the relationship between
the collection of Department Records
with the collection of employee Records
Department Records have a one-to-many
relationship with employee records
a specific Department can have many
employees as members
a specific employee cannot belong to
more than one department at a point in
time
data collections can also have
one-to-one relationships with one
another or many too many relationships
with one another so in this example we
are going to look at how we can use Link
to implement a join operation between
two collections of records that have a
one-to-many relationship with one
another I.E one Department to many
employees
so let's Implement a query that joins
the department list collection with the
employee list collection where the ID
property of the relevant objects of type
Department match the department ID
employee
so the Syntax for this link query would
look like this when we implement the
join operation using method syntax
so to join Department Records to
appropriate employee records we can use
the join extension method and invoke the
extension method on the department list
collection
the first argument we need to pass into
the join method is the collection on
which we want to join the department
list collection
so we pass in the employee collection
object here
the second argument is the key from the
outer collection the department list
collection so the outer join key is the
ID property that resides in the
department type we can express this
argument as a Lambda expression like
this
the third argument is the inner join key
which is the department ID property
which is a member of the employee type
we can express this argument as a Lambda
expression like this so we are joining
on the ID property which is a member of
the department type with the Department
ID property which is a member of the
employee type
we can define an anonymous type where we
are able to shape the data for each item
in an i enumerable collection that we
want returned from the relevant query
here we are defining an anonymous type
within our link query that includes the
employee full name which is a
concatenation of the employee's first
name and last name the employee's annual
salary as well as the relevant
Department objects long name property
the long name property will give us a
descriptive Department name in our
results
we are including the department types
long name property and the relevant
Anonymous type this is the whole point
of joining the department list
collection with the employee collection
so that we are able to include a
descriptive Department name within our
results we only have the department ID
as a member of our employee type so if
we only return to results from the
employee list and wanted to include
Department information we would be
restricted to the department ID property
which is an integer value and is
unlikely to be meaningful to a user
thank you
let's run the code
great
but as discussed where it is possible to
use Query syntax rather than method
Syntax for our link queries
we should use Query syntax because the
logic expressed and the relevant query
is far easier to read
so let's write the same query using
query syntax
as you can see it is far easier to read
and it is also similar to query
languages with which we may already be
familiar for example transact SQL let's
Express what a similar query and
transact SQL might look like
so let's imagine that we have a table in
a SQL Server database that could map to
our employee type
let's say this table has the same name
as our employee type let's also imagine
that we have a table in the same SQL
Server database that contains a table
schema that could map to our department
type
let's say this table has the same name
as our department type
so the transact SQL would look something
like this
you can see how the from Clause the join
clause and the select Clause are
implemented in both the link query
syntax and the transact SQL syntax
even though the link query contains the
same Clauses in a different order to the
comparative Clauses in the transact SQL
query for someone who is familiar with
transact SQL and not necessarily
familiar with link query syntax this
link query syntax at a glance should be
fairly easy to understand
so the point share is that link query
syntax is similar to query syntax with
which many of us will already be
familiar so this makes the
implementation of Link queries using
query syntax more intuitive
as discussed the link query syntax is
also more readable than the equivalent
link query implemented using method
syntax so the key takeaway here is to
use Link query syntax rather than method
syntax where possible because it is more
intuitive to implement and easier to
read
let's run the code
great
so let's look at the group join link
operator and while we might want to use
the group join operator in our link
queries
we have just performed an inner join
using the join operator this query will
only return those records based on the
ID property of relevant objects of the
department type in the department list
collection matching with the Department
ID property of relevant objects of the
employee type in the employee list
collection diagrammatically an inner
join query can be represented like this
what if we wanted to return through a
link query all the Department Records in
our department list collection and only
employee records where the department ID
property of employee objects and the
employee list collection match the ID
property of Department Records in the
department list collection so if we were
to write to the transact SQL version of
this query it would look something like
this
we would use a left outer join to
achieve the desired result
this query would bring back all
Department Records but only those
employee records where the relevant
employee records department ID values
match the ID property of the relevant
Department Records
so diagrammatically we can represent a
left outer join query like this
so let's look at the diagram
representing an inner join operation and
compare the diagram to the diagram
representing the left outer join
operation
so let's use our group join operator in
a link query to return all Department
Records from the Department list
collection but only the employee records
from the employee list collection with a
department ID property that matches an
ID property of a department record in
the department list collection
so here we are implementing our query
using method syntax
you can see the implementation of the
group join operation using method syntax
is very similar to The Way We
implemented the join operation in the
previous example
foreign
the code
note the way we have structured our
output is clearly different when
outputting the results of our group join
query when compared to the way we
structured our output of the results of
our join query but note that at the
moment the same join between Department
Records and employee records has
occurred
the reason for this is not because the
group joined and the join operators
perform the same type of join operation
it is because currently each of the
records in the employee list collection
match with a department record in our
department list collection
let's change our data to highlight a key
difference in the join operation and the
group join operation
let's do this by going to the code where
we have hard-coded made up employee and
Department Records and added these
records to their respective collections
let's ensure that the technology
department which has an ID of three does
not match with a department ID property
of any of the employee objects in our
employee list collection
we only currently have one employee that
is in the technology department
according to our data let's change the
relevant Department ID so that there are
no employees that are members of the
technology department so let's change
this department ID property now no
employees are members of the technology
department according to our data
let's run the code
so you can see our technology department
record is being returned along with all
the other department records in the
department list collection even though
its ID property doesn't match the
department ID property of any employee
records stored in the employee list
collection
so simply put Department information for
departments that contain employees are
included in the query results and
departments that don't contain any
employees are also included in the query
results
in this example the technology
department has returned even though it
contains no matching employee records
so here we have performed a left outer
join query using links group join
operator
so let's rewrite this link query using
query syntax
you can see here that the group join
extension method does not get explicitly
called when we Implement our query using
query syntax the into keyword is used
within the query to create a group of
employees for each department
so as discussed link query syntax does
not match exactly when comparing link
query syntax to familiar query languages
like transact SQL but in many ways it
does resemble a language like transact
SQL in this sense link query syntax is
more intuitive to implement than method
syntax when implementing link queries
and just to labor the point as discussed
it is also better to implement link
query Syntax for our link queries then
implementing method Syntax for the same
purpose because of better readability
let's run the code
great and we get the exact same result
as when we ran the same query that was
implemented using method syntax
now that we have changed the data so
that the technology department does not
match with any employee records let's
run our join operation that we created
earlier
notice that the results of the join
operation doesn't include the technology
department this is because the join
operation performs an inner join and
with the group join operation we are
able to perform a left outer join
operation
so let's comment out our join query and
uncomment our group join query
and for good measure let's run the code
again
and as you can see the technology
department is now included in the
results displayed to the screen even
though the technology department does
not have any matching employee records
great
so the left outer join operation returns
all records from the outer left
collection in the query but does not
return records from the inner collection
where the inner collection records do
not match any of the outer collection
records
so if there were employee records in the
employee list collection that did not
match any of the Department Records in
the department list collection these
employees would not appear in the
results outputted to the screen we can
prove this let's change the department
ID of this employee record where the
first name property is Bob and the last
name properties Jones
we have changed the department ID
property for this record to six and
there's no matching Department record
I.E no Department record has an ID of
six let's run the code
and you can see that the employee record
with first name Bob and last name Jones
does not appear within the results
however even though the human resources
department has no matching employee
records it is still included in the
results output to the screen great let's
add Bob Jones back into the human
resources department like this and let's
run the code
excellent
so hopefully this made it clear how we
are able through link to use the join
operator to perform inner join queries
between two object Collections and how
we are also able to perform left outer
join queries using the group join
operator
[Music]
hi and welcome to the third part of a
video series on the link technology
using c-sharp this video is also part of
the seventh tutorial in an advanced
c-sharp course link was introduced with
c-sharp version 3 which was released on
the 19th of November 2007.
link stands for language integrated
query
in this video we are going to focus on
code examples that make use of several
link operators
the code examples demonstrated in this
video will hopefully help us gain an
understanding of a broad array of
operators that are made available to us
through link
we'll learn how we can use these
operators to query and transform data
this quote from the Microsoft docs
provides a basic definition of standard
query operators and can be found at this
URL
standard query operators are the methods
that form the link pattern most of these
methods operate on sequences whereas
sequence is an object whose type
implements the generic I.E numerable
interface or the generic I queryable
interface
a lot of the more frequently used query
operators have dedicated c-sharp keyword
syntax that enables them to be called as
part of a query expression as discussed
in the previous video in this video
series it is advantageous to use Query
syntax rather than method syntax where
possible because query syntax is more
readable note that query expression
Clauses are translated into calls to
query Methods at compile time
for a useful tabular representation of
standard query operators that have
equivalent query expression Clauses
please navigate to this URL we discussed
what is meant by deferred execution and
immediate execution in the previous part
of this video series
for a useful tabular classification of
operators in terms of deferred execution
or immediate execution please navigate
to this URL
for additional information on deferred
execution versus immediate execution and
Method syntax versus query syntax please
View the second part of this video
series
so to gain an understanding of several
useful link operators let's create a few
code examples
as with the previous video in this
series I'll be demonstrating these code
examples on my Mac platform using visual
studio for Mac
the code creation process for these code
examples is almost exactly the same
process as creating the equivalent code
examples on a Windows platform using
visual Studio for Windows
the fact that I'm using visual studio
for Mac should not be a barrier for a
learner to follow along with the
creation of these code examples
let's start by creating a.net core
console project
we created a project in the previous
video named link examples underscore one
let's name this project link examples
underscore 2.
in order to save time let's copy data
related classes that have already been
created in the previous videos of this
series and incorporate these classes
into our new project these classes
contain class definitions for an
employee and a department record as well
as code that adds several made up
objects of type employee and Department
to their respective collections
as in the previous parts of this video
series we can then use these collections
of strongly typed objects in our link
query examples
so to copy the relevant code let's
navigate to this URL IE to a GitHub
repository that was created in the
previous video
let's click on the directory icon
labeled link examples underscore one
then let's click on the file icon
labeled program.cs
let's copy the employee class to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
within the new project that we have just
created
let's copy the department class to our
clipboards and paste the contents of our
clipboards below the employee class
within our new project
lastly let's copy the data class to our
clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
below the department class within our
project
so in the previous video we looked at
the following operators
the select projection operator the where
filter operator the join and group join
join operators in this video we'll
create code examples that implement the
following operators
we'll start by looking at the following
sorting operators order by order by
descending then by and then by
descending
we'll then look at these grouping
operators Group by and to lookup
we'll then look at these quantifier
operators or any and contains
we'll then look at the following
filtering operator of type
note that another example of a filtering
operator is the where operator we have
looked at the where filter operator in
the previous parts of this video series
lastly we'll look at the following
element operators element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default
we'll look at even more link operators
and create code examples in the next
video
the next video will be the final video
in this video series on link
right let's get started so let's start
by looking at the data related classes
that we copied from GitHub we have the
employee class which provides a
definition for an employee record we
have the department class which provides
a definition for a department record we
have the data class that contains code
where lists of hard-coded made up
employee and Department objects are
added to their respective collections
within their respective methods and
returned from their respective methods
in the previous video in this series we
looked at join operators namely the join
operator and the group join operator
so in the context of join operations the
department collection has a one-to-many
relationship with the employee records
in the employee collection
this simply means that one or many
employees can be members of a specific
Department a specific employee can be a
member of only one department at a point
in time
so let's go to our main method
we can use the data dot get employees
method to return a collection of made up
employee records
let's use this method to assign the
relevant collection of employee records
to a local variable named employee list
the employee list variable is defined as
a generic list that is strongly typed as
employee
so here we have red squiggly lines
because we need to include a using
directive to the
system.collections.generic namespace
let's use the data dot get departments
method to return a collection of made-up
Department Records that have a
one-to-many relationship with the
relevant collection of employee records
and let's assign the relevant return
collection of Department Records to a
variable named Department list
the department list variable is defined
as a generic list that is strongly typed
as Department
so let's get into the creation of our
examples
sorting operators order by
so let's create an example for the order
by operator in this example we want to
return all employee records from the
employee list collection and order by
Department ID
to make things a little bit more
interesting let's say we want to include
the department name within our outputted
results
the problem here is that the department
name does not exist in the employee type
so we need to join the employee list
collection to the department list
collection so that we can include the
department name in our results
we can do this by using the join
operator
so let's write this query using method
syntax so that we can see all the link
extension methods used in the relevant
query
so we first need to make sure that we
include a using directive to the
system.link namespace
this directive will give us access to
the relevant link operators that we will
be implementing in our code examples
we know that the system.link namespace
contains two static classes namely
innumerable and queryable and these
static classes mostly contain extension
methods our link operators which are
implemented in the form of extension
methods are implemented within the
enumerable and queryable static classes
so this link query joins the employee
list collection to the department list
collection on the department ID property
of each of the relevant employee records
with the ID property of relevant
Department Records
foreign
this query let's alter the data a bit
let's make the employee record
pertaining to Sarah Jameson a member of
the technology department by changing
the relevance Department ID property
from two to three let's also change the
department for the employee record
pertaining to Jane Stevens to the
technology department by changing the
relevant Department ID from 2 to 3. this
change to the data will make the effects
of our sorting operators more apparent
when we view our results
so if we run the query first without the
use of any order by operators note that
the data appears to us in the same order
as it was added to the employee list
but now let's say there is a requirement
to order our results by the department
ID property in ascending order
we can do this by chaining the order by
extension method to the end of the query
like this
for more information on method chaining
please view the previous video in this
series
so we can pass in a Lambda expression to
the order by extension method to
indicate that we wish to order the
results by the department ID property
let's run the code
and you can see that the results are now
ordered in ascending order by Department
ID
if we look at the code that added each
department to the department collection
we can see that the human resources
department has an ID of one the finance
department has an ID of two and the
technology department has an ID of three
our results have been ordered in
ascending order based on the department
ID property of the employee record
so we can clearly see the effects of the
order by operator on our results great
if the requirement changed such that we
needed to order our results by the
department ID property in descending
order we can chain the order by
descending extension method instead of
the order by extension method for this
purpose
our results are now ordered by
Department ID in the reverse order when
compared to the previous output great
so let's say that we want to order our
results by the department ID property in
ascending order and then by the annual
salary property also in ascending order
so let's replace the order by descending
extension method with the order by
extension method in our results like
this then let's chain the then buy
extension method to the query like this
we can then pass a Lambda expression to
indicate that we wish to further order
our results by the annual salary
property the then by extension method
will order the results produced by the
order by sorting operator in ascending
order
great
and if we want to order by the annual
salary property in descending order we
can replace the then buy extension
method with the then by descending
extension method for this purpose
excellent
foreign
we can represent sorting operations
within link queries that are represented
using query syntax like this
note the order by and descending
keywords in the query syntax version of
the relevant query
we use the order by keyword within our
query to order by our first specified
property
if we want to subsequently sort on other
properties instead of chaining the then
by extension method to our query and
query syntax subsequent Properties by
which we wish to sort are separated by
commas
the descending keyword can follow any of
the properties that we wish to sort in
descending order
the default order is ascending order
so let's look at the group by and to
lookup grouping operators
let's start with the group by operator
so this operator is akin to the group by
Clause we would apply in a transact SQL
query
so we can implement the group by
operator using the group by extension
method or the group and the buy keywords
within query syntax to perform the same
operation so let's say we wish to query
the employee list collection
and group our results by the department
ID property
the query using query syntax would look
like this
this query is simply grouping our
results by the department ID property
using method syntax this query would
look like this
in all of the link query examples using
query syntax that we have looked at up
till this point in this video series we
have ended all our queries with a select
operator
notice that this query does not end with
a select operator
it is important to note that a link
query implemented in query syntax must
either end with a select operator or a
grouping operator
notice how this query does not end with
a select operator but a grouping
operation is being performed at the end
of this query
so we can Traverse the results of this
grouping operation using nested for each
Loops the outer loop traverses each
group that has been created based on the
department ID property the inner loop
traverses the item members within each
of the groups that have been created in
our query based on the department ID
property
great
we could also include the order by
operator within our query like this
let's run the code
great
we can implement the same query using
methods syntax using the two lookup
extension method like this
great
we can also include sorting
functionality through the order by
operator through the implementation of
method chaining like this
great
note that the two lookup method performs
the same operation as the group by
operator the only difference is the
execution of the group by operation is
deferred whereas the execution of the
two lookup operation is executed
immediately
we discussed deferred execution and
immediate execution in the previous part
of this video series for more
information on deferred execution and
immediate execution please View the
second part of this video series the
link to this video has been included
Below in the description
note that the results returned from a
group by operation and a two lookup
operation return a group contained in a
special type of collection that
implements an eye grouping generic
interface
so let's look at the all any and
contains quantifier operators let's
first look at the all and any operators
let's create a variable named annual
salary compare and assign it with a
value of 20 000.
let's Implement a block of code related
to the all operator
let's Implement a similar block of code
related to the any operator
so the all and any operators return a
Boolean value
the return value will equal true if the
elements in the relevant collection
satisfy a condition passed to the
relevant method this condition can be
passed in the form of a Lambda
expression
this query will return true if all
employee records
have annual salary property values that
are greater than twenty thousand
this query will return true if one or
more employee records have an annual
salary property value that is greater
than twenty thousand
let's run the code
foreign
this is an expected result
let's change the annual salary compare
variable to a hundred thousand
great
and let's change the annual salary
compare variable to 40 000.
so let's move on to the contains
operator
so we want to be able to assess whether
an employee record exists within our
collection of employee records the
contains operator will return true if we
pass in an object that is equal in value
to an object within the relevant
collection
to understand how the contains operator
Works let's create an employee record
that we know matches an employee record
within the employee list collection
let's copy this record for the employee
named Douglas Roberts that is a member
of the relevant employee collection
and paste it in our main method
let's name the variable that stores a
reference to the employee record we wish
to find within the employee list
collection search employee
so how can we assess whether the
employee record pertaining to Douglas
Roberts exists within the employee list
collection
we can use the contains extension method
we can simply pass the variable we named
search employee to the contains
extension method which we have invoked
on our employee list collection object
so the contains method returns true if
the search employee object matches any
of the objects within the employee list
collection and false if the search
employee object does not match with any
of the objects stored within the
employee list collection
so let's write code to write an
appropriate narrative to the screen
based on the Boolean value returned by
our query
foreign
let's run the code
and this is not the result we expected
because we literally copied and pasted
the code representing one of the
employee objects that has been added to
the employee list collection from our
data class to the main method as our
search object so why is our output
indicating that the search employee
object does not match any of the objects
stored within our employee list
collection this result is unexpected
the answer is that the compiler knows
how to compare built-in c-sharp types
like for example integer or bull the
employee type is a user-defined type or
custom type we need to tell the compiler
how we wish to compare two objects of
type employee to establish where the two
employee objects are equal
so we can do this by creating a class
that implements the generic I equality
comparer interface
the eye equality compare interface is a
member of the
system.collections.generic namespace
we have already included a using
directive to this namespace within our
code
so let's create a class named employee
comparer and let's indicate that we want
the employee comparer class to implement
the I equality compare a generic class
that is strongly typed with the employee
user-defined type
so let's hover our Mouse pointers over
the red squiggly line and create the
stubs for the methods that we need to
implement like this
so two method stubs have been generated
one named equals and the other named get
hash code so the get hash code method is
used for the purpose of uniquely
identifying an object we can implement
the code for the get hashed code method
by returning the hash code of the ID
property of the relevant employee object
like this
the equals method must be implemented in
a way that establishes how we wish
employee objects to be compared when
determining whether two employee objects
are of equal value
so let's say that we are satisfied with
comparing the relevant employee objects
based on their ID first name and last
name properties to establish equality
between the relevant employee objects
so we can achieve this with the
following code
if the relevant properties are equal
return true else return false
so we are already passing in the search
employee object to the contains method
let's also pass a newly instantiated
object of type employee comparer to an
overload version of the contains method
like this
and now we are telling the compiler how
we want to compare our employees search
object with the objects stored within
the employee list collection
let's run the code
and this is an expected result the
contains method now returns true as
expected because our search record
matches the employee record for Douglas
Roberts within the collection on which
we are performing our search great
so now let's look at the of type filter
operator so before we use the of type
filter operator in our code examples
let's create a method named get
heterogeneous data collection
heterogeneous in this context of course
is referring to the storage of objects
of multiple different data types within
the same collection
so we can store objects of multiple
different data types in an arraylist
note that Microsoft does not recommend
using arraylists for new development it
is far better to use strongly typed
lists to store collections of data
for more detail as to why strongly typed
lists are recommended please view a
video on generics created by this
channel a link to this video has been
included Below in the description
so a use case where we could apply a
link query on an arraylist could be
perhaps we have a legacy piece of code
that includes an arraylist containing
objects of multiple types and we need to
filter the relevant arraylist based on
specific types
we can achieve this using the of type
link operator
we'll look at how we can do this in a
bit let's first add some made up data to
an arraylist
so the arraylist stores integers strings
objects of the employee user defined
type and objects of the department
user-defined type
excuse me
let's go to our main method and write
code to use the of type operator to
query this arraylist based on specified
data types
let's query for all string values in our
arraylist
great
so let's query all integer values in our
array list
great let's query for all objects of the
employee user defines type
department user defines type
excellent
so you can see how we can query an
arraylist for objects of a specified
type using generics and the of type
Operator by passing in the relevant type
between angle brackets like this
this will return those objects within
the arraylist that are of the specified
type
let's move on to the element operators
let's look at the element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default element operators
so let's first look at the element at
operator
so the element at operator is used for
querying for an item in a collection
that resides at a specified ordinal
location within the relevant collection
so we can pass an integer value
representing the relevant elements
location in the relevant collection into
the element add method to return the
desired items value from the relevant
collection like this
great and our query has returned the
value for the relevant element
foreign
but what happens if we pass in a value
representing a position in the relevant
collection where an element does not
exist so let's try this let's pass in a
value of 8.
right so it is important to note that no
item exists within the relevant
collection at ordinal position 8. so in
this case an argument out of range
exception is thrown
this brings us to an important point
about the difference between the element
at and the element at or default method
if we replace the element at method with
the element at or default method and we
query the relevant collection for an
item at a position where the desired
item does not exist within the relevant
collection the element at or default
method does not throw an exception
but rather Returns the default value for
the desired items relevant data type
let's briefly discuss what we mean by
default value for a particular data type
the c-sharp language Associates default
values for c-sharp data types so if for
example we are querying a collection of
integers using the element at or default
method for a value that did not exist at
the specified location in the relevant
collection the element at or default
method would return the default value
for the integer data type which is a
value of zero
the integer value of 0 is the default
value for the integer data type in C
sharp if however we are querying a
collection containing a reference type
object like an object of our
user-defined type employee the default
value returned by the element at or
default method would be null null is the
default value for reference type data
types like user-defined types or the
string data type
for more detail regarding default values
in c-sharp please navigate to this URL
so let's use the element at or default
method to query the relevant collection
of employees for a value at position 8.
I.E where no employee object is present
within the relevant collection
we can then write code to check if the
returned value is null
and you can see that an exception is not
thrown and no results are outputted to
the screen which is an expected result
because the query returned a null value
let's pass in a value of 2
foreign
and then one
and in both cases the appropriate result
is outputted to the screen
so let's write code to Output an
appropriate narrative to the user based
on the value returned from the element
at or default method
so let's pass in a value of 12.
the output indicating that the return
value is null I.E the employee object
does not exist in the collection as
output to the screen this is an expected
result great
so the first operator Returns the first
element in a collection if no condition
is specified we have the option of
passing a condition to the first method
or we can leave the brackets following
the first method empty if we do not
specify a condition the query will
return the first element in the relevant
collection if a condition is specified
the first operator will return the first
element in the collection that satisfies
the specified condition we can specify a
condition in the form of a Lambda
expression right to prove this let's
first create a strongly typed list of
integer values
foreign
this collection using the first operator
and don't provide a condition passed as
an argument to the first method
the query Returns the first item in the
collection as expected
so let's pass a condition in the form of
a Lambda expression to the first
extension method
so this condition is simply querying the
collection for the first even number in
the collection
let's run the code
great
but now what happens if we alter the
collection of values so that no value
satisfies the condition I.E no even
numbers exist within the relevant
collection
an invalid operation exception is thrown
so if we don't want an exception to be
thrown we can replace the first operator
with the first or default operator
as you may have guessed where no items
in the relevant collection satisfy the
relevant condition this method will not
throw an exception but will rather
return the default value of the relevant
data type
we know that the default value for the
integer dates type is zero
let's write code to Output an
appropriate narrative to the screen if
the relevant condition is not satisfied
let's run the code
and this is an expected result
so let's include an element in the
relevant list that does satisfy the
condition
excellent
so the last and last or default
operators work in much the same way as
the first and the first or default
operators the only difference is that
the last item in the collection is
returned where no condition is specified
the last item that satisfies a specified
condition and the collection is returned
when a condition is specified
the last method will throw an exception
if an appropriate element is not present
within the relevant list
we can use the last or default method
rather than the last method to return
the default value for the relevant data
type in the case where an appropriate
element in the relevant collection is
not present
great so let's move on to the single and
single or default element operators
the single operator Returns the only
element in a collection or one element
that satisfies a specified condition
from a collection
we have the option of passing a
condition into the single method through
the use of a method overload or we can
leave the brackets following the single
method empty which means we have chosen
not to pass in a condition into the
single method
if we choose not to pass in a condition
into the single method and there's more
than one element or zero elements in the
collection and invalid operation
exception will be thrown if however
there is only a single element in the
collection the value for this element
will be returned by the query
if we do choose to pass in a condition
and zero or more than one element
satisfies the condition an invalid
operation exception will be thrown
if we pass in a condition to the single
method and only a single element
satisfies the condition the value for
this single element will be returned
from the relevant single operation
let's apply the single operator to a
collection of employees
let's first modify the data for our list
of employees so that only one employee
element exists within the relevant
employee collection
foreign
let's write code using the single
operator to query the relevant employee
list
foreign
this is an expected result
let's now include the employees that we
just commented out back within the
relevant employee list
let's run the code
and an invalid operation exception is
thrown as expected this is because more
than one employee resides in the list
if there is only one item in the
relevant collection the value for this
item is returned
if there are zero items or more than one
item in the collection and the condition
is not specified for the single operator
and invalid operation exception is
thrown
so let's test the single method and this
time specify a condition where one item
within the relevant collection satisfies
the specified condition
great
let's specify a condition where more
than one item in the relevant collection
satisfies the specified condition
as you can see an invalid operation
exception is thrown
so let's test the same scenario I.E more
than one element in the relevant
collection satisfies the specified
condition but this time let's use the
single or default method
that's interesting
so note where more than one element
satisfies the specified condition when
the single or default method is applied
and the relevant query an invalid
operation exception is thrown just like
when the single method is applied to
perform the same operation
so we can use the single or default
method instead of the single method if
we don't want an exception to be thrown
under the scenario where no elements
exist within the collection the default
value for the data type will instead be
returned by the query
if a condition is specified for the
single or default method and no elements
satisfy the condition the same result
will be produced I.E the default value
for the data type of the elements stored
in the collection will be returned by
the query
if a single item is present within the
relevant collection and the single or
default method is applied to perform a
query against the relevant collection
the single elements value that exists
within the relevant collection will be
returned by the query
[Music]
hi and welcome to the fourth and final
part in this video series on the link
technology using C sharp this video is
also part of the seventh tutorial in an
advanced c-sharp course
this video is a continuation of the
previous three videos in this video
series on link so I recommend viewing
the previous three videos in this video
series before viewing this video
in the previous video in this series we
looked at code examples where certain
link operators were implemented to query
and transform data this video is a
continuation of the previous video in
this series where we'll create code
examples using some of the other link
operators to gain a broader
understanding of what can be
accomplished using the Link Technology
in c-sharp so in the previous videos in
this series we have created code
examples using the following link
operators
the Sorting operators order by order by
descending then buy and then by
descending the grouping operators Group
by and to lookup The quantifier
Operators all any and contains
the filter operators of type and where
the element operators element at element
at or default first first or default
last last or default single and single
or default the join operators join and
group join
we have already looked at the select
projection operator and we'll also look
at the select operator in this video and
in addition to this we'll also look at
the select many projection operator
so in this video we'll look at the
following link operators
the equality operator sequence equal
the concatenation operator concat
the set operators distinct except
intersect and Union
the generation operators the fault of
empty empty range and repeat operators
the aggregate operators aggregate
average count sum and Max
the petitioning operators skip skip
while take and take while
the conversion operators to list two
dictionary and two array
and lastly the projection operators
select and select many
we'll also look at the following
keywords that are useful when used in
queries implemented in query syntax
namely the let and into keywords
we have looked at the select projection
operator already in previous videos but
we'll look at this operator again in
this video as well as look at the select
many projection operator we'll then be
able to gain an understanding of the
difference between the select and the
select many projection operators
as in the previous videos I'll be
demonstrating the code examples on my
Mac platform if you are using a Windows
platform to follow along the experience
of creating these code examples will be
almost exactly the same so the fact that
I'm using visual studio for Mac should
not be a barrier for a learner using
visual Studio for Windows to follow
along with the creation of these code
examples okay so let's create a.net core
console project
thank you
so the official release of.net 5 has now
been released so I'll be running this
project using the new.net5.net runtime
for more information on the significance
of the.net 5 runtime please View the
second part of this Advanced c-sharp
course I've included a link to this
video Below in the description
the project we created in the last video
was named link examples underscore 2.
let's name this project link examples
underscore 3.
so as we did in the previous video let's
navigate to this URL where we can access
code on GitHub for the project that was
created in the previous video of this
series
here we can copy the data related code
that we created in our previous project
so that we can reuse these data related
classes in this project
let's click the directory icon labeled
link examples underscore 2.
let's then click the file icon labeled
program.cs
let's copy the class named employee
and paste the contents of our clipboards
to our new project
let's do the same for the Department
class
and the data class
okay so we won't be using the get
heterogeneous data collection method
that resides in the data class in this
video so let's delete this method
let's refresh our memories about the
classes we have just copied and pasted
from GitHub the employee class contains
a definition for an employee record
the department class contains a
definition for a department record
the data class contains hard-coded made
up data for employee records and
Department Records the employee records
are stored in a generic list strongly
typed as employee the Department Records
are stored in a generic list that is
strongly typed as Department
we can access the data stored in the
employee list collection from calling
client code in this case this will be
the main method by calling the static
method named get employees we can access
the data stored in the department list
collection by calling the static method
named get departments note that the data
class in which these methods reside is a
static class
let's navigate to the main method and
before we create our example code let's
add the appropriate using directives
first let's add a using directive to the
system.collections.generic namespace
the generic list type is a member of
this namespace
let's also add a using directive to the
system.link namespace once we have added
our system.link using directive we can
access our link operators on collection
types that implement the I enumerable
interface so for example list types
implement the I enumerable generic
interface so we are able to access
extension methods stored within the
innumerable static class which is a
member of the system.link namespace by
including a using directive to the
system dot link namespace
the queryable static class also includes
link extension methods and is a member
of the system.link namespace for more
information on how extension methods
work in c-sharp please view the first
video in this video series a link to
this video has been included Below in
the description
before we get started creating our code
examples I want to draw your attention
to what might be an issue for visual
studio for Mac users when we run our
code interactively through Visual Studio
for Mac by default the output may appear
in the terminal console window within
visual studio for Mac like this
this is absolutely fine for testing code
but you may prefer to present the output
externally I.E in a terminal console
window outside of visual studio for Mac
if you'd prefer to present your output
externally I.E outside of visual studio
for Mac please navigate to visual studio
format preferences then Under The
Heading marked other select the item
labeled terminal
in the right pane of the relevant dialog
box ensure that the enable integrated
terminal checkbox is unchecked
this is obviously not a functional issue
it really comes down to personal
preference
let's define a generic list variable
named employee list that is strongly
typed as employee and let's assign the
collection of employee records returned
by the data dot get employees static
method to the employee list variable
let's define a generic list variable
named Department list that is strongly
typed as department and let's assign the
collection of Department Records
returned by the data.get department
static method to the department list
variable okay so we are now ready to
query and transform data using link
so let's start with the equality
operator sequence equal
so the use case here is we want to
compare two lists of data and we want to
know if these two lists contain elements
of equal value and each element in each
of the relevant lists are stored in the
same order if each item in each list
matches in terms of value and order the
sequence equal method will return true
if any of the items in each of the
relevant lists does not match in terms
of value and order the sequence equal
method returns false let's create a
generic list named integer list one
that are strongly typed as integer let's
copy and paste this line of code to the
next line let's change the name of the
second list to integer list 2.
let's run the code
and the sequence equal method returns
true because the values and sequence of
elements in integer list 1 is identical
to the values and sequence of elements
in integer list 2.
let's change the order of the items in
integer list two so this sequence of
values is not equal to the sequence of
values stored in the list named integer
list one
let's run the code and this is an
expected result
let's change integer list to once again
for good measure
and this is an expected result great
so let's change the data in integer list
2 so that the order and values in the
lists are equal
and now the result is true which is an
expected result
that was pretty straightforward I.E
comparing two sequences of values of a
primitive data type IE the integer data
tab but what if we want to test this
type of equality between two lists that
are strongly typed with a complex type
like for example our employee uses
defined type
so let's Define a variable named
employee list compare as a generic list
type that is strongly typed as employee
and let's assign The Collection returned
from the data dot get employee's static
method to our employee list compare
variable
let's run a sequence equal operation and
compare the values stored within our
employee list compare collection with
the values stored within the employee
list collection
so one would expect the result of the
sequence equal operation to return true
because both collections contain exactly
the same data let's see what happens
oh and false is returned
the reason why false is returned is
because we need to tell the compiler how
to establish equality between objects of
the relevant complex type IE in this
case the employee type so we achieved
this in the previous video in this
series by implementing the built-in I
equality comparer generic interface so
let's copy the relevant code for this
that we implemented in the previous
video in the series
let's navigate to the GitHub repository
at this URL that contains the code we
created in the previous video in this
series
let's copy the class named employee
comparer to our clipboards
and paste the contents of our clipboards
to our projects like this
we have red squiggly lines so let's fix
this by bringing in the appropriate
using directive so here we have
implemented a class named employee
comparer that implements the generic I
equality compare interface that is
strongly typed as employee
this gives us a way of telling the
compiler how we want objects
in our lists of type employee to be
compared when determining equality
between the relevant objects
so we are explicitly doing this here in
the equals method where we are comparing
the ID first name and last name
properties between two employee objects
we are returning true if the relevant
properties of the relevant two objects
are equal and false is returned if any
of the relevant properties of our two
objects are not equal
within the get hash code method we are
returning the hash code of the ID
property of the relevant employee
objects for more information on hash
codes please navigate to this URL
so now let's go to our main method and
we can pass in a new instance of the
employee comparer class to an overloaded
version of the sequence equal method
this object will tell the compiler
explicitly how we want our employee
objects to be compared
let's run the code
and now the sequence SQL operator works
as expected so note that we need to tell
the compiler how we want objects that
are defined as complex types to be
compared when determining equality
between the relevant objects
we can do this by creating a class that
appropriately implements the I equality
comparer generic interface great
let's move on to the concatenation
operator named concat
we can use the concat operator to append
one collection of data to another
collection of data
so let's see the concat operator in
action let's create a collection of
integer values
let's then create another collection of
let's append the second collection of
integer values with the first collection
of integer values using the concat
operator
let's write code to Output the results
of this concatenation operation to the
screen
let's run the code
great
let's do another example but this time
let's append a collection that contains
a collection of objects of a complex
type to another collection of objects of
the same complex type the complex type
we'll use in this example will be our
employee user defined type once again we
can use the concat operator to achieve
what we want here
let's run the code
great
let's move on to the aggregate operators
let's first look at the aggregate
operator
using the aggregate operator we can
perform a custom operation on values
within a collection
let's say we have a requirement where we
need to provide a total for the annual
salaries of our employee records
we also need to include the addition of
an appropriate annual salary bonus in
the final result let's say a manager
gets a bonus of four percent and
employees that aren't managers get a
bonus of two percent so let's say we
have a use case where we need a result
that is a total of all employee annual
salaries which must include each
employee's bonus
we can take this added complexity into
account when totaling up our employee
annual salaries through the use of the
aggregate operator
so the first argument is the seed value
so let's provide zero for this argument
using this argument we are initializing
the value that will be returned by our
aggregate operator
the next argument is of a delegate type
where we can include the logic for our
aggregation functionality in the form of
a Lambda expression so as you can see in
our Logic for the relevant Lambda
expression argument we are checking to
see if the relevant employee is a
manager whereby we need to add a bonus
of four percent to the relevant
employees annual salary if the employee
is not a manager we need to add a bonus
of two percent to the relevant employees
annual salary
we can then include the appropriate
bonus amount in our calculation so we
are adding up all employee annual
salaries which includes each employee's
appropriate bonus
let's run the code
great
say we want to Output a comma delimited
string from our employee list collection
each delimited item containing the
employee full name a dash then the
employee annual salary each annual
salary must include the appropriate
bonus
we also want to include a label
preceding the comma delimited string
we can achieve this using the aggregate
operator like this
the first argument is the label where an
appropriate value could be something
like employee annual salaries including
bonus
then the logic of our aggregation
functionality
can be expressed in a Lambda expression
for the second argument like this
we can apply the same logic to include
appropriate bonuses from our previous
example
let's run the code
great but we have a slight issue where a
comma is presented at the end of our
string
we don't want this comma in our final
result
we can express this by passing a Lambda
expression as our third argument to an
overloaded version of the aggregate
operator
this argument allows us to perform a
final operation on the results produced
by the Lambda expression passed in as
the second argument
we first need to include another data
type argument with an angle brackets
following the aggregate method to
declare the data type of the final
output I.E provided by the Lambda
expression we are passing in to the last
parameter of this overloaded version of
the aggregate method
in the Lambda expression passed in as
our final argument we are using the
substring method to remove two
characters from the end of the result
which means a comma and a space will be
removed
this result is what we want excellent
so let's move on to the average
aggregate operator
so to find the average annual salary for
a list of employees we can apply this
code
great if we want to find the average
salary for all employees in the
technology department we can use method
chaining and the where operator to
achieve this like this
great
for more information on method chaining
please View the second part of this
video series
let's move on to the count aggregate
operator
so if we want to know how many employee
records we have in our collection of
employee records we can apply the count
operator like this
great
if we want to know how many employees or
members of the technology department we
can pass in a condition as an argument
to the count operator
the condition that is passed in as an
argument to the count method can be
expressed in the form of a Lambda
expression
great
let's move on to the sum aggregate
operator so let's keep this simple we
just want the sum total of all annual
salaries of all employee records stored
in our employee list collection we can
apply the sum operator to achieve this
great
let's move on to the max aggregate
operator
so if we want to return the highest
annual salary property of all employee
records stored in our employee list
collection we can apply the max
aggregate operator in a link query like
this
great
let's move on to the generation
operators namely default of empty empty
range and repeat
let's first look at the default fmt
operator
so we can use the default if empty
operator to return a new I enumerable
collection that when for example we
apply the element at method on the new
collection to check if the new
collection is empty the operation will
return the default value for the
relevant type used to strongly type the
relevant collection
a query using for example the element at
method against a collection returned
from a default of empty operation will
not throw an exception if the collection
is empty the default value of the type
with which the relevant collection is
strongly typed will instead be returned
for more information on default values
for C sharp dates types please navigate
to this URL
we'll see later how we can pass in a
value to the default of empty method to
specify our own default value that we'd
prefer to be returned when for example
the element at method is used to check
if the relevant collection is empty
rather than the default c-sharp value
for the relevant data type
let's look at an example using the
default fmt method
so let's create an empty list of integer
values let's perform a default fmt
operation on this collection of integer
values and assign The Returned
collection to a new collection of
integer values let's use the element at
operator and pass in 0 to the element at
method to check if the collection is
empty
you can see that the element at operator
Returns the default value for the
integer data type which is zero this is
an expected result let's create another
example but this time let's use the
employee data type to strongly type our
collections as discussed the default
value for a reference type in c-sharp is
null
but as discussed we can pass in a
default value that we would prefer to be
returned by for example the element at
operator when the relevant collection is
empty
so let's person an employee object where
the ID property of the relevant employee
object is set to zero
null is not returned as would be the
case if we hadn't passed in a value to
the default fmt method because we have
specified our own default value where
the ID property of the default employee
object is zero
great
similarly we could have set the default
value for our integer collection example
by for example passing in 999 999 to the
default if empty method instead of
returning the default c-sharp value for
an integer which is 0
99999 is returned this is an expected
result excellent
right let's look at the empty method
so we can use the empty method to
generate a new empty collection
so for example we want to create a new
innumerable generic collection of
employee records we can do this by using
the empty operator like this
note the empty method is not an
extension method of innumerable or I
queryable like other link methods it is
a static method included in the
enumerable static class
so for example we could instantiate a
new empty generic list strongly typed
with the employee user defined type
through the use of the empty method
we can then chain the two list
conversion operator to this operation
and return an empty generic list we are
using the two list operator to convert
an i enumerable generic collection that
is strongly typed with the employee data
type to a generic list that is strongly
typed as employee
so for good measure let's add a new
employee item to our new list that we
have generated through the use of the
empty method and the use of the two list
conversion operator
let's write code to write the items or
in this case one item stored in our new
list to the screen
great
let's move on to the range generation
operator
we can use the range operator to return
a collection of values that are within a
specified range so let's clarify this
with an example
we want to return a range of integer
values in a collection where the first
item in the range has a value of 25 and
each subsequent item is incremented by a
value of 1 until there are a total of 20
values in the relevant collection
we can achieve this by using the range
method like this
in this example the first argument
specified is 25.
this is the value of the first element
and the second argument specifies the
number of elements to include in the
relevant generated collection
when each item is added to the
collection It Is incremented by a value
of one so the second item will be 26 the
third item will be 27 the fourth item
will be 28 and so on
let's run the code
great so using the range operator we
have generated a collection of integer
values that fall within a specified
range excellent
let's say we want to generate a
collection of a specified amount of
elements where a value for each element
in the collection is repeated
we can use the repeat operator for this
purpose like this
great
let's move on to the set operators
namely distinct except intersect and
Union
let's start with distinct
so let's say we have a strongly typed
generic list that contains a list of
integer values some of which are
repeating values we want to perform a
query against this list of integer
values where we only want distinct
values returned
we can achieve this by applying the
distinct operator to our query like this
great
let's say that we have two collection of
a specific type and we want to return
elements with values in our first
collection that are not equal to any of
the values of the elements in our second
collection we can achieve this by using
the accept operator let's look at an
example of using the accept operator
applied to two collections of integer
values
so one and two are returned in our
results collection because these values
exist in our first collection and don't
exist in the second collection
the values 3 and 4 exist in our first
collection and also exist in our second
collection
the values five and six exist in our
second collection and even though these
items don't exist in our first
collection
the accept operator does not return
these items as part of the results
collection because in this example the
accept operator returns values that
exist in the first collection and don't
exist in the second collection
let's try an example using complex types
let's use our employee type
let's create a generic list strongly
typed as employee
let's copy data
that we know will exist within our
employee list collection and add these
items to the list we have named employee
list 2. let's add some additional items
to the employee list to collection
let's then call the accept method on the
employee list collection and pass in the
employee list 2 collection as an
argument to the accept method then let's
assign the results of this operation to
an implicitly typed variable named
results
we have of course used the VAR keyword
to implicitly type our results variable
let's write code to Traverse the results
and output the results to the screen
let's run the code and see what happens
and this result is not expected the
output contains all items within the
employee list collection
I would have expected that the items
that were copied from the data class and
added to the employee list 2 collection
as well as the other items that we added
to the employee list collection would be
excluded from the results
the reason for the unexpected results is
because we have not told the compiler
how to compare employee objects when
determining if one employee object is
equal to another employee object
so how can we let the compiler know how
we want one employee to be compared to
another employee within our collections
when determining equality between the
two relevant objects
you may have guessed already how we can
achieve this we first need to create a
class that implements the eye equality
comparer generic interface
we can then write code to establish how
one employee object should be compared
to another employee object when
determining equality between the
relevant objects
we have already included the code for
this which we applied when we created
code to perform a sequence equal
operation on two lists that were
strongly typed as an employee so we have
our class named employee comparer that
implements the IE quality comparer
generic interface
so we can reuse this class for our
example that performs an accept
operation on two generic lists that are
strongly typed as employee
so all we need to do is create a new
object of type employee comparer and
pass this object into an overloaded
version of the accept method like this
let's run the code
great
this is now an expected result let's
move on to the intersect operator
so we can use the intersect set operator
to return a collection containing only
those items that exist in the employee
list collection that are equal to the
items that exist within the employee
list 2 collection
and now that we know we are comparing
elements in two collections that are
strongly typed with the employee complex
type we need to pass in a new object of
the employee comparer type I.E a type
that appropriately implements the
generic IE quality comparer interface
this tells the compiler how to compare
two objects of type employee when
determining if the relevant employee
objects are equal let's run the code
and this is an expected result great
let's move on to the union operator the
union extension method requires two
Collections and returns a new collection
that includes distinct elements from
both the collections
we can again use the same data we have
used in the previous two examples to
test the union operator right let's
write the code for this you will notice
we are also passing in an object of type
employee comparer to the union method
Let's test the code
great
so let's see what happens in this
example when we don't pass in an object
of type employee comparer to the union
method
you can see that duplicate records are
included in the results as a consequence
of not passing in an object derived from
a class that appropriately implements
the generic IE quality comparer
interface and of course we know we have
already created such a class so let's
ensure that we pass in our object of
type employee comparer to the union
method so that only distinct employee
objects are included within our results
excellent
so let's move on to the partitioning
operators these partitioning operators
include the skip skip while take and
take while operators
let's first look at the skip operator
use the skip operator to skip over a
given number of elements in a sequence
and then return the remainder
so let's query our employee list
collection using the skip operator
let's skip over two of the elements
stored in our employee list collection
and return the remainder of the elements
using the skip operator
great this is an expected result
let's look at the skip wow operator
using the skip while operator bypasses
elements in a sequence as long as a
specified condition is true and then
Returns the remaining elements
let's see this operator in action
so the condition here is Skip elements
in our sequence of employee objects in
the employee list collection while the
relevant employee object's annual
salaries are above 50 000.
great this is an expected result
just to make things a little bit more
clear on how this operator Works let's
add a new employee record to the
employee list collection this employee
record has an annual salary of one
hundred thousand which of course is
above fifty thousand
let's run the code
and you can see that while the condition
is true the items in the relevant
collection are skipped I.E will not be
returned from the query however all
subsequent elements in the sequence will
be returned once the condition returns
false
even though the last element in the
relevant sequence has an annual salary
property greater than fifty thousand it
is still returned because the third
element in the sequence caused the
condition to return false
the fact that the last element has an
annual salary above 50 000 and therefore
causes the condition to be true doesn't
mean that the last item will be returned
by our query note that once the
condition returns false all items from
that point will be returned from our
query
right let's move on to the take
partition operator
the take operator is used to return a
specified number of contiguous elements
from the start of a sequence
let's see this operator in action
this is an expected result great
the first two elements in the relevant
sequence of elements in our employee
list collection are returned by our
query
so let's move on to the take while
partitioning operator
the take while operator returns elements
from a sequence as long as a specified
condition is true and then skips the
remaining elements
so let's use the same condition that we
used in the skip while operator example
so here we are using the take while
operator to return elements from the
relevant sequence that have an annual
salary above 50 000. so the first two
elements in the sequence are returned by
our query
as soon as the third element is
evaluated and the condition returns
false the elements from that point
onwards in the relevant sequence will
not be returned by our query
so for example the fact that the fifth
element in the employee list collection
has an annual salary property that is
greater than 50 000 is irrelevant
because when the third element causes
the condition to return false and in
terms of the take while operator this
means that from that point onwards the
rest of the elements and the relevance
sequence will not be returned by our
query great
let's look at the conversion operators
to list two dictionary and two array
so let's look at the two list conversion
operator a query written and query
syntax will return an i enumerable
collection containing the results of the
query what if we need our results to be
returned as a generic list
we can achieve this using the two list
conversion operator
let's create an example to clarify this
point
so for this example let's query our
employee list collection for employee
records that have an annual salary
property greater than 50 000 using query
syntax
note the red squiggly lines here
this is because we are attempting to
assign an inumerable collection to a
variable of type generic list
the compiler is telling us that we have
created a type mismatch
so we can use the two list operator to
convert the I enumerable collection
returned by our query to a generic list
by wrapping the relevant query in
Brackets adding a DOT after the last
bracket and applying the two list
operator like this so now you can see
the red squiggly lines disappear because
we have removed the type mismatch
let's run the code
excellent
as discussed earlier in this video
series wherever a two conversion
operator is applied to a query as we
have done here
this causes the query to execute
immediately I.E query execution is not
deferred it is executed immediately
so if we want to convert an innumerable
collection returned from a query to a
dictionary object
we can apply the two dictionary operator
to the query let's create an example to
clarify what is meant by this
so as in the previous example here we
have a standard query written in query
syntax to query our employee list
collection for all elements where the
relevant elements have annual salary
properties that have values greater than
fifty thousand so this is a basic query
that will return an i enumerable
collection
but what if we want to return a
collection where each element has a
unique key associated with the relevant
element
we can do this by converting the query
result to a dictionary generic
collection type
so let's alter our code so that the
innumerable collection returned by our
query is converted into a generic
dictionary collection So within angle
brackets after two dictionary we need to
pass in two data types the first data
type declares the data type of the
values stored in the dictionary
the second data type declares the data
type of the key that will be used to
uniquely identify each element in the
collection so the First Dates type is of
type employee and the second data type
is of type int note that we want each
element to be keyed on the employee ID
property
we can express this by passing in an
appropriate Lambda expression to the two
dictionary method like this
so let's Traverse the key values stored
in our dictionary object using a for
each Loop
note how we are able to use the key
values to retrieve the values of each
element stored in the dictionary
we are doing this by passing in the
relevant key within square brackets to
the dictionary object
here we are outputting the key as well
as each employee's first name and last
name to the screen
and as you can see we have each
employee's ID which we have designated
as our key value followed by the
corresponding employees first name and
last name properties excellent
we have successfully converted a query
result from an innumerable collection to
a dictionary object
as discussed when we call any of the two
conversion operators on a query result
this causes our query to execute
immediately for more information on
deferred execution versus immediate
execution please View the second part of
this video series
for good measure let's also create a
result using the two array conversion
method
so if we try to assign the results of
this query to a variable defined as an
array of employees the compiler
complains of a type mismatch the query
result is returned as an innumerable
collection and not an array of employee
objects
to remove the tap mismatch we can apply
the two array method like this
great
so let's discuss the let and the intu
Clauses that can be applied when using
query syntax to represent a link query
let's look at the Microsoft docs for an
overview of the let Clause this overview
of the let Clause can be found at this
URL
in a query expression
it is sometimes useful to store the
result of a sub-expression in order to
use it in subsequent clauses
you can do this with the let keyword
which creates a new Range variable and
initializes it with the result of the
expression you supply
once initialized with a value the range
variable cannot be used to store another
value
however if the range variable holds a
queryable type it can be queried
so let's look at a basic example using
the let keyword in a link query
let's say we wish to query our employees
based on employee initials now we don't
have an initials property for an
employee record but within our query
using the let keyword we can extract the
initials from each employee records
first name and last name properties and
assign the result
of this extraction process to a variable
named initials directly within our query
using the lit keyword this allows us to
use the initials variable in our where
Clause as well as reuse the initials
variable within our select clause
through the use of the let Clause we can
also apply a condition and based on the
evaluation of that condition store a
value in a variable that can be used
later in the query like for example
within aware clause
here we have a condition where we need
to add an appropriate bonus to the
annual salary property based on whether
the employee is a manager or not a
manager if the employee is a manager we
need to add a bonus of four percent to
the relevant employee records annual
salary property
if the employee is not a manager we need
to add a bonus of two percent to the
relevant employee records annual salary
property we can store the relevant
annual salary plus bonus value for each
employee record by assigning the value
returned by a ternary operator to a
variable we have named this variable
annual salary plus bonus the let clause
in this example enables us to reuse the
annual salary plus bonus variable both
within the where clause and the select
Clause later in the query
let's run the code
excellent
let's look at the into keyword
we can use the into keyword in a link
query to collate data within a group and
then after this operation we are able to
perform a filter operation within the
same query if required on the grouped
data through the use of aware clause
so for example let's use a link query to
First create a group of high earning
employees based on a condition let's say
that the employee must earn above 50 000
to fit into the relevant group we can
use the where Clause at this point in
the query to appropriately filter the
relevant employee records and the into
keyword to put the filtered data into
the relevant group of high earning
employees
so we can use the into keyword to group
The High earning employees into a group
named High earners let's say we then
want to further filter this group of
high earning employees by management
status
so we only want these employee records
where the is manager property is set to
true return from our query
we want to know which of those High
earning employees are managers
so we can use another where Clause
within our query to filter the high
earner group based on the relevant
condition
we have used a where Clause earlier in
our query to create the group of high
earning employees
then once the group is created through
the use of the into keyword we can
further filter the group of high earning
employees based on each employee records
is manager property
so we are able to include another where
clause in our query to filter the
grouped data let's run the code
great
so lastly let's look at the select and
the select many projection operators
in this video series we have already
looked at the select projection operator
so the focus in this example is on the
select many operator
we want to know how it differs from the
select operator and in what
circumstances we may wish to apply the
select many operator in a link query
let's navigate to a Microsoft docs
webpage to see what the Microsoft docs
say about these two projection operators
projection refers to the operation of
transforming an object into a new form
that often consists only of those
properties that will be subsequently
used
by using projection we can construct a
new type that is built from each object
you can project a property and perform a
mathematical function on it you can also
project the original object without
changing it
select projects values that are based on
a transform function
select many projects sequences or values
that are based on a transform function
and then flattens them into one sequence
to understand the difference between the
select many operator and the select
operator let's modify our department
class so that it includes a property
that stores a collection of employees
we have already discussed that
Department Records have a one-to-many
relationship with employee records so
each department object will now store a
collection of related employee records
let's also alter the get Department's
static method that resides in the data
static class so that the get
Department's static method accepts an
argument containing a collection of
employee objects
then for each department object added to
the department list collection within
the get Department static method let's
include a query to return an appropriate
collection of employees I.E those
employee records that have a department
ID property matching the ID property of
the relevant Department object
so let's go to the main method and pass
in the collection of employees to the
get Department method so now the get
departments method will return a
collection where each department
contains a related collection of
employee records
so now what if we want to query the
department list collection for all
employees we can achieve this using the
select operator but when traversing the
results of the select operation we will
need to use an outer and an inner for
each Loop like this
in this scenario the select many
operator is better to use for this
purpose the select many operator is
better in this case because we can use
one for each Loop to Traverse the
results of our query
unlike where we needed to use an
additional nested for each Loop to
Traverse the results of our query
where we used the select operator
behind the scenes as it were the select
many operator appropriately flattens the
results
and this means we don't need to use a
nested for each Loop to Traverse the
results of our query
we are able to use one for each Loop for
this purpose
excellent
so we have covered a lot of ground in
this video series on link operators I
would encourage you to practice using
these operators to become proficient in
writing link queries this is a very
powerful technology and it's used with
Entity framework to perform database
queries in modern.net applications
Entity framework is now the recommended
technology to use a.net for implementing
database related functionality in.net
applications if we navigate to this
Microsoft docs webpage we can see this
paragraph that states Entity framework
core is a modern object-based mapper for
net it supports link queries change
tracking updates and schema migrations
EF core works with many databases
including SQL database on-premises and
Azure sqlite MySQL postgres and Azure
Cosmos DB
this makes link a very important
technology to learn for net Developers
link enables developers to write one set
of code that can be applied to handle
data related functionality for multiple
different data sources in link
expression trees are used to represent
structured queries that Target sources
of data that implement the generic I
queryable interface
if you would like to delve deeper into
expression trees please navigate to this
URL
so let's summarize what we have learned
in our four part series on using the
Link Technology in C sharp in the first
part of this video series we created our
own extension method to filter data we
also demonstrated how a Lambda
expression can be used to express a
condition that can be passed into our
extension method to filter the data and
return the filtered results from a query
the reason we created the filter
extension method is because link is
mostly made up of extension methods
stored in two static classes namely a
static class named enumerable and a
static class named queryable
we are able to access the extension
methods Within These static classes by
including a using directive to the
system.link namespace the enumerable and
queryable classes are both members of
the system.link namespace
in the second part of this series we
demonstrated examples using the select
where join and group join operators we
also discussed the difference between
when a query is executed with deferred
execution or immediate execution we
discussed how a link query is executed
with deferred execution but we can make
the link query execute immediately by
applying a two conversion operator to
the query for example two list two
dictionary or two array
in the third video in this series we
demonstrated code examples using the
following link operators
sorting operators order by order by
descending then buy and then by
descending grouping operators group buy
and to lookup
quantifier operators or any and contains
filter operators of type and where
element operators element at element at
or default first first or default last
last or default single and single or
default
in the fourth and final video in this
series we demonstrated code examples
using the following link operators the
equality operator sequence equal
the concatenation operator concat
the set operators distinct accept
intersect and Union
the generation operators
default if empty empty range and repeat
operators
the aggregate operators aggregate
average count sum and Max
the partitioning operators skip skip
while take and take while
the conversion operators to list two
dictionary and two array
projection operators
select and select many
in this video we also looked at code
examples using the let and the N2
keywords
I hope you have enjoyed this video
series on using the Link Technology in
c-sharp
[Music]
hi and welcome to the eighth part of
this Advanced c-sharp course
in this video we'll focus on the use of
attributes and c-sharp for more content
on advanced c-sharp concepts and much
more please consider subscribing and
please ring the bell so that you'll be
notified of future content if you like
this video at any point please consider
giving it a thumbs up it will be greatly
appreciated
so let's discuss attributes attributes
allow the developer to add metadata in a
declarative way to program elements and
code for example classes methods
properties parameters Etc
a declared attribute is instantiated
into an object at runtime and at compile
time we can declare attributes against
program elements to provide additional
metadata to relevant program elements
the developer is also able to declare
Global attributes against assemblies and
a doing so add or modify metadata about
the relevant assembly
so the developer can use attributes to
add or modify metadata about a
particular program element or the
assembly itself
in this video we'll also briefly look at
reflection reflection is a technology
that we can use to read the metadata
provided through the use of attributes
at runtime we are then able to for
example Implement codelogic based on the
metadata provided through the use of
attributes we'll look at how we can do
this later in this video
there are two broad categories for
attributes predefined attributes and
custom attributes
predefined attributes are built into the
baseclass libraries and net in this
video we'll look at two main types of
predefined attributes Global predefined
attributes and general predefined
attributes Global attributes like for
example assembly version attribute and
assembly description attribute
facilitate adding and modifying metadata
for an assembly General attributes lack
for example conditional attribute
obsolete attribute and attribute usage
can be applied to appropriate program
elements
we'll start by implementing a code
example using the assembly version
attribute and assembly description
attribute which are Global attributes
we'll use reflection to read the
relevant assembly metadata and output
the assembly metadata to the console
screen
we'll then Implement a code example
using the following General attributes
conditional attribute obsolete attribute
and attribute usage
the attribute usage attribute will be
declared on our own custom attributes
that will create a bit later in this
video
we'll use custom attributes and
reflection to implement field validation
functionality we'll demonstrate how
custom attributes can be created by
creating classes that inherit from the
built-in system.attribute class later in
this video we are going to create custom
attributes as part of validation logic
that imitates how the asp.net MVC
framework provides flexibility to
developers through the use of reusable
validation related attributes
this video sets us up well for the next
video provided by this channel which
will be a demonstration of creating a
basic asp.net MVC application on.net 5.
right let's create our code examples so
that we can gain an understanding of
attributes in C sharp let's create a.net
core console application project
let's name this project attributes
examples
let's ensure that we are using.net 5 for
this project
if you haven't yet installeds.net5
please see a link below in the
description where you are able to
download the.net5 SDK
note that you'll mostly be able to
follow along even using earlier
versionsoft.net but it is advisable to
download.net 5 to follow along with this
tutorial and future tutorials
one of my core aims is to keep these
tutorials right up to date
please view a video created for this
Channel about the significance of the
release of.net 5. a link to this video
can be found Below in the description
so let's say that we wish to declare the
assembly version Global attributes in
our code
we are able to do this by declaring This
Global attribute between the namespace
Declaration and the using directives
okay so why can't I see the assembly
version attribute in the intellisense
drop down
the reason is that the assembly version
attribute is part of the
system.reflection namespace
so let's add a using directive to the
and now we are able to see the assembly
version attribute along with other
Global attributes in the intellisense
drop down list and we can now declare
the global attribute against our
assembly like this
so here we are attempting to set our
attribute version number to
2.0.1 through the Declaration of the
assembly version Global attribute
great so let's see what happens when we
attempt to compile the code
so we have a compile time error let's
look at our error list to take a look at
the details of this error
the description of the error is
duplicate
system.reflection.assembly version
attribute attribute
so let's double click on the error item
in our list that is causing the compile
time error to occur
okay so a new file is open and we can
see a red squiggly line under the
offending code
it is a file that has a name that
contains the assembly name followed by
the suffix dot assembly info and we are
able to find this file within our
projects directory structure
and if we look at the comments within
this file it is clear that this file has
been auto-generated
it's in fact being Auto generated by Ms
build
let's navigate to this URL to read a bit
about Ms build
the Microsoft build engine is a platform
for building applications this engine
which is also known as Ms build provides
an XML schema for a project file that
controls how the build platform
processes and builds software Visual
Studio uses Ms build but Ms build
doesn't depend on Visual Studio
by invoking msbill.exe on your project
or solution file you can orchestrate and
build products in environments where
Visual Studio isn't installed
Visual Studio uses Ms build to load and
build managed projects the project files
in visual
studio.csproge.vbproj.vcx project and
others contain Ms build XML code that
executes when you build a project by
using the IDE Visual Studio Projects
import all the necessary settings and
build processes to do typical
development work
but you can extend or modify them from
within Visual Studio or by using an XML
editor
so the basic point I'm trying to make
here is that many of these Global
attributes will be automatically
declared in the assembly info file when
compiling your code using the visual
studio IDE
you can gain access to some of these
Global attributes through the visual
studio IDE
if you try to declare a global attribute
as I have attempted to here you may get
a compile time error because Ms build
has automatically declared the global
attribute in the assembly info file
as we have seen this results in the
duplication of the relevant Global
attribute declaration which ultimately
results in a compile time error
occurring
you are able to declare certain Global
attributes and the way we tried to
declare the assembly version attribute
for example let's declare the assembly
description attribute
let's comment out the assembly version
attribute declaration let's add our own
assembly description metadata to our
assembly through a declaration of the
assembly description Global attribute
let's pass a value of my assembly
description to the Constructor of the
assembly description attribute
note that depending on how the relevant
attribute has been written when the
developer declares an attribute the
developer is able to provide custom
metadata to the relevant attribute
through the attributes exposed public
Properties or the relevant attributes
Constructor parameters
so we know that the purpose of
attributes is so that we can add or
modify metadata against certain program
elements or even against the assembly
itself note that attributes on their own
do not change application Behavior
the metadata provided through attribute
declarations can be read at runtime
through the use of reflection relevant
metadata can then be evaluated by our
code and appropriate code logic can be
invoked based on the declared metadata
so this is how the Microsoft docs
describes reflection reflection provides
objects of type type that describe
assemblies modules and types you can use
reflection to dynamically create an
instance of a type bind the types to an
existing object or get the type from an
existing object and invoke its methods
or access its fields and properties
if you are using attributes in your code
reflection enables you to access them
right so let's use reflection to access
and read certain metadata that has been
added through the use of global
attributes
so we need a using directive to the
system.reflection namespace which has
already been included in our code
so let's write some code in our main
method
let's get a reference to the current
assembly
we can do this by getting a reference to
the program classes type and then
assigning its assembly property value to
a variable
we have named our variable this SM
referring to the current assembly we can
then get the relevant assembly Name by
using the assembly reference stored in
the this assemb variable and calling its
get name method
and we can access the assembly's version
information through that version
property
now we want to read the assembly's
description which should be the
description that we included when we
declared the assembly description Global
attribute
to get a reference to the assembly
description attribute we can call the
get custom attributes method under this
the same object and pass in the type of
the attribute of interest to us
note that we are using the type of
method to get a reference to the object
type of the relevant attribute remember
attributes and C sharp are objects at
runtime
an object instantiated from the assembly
description attribute class should be
the first item in our object array
we can use the as operator to cast the
object to the assembly description
attribute type
if the casting operation fails now will
be returned if the operation succeeds an
object of the assembly description
attribute type is returned
let's write code to write out the
metadata information about the current
assembly that we have been able to
retrieve through reflection to the
console screen
let's run the code
great
so we have looked at examples of global
predefined attributes let's look at some
general predefined attributes let's
start with the conditional attribute
let's first add a new standard Library
project to our solution
and let's name our project logging
component
let's remove the automatically created
class named class 1 and add a new class
named logging to our new project
let's add a public static method to the
login class named log to screen
it contains one parameter named MSG and
is defined as a string the code for this
method simply outputs the value
referenced by the MSG argument to the
console screen let's declare the
conditional attribute against the log to
screen program element we have a red
squiggly line because the conditional
attribute as a member of the
system.diagnostics namespace
so let's add a using directive to the
and now let's pass in an argument into
the Constructor of our conditional
attribute let's pass in the text log
underscore info so what does log
underscore info mean
log underscore info is a piece of text
that I've made up this text represents a
symbol in our code we can use the Define
preprocessor directive and include the
log underscore info symbol in our code
if the log underscore info symbol is
defined using the preprocessor defined
directive within a file containing
method calls to the log to screen method
the code within the log to screen method
will be executed at runtime however if
the predefined processor directive is
not used to define the log underscore
info symbol in the file where the log to
screen method is called its code will
not be executed at runtime because we
have used the conditional attribute to
declare to the compiler that we would
like this Behavior to occur regarding
the log to screen program element so
the combination of the conditional
attribute and the use of the Define
preprocessor directive can act like a
switching mechanism I.E using this
mechanism we are able to switch certain
code on or off this is especially useful
for debugging purposes
if this is not clear don't worry we will
demonstrate what is meant here through a
code example
we are able to Define our log underscore
info symbol through the use of a
preprocessor directive
we are going to use the Define
preprocessor director for this purpose
preprocessor identifiers are used to
help in conditional compilation
if we navigate to this URL
we can see some of the preprocessor
directives available in c-sharp
for more information on pre-processor
directives please use this section of
the Microsoft docs as your guide so here
we have the hash Define preprocessor
directive that we can use to define a
symbol in our code
so let's see how we can use a particular
preprocessor directive in conjunction
with the conditional attribute to
conditionally output information to the
console Screen through our log to screen
method we must add our appropriate
pre-processor directive code right at
the top of our program.cs file in our
code editors like this to implement the
desired functionality
you can see we have the Define
preprocessor identifier in this line of
code as well as the log underscore info
symbol that we made up and passed as
text to our conditional attribute which
was declared against the log to screen
program elements
let's include a using directive to our
login component namespace
in our main method let's make a call to
the logging.log to screen method and
pass in the following text as an
argument to the MSG parameter this code
is testing logging functionality
let's run the code
and as expected the appropriate text is
written to the console screen
so now let's see what happens when we
comment out the relevant preprocessor
directive code and run the code again
and you can see that nothing has been
outputted to the console screen using
our pre-processor directive we can
switch the execution of the code against
which the relevant conditional attribute
is applied on and off at compile time
this functionality can be very useful
for debugging purposes
so let's say we have a change to our
login component where we want all
logging to be done to a text file rather
than to the console screen and we want
the consumers of our code to use the
method that logs the information to a
text file rather than to the console
screen so how can we let the consumers
know to use the log to file method
rather than the log to screen method
we can simply declare the obsolete
predefined General attribute against the
log to screen method
let's create a public static method
named log to file
in the interest of time rather than
writing the code to actually log the
value passed into this method to a file
let's just write code to Output the
value to the console screen and pretend
that it's method logs relevant text to a
text file
okay so let's declare the obsolete
attribute against the log to screen
method and let's pass a meaningful
message to the Constructor of the
obsolete attribute
so we want any calling code that is
currently using the log to screen method
to receive the following warning message
the log to screen method has now been
deprecated please use the log to file
method instead
so now if we go to our main method we
can immediately see a green squiggly
line under the code that is calling the
log to screen method
and if we hover our Mouse pointers over
the green squiggly line we can see that
the text that we passed as an argument
to the obsolete attribute is presented
to us
and note that if we want to force the
user of our code to not use the log to
screen method at all
we can set a second parameter in the
obsolete attribute to true
if this value is set to True an error is
flagged when a user attempts to use the
deprecated method I.E the log to screen
method
now you can see that the green squiggly
line has turned into a red squiggly line
meaning that we no longer just receive a
warning message we are receiving an
error message
this means we won't be able to compile
the code
the last predefined attribute that I
wish to discuss is the attribute usage
attribute
we are going to create our own custom
attributes and use reflection to read
the relevant metadata added to relevant
program elements through our custom
attributes so reflection and attributes
will be implemented to provide
flexibility to developers using our
custom attributes to declare how
relevant Fields should be validated
this code is going to be very similar to
the code that the asp.net MVC framework
implements for field validation
in asp.net MVC we can declare certain
validation related attributes against
relevant program elements and the MVC
framework automatically handles
validation of relevant fields for us
behind the scenes as it were
in this code example however we are
going to create the custom attributes
used for declaring how we want relevant
Fields validated and we will also write
code using reflection to read the
attribute data declared against relevant
program elements in this case the
program elements will be properties
we will also write the validation code
related to each of our custom attributes
okay so let's add a new standard Library
project to our solution
let's name this project validation
component
let's delete the class that was
automatically created by Visual Studio
let's create a new folder named custom
attributes
let's add our first custom attribute
class to the custom attributes folder
let's right click the custom attributes
folder and add a new class let's name
this class required attribute note that
we must include the attribute suffix and
the class name of our custom attribute
however when we declare our custom
attribute you'll see that in the
Declaration we can omit the attribute
suffix from the attribute name
we are however allowed to include the
attribute suffix in our attribute
declaration but functionally this is
unnecessary we'll demonstrate this a bit
later
the code for this attribute is very
simple
let's create a public auto implemented
property of type string named error
message
let's add code to a parameter-less
Constructor whereby the error message
property is set to a default value so
let's say we want to default error
message of you cannot leave field and
then in curly brackets we have a zero
followed by the word empty
so the zero and curly brackets allows
the relevant field name to be inserted
into the message at a later time
this is achieved through the use of
composite formatting if you are not
familiar with composite formatting
regarding string values please view a
tutorial created for this channel on C
sharp strings a link to this tutorial
has been provided Below in the
description
right let's create a parameterized
Constructor
this will allow the developer to pass in
a custom error message when declaring
the required attribute against the
relevant program element
the Declaration of the required
attribute will be demonstrated a bit
later
in order for our class to be recognized
as a custom attribute we must ensure
that our class inherits from the
built-in system.attribute class
a custom attribute must inherit from the
system.attribute class
either directly as we are doing here or
indirectly for example if our class
inherited from another use a defined
class that inherits from the system dot
attribute built-in class
so now all that is left to do is apply
the predefined attribute usage attribute
against our required attribute class
like with the obsolete predefined
attribute the attribute usage predefined
attribute is a member of the system
namespace
basically the attribute usage predefined
attribute allows us to provide metadata
to the compiler that will tell the
compiler which elements are allowed to
have our predefined attribute declared
against them
so we can apply rules or constraints
through the use of the attribute usage
predefined attribute against our custom
attribute at the class level
this is an example of declaring an
attribute against a class
so in the first argument passed into the
attribute usage attribute we can declare
which program elements are allowed to be
decorated with our custom attribute
so if we have decided that we only want
our custom attribute to be declared on
the following program elements Fields
parameters and properties we can declare
this by passing in this code to the
first parameter of the attribute usage
attributes Constructor like this
so here we are declaring which Target
program elements are able to be
decorated with our required custom
attribute
we can optionally set a property of type
Boolean named allow multiple through our
declaration if we set the allow multiple
property to true this means multiple
instances of our custom attribute can be
declared against a single program
element
we only want one instance of our custom
attribute to be declared against a
single program element so let's set the
allow multiple property to false
we also have a property named inherited
that we can optionally set through this
declaration
setting this property determines whether
the relevant custom attribute is
inherited by a derived class in this
example we won't set this property
and that's it we have now created our
required custom attribute
so let's create our next custom
attribute let's add a new class file to
our custom attributes folder and let's
name this class string length attribute
let's add three public auto implemented
properties to our string length
attribute class
max length for the storage of an integer
value denoting the maximum number of
characters that a user can enter for a
field related to a property against
which the string length attribute has
been declared
error message for the storage of a
string value denoting the message
outputted to the user when the user has
entered an invalid value into a field
related to a property against which the
string length attribute has been
declared
men length for the storage of an integer
value denoting the minimum number of
characters that a user can enter for a
field related to a property against
twitch the string length attribute has
been declared
so let's create a private method named
set properties that we can reuse for
setting our public properties this
method will be called from a number of
Constructor overloads that we'll
Implement in a bit for this class
this method does not return a value and
contains three parameters that correlate
to the public properties that we have
already created
the first parameter is max length which
is defined as int
second parameter is error message
defined as string
the third parameter has been length
defined as a nullable integer
the question mark symbol following the
int keyword denotes that this parameter
is nullable
so it is a nullable value type parameter
because it's defined as an integer which
is of course a value type
let's also make our Min length parameter
optional we can do this in C sharp by
simply assigning the relevant parameter
a default value within the method
definition like this
so if a value is not passed into this
parameter by default the Min length
argument will have a value of null
before we move on with our example let's
go to the Microsoft dots specifically to
this location to read a bit about
nullable value types a nullable value
type T question mark represents all
values of its underlying value type T
and in addition of null value for
example you can assign any of the
following three values to a bull
question mark variable true false or
null
an underlying value type T cannot be a
nullable value type itself
very basically a null value means that a
value for the relevant variable has not
been set
adding a question mark at the end of the
value type definition for a variable or
a parameter means we have the option of
storing a null value in the relevant
variable or parameter
note that optional parameters must be
included at the end of the parameter
list in the relevant methods method
signature
okay so let's implement the logic for
the set properties private method so
firstly let's check to see if the error
message argument contains an empty
string if it does we want to set a
default error message value
in order for our error message to
contain appropriate text depending on
whether the Min length value is set
we can create a nested if statement so
if the Min length value is null let's
appropriately set our default error
message
if the Min length value is not now let's
include appropriate text relating to the
Min length value within our default
error message
so if the developer does not pass in an
error message when declaring the string
length attribute against an appropriate
program element a default error message
will be used
for the scenario where an error message
value is set when the relevant attribute
is declared against a program element
the error message provided must be
assigned to the error message public
property of the attribute
then let's set the max length property
this is a property value that the
developer must pass in when declaring
the string length attribute against an
appropriate program element
less than assign the appropriate value
to the Min length property
so let's use a ternary operator to check
if the Min length argument is null IE
has not been set by the developer
declaring the string length attribute
against an appropriate program element
if the Min length argument is null let's
assign 0 to the Min length property if
the Min length argument contains a value
let's assign the value to the Min length
property
so let's create our Constructor
overloads firstly let's create a
Constructor that contains just the max
length parameter
then within our Constructor let's call
our private set properties method to
assign values to the appropriate public
properties of the string length
attribute class
okay I also want to make the error
message parameter in the set properties
method and optional parameter
we can do this by simply assigning
default value to the error message
parameter like this note that the
parameter after the error message
parameter in our parameter list is also
the last parameter in the parameter list
and is optional so it is perfectly legal
to make our error message parameter
optional remember the optional
parameters must be included at the end
of the relevant parameter list
let's create Constructor overload that
contains the max length parameter and
the error message parameter
then let's use our private set
properties method to assign values to
the appropriate public properties of the
string length attribute class
let's create a Constructor overload that
contains the max length parameter and
the Min length parameter
let's use our private set properties
method to assign values to the
appropriate public properties of the
string length attribute class
note how we are passing in a value to
the Min length optional parameter of the
set properties method we need to be
specific as to what parameter is being
passed an argument here
because in this case we are not passing
in an argument to the error message
parameter
the fact that the error message
parameter and the Min length parameter
are both optional means in cases like
this
we have to make it clear which parameter
we want to pass our arguments to
let's create one more Constructor
overload this Constructor overload
contains the max length parameter the
error message parameter and the Min
length parameter
let's use our private set properties
method one more time to assign values to
the appropriate public properties of the
string length attribute class
let's ensure that we include the code
whereby our class inherits from the
system.attribute built-in class
so now let's declare the attribute usage
predefined attribute against our string
length attribute class so we can copy
the attribute usage declaration from our
required attribute class and
appropriately paste it in to declare the
attribute usage attribute against our
string length attribute class
great so we have now completed two
custom attributes the required attribute
custom attribute and the string length
custom attribute let's create one more
custom attribute this attribute will be
responsible for indicating when declared
against a program element that the input
Fields value related to the relevant
program element should match a specified
regular expression pattern
so regular expressions are great for
defining patterns that an input field
value must match for field types that
must be constrained to a particular
format like for example postcodes phone
numbers credit card numbers email
addresses Etc
so the validation code for Fields like
this will be simple
if the relevant input field value
matches the specified regular expression
pattern the user's input is deemed as
valid if however the input field value
does not match the specified regular
expression pattern the user's input is
deemed as invalid
we can implement the validation logic
related to our custom attributes once we
have completed the code for this final
custom attribute
so let's add a class to our custom
attributes folder and let's name this
class regular expression attribute
let's create two public autoimplemented
properties the first property named
error message is of the string data type
the second property named pattern is
also of the string data type the pattern
property denotes the regular expression
pattern that must be supplied by the
developer when the regular expression
custom attribute is declared against an
appropriate program element let's create
two Constructor overloads the first
Constructor overload contains one
parameter named pattern
the developer is able to pass an
appropriate regular expression pattern
argument to this parameter when
declaring the regular expression custom
attribute against an appropriate program
element
the error message argument is not passed
into this Constructor but we can provide
a default error message in this
Constructor and assign it to the error
message property
let's create a Constructor overload this
Constructor contains two parameters one
denoting the regular expression pattern
and the other denoting the error message
so this Constructor allows the developer
to pass in a regular expression pattern
argument as well as a custom error
message to a declaration when declaring
this attribute against a program element
so all we need to do within the
Constructor is assign the public
property members of this class with the
appropriate values passed into the
relevant Constructor as arguments
let's ensure that we include the code
whereby our class inherits from the
system.attribute built-in class
the last step is to appropriately
declare the attribute usage predefined
attribute against the regular expression
attribute class this declaration will be
the same declaration applied against our
other two custom attribute classes
so let's copy the appropriate
declaration from one of our other custom
attribute classes and appropriately
paste the contents of our clipboards
into our regular expression attribute
plus file
so now we have created three custom
attributes implemented in three separate
files
the first custom attribute we created is
named required attribute
when this attribute is declared against
an appropriate program element this
means that the associated input field
must not be left empty if it is left
empty the field value is deemed as
invalid
the second custom attribute we created
is named string length attribute when
this attribute is declared against an
appropriate program element this means
the associated input field must contain
a character length that falls within the
boundaries defined by a specified
minimum value and a specified maximum
value
the third custom attribute we created is
named regular expression attribute when
this attribute is declared against an
appropriate program element
this means that the associated input
field must contain a value that matches
a specified regular expression pattern
so through the Declaration of one or
more of our custom attributes a
developer can express how a certain
input field should be validated
without the logic to implement the
validation rules however these
attributes are useless these custom
attributes perform no functionality
other than to add metadata to relevant
program elements
so the next step is to write the
validation code we must write the
validation logic that correlates with
each of our custom attributes
through the use of reflection we'll be
able to read the metadata added to the
relevant program elements through the
use of our custom attributes
the use of our custom attributes is for
the purpose of declaring how validation
logic is related with relevant program
Elements which are also related to
relevant input fields
so let's write the relevant validation
logic
so to do this let's first add a new
class named validation directly to the
project node
so we want this class to be separate
from our custom attribute classes
we are going to implement our own
validation code in this class so we
first want to create the validation
logic that corresponds to each of our
custom attributes the required attribute
the string length attribute and the
regular expression attribute let's
encapsulate this functionality within
three private methods
let's first implement the validation
logic that corresponds to the required
attribute
so let's create a private static method
named field required is valid that
returns a Boolean value
this method contains one parameter let's
name this parameter entered value and
Define it as a string the logic for this
method is basic
if the entered value passed into this
method as an argument is not null or
empty return true because this means the
user has entered a value which makes the
input field entry valid if the code that
returns true is not executed this means
the entered value is invalid and false
must be returned to the calling code
let's implement the validation logic
that corresponds to the string length
attribute
the method signature for this method is
the same as the field required is valid
method except we need to also pass in a
field of type string length attributes
to this method in addition to the
parameter representing the entered value
this is so that we can access the Min
length and max length public properties
that we implemented for the string
length attribute class
the values stored in these two
properties are integral to the
validation logic performed against
relevant inputted values
let's name this method field string
length is valid
so to implement the validation code
let's Implement an if statement where
the condition evaluates the entered
value argument to see if its character
length is greater than or equal to the
Min length property and is less than or
equal to the max length property
if the character length of the entered
value argument Falls within the range
defined by the Min length and back
length property values the entered value
is valid so we can return true to the
calling code if however the character
length of the entered value does not
fall within the specified range we must
return false because the entered value
is not valid
so let's now implement the validation
private method that corresponds to the
regular expression attribute so the
method signature is almost the same as
the field string length is valid methods
method signature let's appropriately
name this method field pattern match is
valid
instead of including a parameter of type
string length attribute let's include a
parameter of type regular expression
attribute
this is so that we can access the public
property named pattern which is a member
of the regular expression attribute
class
for pattern property will contain the
regular expression pattern against which
we need to validate the entered value
so let's use the reg X class to perform
our validation logic
this class is a member of the system.txt
dot regularexpressions namespace so
let's include an appropriate using
directive
the reg X class contains a public static
method named is match we can use this
method to validate the entered value
against the relevant regular expression
pattern
if the is match method returns true this
means the entered value is valid so we
must return true to the calling code
if however the is match method returns
false this means the entered value is
not valid and we must return false to
the calling code
okay so we have now implemented the
validation logic that corresponds to our
custom attributes
let's create a public static method
named property value is valid that
returns a Boolean value
this method is responsible for calling
relevant validation code
that is relevant to a specific program
element and a user inputted value
the validation code executed is
determined by the custom attributes that
have been declared against the relevant
program element
in the interests of keeping this code
simple the code will only be relevant to
a program element that is a property
so the first item in the parameter list
for the property value is valid method
is a parameter of type type
this parameter represents the type that
contains properties against which our
custom attributes may have been declared
for example a user-defined type
representing an employee record the next
parameter represents the value that a
user enters I.E an input field which is
correlated to a particular property and
needs to be validated by our code this
parameter is appropriately named entered
value
the next parameter represents the
program element which will be a property
in this case that is a member of the
type represented in the first parameter
so for example the program element could
be the first name property which is a
member of a user-defined type named
employee
the last parameter for this method
represents the error message that will
be displayed to the user if the user's
input is deemed as invalid
we want to Output the error message
value so let's include the out keyword
in the relevant parameter definition
let's implement the logic for this
method
firstly let's get a reference to the
relevant program element
so the program element in this example
will be the property on which one or
more of our custom attributes has been
declared
so for example if we are validating the
first name property on the employee
user-defined type the element name
argument will contain the literal text
first name which is the name of the
first name property
to get a reference to the user-defined
type in this case employee the calling
code would pass in type of employee
this means we can use reflection to
inspect the relevant program element to
ascertain which custom attributes have
been declared against the relevant
program element using reflection we can
then ascertain how we should validate
the relevant entered value
so let's write code to get a reference
to the relevant program element which in
this case will be a property reflection
can be used to get relevant information
about a program element
we want to know in our code what custom
attributes have been declared against
the relevant program element
so we can use the property info type
which is a member of the
system.reflection namespace to gain
access to the property information that
we need
we must include a using directive to the
system.reflection namespace
let's Define a variable named prop as
the property info type and let's assign
a value returned from a call to a method
named get property which is invoked on
the type argument passed into the T
parameter of this method
note that we need to pass the element
name argument to the get property method
the element name argument will store a
reference to the name of the relevant
property
we now have a reference to the relevant
property information we can use the get
custom attributes method to return a
collection of custom attributes that
have been declared against the relevant
property
we can assign The Returned value to an
array of type attribute
the get custom attributes method is
returning a collection of type I
enumerable and I want to store a
reference to the relevant custom
attribute objects in an array so let's
use links to array extension method to
convert the I enumerable collection into
an array
let's initialize the error message
output parameter to an empty string
let's write code to perform a for each
Loop and loop through each attribute
object declared against the relevant
program element
then within the for each Loop let's
Implement a switch statement and use
pattern matching code to get a reference
to the relevant custom attribute objects
so that we can perform appropriate
validation on the entered value
so the switch statement evaluates the
type of each relevant attribute object
using pattern matching
using pattern matching we are able to
get a reference to the attribute objects
that have been declared against the
relevant program element
this is the magic of pattern matching in
action pattern matching was introduced
in c-sharp version 7. it allows the
developer to write code to assess
whether an object type matches the
object type specified in a case
statement
if there is a match a reference to the
relevant object is made available on the
same line of the code as the case
statement
so here we have case required attribute
if the object referenced by the att-r
variable is of type required attribute
the ra variable is assigned the value
referenced by the att-r variable
we are then able to use the ra variable
in our validation code that resides
within the relevant case block
so we can call the appropriate private
method for validating required fields
that we implemented earlier to validate
the relevant user entered value
if the entered value is deemed as
invalid we can output an error message
to the user through the error message
output parameter which has been
appropriately marked with the out
keyword meaning we can output a value
through this parameter to calling client
code
if the relevant user input fails
validation we need the property value is
valid method to return false
so let's include the other case
statements pertaining to the other two
custom attributes
so let's implement the case block for
the string length custom attribute
and lastly let's implement the case
block for the regular expression custom
attribute
great
let's write the calling client code
let's go to the.net core console project
let's start by creating classes that can
represent data models the first model
will be a class that represents an
employee record
so let's create a new folder and name it
models
let's add a new class named employee to
the models folder
this class contains six autoimplemented
properties ID as int first name as
string last name as string phone number
as string email address says string and
postcode as string great
so we are now going to appropriately
declare our custom attributes against
the properties we have just added to the
employee class
these attribute declarations will
indicate to our validation code how the
input values associated with the
employee classes relevant properties
should be validated
let's include an appropriate using
directive at the top of our code to the
validation component dot custom
attributes namespace
so let's apply the required attribute to
the ID program element notice how when
we declare our custom attributes we
don't need to include the attribute
suffix
so even though the class representing
the required attribute is named required
attribute when we declare the attribute
against the relevant program element we
can omit the attribute suffix
so in this case we can declare the
attribute using the name required
let's declare the string length
attribute against the first name
property
let's pass appropriate values to the
Constructor of the string length
attribute
so let's say the maximum character
length for the first name input field
should be 15.
our next argument is the error message
we wish to Output to the user if the
user enters an invalid value for the
first name field
for the last parameter let's say the
user must enter a value for the first
name field that has at least two
characters
let's declare the required attribute
against the first name property
so we can copy and paste the custom
attributes declared against the first
name property to the last name property
now the phone number property will
include the same attributes and settings
applied against the first name and last
name properties
but we also want to validate the phone
number against a regular expression
pattern that can be used to validate UK
phone numbers
so let's navigate to this URL
I find this website very useful for
finding regular expression patterns
let's do a search for UK phone numbers
let's copy an appropriate pattern from
our search results
we can then appropriately pass this
pattern as an argument to our regular
expression custom attribute
so let's appropriately paste our pattern
into our code
note that we may need to include the ad
symbol preceding the string references
of the regular expression patterns
this is because the pattern may include
backslash characters which need to be
escaped because the backslash character
is used by C sharp within strings for
escape sequences for example the
backslash n escape sequence denotes a
new line within a string the backslash T
escape sequence denotes a horizontal tab
character within a string Etc
so by including the at symbol preceding
the string we are indicating that any
backslash character should be
interpreted as a literal backslash
character and not as part of an escape
sequence
so let's apply the custom attributes for
the email address property
let's find an appropriate regular
expression pattern
and appropriately paste it into our code
let's do the same for the postcode
address let's say we need the postcode
to be a valid UK postcode
great
so now let's build a basic front end so
that we can test our validation code
let's write a reusable private method
that contains logic to prompt the user
for a relevant field value
we need this code to run within an
infinite Loop which we can Implement
using a do Loop
once the user enters a valid value the
code will break out of the infinite Loop
the get input method returns true once
the user has inputted valid data for the
relevant input field
we can use the out keyword to make the
last field and output parameter where we
can pass the valid data to the calling
code
foreign
let's go to the main method and
implement the calling code let's
instantiate an object of type employee
let's ensure that we have a using
directive to the attributes
examples.models namespace
because of course the employee class is
a member of this namespace
let's create three local string
variables amp ID first name and postcode
we need to get a reference to the
employee classes type we can do this
using the type of method like this
let's write codes to handle the user
input for the employees ID
so once the user has entered a valid
value for this field
the valid data can be assigned to the ID
property the ID property of the employee
type is an integer value so let's write
code to convert the relevant string
value to an integer value
let's write code to handle the user
input for the employee's first name
field
once the user has entered a valid value
for this field the inputted value can be
assigned to the first name property
let's write code to handle the user
input for the employee's postcode
so let's write code so that once the
user has entered valid information for
the relevant Fields a message stating
that the user has now entered valid data
for the relevant employee is outputted
to the console screen
great let's test the code
so if we press the enter key without
entering an employee ID
we get an expected output
an appropriate error message is
outputted to the console screen
let's enter a valid ID
great so if we leave the first name
field blank and press the enter key
we get an appropriate error message
output to the console screen
if we enter just one character for the
first name field
the string length validation code deems
our input as invalid and an appropriate
error message is output to the console
screen
so now if we enter a value for our first
name field that contains a character
length that falls within the character
length range which is between 2 and 15.
this input is deemed as valid
if we leave the postcode field blank we
are presented with an appropriate error
message
let's enter a valid UK postcode
great
just to demonstrate that we are able to
reuse our custom attributes on other
user-defined types let's create another
model
let's create a class to represent a
department record
let's apply some of our custom
attributes
let's go to our main method and test our
code
in the interests of time we'll only
include the department short name field
in our test here
excellent
so let's use a predefined attribute that
already exists in a.net library
so the attribute I want to use is named
Json ignore
so we want to add functionality to
Output our employee object to the
console screen in Json format
using the Json ignore attribute we can
choose which fields to exclude from our
employee object Json output
let's declare the Json ignore attribute
against the phone number property and
the postcode property
let's go to our main method and write
the code to serialize the employee
object in Json format
let's run the code
and you can see that the Json output
does not include the phone number and
the postcode Fields great
let's comment out the Json ignore
attribute declarations so that we can
include all of our property values for
the relevant employee object in our Json
formatted output
okay so I accidentally inputted Bob's
surname which is Jones for the postcode
field and I've noticed that there is a
bug in our code the error message format
outputted to the screen isn't correct
the validation was run correctly I.E
clearly Jones is not a valid postcode
but the error message itself is
incorrect the xero wrapped in curly
brackets in the appropriate code should
serve as a placeholder for the property
name of the property against twitch the
relevant attribute has been declared
the one wrapped in curly brackets should
serve as a placeholder for the regular
expression pattern specified for the
purpose of validating that a postcode
entered by the user is in a correct UK
postcode format
so I can see what is causing this issue
we need to remove the dollar symbol
preceding the error message specified in
this Constructor
we want to use composite string
formatting and not string interpolation
for this string value
for details on composite formatting
versus string interpolation please view
a video on c-sharp strings created by
this channel a link to this tutorial is
available Below in the description
so let's repeat the input that we
specified in the previous test
great the validation code is correct
and the outputted error message is also
correct
okay but in our outputted Json text here
the postcode field is null so it looks
like we have another bug here
all right so when I copied and pasted
the code here I forgot to change the
relevant code so that the postcode
property is set to the user's input
okay
let's correct this
and let's test the code again
excellent
we looked at how attributes are used in
code to add metadata to program elements
like classes methods properties Etc and
reflection can be used to read the
metadata added through the use of the
attributes at runtime
we discussed that there are two broad
categories in c-sharp for attributes
namely predefined attributes which are
built into the.net Base Class libraries
and custom attributes which allow the
developer to implement the developer's
own attributes by creating a class that
inherits from the system dot attribute
built-in class either directly or
indirectly
we created code examples using
predefined Global attributes namely
assembly version attribute and assembly
description attribute
this demonstrated how Global attributes
can be used to add and modify metadata
at the assembly scope
we created code examples using
predefined general attributes namely
conditional attribute obsolete attribute
and attribute usage attribute this
demonstrated how we can add and modify
metadata for program elements
we then created our own custom
attributes as part of codelogic used for
the purpose of field validation
the use of reflection was also employed
as part of this code logic this code
implementation imitates how the asp.net
MVC framework uses attributes for field
validation
I hope you've enjoyed this video on
using attributes in c-sharp in the next
part of this course we'll create a basic
asp.net MVC application where we'll use
Technologies like attributes link and
Entity framework along with front-end
Technologies like HTML bootstrap CSS and
more please consider subscribing for
more content on Advanced c-sharp topics
and much more and please ring the bell
so that you'll be notified of future
content
if you liked this video please give it a
thumbs up it'll be greatly appreciated
please feel free to share this video
with anyone you feel May benefit from
its content
I really enjoy reading your comments so
please feel free to engage with me in
the comments section
as always the code created for this
video can be downloaded from GitHub
a link to the relevant GitHub repository
is available Below in the description
[Music]
foreign
hi and welcome to the ninth and final
part of this Vance c-sharp course
I was going to end the advanced c-sharp
course with an example of creating an
asp.net MVC web application using
c-sharp the more I delved into writing
the tutorial on asp.net MVC the more I
realized that asp.net MVC at least
demands its own video series so I'm
currently working on a video series
where we'll build an asp.net MPC web
application using C sharp I'll bring
these videos to you as soon as I can as
I had originally intended I'm going to
finish the advanced c-sharp course
focusing on the topic of c-sharp
reflection
so let's get into it
let's first gain a basic understanding
of reflection and then we'll write a
code example using the reflection
technology and C sharp
so what is reflection reflection
provides objects of type type
that describe assemblies modules and
types
you can use reflection to dynamically
create an instance of a type bind the
type to an existing object or get the
type from an existing object and invoke
its methods or access its fields and
properties if you are using attributes
in your code reflection enables you to
access them
for Content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so that you'll be notified
of future content if you like this video
at any point please give it a thumbs up
it will be greatly appreciated
in the eighth part of this Advanced
c-sharp course on c-sharp attributes we
use the reflection technology to read
metadata provided through the use of our
own custom attributes from relevant
program elements when I say program
elements I'm referring to classes
methods Fields properties Etc
so reflection allows the developer to
access metadata within.net assemblies at
runtime.net assemblies are
self-describing entities which means the
metadata data about the relevant
assemblies reside within the assembly
itself so at runtime we are able to load
a Target assembly and read its metadata
using reflection
using reflection we are able to for
example instantiate objects from classes
that reside within the target assembly
and invoke the relevant objects methods
or get and set the relevant objects
property values
so in this video we are going to create
a code example that will serve as a test
harness
we are going to create code that loads a
Target assembly and displays a list of
relevant classes that reside within the
target's assembly
we can then select an item in the
relevant list that represents a class
and test the functionality within each
of the classes methods
the important thing to note here is that
in this example we will not reference
the target assembly from within the
project that contains our calling client
code
we are using reflection to late bind to
the classes that reside within the
target assembly
so that we can instantiate objects and
test the object's functionality at
runtime
note that when I refer to the Target
assembly I am referring to the assembly
that contains the functionality we wish
to test through our test harness
we will be using what is known as late
binding to test the methods that reside
within the relevant classes contained
within the target assembly so what is
late binding
when we reference an assembly from a
project through for example visual
studio and subsequently write code to
instantiate an object from a class that
resides within the referenced assembly
this is known as early binding when we
reference an assembly like this the
compiler has information about the
target assembly at compile time
light binding occurs when we don't set a
reference to a Target assembly at
compile time and we instantiate an
object from a class that resides within
the target assembly at run time
the obvious disadvantage to late binding
is that late binding is prone to runtime
errors when early binding is employed
the compiler has relevant knowledge for
example relevant type information about
the target assembly's constituents at
compile time so compile time errors can
be flagged and corrected at compile time
potential errors are averted at compile
time and therefore certain runtime
errors are avoided with late binding
reflection can be employed to gain
necessary information about the target
assembly itself and its constituents at
runtime
so let's create our test harness code
example where we'll use late binding to
test the functionality that resides
within a Target assembly
let's create a.net core console
application named test harness
let's creates.net standard Library
project named utility functions
the utility functions project will be
compiled into our Target assembly
now it is important to note that I have
included the utility functions project
which of course when compiled is
compiled into a.net assembly in the same
solution as the.net core console project
where we'll write our calling client
code this is important to note because
we are not going to explicitly reference
the utility functions assembly from
the.net core console project so if we
were to early bind to the utility
functions assembly we would reference
our utility functions project like this
but let's cancel this dialog box because
we are going to load the utility
functions assembly at runtime using
reflection
we are not going to set a reference to
it at compile time we want to late bind
to the utility functions assembly at
runtime
this is obviously just a mark example
and not a real world application but you
can see how we could put a number of
assemblies within a directory Traverse
the assemblies within the relevant
directory and automate the testing of
functionality within the target
assemblies at runtime we would not have
to reference any of these assemblies
within our test harness project because
using reflection we can access all the
information we need for each assembly
and test the functionality within the
assemblies so the advantage of this
loose coupling of our test harness
application with the assemblies that we
are testing is that we don't need to
early bind to the assemblies that
compile time we can simply put an
assembly or assemblies in an appropriate
directory and our test harness
application can learn about the assembly
or assemblies at runtime by accessing
the relevant assembly's metadata at
runtime through reflection
but we will simplify this example and
focus on classes within a particular
namespace within one target assembly our
Target assembly in this case will be the
utility functions assembly if this
doesn't make sense to you at the moment
please bear with me and this will become
clearer as we progress with creating
this code example
let's include basic functionality within
our utility functions project once
completed this project will be compiled
into an assembly which will serve as our
Target assembly I.E the assembly against
which will perform our reflection
functionality
through the use of reflection we'll be
able to read relevant information about
the assembly instantiate objects from
its classes and test its methods
so let's write the code for the utility
functions assembly let's start by
deleting the class that was
auto-generated by Visual Studio
let's add a class named basic utility
functions
within the basic utility functions class
let's create four very simple methods
let's create a method named write
welcome message the right welcome
message method contains no parameters
and returns a welcome message as a
string
let's write a method named integer plus
integer the integer plus integer method
contains two integer parameters and
returns an integer value
The Returned integer value will be the
mathematical result of the first integer
argument plus the second integer
argument
we can appropriately name our parameters
operand 1 and operand 2 respectively
let's write a method named concat three
strings this method contains three
string parameters and returns a string
value
The Returned string is a concatenation
of the arguments
passed into the concat three strings
method
the order in which the string arguments
are concatenated is the order in which
their corresponding parameters appear in
the relevant parameter list from left to
right
let's write a method named get string
length it contains one string parameter
this method returns an integer value
the character length of the string
argument passed into the get string
length method
and that's it that is our very basic
basic utility functions class completed
let's create another basic class let's
name this class basic math functions
let's create two really simple methods
in this class
let's create a method named divide
operation which contains two parameters
of type double this method returns a
value of type double that is the result
of a divide mathematical operation in
this method the second argument is
divided into the first argument and the
result of the Divide operation is
returned to the calling code
let's create a method named multiply
operation
which contains two parameters of type
double this method returns a value of
type double that is the result of a
multiplication mathematical operation
where the first number argument is
multiplied by the second number argument
the return value will be the product
which of course is the result of the
multiplication of the first number
argument
by the second number argument
okay so we now have two classes in our
utility functions project
so now we want to be able to decorate
certain program elements with a custom
attribute that we can use to provide
additional information to the calling
code about the relevant program elements
in this case the program elements will
be classes and methods
let's create a custom attribute named
information attribute for more
information on custom attributes please
view the previous part of this course
which is a tutorial entitled c-sharp
attributes I have included a link to the
relevant video Below in the description
so in order to create a custom attribute
the relevant class must inherit from the
system.attribute built-in class
let's keep this class really basic so
let's add one Auto implemented property
named description this property will
enable us to provide a custom
description about a program element that
we'll decorate with our information
attribute custom attribute we want to
constrain our information attribute
custom attribute to the decoration of
only class and Method program elements
so we can do this by decorating our
information attribute custom attribute
class with the attribute usage built-in
attribute we can then pass the following
bitwise operation to the Constructor of
the attribute usage built-in attribute
so let's pass
attributetargets.class or attribute
targets.method to the Constructor of the
attribute usage built-in attribute so
this means that only classes and methods
can be decorated without information
attribute custom attribute
so next let's apply our custom attribute
to the relevant classes and methods
let's go to the basic utility functions
class and let's decorate the class
itself and its methods with the
information attribute custom attribute
so let's set the description property
for our custom attribute declared
against the basic utility functions
class to this class contains basic
utility methods
let's set the description property for
our custom attribute declared against
the right welcome message method to this
method returns a welcome message
let's set the description property for
our custom attribute declared against
the integer plus integer method to this
method Returns the sum of two integer
operands
let's set the description property of
our custom attribute declared against
the concat three strings method to this
method concatenates three strings in the
same order as they appear in the
parameter list from left to right
let's set the description property for
our custom attribute declared against
the get string length method to this
method Returns the character length of a
string argument
so let's move on to our basic math
functions class let's decorate the basic
math functions class with our
information attribute custom attribute
like this so here the description
property is set to this class contains
basic math functionality let's decorate
The Divide operation method with our
custom attribute where the attributes
description property is set to this
method divides the first number by the
second number and returns a result of
this divide operation
and lastly let's decorate the multiply
operation method with our custom
attribute and set its description
property to this method multiplies the
first number
by the second number and returns a
result of this multiplication operation
so we have included in the metadata for
our utility functions assembly very
basic descriptions about method and
class program elements through the use
of our information attribute custom
attribute
now let's write the calling client code
so in the calling client code we want to
provide functionality that targets a
particular namespace within the target
assembly in this case our Target
assembly will be the utility functions
assembly
and reads all the relevant information
about the assembly's classes and methods
that are members of the relevant
namespace
we'll create functionality where the
user can choose a class from a list of
classes that reside within the relevant
namespace once the user has chosen the
class that the user wishes to test the
user can then choose a method from a
list of methods that are members of the
relevant class the user can then select
from a list of methods the method that
the user wishes to test once the user
has chosen the method that the user
wishes to test the user is prompted for
values for each of the parameters
contained within the relevant methods
method definition
once the user has provided values for
all the relevant parameters our code
will invoke the method and the result
returned by the method is displayed to
the console screen
so you can see that this test harness
application can be used to test
functionality within an assembly note
that you can extend the code that we are
about to write to Traverse a number of
assemblies within a directory and
automatically test particular
functionality within the assemblies
so you could write your own automated
test facility based on the code we are
about to write
for the purposes of this tutorial
however the code will be simplified
so let's write the code for our test
harness project which is our.net core
console project
the first thing to do is within our
calling client code is include a using
directive to the system.reflection
namespace like this so that we can make
use of reflection in our application
so let's start writing our code in the
main method
let's first create two local string
constants the first constant stores the
target assembly file name utility
functions.dll the second constant stores
the Target namespace that contains the
classes that the user will be able to
test through our test harness
application so the namespace is utility
functions
let's write the code that will load the
target assembly at runtime
so we are using the assembly.load method
to do this
but we may need to replace this with the
assembly.load file method when we test
and debug the code later in the tutorial
we'll know which method needs to be
employed here either the load or load
file method so we'll leave it as load at
this point
we pass in the path of where the target
assembly will be in order to load the
target assembly into memory
so later in this tutorial just before we
test our code for the sake of Simplicity
we'll copy the target assembly into the
same directory as where the assembly for
this project will reside so let's write
code here to point to the path of the
target assembly which will be the
current directory the same directory as
where the test harness assembly will
reside
let's use the path.combine method to
combine a path with the name of the file
the path class resides in the system.io
namespace so let's include a using
directive to the system dot IO namespace
so we are able to get the current path
from the appdomain.current domain dot
base directory property
this is the directory where the assembly
that we are currently working on will
reside
let's pass this value as the first
argument to the path.combine method
then let's pass the name of our Target
assembly which is utility
functions.dll as the second argument
into the path.conbind method
the return value from the assembly.load
method will be the object of type
assembly so let's assign a variable of
type assembly the value returned from
the assembly.load method
so we have now got a reference in memory
to our Target assembly
let's write code to get a list of
classes from the target namespace within
our Target assembly
so the namespace within our Target
assembly is named utility functions
so let's use Link to get a list of types
or classes from within the utility
functions namespace
let's ensure that we have a using
directive to the system.link namespace
so we can use the assembly objects get
types method to return a collection of
classes that reside within the target
assembly
we can use the where method to filter
on the assemblies utility functions
namespace like this
let's assign The Returned result to a
generic list that is strongly typed as
system.type
then let's convert the innumerable
collection returned by the link query to
a list and we can do this by using the
to list conversion method like this
let's write a method that encapsulates
writing a prompt to the user
let's write code to display a message
prompting the user for input to the
console screen
as you can see we are prompting the user
to press a number key to indicate to the
application which class the user wishes
to test
so it is better to encapsulate this
prompting functionality in a method that
we can reuse for this purpose throughout
the creation of this application
this method encapsulates the
functionality of displaying text to
prompt the user for input to the console
screen
so next we want to write code to display
a list of classes to the console screen
so that the user can select a class that
the user wishes to test
so we can simply write code that
traverses the items stored in the
classes list
which contains the result of our link
query and output the relevant class
names to the console screen in
sequential order
so let's do this
in our list of classes each class name
is preceded by a number which will allow
the user to press a number key to select
the class that the user wishes to test
let's write the code where the user can
press a number to select a class from
the classes list
let's use a switch statement to return
the relevant item from the list
so now we want to create an object
instance from the user's chosen class or
type we can use the activator.create
instance method to do this
and here we are writing code to late
bind to a class within the target
assembly we can assign The Returned
object from the activator.create
instance method to a variable of type
object
you can see that when we like bind like
this we do not have the benefits of type
safety so code like this is prone to
runtime errors this highlights a
disadvantage of late binding like this
in code
so because at compile time we don't know
the type that will be returned at
runtime by the activator.create instance
method we need to use a variable of type
object to reference The Returned value
so we have now written the code enabling
the user of our application to choose a
class from a list of classes by pressing
a number key associated with the
relevant class
once the user has chosen a class the
user will be presented with a list of
relevant methods
let's write code to clear the screen
once the user has chosen the class from
the list of classes
let's write a method where we can
encapsulate code to Output a heading to
the console screen on the screen that
displays a list of methods belonging to
the class that the user has selected we
want to include a heading at the top of
the screen containing the class name
that the user has chosen let's go to the
main method and write the code to Output
the relevant heading to the console
screen
let's write code to prompt the user to
choose from a list of relevant methods
we now want to write code to Output a
list of relevant methods to the console
screen
so logically the code to present the
user with a list of methods is exactly
the same as the code that presents the
user with a list of classes
so we have an opportunity here to
refactor our code by creating a reusable
method that encapsulates functionality
to Output a list of both classes and
methods
so this will be one block of code that
can output a list for both classes and
methods
in this method we need to account for
the difference between the type
representing a class and the type
representing a method in this context
classes are of type system.type and
methods are of type method info
so to solve this problem we can apply
generics
let's create a method named display
program element list let's include the T
placeholder between greater than and
less than symbols to indicate that this
is a generic method
let's base the code for this method on
the code that we have already written in
the main method to Output a list of
classes
you can see that we are writing this
code in a more generic style because
this code will output the items of a
generic list that is strongly typed as
system.type and a generic list that is
strongly typed as method info
great
so let's replace the code in the main
method that outputs a list of classes
with a call to our display
program element list method
the type that represents a class in
terms of reflection is system.type
we have another opportunity to refactor
our code because the code to return an
object of type system.type from our list
of classes or types logically is the
same as the code to return an item of
type method info from a list of methods
so let's write code to encapsulate this
functionality in a method named return
program element reference from list
so we need to include generic
functionality within the method
definition of the return program element
referenced from list method we also need
to return a value of type T from this
method
and we can copy the code for this method
from our main method and paste it into
our return program element reference
from list method
so let's replace the code in our main
method that enables the user to choose
from a list of classes with a call to
the return program element reference
from list method
so let's call the get methods method on
the type Choice object which represents
the class that the user has chosen from
the relevant list and assign The
Returned value to a generic list
that is strongly typed as method info
note that a generic list that is
strongly typed as system.type is used to
store references to classes or types and
a generic list that is strongly typed as
method info is used to store a list of
methods
we can now reuse the display program
element list method
in our main method to display a list of
methods
we can pass in the method info type to
the relevant type parameter but we don't
actually need to do this here because
the compiler has enough information to
determine the type
let's call the return program element
reference from list method which will
enable the user to choose a method from
a list of methods displayed to the
console screen
let's write an if statement to check if
the method info object returned from the
return program element reference from
list method is not null
let's write code to clear the screen
let's write code to Output a heading
containing the class name and the method
name of the class n method that the user
has chosen to test
so the next step is to prompt the user
to provide a value for each parameter of
the relevant method
so we are able to get a list of
parameters from the relevant method by
implementing the method info objects get
parameters method like this
and we can assign The Returned result to
an array of type parameter info
the next step is to invoke the method
chosen by the user and pass in the
relevant parameter values that will be
provided by the user's input I.E if the
relevant method contains any parameters
if the relevant method does not contain
any parameters the method can be invoked
without any arguments passed to it
so let's encapsulate the functionality
for this in a method named get result
in order to execute the functionality
for the get result method we need the
relevance class instance object the
relevant method info object and the
array containing the relevant array of
parameter info objects
so in the get results method definition
let's include a parameter of type object
to accommodate the class instance let's
include a parameter of type method info
to accommodate the relevant method to be
executed and let's include a parameter
that accommodates an array of type
parameter info so the invocation of our
method is going to be different in terms
of code implementation when the method
that is invoked requires a number of
arguments to when the method requires no
arguments passed to it I.E the relevant
methods method definition contains no
parameters
so let's create an if statement that
checks to see if the parameter's
argument contains any items if it does
not contain any items we can call the
method info objects invoke method and
pass null into the second argument
the first argument must be passed an
argument that references the appropriate
class instance
this class instance or object contains
the method that we are invoking here
through this line of code the else part
of the if statement invokes a method
that does contain parameters so we must
write code to prompt the user for a
value for each parameter
so let's create a method that allows for
an argument which will contain an array
of parameter info objects to be passed
to it
so let's name this method return
parameter value input as object array
let's create a one-dimensional array
named param values and provision the
array to hold a number of items equal to
the number of items stored in the array
passed into this method I.E the array of
type parameter info
let's create a counter variable named
item count
and initialize it to a value of zero
let's create a for each Loop to Loop
through each item in the parameters
array let's write codes to prompt the
user to enter a parameter value
so let's say that we know that the
parameter type can only be one of the
following string int or double
so let's write an if statement to check
the type of the relevant parameter if
the parameter is a string
then no type conversion of the
console.redline method value is
necessary because this method returns a
string
so we can then write code to assign the
user's inputs to the relevant position
in the parameter values array
so the code for when the relevant
parameters of type int or double is
slightly different we must include an
explicit type conversion from string
returned by the console.readline method
to the relevant type before assigning
the inputted value to the appropriate
position in the param values array we
must increment the item count variable
by 1 for each iteration of the loop
in the location in our code editors
where the loop has exited
we can write the code to return the
param values array to the calling code
great
so let's go back to the get result
method and call the return parameter
value input as object array method
then we can write codes to invoke the
relevant method and pass in an array
argument containing the user's input for
each parameter as the second argument to
the method.invoke method like this
as stated earlier the first argument
passed to the invoke method is the
relevant instantiated object
instantiated from the class that the
user has chosen to test
to finish this method off let's write
the code to return the result returned
by the relevant method to the calling
code
let's then go to the main method and
call the get result method let's write
the code to display The Returned result
from the get result method to the
console screen
great
before we test the code let's compile
our two projects
let's find the targets assembly
and let's copy the assembly to our
clipboards
then let's go to the directory of our
test harness project
and paste the target assembly into this
directory
Let's test our code
okay so we have a little bug here so I
suspect this is because we need to use
the load file method instead of the load
method so let's change the code
accordingly
let's run the code again
great we can see our class is displayed
in a list
but our information attribute custom
attribute class is also present in the
list and this is not desirable
we don't have any methods in the
information attribute custom attribute
class to test
so if we select one of the classes that
we wish to test like for example the
basic utility functions class we are
presented with a list of methods which
is great there are some methods listed
here that we are not interested in
testing like for example the equals
method or get hash code method these
methods belong to the object class which
as we know is ultimately the base class
for all types in C sharp so we only want
to test the methods that perform
functions directly related to the class
we have selected in this case the basic
utility functions class
we'll modify the code to filter out
undesirable code elements in a bit for
now let's continue with our test let's
select the integer plus integer method
oh we should be receiving a prompt to
enter a value for each of the parameters
contained within the integer plus
integer method
so we have another bug to fix
so here's where we need to fix the bug I
forgot to include the prompt text in the
return parameter value input as object
array method
so let's include a prompt for each
parameter item
foreign
Let's test the code again
let's select the basic utility functions
class from our list of classes
let's select the integer plus integer
method
so we are now prompted to enter a value
for the first parameter great
so let's do that let's enter five
we are then prompted to provide a value
for the second parameter let's enter a
value of 6 for this parameter
once we press the enter key the correct
result of 11 is presented to us great
so except for the fact that certain
program elements that we have no desire
to test
are appearing in our lists the basic
functionality of our test harness is
working as expected so let's write the
code to filter out those unwanted
program elements
we are going to use the information
attribute custom attribute for this
purpose
let's say that we only want those
program elements that are decorated with
our information attribute custom
attribute to appear in our lists of
program elements to test
so let's write a method that checks the
CFA program elements iea class or a
method is decorated with the information
attribute custom attribute if the
program element is decorated with the
information attribute custom attribute
we want to include the relevant program
element in our list of program elements
to test
if however the program element is not
decorated with the information attribute
custom attribute we must exclude the
relevant program element from our list
of program elements to test
so let's write a private static method
named has information attribute
and let's include one parameter within
its method definition this parameter
will represent the program element that
we need to check so we need the has
information attribute method to check if
the information attribute custom
attribute has been declared against the
relevant program element in the context
of the requirement of this application
the program element can either be a
class or a method
so the parameter must be of a type that
can accept a class or a method as an
argument in this particular case those
types will either be of type system.type
or of type method info we could include
two methods named has information
attribute and differentiate their method
definition where each method definition
contains a parameter of a different type
one version of the has information
attribute method can contain a parameter
of type system.type and the other
version of the method can contain a
parameter of type method info
so we could use method overloading to
perform the desired check for if a
custom attribute has been declared
against a program element I.E either a
method or a class however we can achieve
what we want with only one version of
the has information attribute method
because the system.type and Method info
types both inherit from a common class
the member info class if we right click
the text in our code editors
representing the type class and select
go to definition we can see that the
type class inherits from the member info
class if we do the same thing against
the method info class we can see that
the method info class also inherits from
the member info class
if we look at the member info class
definition we can see that it contains a
method named get custom attributes and
this is the method we need to use to
check if the relevant program element is
decorated with the information attribute
custom attribute
so the point is we don't need to
overload the has information attribute
method we can simply Define the
parameter for the has information
attribute method as member info in one
method
this will mean we can pass both types of
arguments to the has information method
I.E an argument of type system.type
a class program element or an argument
of type method info
a method program element
so let's look at the code for the has
information attribute method we have
created a local string constant to store
the name of the type of our information
attribute custom attribute so this name
includes the namespace of where the
information attribute custom attribute
resides a full stop and the attribute
class name
we have written code to Loop through all
the custom attributes that may be
declared against the program element
type passed into this method
as you can see we are able to call the
get custom attributes method for both
class and Method program elements in our
method because the system.type class
which represents class program elements
and the method info class which
represents method program elements both
inherit from the member info class which
contains the get custom attributes
method within our for each Loop we first
get the type of the current attribute
so we have written type attrib equals
attrib the current attribute object dot
get type
we then check to see if the name of the
type attribute is equal to the
information attribute custom attributes
name if it is this means that the
information attribute custom attribute
has been declared against the program
element type passed as an argument to
this method so we can return true to the
calling code
if all attributes have been traversed
and none of the attributes match our
information attribute custom attribute
this means that the program element
passed as an argument to the method does
not have our information attribute
custom attribute declared against it so
we must return false
so this method can be used in our
calling code to filter out program
elements based on whether or not
the relevant program element is
decorated with the information attribute
custom attribute so how can we use our
method for this purpose in our main
method the answer is we could modify the
relevant link queries to include our has
information attribute method
and we can include our has information
attribute method in the relevant where
filters
so let's first modify the link query for
returning a list of class program
elements we can simply include a call to
our has information attribute method in
the where filter method like this
to filter out methods that aren't
decorated with the information attribute
custom attribute we can modify the
appropriate link query like this
Let's test our code
excellent
you can see that only those classes in
our Target assembly that are decorated
with the information attribute custom
attribute appear in the relevant list
if we select the basic math functions
class from our list of classes we can
see that its methods that are not
decorated with the information attribute
custom attribute have been filtered out
of the relevant list
great
let's also include functionality to
appropriately outputs to the console
screen the description property value of
the information attribute custom
attribute for our relevant program
elements in terms of the user's
experience this functionality will
provide additional information about the
classes and methods that the user wishes
to test
so let's write a private static method
named return information custom
attribute description
this method returns a string and
contains a parameter of type member info
remember both the system.type class and
the method info class inherit from the
member info class so this method can be
reused for both class and Method program
elements
we want to read the description property
so let's create a local string constant
that references the text description
let's create a for each Loop that Loops
through the custom attributes that may
have been declared against the relevant
program element
which in this case will either be a
method or a class
So within the loop let's reference the
attribute type like this
we can then apply an if statement to
check if the current attribute is the
information custom attribute okay so
let's refactor our code here so that the
target information attribute type
constant can be accessed from both this
method and the has information attribute
method
if the current attribute is the
information custom attribute then let's
access its description property
we can do this using reflection like
this
so we are attempting to check if the
property info object is not null but the
compiler is complaining
this is because the project is currently
built on.net core version 3.1
checking for nulls like this is only
allowed in a later version of C sharp so
I'm going to change the version
of.net.net5 for this project
great and you can see now that this line
of code is Now supported
I.E using the is not null line of code
but I'm going to use the old way of
checking for nulls anyway just in case
the followers of this tutorial are using
an older version of.net for their
projects
so we have now written the code to read
the description property from objects
derived from the relevant information
custom attributes that have been
declared against relevant class and
Method program elements
so let's write the code to appropriately
output the program element descriptions
declared through the use of our
information attribute custom attribute
to the console screen
let's create a method named display
element description for this purpose
this method only needs one parameter
which will be the text we wish to Output
to the console screen
let's write code to check if the
argument passed to this method is not
null if it is not null
let's write its value to the console
screen using a different background and
foreground color to the default console
screen colors so that the text stands
out
then let's use the console.resetc color
method to reset the color back to the
default console foreground and
background colors
let's go to the main method and use the
display element description method to
Output the relevant program element
descriptions to the console screen
so we can pass the result of the return
information custom attribute description
method into the display element
description method on one line like this
this code will display our custom
descriptions of the program elements
that the user wishes to test
Let's test the code
okay so we are getting a bug and this is
because the load file method cannot find
the target assembly
the reason for this is because when we
changed our version of.net for the test
harness project a new directory for
dotnet 5 was created this directory
contains the assembly for the test
harness project
but it doesn't of course contain the
target assembly
so let's copy the most recently built
utility functions assembly
to the net 5.0 directory
let's run the code again
and you can see that our custom elements
are displayed and we are able to test
the functionality of methods and classes
that reside within our Target assembly
we have used the reflection technology
to accomplish this
you can also see that additional
information about the relevant program
elements is outputted to the console
screen
this was made possible through the use
of our information attribute custom
attribute excellent
to finish off the application let's add
code to enhance the user's experience
as you may have noticed once the user
has tested a method the application
automatically ends we currently have no
way of navigating back to the first
screen where we are presented with a
list of classes that we may wish to test
we want the user to have the option of
returning to the list of classes so that
the user can carry on testing other
classes and methods
so we can do this by putting the
relevant code within an infinite Loop
once the user has tested a particular
method the user can either press let's
say the spacebar key to end the
application or any other key to return
to the screen that contains a list of
classes
Let's test the code
foreign
excellent
so the last thing I'd like to bring to
your attention is the technology
encapsulated in the
system.reflection.emit namespace using
this technology a developer is able to
generate code dynamically
so the developer is able to generate
Dynamic methods or even Dynamic
assemblies on the Fly the user could for
example generate Intermediate Language
code on the Fly based on user input
so because of functionality like this
you can see how incredibly powerful the
c-sharp language is I recommend
navigating to this location to read more
about this powerful aspect of reflection
I hope you've enjoyed this tutorial on
c-sharp reflection we have now come to
the end of this Advanced c-sharp course
if you've got this far congratulations
this channel now provides two complete
in-depth courses on features of the
c-sharp language a beginner's course and
an advanced course the next series of
videos will focus on the asp.net MVC
framework
where we'll build an application in
c-sharp using the asp.net MVC framework
on.net 5. during this time I will also
produce other videos relating to c-sharp
and other Technologies
so let's end this video by summarizing
what we have learned about c-sharp
reflection
reflection provides objects of type type
that describe assemblies modules and
types
you can use reflection to dynamically
create an instance of a type bind the
type to an existing object or get the
type from an existing object and invoke
its methods or access its fields and
properties
if you are using attributes in your code
reflection enables you to access them
we demonstrated using reflection to
create an application that can serve as
a test harness
the test harness allows the user to add
a target's assembly to the same
directory where the test harness
application resides and choose a class
that the user wishes to test from a list
of classes that belongs to a specific
namespace that resides within the target
assembly
when the user selects a specific class
from the class list that class is
instantiated into an object through the
use of late binding
this is how the test harness is able to
test the functionality within a Target
assembly without referencing the target
assembly at compile time
in the test harness application
reflection is employed to instantiate
the relevant class into an object
when an assembly is referenced by a
project at compile time this is known as
early binding with early binding the
compiler has relevant information about
the types within the target assembly at
compile time
late binding is used when the compiler
does not have compile time knowledge of
the target assembly
so a technology like reflection is used
to access the relevant information about
the assembly which allows for late
binding to occur at runtime
it was noted that late binding has the
disadvantage of being prone to runtime
errors
when early binding is employed a
specific type can be instantiated into
an object using the new operator and we
have the advantage of compile time type
safety
we do not have the advantage of compile
time type safety when late binding is
employed in code and the
activator.create instance method is used
to instantiate an object from a type
lastly we briefly discussed the
technology encapsulated within the
system.reflection dot emit namespace
functionality for generating
Intermediate Language code or IL code
dynamically resides within the
system.reflection.emit namespace
a developer can use the functionality
within the
system.reflection.emit namespace to
create code for dynamically generating
methods and even assemblies at runtime
for Content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so that you'll be notified
of future content if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up it will be
greatly appreciated please feel free to
share this video with anyone you feel
May benefit from its content
I really enjoy reading your comments so
please feel free to engage with me in
the comments section
the code created in this tutorial can be
downloaded from GitHub a link to the
relevant GitHub repository has been
included Below in the description thank
you and take care
let's go back in time to the end of
February 2002 with the first release of
the.net framework this is when c-sharp
was first released it is a new fully
object oriented general purpose
programming language
Visual Basic through its donut Evolution
has been upgraded from a largely
event-based language tightly coupled
with the visual Basics 6 IDE to a new
object-oriented version of itself called
visualbasic.net a managed version of C
plus could also run within the.net
sphere new languages like F sharp which
was first released in 2005 could also
run within the.net environment these
languages are all interoperable which
essentially means for example a c-sharp
application can consume a.net component
written in Visual Basic or an
application written in Visual Basic can
consume a component written in C sharp
what makes this possible is the common
Intermediate Language or Cil all
high-level.net programming languages
like c-sharp Visual Basic C plus plus
Etc
are first compiled into the common
Intermediate Language before further
compilation into machine Language by the
common language runtime
all code that runs within the.net
runtime is considered managed code
the.net runtime also makes available a
number of libraries that can be
leveraged by our custom.net code
this is essentially done through a
library of files called the framework
class libraries or the abbreviation of
this fcl
which provide generic functionality for
our applications to consume the common
language runtime or CLR can be described
as the.net virtual machine and provides
services like just-in-time compilation
memory management security and exception
handling it is important to note that
the.net framework will only run on
appropriate Windows operating systems
and must be installed in its entirety on
the target computer there have been many
versions of the.net framework released
since its Inception and they are able to
run side by side on the same computer
the latest version of the.net framework
at the time of writing this tutorial
is.net framework version 4.7 let's go
back in time again to June 2016 when the
first stable version of the.net core
runtime was released
it can be described as a cross-platform
or agile modularized lightweight version
of the.net framework it supports
appropriate standards so that multiple
languages can run and be managed within
the.net runtime and also provides
language interoperability
core language compiles into the common
Intermediate Language or Cil
net core provides some of the standard
framework class libraries which can be
called The Core FX and can be described
as a partial Fork of the framework class
libraries
dotnet calls virtual machine can be
referred to as core CLR or core common
language runtime and it provides
services like improve just-in-time
compilation memory management security
and exception handling
unlike the.net framework.net core can
run on Mac OS Linux as well as Windows
dotnet core also provides a modular
framework so that only the modules that
your application uses are shipped with
your application an important difference
between.net core and the.net framework
is that you no longer need the
entire.net framework installed on the
target computer but only those
components of the.net runtime that your
application needs
this is why.net core is often referred
to as a more agile version of the.net
framework.net core is open source
software which makes things like the bug
fix release process more efficient
it is optimized for the cloud
it is designed for high performance
provides a great base for microservice
architecture
[Music]
it is designed to be highly scalable
dot net core is definitely a significant
evolution of the.net runtime but it must
be noted that it does not replace
the.net framework please see in the
description below a URL for a Microsoft
docs webpage containing recommendations
for when to use the.net framework and
when to use.net core as the.net runtime
for your server applications net 6
completes the unification of the
platform and adds new capabilities for
building web native and hybrid apps for
Linux Windows Mac IOS and Android with a
single code base this video is an
overview of what to expect with the
release of net 6 which is due to be
released on the 9th of November of this
year 2021
for Content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so that you'll be notified
of future content please feel free to
share this video with anyone you feel
May gain value from its content
before I give a brief summary of what
new features and improvements to expect
with the release of.net 6. I'd like to
present you with a brief summary of my
personal experiences as a developer with
the technological innovations that have
been made over the years
I remember working as a young developer
in the late 90s on Enterprise web
applications
when I look back I'm proud of what we
were able to achieve using what is now
known as classic ASP or classic active
server Pages classic ASP was introduced
as Microsoft's first server-side
scripting technology for creating web
applications
the ASP files were coded in vbscript
I remember we wrote our business logic
in Visual Basic and compiled our code
into com components
we then installed our com components in
an environment known as MTS Microsoft
transaction server
the Microsoft component object model com
and Microsoft transaction server MTS
later evolved into com Plus
using active server Pages our code was
written in vbscript
and we would call our com components
from our active server pages
com plus handles many of the resource
management tasks that previously needed
to be programmed by the developer such
as thread allocation and security
active server Pages allowed a developer
to implement codelogic using vbscript
and output HTML client-side JavaScript
and CSS code to the client's browser
so back then we typically created our
applications using a three-tier
architecture classic ASP contained code
and logic to Output HTML code JavaScript
and CSS to the client's browser com
components that contained business rules
ran and MTS later known as complex SQL
server was used for our backend storage
facility
[Music]
in the early 2000s I moved to London my
move to London coincided with the first
release of c-sharp and net
net was a gigantic step forward for
Microsoft Technologies
Visual Basic 6 was the last version of
Visual Basic before the dramatic change
that was to follow in the form
of.net.net was a complete rethink Visual
Basic was still offered as a language
but instead of being limited to being a
largely event-based language tightly
coupled with the Visual Basic 6 IDE was
now known as visualbasic.net and is a
fully object-oriented programming
language the first version of.net was
named.net framework programs written
in.net framework executed in a software
environment in contrast to a hardware
environment the software environment is
named The Common Language runtime CLR
a number of class libraries called the
framework class libraries are built
into.net framework and are available to
be consumed by.net applications
developers can produce their software by
combining their source code with.net
framework class libraries so.net
framework provides a library of classes
that can be leveraged from our
applications
net applications run in an environment
known as the common language runtime or
CLR which can be described as the.net
virtual machine and provides services
like just-in-time compilation memory
management security and exception
handling
so.net framework provided developers
with a sophisticated environment that
would revolutionize the developers
experience in the early 2000s I was now
working on web applications using a.net
version of active server Pages known as
asp.net
and I was able to write my code using a
new fully object-oriented programming
language known as C sharp
so in the early 2000s the introduction
of.net was a massive leap forward.net
framework was interoperable meaning you
could write code in any language that
supported the common type system so we
could write our applications using for
example c-sharp visual Basics C plus
Etc
this was great but NET Framework could
only run on Windows platforms and
required a monolithic installation
NET Framework does not run on Linux or
Mac OS
mono was released on June the 30th 2004.
mono is a free open source
implementation of microsoft's.net
framework based on the ecma standards
for c-sharp and the common language
runtime mono was a version of.net that
could run on multiple platforms mono can
run on Windows Mac OS and Linux
on June the 27 2016 the first version
of.net core was released
.net core is the.net successor to.net
framework
.net core is primarily developed by
Microsoft employees
by way of the.net foundation
and released under the MIT license
.net core supports the use of nuget
packages.net core can be described as a
lightweight modular cross-platform and
more agile version of.net framework
to prevent future fragmentation of.net
implementations.net standard was
introduced
the motivation behind.net standard was
to establish greater uniformity in
the.net ecosystem
net standard is a formal specification
of net apis that are available on
multiple.net implementations
the specification is maintained by.net
implementers specifically Microsoft
includes.net framework.net core and mono
and
unity.net 5 was a significant release
of.net and was released on the 10th of
November 2020.
Net 5 is the first release of a version
of.net that attempts to unify all
features of all versionsoft.net under
one implementation of.net
the idea behind this vision of.net is to
have one.net moving forward
that can Target Windows Linux Mac OS iOS
Android TV OS watch OS and webassembly
and more
dotnet 5 is the future of.net core and
is almost a complete reimagine of the
old.net framework in fact Net 5 is the
first major update since the 2016
release of.net core
dotnet 5 was a direct Evolution from.net
core 3.1
and the reason why it was called.net5
and not.net4 is because the last release
of.net framework was version 4.8 which
was released on July the 25th 2019.
both.net core and framework were
maintained in parallel allowing you to
choose between one or the other you
could leverage.net standard to make
shared libraries between the two the
release of.net 5 meant that.net
framework will be deprecated this means
you can only use.net framework as long
as your operating systems for example
Windows Server 2019 will support it
so.net 5 was the first step forward to
unified.net
and finally we get to the release of.net
6. the main significant aspect of net 6
is the fact that it delivers the final
parts of the.net unification plan that
started with dotnet 5. here is a brief
overview of the new features and
improvements that we can expect with the
release of.net 6.
C sharp version 10.
the significance of version 10 of
c-sharp and future versions of c-sharp
that are to be released in line with
each new version of.net is that the
developer can write less code with the
evolution of c-sharp there's a strong
focus on simplification much of the
boilerplate code that needed to be
written when using previous versions of
c-sharp do not need to be written when
using c-sharp version 10 so this
improves the clarity and simplification
of a developer's code and potentially
increases productivity allowing the
developer to focus more on application
business logic
net multi-platform app UI for Native
mobile and desktop apps
dotnet multi-platform app UI or net Maui
is an evolution of xamarin it allows the
developer to create applications for
multiple different types of platforms
using a single code base you can write
one project that can be compiled into an
application that runs on Android devices
iOS devices Windows desktops Windows
devices as well as Mac OS
so one code base written in for example
C sharp that can leverage native
capabilities on multiple heterogeneous
devices
Blazer desktop web apps with Native
device capabilities
so one advantage of this is that if
you're a web developer and don't want to
learn xaml to implement your front-end
code as you would When developing an
application using for example WPF uwp or
xamarin forms
you can use HTML5 CSS bootstrap and
JavaScript I.E the web Technologies with
which you are already familiar to create
desktop applications through Blazer
desktop web apps you will still be able
to leverage native device functionality
and not worry about learning new
technologies to leverage these native
functionalities
minimal web apis for cloud native apps
this is a great feature that allows a
developer to be up and coding for
example a simple macro service a lot
quicker than if the developer were to
code that microservice using a typical
web API that implements the MVC
architecture
there is far less ceremony involved in
getting started
more device targets including Apple M1
.net 6 will support single file
deployments for windows with up to 50
smaller file size dotnet 6 supports
ahead of time compilation
productivity enhancements like part
reload
if for example you've developed angular
applications with node you may be
familiar with the hot reload feature
this feature is now coming to net
developers this means improved
productivity simply because there's less
need to stop and start the running of
our code during the development of our
applications
continued performance improvements in
runtime and builds time
EF core performance is now 70 better on
the tech and power benchmark
so that was a brief overview of what you
can expect with the release of.net 6.
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long in this
video we are going to look at some of
the great features and improvements that
are due to be released with net 7. we'll
cover these aspects thematically for
more details of what to expect with the
release of.net 7. I've included relevant
links Below in the description of this
video
this video will give you a broad
overview of some of the improvements and
new features that stand out to me that
will be included in the official release
of Net 7 which is due to be released in
November of this year 2022 since the
release of.net 5 on November the 10th
2020 Microsoft committed to a new
release of.net in November of each year
moving forward
so.net 6 was released on the 8th of
November 2021 and in November of this
year we are expecting the release of net
7.
Net 5 was what's known as a current
release and net 6 was what's known as a
long-term support release LTS release
note that there is no quality difference
between long-term support releases LTS
releases and current releases the only
difference is the length of support LTS
releases get free support and patches
for three years current releases get
free support and patches for 18 months
at the time of creating this video the
latest preview release of.net 7 is
preview 6. I've included links Below in
the description to blog posts that
contain details of each of the preview
releases of.net 7. the official release
of.net 7 will be a current release which
means it will be supported for 18 months
the release of dotnet 8 due to be
released in November 2023 will be a
long-term support release which means it
will be supported for three years
preview releases are typically not
supported but they are offered for
public testing ahead of the final
release a preview or release candidate
release are supported through Microsoft
developer support only if they're
specifically designated go live
a brief history of.net this channel has
released several videos on the history
of.net the first video I released on.net
is a video on the difference between.net
framework and net core I've since
released a video on the.net 5 release
and a video on the.net 6 release in each
video I've provided foundational content
on the evolution of.net please see a
link to a playlist Below in the
description to view the videos released
by this channel on the progression
of.net so in this video I'll give a
brief overview of the history of.net
before we look at the new features due
to be released in.net 7 and also the
improvements and optimizations that are
due to be released in.net 7.
NET Framework was released February the
13th 2002 at the time it was a
revolutionary release for Microsoft as
it fundamentally changed the environment
in which Microsoft applications run
dot net applications run on what can be
described as a virtual machine similar
to how Java applications run on the jvm
Java virtual machine the virtual machine
provided in the.net framework is known
as the CLR common language
runtime.net framework however can only
run on Windows platforms and requires an
installation of all the Base Class
libraries shipped with the.net
framework.net core was released on the
27th of June 2016. it is a free open
source managed computer software
framework that is cross-platform it can
run on Windows Linux and Mac OS
operating systems only the Base Class
libraries that are needed by an
application need to be shipped with that
application so it is a more agile
version of.net when compared to the.net
framework
so.net framework and net core is being
supported concurrently this resulted in
the fragmentation of.net to alleviate
this fragmentation the.net standard was
introduced the first steps to
properlyunify.net under one umbrella as
it were came with the release of.net 5
on November the 10th 2020 the release
of.net 6 came approximately one year
later on the 8th of November 2021 which
shipped with many great enhancements but
most
significantly.net 6 further cemented the
unification of.net
so.net 6 is Unified free open source
software that is cross-platform and
agile
it is an extremely versatile framework
in terms of the types of applications
that can run on.net and the performance
of.net has been optimized for the cloud
it is also versatile in terms of the
number of platforms on which it can run
dotnet 6 is supported on multiple
operating systems Windows Linux Mac OS
Android iOS tvos including Mac OS
silicon and windows arm 64.
so what is coming
with.net7.net Maui there is significant
investment in.net Maui for net 7.net
multi-platform app ui.net Maui is a
cross-platform framework for creating
native mobile and desktop apps with
c-sharp and xaml using.net Maui you can
develop apps that can run on Android iOS
Mac OS and windows from a single shared
codebase.net Maui is open source and is
the evolution of xamarin forms
with the release of.net 7 you can expect
performance improvements and better
tooling in.net Maui
Cloud native and containers
Cloud native Computing is an approach in
software development
that utilizes cloud computing to build
and run scalable applications in modern
dynamic environments such as public
private and hybrid clouds
so common Technologies used in building
Cloud native applications are for
example Docker containers a set of
platform as a service products that use
OS level virtualization to deliver
software in packages called containers
kubernetes
an open source container orchestration
system for automating software
development scaling and management and
micro Services a collection of loosely
coupled services that run inside Docker
containers
there'll be a broad set of investments
in Cloud native and containers in.net 7.
in terms of for example simplifying
authentication Improvement of
performance in terms of startup
performance and runtime performance and
better integration with containers
there's also investment in better
alignment with the Orleans technology
Orleans is a cross-platform framework
for building robust scalable distributed
applications Orleans scales with a
single on-premises server to globally
distributed highly available
applications in the cloud
audience uses the virtual actor model
where grains serve as the fundamental
building blocks of Orleans applications
grains are entities comprising
user-defined identity behavior and state
so with Net 7 there will be investment
in better alignment of all yields
with.net modernizing existing.net
applications
with.net 7 there is investment to make
it easier to upgrade older.net
applications to modern.net applications
for example You may wish to upgrade an
old asp.net MVC application to an
asp.net core MVC application for Net 7
Microsoft is making investments into its
Upgrade Assistant to make these types of
upgrades easier the Upgrade Assistant
can for example change code written for
older.net environments to be appropriate
for modern.net environments it will also
be made easier to upgrade applications
in sections rather than upgrading the
entire application at once
they are framework Investments for
application modernization and net 7.
abstractions will be provided that for
example allow the sharing of parts of
the asp.net side of the application with
parts of the asp.net core side of the
application so the upgrade can be done
in an incremental fashion rather than
all at once which may not be a practical
solution
dotnet 6 contained many performance
improvements Investments are being made
in Net 7 to make.net even faster and
more efficient
asp.net core
HTTP 3 will become part of the.net
framework in.net 7. HTTP 3 is a new
standard in development that will affect
how web browsers and servers communicate
unlike previous versions which relied on
the well-established TCP HTTP 3 uses
q-u-i-c a multiplexed transport protocol
built on UDP
HTTP 3 includes significant upgrades for
user experience including performance
reliability and security minimal API
minimal apis are architected to create
HTTP apis with minimal dependencies they
are ideal for microservices and apps
that want to include only the minimum
files features and dependencies in
asp.net core minimal apis provide
developers with the advantage of less
ceremony when setting up web API
applications they are lightweight
minimal apis hook into asp.net course
hosting and routing capabilities and
allow you to build fully functioning
apis with just a few lines of code
in.net 7 minimal API will be more
consistent in terms of what can be
achieved when compared to web apis that
use the traditional MVC design pattern
one new feature in.net7 is providing a
way to group minimal apis together with
a common root prefix so that they
represent one part of the API space as
it were a developer can take the apis
and put them in different files so that
it is more manageable from a project and
code management perspective
currently you can apply action filters
to controllers in a web API component
the ability to implement such code for
cross-catching concerns will now be
available for minimal apis the concept
of endpoint filters will be available in
Net 7 to apply the same cross-cutting
functionality that for example action
filters provide for controllers
grpc
grpc was created by Google to speed up
data transmission between micro services
and other systems that need to interact
with each other
with.net 7 there is investment in grpc
Json transcoding the feature allows grpc
services to be called like restful HTTP
apis with Json requests and responses so
for example this will make it easy for
JavaScript code running within a browser
to call a grpc service
signal R signal R is a free and open
source software library for Microsoft
asp.net that allows server code to send
asynchronous notifications to
client-side web applications signalr was
built for high performance and is one of
the fastest real-time Frameworks around
in.net 7 there will be support for
strongly typed clients and returning
results from client invocations a new
client Source generator for Signal R
will be included the signalr client
Source generator generates strongly
typed sending and receiving code based
on interfaces that the developer can
Define
Net 7 will come with various
improvements to the Razer compiler to
improve performance resilience and to
facilitate improved tooling
Blazer
broad improvements will be made to
blazer for example mixed mode aot ahead
of time compilation will allow for
certain assemblies to be ahead of time
compiled rather than the entire
application needing to be ahead of time
compiled when ahead of time compilation
is implemented this makes the overall
size of the application to be downloaded
to the browser much larger so although
runtime speeds are increased for the
application the file size is much larger
enabling mixed mode means that parts of
the application can be optimized for
Speed
those parts of the application that
require greater speed can be ahead of
time compiled leaving the rest of the
application to be interpreted so speed
can be increased where it counts and a
balance is maintained between less size
of the application and the benefit of
speed optimizations
most browsers are now capable of
facilitating multi-threading so.net 7
will take advantage of this and will
provide multi-threading to Blazer
webassembly applications web crypto
simply means that cryptographic
functionality available in browsers can
be leveraged from Blazer applications
with the release of.net 7 there will be
enhancements in hot reload support
data binding improvements more flexible
pre-rendering pre-rendering razor files
into HTML allows passing of static files
which for example makes SEO search
engine optimization effective and Blazer
applications more control over the life
cycle of Blazer server circuits improved
support for micro front ends micro front
ends are a new pattern where web
application uis front-ends are composed
from semi-independent fragments that can
be built by several teams using
different Technologies support for
custom elements is an exciting feature
where you can shrink wrap as it were a
Blazer component in a standard custom
HTML element this means you could reuse
the relevant custom element created in a
Blazer application within for example an
angular or a react application so that's
a super exciting feature
mvc.net will include improvements made
to endpoint routing link generation and
parameter binding
Orleans
the asp.net core and Orleans teams are
investigating ways to further align and
integrate The Orleans distributed
programming model with asp.net core
Alliance 4 will ship alongside.net and
focuses on Simplicity maintainability
and performance including human readable
stream identities and a new optimized
version tolerant serializer
this video provides a brief overview of
some of the features and improvements to
expect with the next official release
of.net
which is due to be released in November
of this year.net 7 will be a current
release meaning it will be supported
free of charge for 18 months and will
contain many great new features many
performance and optimization
improvements
with this new release of.net and the
commitment to release a new version
of.net every year moving forward makes
it a great time to be a.net developer
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and please feel free to share
this video with anyone you feel May
benefit from its content for Content
like this and much more please consider
subscribing and please ring the bell so
as to be notified when new content is
released
I really enjoy reading your comments so
please feel free to leave a comment
below in the description
I hope you've enjoyed this video thank
you and take care